that's right it's time once again to
activate the famedron 6000 our patented
machine that definitely wasn't developed
in affiliation with Dr wondertainment we
swear after recalibrating rebooting and
hitting restart our Infamous specialized
supercomputer is ready to bring you all
manner of improbable scenarios we'll
simulate encounters between the SCP
foundation's various anomalies and any
other character from any other Universe
you could possibly imagine here's a
question for you what do you think would
happen if scp-096 the notorious shy guy
ran afoul of someone he couldn't just
kill for daring to look at it what if
the scourge of the underworld battler of
demons and the Devil Himself set his
sights on
scp-096 well we're about to hit the
button and discover the outcome of
scp-096 versus the dreaded Doom Slayer
so you've heard the old philosophical
debate about a tree falling down in the
woods and whether or not nobody being
around to hear it brings into question
if it actually happened at all right
well let's reframe that one a little if
an interdimensional rip in the very
fabric of the time space continuum opens
up in an SCP Foundation secure facility
and nobody is around to witness it does
a six foot tall 360 pound hulking
killing machine still emerge to
slaughter everything in his path it
turns out yes yes he definitely does
horrified screams and the loud bang of
shotgun blasts rang out through the
hallway as Foundation researchers ran
for their lives the Doom Marine had just
been unceremoniously dropped out of a
portal into a strange and unfamiliar
environment mere minutes earlier he had
been awakened inside a sarcophagus
within a facility on Mars in the year
2148 unfortunately doomguy hadn't had
the best start to his day given that the
base he'd woken up in was being overrun
by the forces of Hell itself thanks to a
rogue scientist opening up portals to
the underworld and allowing all manner
of demonic Abominations to come pouring
through
so naturally when another portal brought
the armor-clad Demon Slayer to a site
run by the SCP Foundation the intensity
of battle had led to the doomslayer
believing that the unsuspecting staff
were actually all demons in Disguise and
to him the only good Demon is one he got
to send back to hell in the most brutal
fashion imaginable he wasn't going to
stop until he'd torn through wave after
wave of foundation Personnel thinking
perhaps if he killed enough he'd be
returned to his previous Locale for more
demon killing as the foundation
dispatches its security forces and
mobile task forces to take down the
Unstoppable force of Carnage decked out
in head to toe green armor it seemed
nothing they could throw at the Doom
Marine was enough to take him down a
hail of bullets rained down on him from
the mtf's weapons ricocheting
ineffectually off his protective plating
as he continued his assault remaining
tireless thanks to his immense physical
condition
the SCP Foundation tried and failed to
contain doomguy they assumed him to
either be a new undocumented anomaly or
a violent and unhinged Maniac from the
church of the broken God given his armor
resembling cybernetic augmentations and
machine parts grafted to his body along
with his arsenal of advanced Weaponry
but there were no enhancements no
augmentations made to the Doom Slayer he
may have once been mortal but centuries
of killing demons had allowed him to
transcend ordinary human physiology he
did not Tire never lost strength never
needed to eat or drink and was near
enough Immortal yet among all the chaos
that was on furling a solitary
researcher had just managed to slip out
of the Doom slayer's reach he ran as
fast and far as he was physically able
the mobile task force troops were
getting eviscerated and the Slater could
easily tear through the whole Foundation
then fleeing for his life the researcher
had an idea either a stroke of Genius or
total idiocy and a risky move either way
he would send an anomaly on the Doom
Slayer he turned to the nearest
containment cell a windowless room with
a heavy locked door hurriedly inputting
his security clearance code the
researcher heaved the door open and
covered his eyes with his arm it
wouldn't have been his first choice of
SCP to send into battle
scp-096's cell was the closest lumbering
out of its containment chamber on its
misshapen elongated legs
scp-096 scanned the area alarms were
blaring it was loud and frightening to
the timid albeit terrifying creature it
reached up to cover its ears and
bewilderment not that the researcher who
at Freda could see what it was doing for
one his eyes were still covered and for
another he was already dead thanks to
the doomslayer barging shoulder first
through a nearby wall and raining debris
onto the nearby researcher beneath the
visor of his helmet
Marine breathes heavily panting but not
tiring as he looked at the pale skinny
creature in the corridor before him it
was clutching the sides of its head its
huge jaw hung open as far as the Slayer
knew he was making progress his attack
was working he'd killed enough of these
demonic imposters that they were
starting to reveal their true forms
although in all his years of Bloodshed
and being a Scourge to the denizens of
hell he hadn't quite ever seen a demon
that looked like the shy guy not that it
mattered to doomguy before long it'd be
dead like all the rest the Towering
stick thin creature turned to face the
armor adorned Warrior and shrieked
immediately overcome with anguish having
a full-blown breakdown as it often did
whenever someone looked at it as the
demon killer stomped down the corridor
towards it the Doom blade a long Sleek
razor sharp edge extended from the
slayer's complex where it was mounted on
his wrist he reached down and yanked the
ripcord on his chainsaw too he was long
overdue for a glory kill but before he
could strike at scp-096 the shy guy
moved with impossible speed faster than
even the Doom Marine himself he'd zip
behind the encroaching Marine moving
quicker than he could perceive one
second scp-096 was crying and wailing in
front of him but not even a full second
later the creature was towering over
doomguy from behind
scp-096 gripped the Doom blade and
snapped it with ease like breaking a
twig before reaching its other long arm
down and pulling the chainsaw from Doom
guy's hand the motorized blade was still
running as he clattered to the ground
cutting a hole through the floor and
falling down into the lower level of the
facility enraged as he very often was
the Doom Slayer reached both arms back
behind his head and gripped the
elongated torso of scp-096 the virtually
Immortal killing machine hurled the
creature over his head with ease thanks
of course to his immense strength
doomguy could lift objects far heavy
heavier than most ordinary humans and
carry heavy weapons without tiring he
had even grappled hand to hand with
demons throwing the shy guy down the
corridor like hurling a basketball was
no trouble for the space-faring
slaughterer of Satan's spawn screaming
and Howling in pain as cp096 crashed to
the ground at the far end of the
corridor tumbling over itself thanks to
its long limbs before landing in a
confused heat as the shy guy reoriented
itself struggling back onto its feet and
standing up at its full height it was
instantly knocked back down as the force
of something Struck it barring down on
scp-096 the Doom machine charged his
signature double-barreled sawed-off
shotgun drawn who was hardly leaving a
scratch on
scp-096's pale skin despite the moderate
amount of damage the weapon was capable
of two shots would ring out reeling the
creature but not harming it then by the
time scp-096 managed to recover from the
blast this player had finished reloading
in time to open fire yet again even as
the Doom Slayer raced nearer closing the
distance between him and what he thought
to be another demon for him to kill the
shotgun seemed to have little effect
against the shy guy at close range
stilling the weapon doomguy put all of
his focus and energy into his charge
heavy boots stomping against the ground
as he raced towards the shy guy still
stunned by the latest shotgun blast
before the creature could steady itself
this time it was struck by another force
a heavy object barreling towards it the
doomslayer shoulder barged scp-096
sending the pair of them crashing
through the nearest wall they burst into
a neighboring room with a doom Slayer
keeping a single armed grip around the
shy guy while repeatedly delivering
vicious punches to its gut with his
other hand not once relenting
scp-096 screeched in pain clawing at the
Slayer but unable to tear through his
impenetrable armor as they crashed
through yet another wall
scp-096 did something it rarely ever did
in fact maybe something it had never
ever done before it ran away from
someone that had looked at it while the
creature was deeply insecure and so
self-conscious that it would kill anyone
who saw so much as a photograph of it
they didn't often feel afraid but the
Doom Slayer this muscle-bound killing
machine that had brutally butchered
actual demons was so imposing so
threatening and so effective at
dispensing painful punishment that he
scared the fight out of
scp-096 sobbing with Terror the creature
zipped away using its anomalous speed
trying desperately to put as much
distance between it and the do Marine as
it possibly could but therein lay the
problem no sooner had scp-096 gotten
away from the scourge of hell then the
creature immediately felt the familiar
poem whether it was an inescapable
compulsion to kill everyone who looked
at it but the fact of the Shy Guy's
biology It could only distance itself
from the Slayer for a few seconds before
it reappeared next to him from the Doom
guys perspective it seemed like the
creature was intentionally disappearing
and reappearing using its
teleportation-like speed to evade a
volley of his attacks
scp-096 came at him again stuck in a
loop of trying to attack the Doom Slayer
for looking at it to immediately
regretting that course of action and
fleeing in fear of its hulking heavy
weapon toting Target doomguy Drew every
weapon he had in his Arsenal launching a
barrage of high explosive ordinance from
his rocket launcher to try and kill
scp-096 the resulting damage practically
reduced an entire wing of the foundation
site to Rubble but still couldn't kill
the slayer's opponent meanwhile in the
moments that the shy guy temporarily
forgot his own fear for the doomguy it
managed to rush towards him swiping the
Marines various technologically advanced
armaments out of his hands before
instantly remembering why he was so
scared of the green armored force of
Destruction and dashing away doomguy's
supply of weapons had all but depleted
neither he nor scp-096 were getting
tired out by their constant back and
forth they were locked in a stalemate
until the shy guy tried to get back to
its cell zipping away once again it
cowered in the corner reaching for an
old worn out paper bag that had slipped
over its head it sat down trembling
rocking back and forth in a fetal
position the shy guy was terrified an
overwhelming debilitating fear gripped
it fear that became pure dread as the
sound of heavy boots began to stomp
closer and closer kicking the steel door
off its hinges the doomslayer walked
into
scp-096's cell carrying something huge
in his hands it was one of the most
devastating weapons doomguy had at his
disposal capable of unleashing Untold
destruction The BFG 9 000 without
remorse no not caring that the creatures
seem to have retreated and was cowering
away from him the Slayer raised the
powerful weapon and fired an enormous
ball of green energy the blast engulfed
the entire room tendrils snaking out
from the energy projectile causing
additional damage to the surrounding
area until there was nothing left of
scp-096 man it's even better on the 15th
raid oh hello I didn't see you there
dear viewers of SCP explained I'm on
break between supervising a cpu-682
termination attempts and inspecting the
mops we use on scp-173's leavings so I
decided to do what all the cool people
are doing in their spare time right now
rereading chainsaw man the hit manga by
Japanese author and artist tatsuki
Fujimoto for the uninitiated it's the
story of denji a poor young man from
Japan who makes his living hunting
Devils dangerous creatures that are
embodiments of Mankind's greatest fears
but when that living leads to him dying
at the hands of a gang of zombie Yakuza
believe me it makes sense in context he
bonds with the legendary chainsaw devil
and is reborn as chainsaw man an
unconventional superhero who chainsaws
first and asks questions later naturally
I was eager to see how one of our own
bloodthirsty Killers would fare against
denji's chainsaws of Fury so I selected
the most violent battle-hardened and
Carnage hungry anomaly out there
scp-076-2 The Immortal Warrior known as
Abel the two of them have a surprising
amount of things in common both are
effectively Immortal and can revive
after sustaining massive physical
injuries both absolutely love to fight
with their array of deadly weapons and
anomalous strength both have been part
of experimental operations groups with
denji being a member of Japan's Public
Safety devil Hunters division IV and
Abel being an ex-member of the SCP
foundation's disastrous Pandora's Box
mobile task force most of which he later
massacred out of boredom you can
probably see why these two really did
feel like the perfect match-up so after
forcing the trusty animatron 6000 to
read every currently available volume of
Chainsaw man and compute years of Abel's
gruesome battle data I've set up the
perfect simulation for your viewing
pleasure and hey fellow fans of the
manga isn't it horrifying that even we
beat mappa to the punch of animating
this thing
oh God that joke will age poorly if that
anime comes up before this anyway let's
crank this machine into action and let
her rep Japan
1997. everything is roasting in the July
heat Men In Black Harrison Ford's Air
Force One and Air Bud are hitting
theaters for the first time everything
is right with the world that's why over
in the headquarters of the public safety
devil hunting Department denji our
chainsaw loving hero is being praised by
his kind boss and Mentor figure makima a
lovable supported woman who will never
do anything wrong she even loves dogs
how could a person who loves dogs ever
be evil that very morning denji and his
chainsaw man form managed to defeat the
accidentally making a mistake on your
tax forms and now you're going to prison
devil who had been terrorizing downtown
Tokyo it was a challenging battle but in
the end he'd managed to turn the tables
and defeat the creature by setting it on
fire needless to say makima was
extremely pleased with dengie's work
here but now she had considerably more
Graver news to impart she'd gotten word
from an Envoy of another organization
that hunts down dangerous and anomalous
creatures the SCP Foundation that an
extremely lethal entity had breached
their containment and was now somewhere
in Japan the entertain question was not
a devil and thereby would be working on
a different rule set makima opened a
mile facts to her by the foundation yes
remember this is set in 1997 and gave
denji The crucial Lowdown several hours
ago the entity known as Abel had
resurrected from his huge black
sarcophagus in the underwater chamber of
the classified facility containment area
25b after waking up Abel had slaughtered
his way through the entire base killing
every SCP Foundation operative in his
path and then swimming out into the
Pacific Ocean sometime after that he
infiltrated a Japanese cargo ship and
murdered all the workers on board before
steering the ship back towards the Land
of the Rising Sun where he hoped to
claim even more victims makima told
denji that it would fall to him and his
associates to stop this able With a
Little Help from the SCP foundation's
intelligence but be warned Abel is an
incredible combatant with extreme
physical strength and durability as well
as surprising tactical intelligence it
wouldn't be an easy fight but makima
promised that if denji won she'd hug him
and go to a nearby karaoke bar with him
denji replied consider him dead already
miss makima meanwhile Abel was walking
through the slums of Tokyo marveling at
the neon signs for bars and clubs his
journey to Japan hadn't been an accident
Abel had been to Japan once before in
the year
1605. he'd faced the legendary Japanese
philosopher and swordsman Miato Musashi
considered by many to be one of the
greatest warriors in human history Abel
had dueled Musashi who famously wielded
two katanas at once in the hills of the
harima province where after a tense
battle Musashi cut him down Abel would
not resurrect again during Musashi's
lifetime but the battle gave him a deep
and abiding respect for the legendary
Warrior Abel knew that if the
opportunity ever rose again he would
return to Japan in hopes of experiencing
such a brilliant battle yet again but
the industrial and technological boom
had changed so much it was no longer the
quiet and pastoral Japan he'd
experienced but a booming epicenter of
trade and commerce he found it all
strange and perplexing suddenly he found
himself surrounded by a group of
Japanese street thugs many of them
wielding switchblades they laughed at
his strange outfit which to them looked
like an old worn bed sheet one of the
smarter members of the group had already
decided to go home when the others made
up their mind to mug Abel the Warrior's
extensive tattoos made him look like a
middle eastern Yakuza Dawn the rest
however were happy to take their chances
with him emptier pockets of that goofy
toga even has pockets the leader said
holding up his switchblade unless you
want to get cut Abel just smirked and
Drew a pair of long obsidian daggers in
the following Moment The Alley was
filled with screams then was silent yet
again Abel walked on breathing a sigh of
disappointment at how incredibly
mediocre this first fight had been his
blade stripping with fresh blood Musashi
is rolling in his grave Abel thought to
himself meanwhile across town denji and
the rest of division four were
mobilizing it was him the serious
swordwheeling Aki and the adorable
pathologically lying blood-phiend power
they'd been told over the phone by a man
named Dr bright that Abel would be
relatively easy to track down he's not
known for his subtlety all you need to
do is follow the trail of Carnage he
causes wherever he goes from the way he
talks about him it seems almost as
though Dr bright Bears a personal grudge
against Abel how strange power didn't
seem intimidated she proudly proclaimed
I don't think this battle will be
difficult at all
fact I faced the
before and defeated him handily Aki
sighed and asked when did this happen
last Tuesday of course
she replied power had only heard about
Abel this morning but denji and Aki had
learned better than to dispute her at
this point suddenly a large television
screen that had been previously relaying
an ad for a cutting-edge stereo system
cut to an emergency news report there
had been a horrific incident in downtown
Tokyo where a bar had been attacked and
most of its patrons murdered by a
deranged tattooed man carrying a pair of
huge swords Aki immediately recognized
this place the bar was Yakuza owned if
this able was on the hunt for worthy
opponents it makes all the sense in the
world that Japan's iconic crime
syndicates would be his first Target
denji Aki and power knew exactly where
they needed to go over at the bar Abel
was having a whale of a Time innocent
patrons were running and screaming while
the Yakuza engaged in an all-out war
with a terrifying inhuman Warrior
several of them had already been cut
down two Yakuza soldiers behind the bar
were reloading illegal Uzis and
preparing to return fire both were
sweating terrified by the sudden random
attack when they'd shot him before he'd
managed to dodge most of the bullets and
expertly block the rest with his swords
who the hell had sent this monster was
he with the Triads the Russian mob or
some devil summoned by the Japanese
government to crack down on them
whatever the case he seemed almost
impossible to kill the two men stood
back up and opened fire Abel held his
two swords and spun like a propeller
blocking all the bullets almost
effortlessly he then produced another
dagger seemingly from thin air and threw
it directly into the heart of one of the
two remaining Yakuza behind the bar he
dropped to the ground dead instantly
leaving only his friend alive in a bar
full of corpses that's when Abel noticed
a decorative katana behind the bar he
smiled and ordered the surviving Yakuza
Soldier to pick up the sword and give
him a real fight the hapless monster
realized in that moment that this this
guy was truly crazy whoever he was but
what choice did he have now with Tara in
his heart the last surviving Yakuza
grabbed the katana and uncheathed it
good Abel said his voice deep and
menacing now come fight me let's see if
you last a few seconds longer than your
worthless friends shall we he did not
the second the Yakuza ran towards Abel
and the ancient swordsman swiped at him
with one of his blades cutting through
the katana and the opponent holding it a
puny gangster never stood a chance
against a deadly Immortal Warrior and
Abel was Furious the last time he was
here he faced a truly expert killer who
even managed to end Abel's life in a
single combat and now he was slaying
insects in a karaoke bar pathetic
suddenly his ears pricked up he turned
to see a red ax flying at his head at
incredible speeds with his superhuman
reflexes he managed to dodge just in
time but the ax don't cleaved off a
chunk of his hair as it passed Abel
could see the one who threw it standing
at the entrance to the bar it was the
blood fiend power that made the ax out
of her own blood standing next to her
were denji and Aki denji wielding an ax
and Aki stoically observing damn Miss
makima promised we do karaoke at this
bar if I beat you Dungy said you're
going down for this Abel smiled and
pulled out another pair of blades
finally he roared Warriors who fight the
old-fashioned way I feared the years had
stolen you all from me power step
forward producing another Blood Ax from
nowhere she yelled tremble in fear Abel
tis I your arch nemesis
Mighty power hour Abel had literally
never seen her before and as thousands
of years of life but he appreciated that
these warriors were at least able to
match his level of drama as far as he
was concerned the fight was on but even
Abel didn't know the level of fighting
he was getting in for here as he charged
forward the trio split immediately
surrounding him good tactics Abel
thought to himself already this was
promising Aki who had remained quiet up
to this point attacked first he drew a
tatano knife from his suit jacket and
slashed at Abel with impressive speed
but unlike three of the other combatants
in this situation Aki was only human
which gave him a serious disadvantage
Abel decided it would be best to put him
out of commission first with a quick and
brutal kick to the chest Aki was thrown
against the wall with the majority of
his ribs broken revved up by his own
bloodlust Abel turned to dengian power
and grin like a maniac this was already
the most fun he'd had in a long time who
are these people doesn't matter he
thought they'll be soon anyway while
Abel was still locked in thought power
pulled out a comically large Hammer made
out of her own blood and brought it down
towards Abel he was surprised by the
sudden attack did this girl have the
same weapon producing Powers as him this
just keeps getting more interesting this
is the end table power screen does the
hammer came down you have once again
been defeated by the mighty power again
just to clarify these two had never met
each other but it was already too late
Abel punched upwards his clenched fist
colliding with the hammer he hit it with
such terrifying force that powers blood
Hammer shattered against his knuckles in
that same instant Abel noticed Genji
running at him with an ax from behind
Abel produced another obsidian dagger
and threw it into denji's forehead
dropping him to the ground immediately
pathetic power tried to produce another
weapon but she used up too much blood
already before she had a chance to make
anything substantial Abel sprung
forwards with terrifying speed trying to
land a killing blow but even weakened
power was freakishly fast she was able
to dodge his blow and kick him in the
ribs momentarily stunning him of course
she took the time to gloat putting her
hands on her hips and laughing
victoriously need a second to catch your
breath
she grandulously announced perhaps you
should just give up and agree to become
my servant
I might even teach you a thing or two
about fighting suddenly what was
standing right in front of her squeezing
her throat with his iron grip he smiled
flashing teeth and said if you want to
kill kill don't talk with a surprisingly
minimal amount of strength he squeezed
and heard a crunch from power's neck he
dropped her limp body to the ground
lucky for power Abel wasn't aware that a
fiend-like power can survive an injury
like this as long as she's fed some more
blood instead he just sighed in
disappointment is that all you weaklings
have to offer he bellowed Aki barely
conscious after being kicked against the
wall remain just conscious enough to
activate his contract with a Powerful
Beast known as the fox devil he twists
his hands into a strange gesture and
Whispers the word con before falling
unconscious but that's still enough
suddenly a gigantic demonic Fox claw
burst through the wall of the bar
spraying dust and Rubble everywhere Abel
was definitely not expecting that he
dodged several times as the claw swiped
for him often barely missing him for its
last strike it launched forward and
raked four claw marks across his chest
Abel was shocked by the sudden pain it
felt fantastic he pulled a long obsidian
spear out of one of his pocket
dimensions and forced it down through
the fox Devil's paw and into the ground
pinning it in place after a moment of
thrashing the claw dissipated into smoke
lending Abel another Victory though even
he would admit this was a more exciting
fight than the other ones had been was
that it had he gained total Victory once
more just like he so often did these
days he was about to take pity on
himself when denji rose up behind him
how about a rematch then she asked Abel
grinned he liked this kid challenged me
child Abel said well since you asked
denji smirked denji reached into his
shirt and grabbed the ripcord emerging
from his chest it was time to go into
overdrive on this thing he gave it a
mighty yank and like the Rev of a
chainsaw the madness began denji
transformed giant blades emerging from
his arms and his head transformed into a
toothy saw blade nightmare he gave a
mechanical Roar that spewed smoke this
wasn't just Dungey anymore this was
chainsaw man now this Abel thought
feeling his adrenaline spike is more
like it following denji's lead Abel
reached into one of his pocket
dimensions and pulled out one of his
favorite weapons one he'd only
previously used against the mighty hard
to destroy reptile
scp-682 the chainsaw Claymore a huge
two-handed sword with the eternally
twisting shredding teeth of a chainsaw
ever circulating around it it was time
for chainsaw vs chainsaw what the hell
are you waiting for chainsaw man Roar
are we gonna stand around all day or are
we gonna fight Abel couldn't have said
it better himself the two charged at one
another at lightning speeds chainsaw
clashing against chain sword the sheer
force of the contact was enough to send
a shock wave blasting through the bar it
rapidly became a power struggle each of
them trying hard to force their
chainsaws out of the stalemate realizing
that this time he perhaps couldn't win
with raw strength able back flipped away
to reassess his options but chainsaw man
had no intention of giving Abel time to
think about it he darted towards Abel
with the weight and momentum of a
runaway freight train if able hadn't
raised his Claymore to Perry it would
have been shredded to Pieces by the
devil's saws in an instant instead the
two of them rocketed out of the nearby
wall in a Cascade of debris causing
everyone on the outside Street to run
for their lives the two quickly stood
from the stumble the two quickly stood
up catching their breath impressive Abel
said you're much better than the others
instead of replying denji briefly
retracted his arm chainsaws and grabbed
a nearby parked car throwing it directly
at Abel Abel reacted quickly leaving the
car in half with his Claymore and
charging for chainsaw man again just
before Abel could land a lethal strike
chainsaw man deployed his chainsaws
again blocking the blow Abel sped around
him trying to strike again and again but
chainsaw man blocked every strike with
stunning efficacy Abel was astonished
few had ever been able to go Toe to Toe
with him like this before he could feel
his heart pounding gloriously in his
chest he would give denji A Warrior's
death for the Furious yell Abel brought
down the chainsaw Claymore for a
devastating vertical strike but chainsaw
man was ready he arranged his arm
chainsaws in a cross formation like a
giant pair of scissors and caught Abel's
chain sword between them chainsaw man
pulled his arms in opposite directions
slicing Abel's mighty sword in half the
immortal swordsman skidded backwards to
avoid the Fallout producing two smaller
blades immediately this chainsaw man
just kept exceeding expectations didn't
he Abel would need to change tactics if
he wanted to win this one chainsaw man
was impressed by the speed and tenacity
of his Foe for someone who apparently
wasn't even a devil Abel sure packed a
hell of a punch did he ever run out of
those damned weapons though attempting
to answer chainsaw man's question for
him Abel began running around his flank
rapidly producing and throwing blades
and axes in a startling volley chainsaw
man was able to use his chainsaw arms
and face to block most of them but not
all of them several daggers and small
throwing axes splattered into the tender
flesh of Chainsaw Man's Chest Abel had
successfully wounded him and he wasn't
done feeling a little more confident now
Abel decided to take a different tactic
he produced a large spiked mace from
thin air and ran at chainsaw man while
the devil was still recovering from his
projectile attack with one brutal whack
he sent denji flying down the street
carving a rut into the concrete beneath
him but Abel wasn't done while chainsaw
man was still trying to recover Abel
leaped on to him and began beating him
into the ground with his mace the
strikes were so brutal they shook the
Earth and sent cracks across the
surrounding ground then Abel stopped he
realized for a moment that he was
letting his bloodlust get the better of
him this was dishonorable where would be
the fun in beating this boy to death
while he lay on the ground and depriving
himself of one of the greatest opponents
he's had in quite some time no that
would not do it all he'd give him one
more chance on your feet boy Abel said
you fight well get up and carry on I
won't let a beast as rare as you die
like a common dog rise and fight me and
Chainsaw man did as he was told Abel was
shocked to see the very ground shatter
underneath him as chainsaw man burst up
through it all his swords at the ready
the mace was thrown from Abel's hands as
chainsaw man launched up towards him all
metal teeth and fury luckily for Abel he
pulled out a battle ax just in time to
block the flurry of brutal strikes from
the patron saint of chainsaws now this
was a fight even Musa she would be proud
of yes Boy Yes Abel yelled this is true
combat chainsaw man replied with the
swing of his blades which Abel was
nearly able to dodge the two finally
landed back down on the ground and Abel
was fast enough to bury his battle ax
and Chainsaw man's shoulder before the
devil could return a blow to Abel the
anomalous swordsman pulled out a pair of
his favorite swords and locked chainsaw
man's arms in place chainsaw man was
undeniably incredibly powerful but it
looked like Abel's Superior experience
and tactics might save him this time
what the hell are you chainsaw landlord
you've been a worthy opponent boy those
are feeling fine between Abel said I'll
remember you for this but before Abel
could execute a killing blow he felt a
blood red throwing ax stick into his
back Abel winced in pain to see Power
and Aki about 30 feet behind him power
was propping Aki up he donated some of
his blood to bring her back to life and
she was just as delusionally cocky as
ever Abel was about to say something but
he already made a fatal mistake letting
his guard down before another word could
pass the cursed Warrior's lips one of
Chainsaw man's armed chainsaws passed
directly through his heart tearing it
apart with enable's chest it was a
sudden and decisive killing blow
chainsaw man pulled his saw back out of
Abel's chest stained with the deadly
anomaly's blood Abel collapsed to the
ground wheezing and bleeding profusely
from the hole in his chest but strangely
as power Aki and Chainsaw man converged
around him they realized he was smiling
thank you Abel said and died yet again
with the battle won like an Incredible
Hulk made of metal chainsaw man
transformed back into denji the trio
stood around Abel's corpse deeply
confused as to what had just happened if
this was the kind of thing the SCP
Foundation normally dealt with they all
silently agree that perhaps it would be
better not to get involved with them
future except power of course who said
you two should be thanking me for
defeating him
you both owe me drinks for this hundreds
of miles away in a black sarcophagus
deep underwater surrounded by
professional SCP Foundation divers
Abel's body once again returned who
knows how long he'd remained sleeping in
there but what we do know is that his
deathless sleep was suffused with the
sweet dreams knowing that this world
still held were the opponents and for
Abel that was everything reality warmers
real pieces of work aren't they it's one
thing when an anomaly is all Claws and
fangs like scp-682 or if their attack of
choice is snapping necks like SCP-173
but it is an entirely different story if
an anomaly can turn the air you breathe
into chocolate pudding or shove you into
a pocket Dimension that looks almost
like our own reality except everyone is
just a walking talking pile of spiders
see what I mean reality warpers real
handfuls though of course not all
reality warpers are created
some are relatively weak only affecting
the world around them in a mild ambient
fashion others can rattle whole
Dimensions with their tremendous power
the same also goes for Morality some
reality warpers are loving and
benevolent such as scp-343 the kindly
old all-powerful being known to some as
God and some are pure evil beings who
want nothing more than to use their
immense power to sow chaos and misery
among everyone else and personally we
can't think of a better example of the
latter than Bill Cipher from Gravity
Falls this demonic Dorito wants nothing
more than to take over our Dimension and
rebuild it in His image of absolute
Insanity so naturally we started
wondering if these two reality warping
Titans
scp-343 and Bill Cipher ever came to
blows who would win we were so curious
in fact that we fired up the animatron
6000 our state-of-the-art simulation
supercomputer to see how exactly the two
might meet and how their epic battle
would play out who do you think would
take the coveted W on this one let us
know down in the comments along with any
other out of universe what-if situations
you'd love to see but in the meantime
let's fire up the machine be warned
folks it's gonna get weird the date was
July 12 2013. for scp-343 it had started
out as a relatively normal day he'd
spent the night playing Solitaire on the
astral plane before warping back into
his humanoid containment cell by morning
leaving the foundation on the wiser
after all he was really here voluntarily
if the foundation had truly wanted to
try to confine him here they were
welcome to give it a go but it would be
about as effective as trying to catch a
whisper in a butterfly net while God had
come to this place to experience the
joyful illusion of giving up control it
truly was little more than an allusion
to him if he wanted to he could
exterminate the SCP Foundation in less
than an afternoon then retire to Burger
King for a Whopper so really they're all
just lucky he is a benevolent being more
interested in hanging out than
dispensing wrath on those he perceived
as insolent that was Old Testament him
he'd done a lot of soul-searching and
growth since then they'd been at least a
millennium since he'd smote anyone for
that matter and the last guy really had
it coming however today was going to be
a little different God knew that
something was going to happen today he
sensed a great source of energy emerging
something dark and malevolent he sighed
and he closed his eyes for a moment
focusing himself he knew whatever the
nature of this threat it would fall upon
him to face and destroy it how
irritating he was hoping to finally
binge stranger things today elsewhere
inside 19 things seemed to be
inordinately peaceful there hadn't been
any containment breaches or new
anomalies brought in there hadn't been
any attacks from rival groups of
interest Dr bright hadn't even done
anything stupid or started any fires to
borrow an old cliche it was quiet too
quiet perhaps the only person who wasn't
having a relatively mellow day was
security officer Frederick Simmons a
mid-level guard who'd been stationed at
site 19 for four years now he just
wasn't really feeling himself today the
work didn't bother Simmons emotionally
at least typically even after seeing
rather traumatic things or being in
near-death situations while in
containment breaches it hadn't left any
lingering effects but lately he'd been
having the strangest dreams it always
played out the same way shortly after
going to sleep he'd open his eyes in a
strange multi-colored void surrounded by
bizarre seemingly random floating
objects none of which seemed to have any
real relevance to him or his life and
just when he'd begin to question it the
other recurring element of the dream
would occur out of the shimmering oil
slick rainbow of mine boggling colors a
strange being would suddenly emerge a
glowing Golden Triangle almost like a
drawing of a pyramid the Eye of
Providence with a stove pipe hat a
little bow tie thin black arms and legs
and most notable of all a single large
eye with a slit pupil staring out from
the center the eye almost seemed to have
a strange hypnotic quality to it Simmons
felt Bewitched whenever he looked into
it he wasn't afraid quite the opposite
actually for reasons he couldn't
understand this strange creature from
the world of Dreams seemed like a good
friend of his he said well well well
well well well if it isn't my number one
guy the Fred Meister in the house I
missed you have you missed me put her
there good buddy The Entity extended his
hand and Simmons shook it the foundation
guard could feel a strange tingling
sensation jolting down his arm the first
time Simmons had encountered The Entity
he'd told him his name
Bill Cipher and he told him how
incredibly important it was that Simmons
kept their little nighttime meetings a
secret in Exchange bill was here to
listen Simmons would spend his time in
the mindscape pouring out his worries
and frustrations with his daily work as
bill paid impeccable attention the
strange Little Dream entities seemed
fascinated by the work Sim instead all
the peculiar and wondrous anomalies he
guarded at site 19. but to Simmons it
was all just boring work zombie creating
Supernatural plague doctors and Immortal
men with metal limbs lose their shine
after you see them day in day out for
years on end frankly Simmons needed a
day off but he'd already used up all his
PTO when he'd gotten the flu earlier
that year he just didn't know what to do
luckily for him Bill had a solution bill
as it turned out had a fancy little
ability he could occupy the body of a
human being and operate it for them bill
could take the wheel while Simmons took
a load off in the mindscape how hard
could standing around pretending to look
busy at the SCP Foundation really be as
Bill explained the offer to him Simmons
couldn't really see any flaws in his
reasoning after all bill was a friend
why would he have any ill will towards
him with that he shook hands with the
bizarre Supernatural triangle and felt
the sudden rough sensation of having his
Consciousness ripped from his body only
for Bill to Slither in and take his
place the new Simmons the bill occupied
Simmons opened up his demonic yellow
eyes and grinned he gave a demented
laugh to Simmons floated disembodied
Soul
oh man he said wiping away a tear of
laughter with Simmons finger with your
body I can use the SCP foundation's
technology to take over the Multiverse
see ya sucker and with one last demented
chuckle Bill left for work at the SCP
Foundation with Simmons being the latest
in his long line of need puppets after
arriving at site 19 he sneaked through
the facility knowing exactly where he
needed to be you see Bill is a native
entity of the second dimension the world
of flat shapes but he's able to access
the minds of beings in the third
dimension like us through the medium of
the mindscape rather than the Physical
Realm Bill's life goal has always been
to find a way to permeate and take over
the third dimension turning it into his
personal playground all he needed was
the right anomaly to bring him forth
into our world in this case a little
anomalous device favored by Dr Kane
pathos Crow
scp-158 also known as the soul extractor
while Dr Crow Left To the courtyard for
his evening walkies the being that most
people assumed was Fred Simmons secreted
himself into scp-158's containment
chamber and locked the door behind him
he didn't have much time he'd need to do
this perfectly if he wanted a real
chance at taking over the universe he
was amused by the irony at the least the
fact that in order to take over he
needed to sneak into the midst of the
people most likely to destroy him still
where's the fun in life with no risk at
scp-158's control console he inputted
the data to Soul extraction and set a
timer however there was one difference
between this and the usual procedures
performed with the soul extractor there
was no containment receptacle on the
other end whatever was extracted would
just be released into the world and this
was exactly what bill was counting on he
laid Simmons body down on the gurney and
watched with Glee as the robotic arm
lowered towards him it reached into his
chest and pulled out the essence of one
three-sided threat to
Bill Cipher one quick Journey Through
the bowels of the machine later the
nightmare scenario had come to pass Bill
floated around the room dragged into
physical reality he let out a long
conceited cackle and spun his Cane
around this was going to be fun
Elsewhere on the facility alarms were
going off and guards were deploying
nobody was meant to be in containment
chamber 158 so how was the soul
extractor currently operating this
couldn't possibly end well bill on the
other end was having a wonderful time it
was pondering all the different ways he
could make the draft clinical corridors
of the SCP Foundation into his vision of
perfect weirdness maybe he turned all
the researchers into mice and turned
site 19 into a giant maze to run them
through maybe he turned the air into
farts and released winged beasts from
the hell Dimension to ravage Humanity
maybe he'd go out into the parking lot
and key everyone's cars oh the
Diabolical possibilities were endless as
he floated out into the Hall his
fantasizing was interrupted by a group
of foundation security operatives
wielding assault rifles they entered an
attack formation and trained their
rifles on him before opening fire bill
just found himself laughing again the
gunfire just tickled wow you guys are
hilarious Bill said between fits of
laughter but wait
he snapped his fingers and suddenly the
guards were transformed instead of the
serious first line of defense for the
SCP Foundation they were now a gang of
literal clowns straight from the circus
holding balloon animals molded into the
shapes of assault rifles they giggled
and threw pies at each other bill was
right this did make them even funnier
and he was just getting started turning
this Foundation snooze Fest into a party
of cosmic proportions Bill began running
a rampage of weirdness across the site
essentially being the ultimate Cosmic
troll he decided he'd simply bother
every single anomaly he could with his
demonic Antics first he appeared in
scp-096's chamber and pulled a brown
paper bag over his head with the words
ugliness lies within written on the
front and just for fun he then
teleported the temperamental Beast to a
nearby Amish community it quickly became
enraged when a gust of wind blew the bag
off its head and a man named Jebediah
saw its face it then killed several
others also named Jebediah during the
Rampage Bill thought it was hilarious he
then released scp-682 into site 19 and
just to annoy the creature into further
violence he stuck in indestructible
party hat on the monster's head no
matter how hard 682 tried it couldn't
remove the party hat this caused it
great frustration which it took out on
any foundation staff it happened to find
in the area it had fulfilled Bill's
expectations wonderfully but his quest
for amusing Carnage didn't end there
next he went to bother scp-049 the
plague doctor who was in the process of
doing surgery on a foundation-provided
dead goat with a snap of his fingers
Bill transformed the plague doctor's
surgical tools into colorful Play-Doh
cutting tools needless to say the
supernatural surgeon was less than
pleased he was about as annoyed as Dr
clef was when bill turned his favorite
shotgun into a bouquet of flowers then
sealed his feet into the floor or how
Vex Dr gears was when bill turned his
plain beige necktie into a considerably
more loud and colorful tie people there
at the time reported hearing Dr gear say
I just don't think that was necessary oh
and he also did some more minor acts of
malice he filled the break room with an
army of flesh-eating zombies he made a
mode filled with molten lava around the
site that prevented anyone from escaping
from his reign of terror and he even
covered all the walls in cognito
hazardous Doodles that instantly drove
any weak-minded human who saw them into
complete gibbering Madness it was clear
this reality warping nightmare needed to
be stopped before he got bored of
playing with his new Foundation toys and
decided to go remodel the universe in
his own image thankfully there was one
anomaly on site who was up to the task
bill was treating himself to another
evil laugh in the site 19 canteen when
something peculiar happened he looked
down to see a man in what looked like a
tunic with graying hair and a beard he
won with a peculiar kind of calmness his
face blank why wasn't the sky panicking
was he stupid bill would seemingly need
to teach this guy a thing or two about
fear hey Grant don't know if it's
escaped your attention but I've been
giving this place an Extreme Makeover
did you forget to put on your glasses
this morning or are you just that senile
The Stranger remained calm as could be
he replied with a voice that was
measured as it was deep now Bill let's
not resort to name-calling that's just
childish don't you think Bill's single
eye widened at this wait wait hold up
how did you know my name Bill asked
irritated are you a friend of the time
baby or something he floated over and
began circling the stranger hoping to
intimidate him much to Bill's
frustration it didn't appear to be
working I know lots of things Bill lots
of things The Stranger replied that's my
line Bill screeched turning red who Do
You Think You Are The Stranger gave a
quiet Reserve chuckle that infuriated
Bill oh personally I just like to think
of myself as a humble Craftsman watching
his beautiful creation play out he said
but I suppose some of the people around
here like to call me God
Bill didn't like this this whole
universe was going to be his and he
certainly didn't appreciate some insulin
old man acting like he ran the roost
around here bill would give him an
education in who was really holding the
Reigns and it would be the kind of
education that left scars if it left
anything at all he extended his spindly
black arms and released bolts of
lightning against the stranger who
simply continued to smile as the
electricity rippled around him seemingly
causing no effect are you done the
stranger asked Bill laughed hoping to
hide his irritation I'm just getting
started he bow out with a thunderous
Roar that shook the very foundations of
site 19. Bill began to grow and shift no
longer a silly little triangle he became
a huge Red Pyramid of pure nightmares
covered in glowing Golden Arms and teeth
with long black tongues drooping out of
each level it was the most terrifying
and demonic form in his entire Arsenal
and yet he was astonished to find that
the stranger still didn't seem to show
any kind of fear very impressive build
the stranger said sounding almost bored
but I think you might be trying a little
too hard oh that does it bill would
simply have to destroy him it was a
matter of Pride now he raised several of
his huge golden fists and began pounding
down on the comparatively tiny humanoid
stranger it was an assault so powerful
that the ground began cracking around
their feet and yet it seemed that with
almost no effort The Stranger was able
to intercept and block every single will
blow naturally bill was infuriated it
was time to finally unleash the full
breadth of his power on this beardy wise
guy he launched Thunderbolts Fireballs
Legions of giant mutant wasps hailstorms
maelstroms bubbles of pure Madness
snakes made out of barbed wire and even
incredible coarse language but despite
it all this man the one who claimed
people called him God was utterly
unfazed you can dish it out he said but
let's see if you can take it Bill began
to laugh what the heck's that supposed
to mean you can't gone snapped his
fingers and Bill was gone vanished and
with a flick of his wrist all the damage
and Transformations that Bill had
performed had disappeared it was as
though the Demonic triangle had never
even been there in the first place
though Dr bright who was acting site
director at the time had some Scranton
reality anchors turned on around the
perimeter just to be safe you can never
be too careful with reality warping
demons after
later that day Dr bright approached God
and asked him what he'd actually done
with Bill God chuckle then replied for a
being of such immense power he really
had a rather childish mindset so I
zealed him away inside a children's
cartoon where he couldn't do any further
damage what was the cartoon Dr bright
asked a Charming little Disney show
called Gravity Falls the animatron 6000.
you know what it is and what it does not
too long ago we had it simulate a battle
between the SCP Foundation and the slimy
Sinister superhero homelander who
terrorizes the world of the boys and in
the comments we kept seeing one name pop
up omniman the terrifying almost
Unstoppable viltermite Warrior who
scared the hell out of all of us in
invincible so we decided to run a
simulation to see if the SCP Foundation
could find the same success battling
this diabolical corrupted Superman the
video you're about to see is that
simulation enjoy and keep an eye on the
skies it was Unthinkable Panic had
spread throughout the foundation as
reports came in that several of the most
high-profile groups of Interest across
the globe had suffered unbearably brutal
attacks from an unknown assailant
notable among the groups targeted were
GOC Global occult Coalition as well as
its opposing organization the Serpent's
hand in all incidents key buildings
belonging to the groups were demolished
and the bodies of all leadership
Personnel were discovered beaten to a
pulp these massacres appeared to send a
terrifying message whoever was behind
these attacks the foundation was most
likely next on The Chopping Block as all
containment sites prepared for the worst
it was site 17 that received subsequent
news on the matter in the most
unsettling way imaginable a small flying
object was discovered in the science
airspace and retrieved by an MTF issue
helicopter the object appeared to be an
action figure of world-renowned
superhero omniman and it bore the
trademark of Dr wondertainment toys the
mobile task force that discovered the
action figure had been on such high
alert that the appearance of this toy
almost seemed comical there was uneasy
laughter within the helicopter which
immediately turned to silence when the
toy began to speak boys and girls for
the very first time Dr wondertainment
presents to you run
your lives on the man is coming for us
all the toy continued what was
apparently a pre-recorded voiceover
which became increasingly frightened and
desperate as it went along the contents
of the recording confirmed that the one
responsible for the devastation of the
other groups of Interest was none other
than omniman himself his reasons for
doing this were unknown but he seemed
adamant on wiping out all groups with
significant control over the planet's
anomalies whoever was in charge at Dr
wondertainment had uncovered the truth
shortly before omniman arrived to do the
same to their group and had deployed the
toy in a last-ditch effort to warn the
SCP Foundation it was an
uncharacteristically opaque gesture from
the terrible toy maker but the
foundation had little choice but to take
it seriously if Earth's most powerful
superhero had really gone Rogue and was
going after influential organizations in
some bid to eliminate competition the
foundation would have to develop
appropriate countermeasures as soon as
possible the first priority was securing
the safety of the o5 council who would
most likely be the intended victims of
omniman's Rampage fortunately their
current location was extremely
classified so rather than shuffled to a
new location the council chose to stay
where they were a conspicuous relocation
process could inadvertently give the
game away especially if the aptly named
ah reductive it just launched us into
space procedure was in effect omniman
was known for his space-faring
capabilities and was fully capable of
pursuing and boarding the o5 council's
getaway shuttle if such a thing was
attempted additionally there would be no
movement of forces to the location of
the o5 council mobile task forces that
were already in the field would be
instructed to immediately cease their
current Mission and focus on locating
omniman while the superhero was
incredibly dangerous it was Paramount
that valuable time was bought so that a
better attack plan could be formulated
that was one advantage that the the
foundation had over most of the other
groups of Interest the reserves to
prolong a war of attrition no matter how
strong the enemy was there was also the
matter of establishing protections for
site 17. since wondertainment had sent
the action figure there of all places to
deliver the message it was likely that
omniman would be headed there first
sight staff requested the immediate
transfer of the infamous mobile task
force tal 5 samsara a unit of immortal
cyborgs with superhuman physiology while
omniman was known to have fought and
defeated everything from the spawn of
ancient gods to cyborgs to Immortals the
four members of samsara were all three
and had strength in numbers the requests
remained pending for several minutes
causing one researcher to blithely
remark that the o5 council had probably
called dibs fearing that MTF tal 5
wouldn't arrive to intercept omniman the
researchers assessed which anomalies
contained on site would be best suited
to holding the superhero back one
ketterclass SCP and particular
immediately came to mind
scp-4051 a male humanoid with the
anomalous ability to create
extra-dimensional wormholes these
wormholes could be used to produce any
object that has scp-4051 desired
including exceedingly unstable Cognito
hazards while scp-4051's Powers were
certainly formidable it was the fact
that the humanoid who went by the name
Rainier Miller had previously been
acting as a vigilante in the United
States in other words Rainier Miller was
likely to be of special interest to
omniman even if that interest merely
amounted to having one more Target to
wipe out while it wouldn't be the only
humanoid SCP that could be considered
similar to a superhero 4051 was
definitely the closest at hand not too
long after the discussion took place the
site Radars began to pick up omniman
closing in his approach was
extraordinarily fast breaking through
the sound barrier and Landing with great
force in the center of site 17 teen
there was no time to waste and all
available guards and mobile Task Force
personnel were ordered to zero in on
omnimance location and open fire as one
might expect bullets weren't exactly
effective against the superhero turned
serial killer but they did provide a
plausible distraction while the
researchers mobilized to find other
means of neutralizing omniman it was a
terrifying sight watching the costume
man stand there within a hail of bullets
bearing no outward signs of distress
aside from a Stern facial expression
they moved smoothly through the air
towards the nearest Soldier and
shattered every rib with a single punch
he then grabbed another and used him to
bludgeon several other agents even with
the substantial advantage in raw power
there was a considered tactical reason
for each of omniman's movements he
systematically made his way through the
sight crushing all within his path with
absolute Prejudice there were going to
be no survivors if this continued
fortunately one of these site 17 in
other contingencies was about to come
into play you see the foundation had
done their research and with the
corroboration of information from other
groups including the United States
government had deduced that omniman
might have psychological weaknesses that
could be exploited namely his teenage
son Mark otherwise known by his
superhero Alias Invincible while the
foundation was far too cautious to
directly contact Invincible mostly out
of fear that the boy could be an
accomplice the next best thing could
still stall omniman and give the
researchers a chance to get scp-4051
ready for combat it certainly took
omniman by surprise when he was floating
down one of the newly blood-soaked
corridors and saw Invincible standing at
the end staring him down Dad what's
going on why are you hurting them said
what appeared to be Mark omniman stopped
in his place and his expression changed
to a look of concern for the first time
since he arrived at site 17 omniman
spoke Mark come on Tab this is crazy you
should stop this and go back home to Mom
Omni man froed his brow something was
off here for one this version of
invincible had both feet on the ground
even though he would have all the same
powers of his father also the fact that
Invincible had an approach suggested
that this individual was in such fear of
omni man that it refused to approach
omniman had been caught off guard by
this at first worried that his son could
be afraid of him to this extent but it
was starting to seem suspicious Mark was
no coward he had become a superhero like
his father because he wanted to protect
the world from all manner of threats
although the difference in combat
experience between the two was fast
omniman knew that the Invincible he knew
was Reckless enough to challenge him or
at least have this conversation at a
regular distance his intuition was right
on the money as this was not Invincible
at all but scp-953 the polymorphic
humanoid instead while this ketter class
SCP was known for taking many forms
usually that of beautiful women the
foundation staff had given it access all
available information on omniman and
invincible's father-son relationship and
in doing so successfully convinced it
that taking the form of omniman's son
was the best path towards
self-preservation during this perilous
scenario
scp-953 continued to make attempts at
talking to omniman doing its best to
remain still not wanting to reveal the
volpine features beneath the Invincible
costume it was wearing but omniman
proved to be too clever for this Gambit
he chuckled then suddenly zoomed forward
with his fist raised in front of him
scp-953 flinched in Terror only to find
that omniman had pulled his punch at
first scp-953 was relieved to still be
intact but this soon dissipated as the
humanoid looked at Omni man and found
none of the compassion that was on his
face just moments ago you're not Mark
omnimant said he's stronger than this
scp-953 trembled in fear the polymorph
humanoid only had one card left to play
and it prayed that it worked 953
shapeshifted again this time into Omni
man's wife Debbie her fox-like features
were more pronounced in this form but it
was clear that the sight of his human
partner's face made omniman hesitant to
attack this hesitation was all the time
that the polymorphic humanoid needed to
run away as several guards and scp-4051
arrived to take over the duty of
stalling omniman several wormholes
opened up a round Omni man deploying
Sonic grenade which stunned him for
several seconds the guards Unleashed all
of their ammo and Drew omniman's
aggression while Rainier prepared his
next weapon a wormhole to a pocket
Dimension filled with flamethrowers
which he directed at omniman hoping to
at least cause some lasting pain if not
proper burns the Flames did temporarily
obscure his vision but that didn't
hinder him for long as omniman moved
straight upwards through the ceiling
before descending back down into the
building massacring the guards
surrounding as cp4 4051 he looked on
Rainier with disdain especially as the
humanoid opened a wormhole and pulled
out an aluminum baseball bat you really
think a piece of Earthling sports
equipment is going to do anything to me
Omni man said it doesn't matter if it
does or doesn't when you replied you're
not the hero you once were and someone
has to try to stop you omniman paused
reminded of his own son though mere
sentiment wouldn't be to spare Rainier
Miller the fate of the rest of his
planet and its people but Rainier opened
a wormhole directly in front of himself
which contained multiple anti-tank
rifles that fired an omni man's
Direction the impact didn't faze omniman
but it slowed the superhero down just
enough for Rainier to tuck and roll
behind him renier reached into another
Wormhole for a gas mask which he quickly
dawned as another one of his wormholes
unleash deadly poison gas into the
corridor omniman held his breath and
flew towards Rainier grabbing his
aluminum bat mid-swing and bending it
into an l-shape without any apparent
effort Rainier let go of his weapon but
on me man quickly grabbed him by the
wrist and lifted him into the air before
slamming him down on the ground Rainier
Miller
scp-4051 was incapacitated perhaps
fatally before omniman could confirm his
kill he was tackled and immediately
thrown to the nearest wall by the
combined force of four individuals in
cybernetic Armor mobile task force
Tunnel 5 samsara had arrived and
together they surrounded omniman and hid
him with everything they had punches and
kicks bombarded him from all angles
offering barely any window for a
response the formation didn't last long
as omniman withstood the hits and
maneuvered behind one of the members of
samsara grabbing and snapping the
Cyborg's neck in one quick motion one of
its fellow members swung from Omni man's
face only for him to catch the blow and
severely batter the arm of the attacker
rendering it unusable omniman grabbed
the last two members by the throats and
squeezed until he heard the familiar pop
and crack then he let their bodies fall
of course this wasn't enough to
neutralize samsara completely the
cyborgs were down but not out as their
fast regeneration began to fix their
injuries with detached contempt omniman
stomped forcefully on their heads
shattering the skulls of each member of
samsara one by one that should be a lot
harder to fix omniman thought to himself
he was almost finished here then it
would be on to the next containment site
and eventually to the o5 council itself
his Planet wouldn't need meddlesome
groups like The SCP Foundation made up
of inferior humans playing at
civilization he made sure they knew how
powerless they were before the rest of
the people of viltrum arrived to
complete the conquest of Earth he
applauded the short-lived bravery of
Rainier Miller and in an
uncharacteristic moment of Mercy chose
not to go back and check if his previous
opponent had truly been killed omniman
rationalized that he had already
inflicted a killing blow but deep down
as he concluded his Rampage through site
17 and departed for the sight of his
next Slaughter he knew that he had
subconsciously gave the boy a chance to
live well hello there SCP fans let's get
this out of the way first you've seen
the title and thumbnail and you're
probably wondering wait is siren had an
SCP and the answer is no siren head is
not an SCP it's a freaky internet
monster created by renowned Canadian
horror artist Trevor Henderson your next
question is probably what's with this
crazy looking server Bank behind me
allow me to introduce you to the
anomatron 6000 the latest advancement of
supercomputing owned and operated
exclusively by the SCP Foundation it's
capable of a whole bunch of interesting
features calculating ideal containment
methods running state-of-the-art
Foundation web caller software making an
editing fun SCP YouTube videos but the
most interesting feature that the
animatron has to offer is running hyper
Advanced simulations regarding all
things anomalous with data fed into it
by thousands of real-life experiments
conducted by the SCP Foundation it's
going to save countless dollars and
lives for foundation researchers but way
more importantly it's going to let us
explore all kinds of weird and wacky
what-if scenarios that would never
happen organically could scp-343 beat
Goku or Superman who's a deadlier
supernatural killer
scp-106 or Freddy Krueger would the
world simply explode from adorableness
if scp-999 and baby Yoda ever crossed
those multiversal barriers and met we
can explore all of these questions along
with any others you may have down in the
comments seriously comment it we dare
you but to get things started we figured
we'd make the animatron pit the
foundation's lankiest nightmare monster
SC 096 against the internet's Trevor
Henderson's siren head sorry Slenderman
you're just not cool anymore so without
further Ado let's kick the animatron
into gear and see how this wild battle
plays out it's time for scp-096 versus
siren head Ricky and Elliott a pair of
aspiring travel YouTubers from
California were taking a vacation to the
Pacific Northwest to spend some time in
the area's beautiful Lush forests
however while the duo were both big fans
of travel for its own sake they weren't
just here for the trees and fresh air
you see despite their jet-setting
lifestyle Ricky and Elliot subscribers
and Views hadn't exactly been phenomenal
lately turns out hiking Vlogs and GoPro
footage of the two of them jumping into
absurdly blue water and Bali weren't
exactly that interesting to people who
weren't actually there but Ricky had
formulated an ingenious plan to pull the
two of them out of obscurity they would
hunt down and film real footage of the
legendary Ironhead a supernatural
monster said to haunt forests and
isolated graveyards there were plenty of
fakers out there on YouTube but if the
two of them could get real footage of
siren head and also preferably survived
the experience they'd be framing their
golden play buttons in no time but they
were already encountering certain issues
for starters the two Californians had
severely underestimated just how cold it
was in the Pacific Northwest and as such
were already shivering from bone deep
cold the second issue was food while the
two of them had thought ahead and
brought a selection of tasty protein
bars they'd also gotten hungry during
the early hours of their walk and eaten
all of them leaving them feeling
severely out of luck by the time dinner
rolled around and the third and perhaps
most problematic issue of all was the
fact that Ricky and Elliot didn't
exactly have a great sense of direction
during all of their previous trips
they'd been on guided tours with local
experts in this instance wanting to take
all the siren head Glory Cloud for
themselves they decided to come in alone
with the incredibly janky Google Maps
app to guide them as such as the Knight
was creeping in the two aspiring YouTube
celebrities had no idea where they were
needless to say it wasn't exactly an
ideal situation and to make matters
worse Ricky and Elliot had been
experiencing some strange feelings for
the last couple of hours when they'd
gotten particularly deep into the forest
that dread-inducing sensation of being
watched by something lurking just out of
sight a gaze with some unknowable and
Darkly malicious intent boiling behind
it these two poor saps had no idea what
was in store for them tonight and
wouldn't you know it the one watching
them right now wouldn't even be the only
monster after them after an expectable
amount of bumbling and buffoonery Ricky
and Elliot managed to gather up enough
Tinder to make a semi-respectable
campfire they could sleep out here
tonight then set off in search of of
siren head or civilization whichever
came first in the daylight the next day
the duo did what they could to remain
chipper in spite of the ominous
circumstances sure they were trapped in
the depths of the woods alone but think
of the amazing Vlog footage they'd get
they'd be like the next Blair Witch crew
except they'd live hopefully but as the
duo sat next to their campfire they felt
that ominous sensation again the hairs
on the back of their neck started
standing up they felt Shivers that
didn't just come from the cold more and
more they started to feel certain that
something in this forest was watching
them something ancient and powerful and
evil that's when they heard The Telltale
crackle of radio static and their
skeletons almost jumped out of their
skin could it be him the patron saints
have gone missing without a trace of
creeping dread of bad things coming
siren head himself both men fell silent
all they could hear was the crackling
their own fire had the sound before just
been an illusion a product of a pair of
paranoid mines also predisposed to sense
siren-headed monsters lurking amongst
the trees they'd been reading about a
higher rate of disappearances in this
area along with a number of frightening
sightings of tall thin beings and radio
static that seemed perfectly consistent
with siren head activity that's why
they'd come here in the first place but
had they come here to their deaths the
two needed to distract themselves or
they'd go mad from the paranoia they
decided to share a few fun little
anecdotes of the travels they'd had
before meeting one another showing the
photos they'd saved on their smartphones
Ricky had been to Hawaii Tahiti Bora
Bora Fiji Saint Lucia and the Maldives
clearly he liked his vacations warm and
Sandy Elliot on the other hand tended to
like his trips to be a little more
adventurous he'd seen volcanoes
waterfalls deep and treacherous cave
systems and of course a little guy
guided mountaineering one photo that
Elliot showed Ricky was particularly
breathtaking he was standing in the
foreground of a snowy landscape with an
incredible mountain range behind him
when Ricky asked Elliot where exactly
he'd taken this picture strangely enough
he drew a complete blank maybe somewhere
in Canada or Siberia or something like
that but it was a hell of a trip
whatever the case he remembered having a
great time it was such a tiny detail but
when looking at the photo Ricky couldn't
help but notice something in the
background a speck of white sure not
exactly newsworthy in the snowy mountain
range but this wasn't snow it was a
speck of white that seemed to be a
slightly different shade than the rest
of the mountain strange perhaps it was
just some tiny particles stuck on the
lens whenever the photo was taken the
two continued to chat and warm their
hands against the fire having no idea of
the horror they just awoken in doing so
over a hundred miles away at an SCP
Foundation containment site researchers
and guards walked around the perimeter
of a huge airtight metal cube rating off
Diagnostics and audio recordings for
reasons that should be obvious to
everyone who's a fan of this channel
there were no camera feeds coming from
the inside of the great metal cube only
a faint whimpering sound like a sad
wounded animal and the clanking of
pacing feet moving back and forth over
the metal dragging fourlorn Knuckles it
turned every head in the room when the
crying started to get louder soon it
wasn't just quiet weeping it was a
series of horrendous slobbering songs
whales of pure pain and despair someone
in the room screamed close your eyes and
hit the deck knowing exactly what had
happened they learned well enough from
the infamous incident
096-1-8 Containment Breach that there
was no way of stopping this thing until
it run its course the best they could do
was minimize their own fatalities in the
process everyone in the room did as they
were told hitting the ground closing
their eyes and covering them with their
hands just to be safe that's when the
solid steel of the cube was torn open
like crepe paper from the howling raging
scp-096 Broke Free Galloping on all
fours through the nearest wall
shattering it and spraying debris
everywhere as mobile task forces were
dispatched to track the rampaging
Abomination and try their best to clear
the path ahead as it sought out its
Target one thought was going through the
minds of everyone in the room woe but
tired of poor fools who saw that
Monster's face back in the deep dark
forests of the Pacific Northwest the
presence of some unnerving force was
becoming far harder to deny for Ricky
and Elliot they heard the sounds of
garbled voices out in the woods the
squeals and crackles of radio static
they saw shapes moving amongst the trees
tall and thin like long spindly limbs
while neither wanted to voice Their Fear
they were both thinking similar things
if there really was a monster out here
why hadn't it killed them it had all the
Time in the World to do it but that was
just it wasn't it it had all the time in
the world so why rush it had every
Advantage it could take its time and do
this exactly how it wanted to Rick and
Elliott had made themselves the perfect
prey and as they saw a huge lith figure
suddenly separated cell from the trees
they began to wonder if it was really
worth it to risk both of their lives for
YouTube Cloud either way it was now
probably too late for regrets Ricky and
Elliot's Jaws fell in horror as the
monster emerged from the darkness before
them they recognized the awful modeled
skin stretched over the monster's
40-foot frame they saw the grasping
hands and up above the nightmarish
faceless head split into a pair of
sirens pointing in different directions
each one filled with gnashing teeth and
slithering tongues it was even more
terrifying than they could possibly have
imagined siren head speakers crackled
into life in his Stout
one child 17 remove file
Ricky and Elliot stumbled backwards as
siren had Advanced its speakers still
bleeding hateful static neither could
move or speak only watch as its long
gnarled fingers reach from the dark to
grasp them there was a terrible pained
whale in the woods after that but it
wasn't coming from Ricky Elliott or
siren head it was distant at first but
soon became louder and louder as the
Force's point of origin came barreling
towards them even siren head couldn't
help but turn to see
scp-096 a flash of terrible white Fury
come charging towards them in the dark
knocking down all the trees in its path
leaves and pine needles scattered trunks
exploded into splinters nothing would
stop the shy guy from claiming its prey
nothing would stop it from destroying
Ricky and now as it approached Elliot
made the Fatal mistake of looking at its
face too 096 lunge ready to go in for
the kill when siren head's hands closed
around the shy guy slender tors so in
one fluid motion with surprising
strength for its scrawny build it hurled
the shy guy into the distance smashing
another several trees in its path the
words
mine mine mine
pissed out of its speakers but 096 was
only down for mere moments it sprung
back up on its hind and four legs and
started Galloping towards Ricky and
Elliot again who were still frozen in
place this time just before the Shy
Guy's terrible claws could close around
the two hapless wannabe YouTubers down
came siren head's clenched fist pounding
096's head into the dirt overhead mobile
task force helicopter circled wearing
their scramble goggles and trying to get
a visual on the situation unfolding
below they could hardly believe what
they were seeing down there with some
other unclassified anomaly managing to
intercept 096 in its rage state only a
handful of anomalies on record have ever
been shown of being capable of such a
feat it seemed that they were dealing
with something serious here down below
the battle continued siren head had a
unique advantage over most other
combatants facing
scp-096 it was an extra dimensional
being with no eyes merely an innate
psychic awareness of its victims around
it not unlike how scp-096 detect people
seeing its face in photographs or videos
without need for any kind of direct
contact as such it was impossible for
siren head to see the shy guy's face and
thus impossible for the shy guy to ever
actually direct its aggression against
it whether or not 096 would kill steel
siren heads intended prey was another
matter entirely in the night's first
minor miracle Ricky and Elliot
remembered that they'd been born with
working legs and decided that right now
would be an excellent time to use them
they turned and began to run while siren
had continued beating the shy guy into
the dirt sprinting with all their might
however the growing distance between
them only aggravated the shy guy further
it sprang out from the dirt with
unstoppable force and broke away from
siren head's grip the shy guy never
wasted time ever it always made a
beeline for its intended victim with one
directive in mind total Annihilation
tonight is no
Ricky and Elliot screamed as they heard
its pounding Gallop on the ground behind
them closer closer closer than suddenly
defying all spatial reasoning siren had
emerged out from the darkness between
Ricky Elliott and 096 being 40 feet tall
siren had dwarfed even the shy guy it
lunged and grabbed the Wailing white
monstrosity holding it as one would a
particularly vicious cat and trying to
keep it in place siren had wanted to
crush the monster's bones and carry on
stalking its feeble human prey who were
currently in the process of getting away
but somehow that was impossible it was
almost like the monster had an
indestructible skeleton up above the
mobile task forces continued observing
this Clash of the Titans from their two
helicopters seeing how siren head was
somehow doing a serviceable job of
subduing the shy guy one of the task
force members joked maybe we should hire
this guy another chimed in I don't think
we have any ballistic vests in his size
the laughter soon turned to screams when
siren had hurled 096's flailing body up
at one of the helicopters with
Incredible Force knocking it out of the
sky it greened down to the ground a ball
of fear and violence before exploding
anyone who survived the initial blast
was unlucky enough to have seen the shy
guy's face their screams rang out
briefly before being abruptly silenced
by the monster helicopter Alpha had no
survivors meanwhile Ricky and Elliot had
kept running until their lungs burned
and their muscles pumped thumbtacks
seeing that the chaos was so far behind
them now they took a moment to stop and
breathe recomposing themselves in the
second minor miracle of the night it
looked like the two of them had actually
survived this ordeal those two horrific
monsters had canceled each other out but
Ricky and Elliot were about to learn a
harsh lesson they really weren't that
lucky the last thing the two of them
ever saw was siren head emerging from
the darkness once more the last thing
they ever felt was the monster's
terrible gnarled fingers curling around
their bodies too fast for them to escape
and the last thing they ever heard was
each other's screams followed by a
sickeningly meaty crunch elsewhere in
the forest
scp-096's whales died down to its usual
mudlin SOB the rage state had ended all
of its targets had been destroyed it
just hadn't been the one to do all the
destroying per se not long after that
helicopter Bravo descended safely and
the remaining MTF members closed around
the blubbering Beast someone black
bagged it and everyone breathed a sigh
of relief knowing that was at least one
monster taken care of tonight what about
the other one the MTF Lieutenant asked
the team's Commander shook his head and
said ah let's worry about that freak
later and get 096 back to containment
this place gives me the creeps hello one
and all and welcome back to the
animatron 6000 our patented device for
projecting any seemingly improbable
scenario for your viewing Indulgence and
today we decided to do something
slightly different with it here at SCP
explained we usually activate the
animatron to bring you encounters
between the anomalous denizens of the
SCP universe and other fictional
characters like Doctor Strange fighting
the Scarlet king or able crossing paths
with Batman but this anomatronic
experiment is one of our more unusual to
say the least if you've been subscribed
to us for a while some of you might
remember our video What If scp-096 was
put inside
scp-914 in it the shy guy was tricked
into entering the input Booth of the
anomalous refinement machine during a
Containment Breach what emerged was
maybe the handsomest man to ever live
Beautiful both on the outside and within
a lot of our comments pointed out that
this refined version of 096 felt akin to
a gigachad and that got us thinking what
if scp-096 was to encounter the real
gigachad well the animatron 6000 has a
few different answers for us scenario
one or as we like to call it but the
obvious outcome pits the thin humanoid
anomaly Against The Man Behind the meme
Ernest kalimov is a Russian fitness
trainer and model forever immortalized
in the annals of Internet history by a
series of black and white photoshopped
pictures that garnered him the nickname
of gigachad thanks to his Practically
Perfect 90 degree jawline and muscular
physique kalimov's seemingly unknowingly
became the archetype for the ultra
masculine handsome man however The Man
Behind the gigachad meme is still just a
man the infamous photos of him were
heavily edited for an art project known
as Sleek in tears and while Ernest does
Sport some impressive muscles from all
his time at the gym that strength isn't
enough to save him from the shy guy
after all he is still just a man
according to the animatron's predictions
the most likely outcome if the two were
ever to meet would end pretty similarly
to the Grim fate of many others who have
gazed upon the face of scp-096 the
moment Earnest looks at the creature he
would in all likelihood activate 096's
rage State his physique and above
average level of Fitness might give him
a slight Advantage allowing him to
perhaps outrun the shy guy for longer
than most but ultimately
Ernest kalamov would be able to run but
not hide from
scp-096 the creature would track him
down and hone in on him with anomalous
speed dispatching him before returning
to its usual docile sobbing State the
result and
scp-096 victory now we know what you're
thinking is that really it we had the
same reaction too but hold on for a
minute after giving the machine an
additional set of variables we were able
to get a few more interesting outcomes
out of the animatron which brings us to
the result that we've given the title of
scenario 2 shy harder of course Ernest
kalimov might be the face of an internet
meme and ultimately just a very strong
Russian man in comparison to the
anomalous traits of SCP 096 but the
gigachad the gigachad is more than a man
so much more than the sum of its parts
existing within the online Zack guys
since as early as 2017 the gigachad is
far more powerful than a mere mortal he
doesn't just represent idealized
standards of over-exaggerated
masculinity like the Action Movie heroes
of the 1980s the gigachad embodies those
ideas he is the very notion of a
physically perfected human specimen
given form you may not like it but Peak
Performance doesn't even come close to
the gigachad and neither does scp-096
even at the top of its game the creature
quite literally pales in comparison to
its imposing opponent in scenario 2 shy
harder the animatron 6000 predicted that
if the two were to meet the scales would
tip in the complete opposite direction
from the first outcome for that was
scp-096 against the man but again the
meme himself while this fight is no
contest as a matter of fact it's hardly
even a fight certainly not a fair one
and instead is more of an execution from
the moment the Unstoppable Tower of
muscle and perfect angular jawline that
is the gigachad clasps eyes on scp-096
it's practically the beginning of the
end the shy guy doesn't even lift brow
but gigachad can bench one million times
his own body weight in his sleep so when
scp-096 comes racing towards him intent
on killing him just for looking at it
screeching wide jogged face the gigachat
does what the Giga Chad does best he
lifts grabbing scp-096 with ease as it
comes to him screeching gigachad
casually hoists the creature off the
ground although he's only using the
tiniest portion of his immense and
Infinite Strength it's more than enough
Force to send the shy guy soaring
upwards crashing through multiple
ceilings as sent hurtling up the
numerous floors of the foundation
facility above of course being lifted is
hardly going to kill the shy guy
outright the creature is known to be
invulnerable after all but it's not like
gigachad can go down easily either don't
forget this is no mere mortal but an
internet meme incarnate and on the
internet nothing ever dies his Perpetual
existence as part of online history
aside the gigachad is so strong that no
doubt his abs could withstand the
Firepower of any conventional weapon
realizing that even if it could reach
him it couldn't even scratch the
gigachad
scp-096 would undoubtedly begin a
downward spiral the shy guy is a
creature so insecure in itself and its
appearance that it kills anyone who so
much has glances at its face in photos
so being presented with the living
embodiment of an idea it could never
even hope to attain the biceps the
perfect right angle jawline it's all
much sending scp-096 into a complete
meltdown the creature would be
neutralized once and for all by the very
existence of the gigachad resulting in
his victory okay so we're one point to
scp-096 and one two gigachad and most
people would maybe consider leaving it
there but not us we wanted more than
that you see we quickly realized that
the animatron's second scenario was
based on a lot of earlier iterations of
the gigachad meme don't get us wrong
that version of the ultimate man could
still easily destroy the shy guy but
around March of 2021 the infamous
photoshopped images of Ernst kalamov
started to be used in slightly different
formats that's the thing about memes
they're not only Immortal forever logged
in the ancient texts of the Wayback
machine and compilation videos here on
YouTube but memes are also adaptable
they can evolve and change finding new
variations as time goes on as such the
average fan and versus average enjoyer
meme saw a new use of the gigachad
before the gigachat this notion of the
ideal Ultra masculine specimen was based
on let's be honest some pretty outdated
ideas about what it means to be a man
after all it takes more than muscle to
be a man not every man or masculine
presenting person has to work out until
they're built like a brick wall perhaps
the real Measure of a Man is how sincere
sensitive and supportive you can be as
well as standing by your interests
rather than caving to Old societal
standards of masculinity and after we
updated our data the animatron 6000 was
able to give us a new revised outcome or
what we like to call scenario three the
average
scp-096 enjoyer in this projection the
gigachad's true strength isn't just his
masculine physique and his unattainable
standards instead it's in part the
inherent adaptable ability of his status
as a meme but also his compassion just
like before he's more than able to
resist
scp-096's attacks and the creature's
insecurity comes out put on full display
when presented with gigachad sharp
jawline but rather than overcome his
anomalous adversary by fighting him this
scenario sees the gigachad comforting
the shy guy through calm empathy and
words of affirmation he reminds as cp096
that true acceptance of oneself comes
from within and that message strikes a
chord with the creature in a turn of
events none of us saw coming the
gigachad offers to help scp-096 overcome
his crippling and deadly sense of
insecurity the pairs start using the
on-site gym together after hours when
there aren't any innocent Foundation
Personnel around their gigachad not only
offers to introduce scp-096 to an
exercise regimen if that's what the
creature wants but also helps the shy
guy work on his confidence they form a
friendship with scp-096 taking a liking
to working out not because it wants to
be buff like its new friend the gigachad
but more so because doing so makes it
feel more comfortable in its own skin
scp-096 gradually starts to like itself
more even eating healthier thanks to
gigachad's advice eventually the shy guy
begins looking far more content and even
starts to develop self-confidence it's
not often that a story involving scp-096
exists with the creature getting to
achieve some semblance of Happiness
while there is one that comes to mind
the very same Shy Guy story that sent us
on this particular streak of pitting it
against the gigachad in the first place
but what if we put them together would
coming across a refined scp-096 spell
the end for the gigachad or the muscular
masculine meme undo the Shy Guy's
previous happy ending well according to
the animatron 6000 neither when we last
left him after being turned into a
handsome nine foot tall man
scp-096 had just started going by the
name David
scp-978 the desired camera had been used
to photograph the refining shine guy it
showed him holding hands with the
foundation scientists responsible for
his transformation who had studied the
new and improved scp-096 in great detail
she had quite the understanding of him
but perhaps the photograph from the
desire camera was more of a metaphor
than what scp-096 or David really
desired wasn't specifically the
researcher who'd studied him but a
partner who understood him someone to
call an equal entered the gigachad
according to the calculations made by
the animatron the embodiment of ultimate
masculinity both strong and sensitive
came bursting into the foundation
facility there the moment he and David
saw each other was like the meeting of
an Unstoppable force and an immovable
object neither one rushed to solve the
encounter with violence both the
gigachad and scp-096 appreciated each
other's aesthetic appeal both were
remarkably handsome and one couldn't
bear the thought of ridding the world of
the other instead it was love at first
sight both David formerly known as
scp-096 and the gigachad fell head over
heels in love with each other and
looking at both it was not hard to see
why they were a pair of fine perfectly
chiseled fellas and they instantly hit
it off the newly established couple
enjoyed each other's company spending
time in deep conversations
scp-096 introducing his new partner to
his friends at the foundation while
gigachad was comfortable with his own
masculinity to express his feelings
towards David without fear or judgment
no relationship is perfect of course for
a short time a sliver of David's old
self re-emerged the shy guy in him
worried that perhaps his relationship
with the gigachad was based purely on
both of their extreme good looks and was
nothing more than superficial but by
being an embodiment of healthy idealized
masculinity the gigachad was able to
sense something was wrong with David and
rather do the insecure thing of letting
it Fester he addressed it directly and
they discussed the issue in a healthy
mature and constructive way not just so
they could put scp-096's worry to rest
but so that both of them could further
strengthen their relationship and grow
as people and of course gigachad wasn't
just attracted to scp-096's refined good
looks far from being superficial he
recognized that David was a complete
person beautiful both inside and out and
loved him as a whole not just because
they were both conventionally attractive
on the surface
scp-096 and the gigachad stayed together
for the rest of their lives or as we
decided to name this fourth scenario
from the animatron happily ever after
somehow most likely through some
nefarious means a fateful postcard has
been sent to one of the residents of the
murky Mysterious arunurum Island living
on this particular Island was already a
strange and scary enough existence given
the horrors the inhabitants of anariram
share their home with but perhaps the
only thing just as horrible as life on
that island was being sent a postcard
sure that doesn't sound all that
horrible postcards are usually used to
show a corner of the world far away and
extend well wishes from friends or
relatives on vacations but ordinarily
postcards don't depict a photo of
scp-096 with the words wish she was
there scrawled on the other side from
its containment saw the SCP Foundation
the shy guy instantly sensed that
somebody somewhere had seen a picture of
its face breaking down into an enraged
of homicidal insecurity
scp-096 immediately broke from its
containment chamber and made a
cross-country beeline heading straight
for Aaron neurum at anomalously
accelerated speeds little did the
creature or the foundation know that the
shy guy was being led straight into a
trap and the poor island resident who
had received the chilling postcard while
they were unlucky enough to beat the
bait while the SCP Foundation started
frantically trying to track down where
it had gone the shy guy had already made
its way to a wooden cabin belonging to
the unfortunate postcard recipient
emerging from the now emptied home once
the owner was no more
scp-096 would have returned to his cell
just as quickly as he left that is if he
wasn't the only monstrous creature on
the island allowed and sudden noise
caught the creature's attention the
sound of an old steam train whistle it
rang out once more from somewhere off in
the distance but there was so much thick
fog hanging in the air around aeronirum
that it was almost impossible to see
anything especially with how dark it was
the second time the whistle sounded it
was closer but there was another sound
too and not the loud chugging of the
steam engine that you would expect it
was an erratic heavy thudding the noise
of lots of something strumming against
the ground causing the Earth itself to
shudder legs they were the steps of
multiple huge legs crawling across the
surface of the island heading straight
towards
scp-096 a third piercing whistle rang
out even closer still this time the
orange glow of a light could be seen
dulled by the surrounding fog but
getting brighter and clearer as it came
closer the light was casting Shadows
against the dark fog long spindly shapes
of spidery appendages until before the
Shy Guy's eyes a creature of pure
nightmares came bursting out of the fog
it was a monstrous sight even to
scp-096 its body was the Red Front
engine of an old-fashioned steam train
hoisted off the ground by four pairs of
enormous black spindly spider-like legs
that propelled the Beast forwards at a
terrifying speed able to move without
the limitations of needing to follow a
railroad track the monster was barreling
towards
scp-096 with a twisted smile on its
grotesque face at the front of the
locomotive was its circular face with
its unnaturally white eyes and a mouth
that sported rows of razor-sharp teeth
all covered in blood this hellish
Abomination a being that was part steam
engine and part giant spider was the
terror of aaronirum himself the
carnivorous choo choo Charles
seeing Charles racing towards them on
its eight spider legs would be enough to
make anyone freeze up and stop in their
tracks out of sheer Terror and scp-096
was compelled to do the same except the
terrifying trained creature's pale eyes
were looking directly at the shy guy as
Charles sized the anomaly up as its next
meal he was looking at it and that meant
scp-096 had to kill him the question was
how could it how could the skinny
spindly humanoid hope to even find
something like choo choo Charles he was
much bigger even more fearsome but as
quick as Charles could move on his
spidery legs he was not faster than
scp's 096 in the blink of an eye the shy
guy raced off shrieking and sobbing in
despair leaving Charles to continue
roaming his island territory in search
of other human inhabitants to terrorize
scp-096 had retreated to some nearby
Woods quick enough to move out of
Charles's path somewhere it could hide
for now but the shy guy could feel a
familiar painful feeling almost pulling
him back towards choo choo Charles right
back into Harm's Way
scp-096 possessed an inescapable
compulsion to kill anyone who looked at
its face and that seemed to include a
horrifying part-train Parts spider
hybrids it was a fact of the Shy Guy's
very existence he had to go after
whoever looked at him and make them pay
in fact it took all the creatures Own
Strength not to instantly rush back over
to Charles to try
scp-096 knew that if it did then there
was little chance it would survive
coming face to train face with the
terror of era nerum however while it was
watching choo choo Charles from a safe
distance seeing him crawl across the
landscape on his multiple legs that
scp-096 noticed something it was another
light obscured by the fog but this one
was much higher up one could almost
mistake it for the moon if it wasn't
getting closer all the while accompanied
by the sound of whirring rotors well the
shy guy had been evading choo choo
Charles the SCP Foundation had been
tirelessly trying to track down its
location and now they'd found their
runaway anomaly here on Aaron niram
Island as the chopper carrying the
mobile task force Drew nearer the
tyrannical train turned and took notice
to scp-096 the foundation's arrival
could have meant a way home and away
from the spidery steam engine but to
Charles the approaching chopper meant
only one thing a new source of food
Captain one of the MTF troops aboard the
chopper called over his headset what is
it do we have eyes on scp-096 the
captain replied before realizing what
he'd said well not eyes on because then
it would have jumped up onto the chopper
and killed us all I mean is there any
sign of scp-096 on the island negative
sir although you should probably see
this the soldier replied begrudgingly
the captain unbuckled himself from his
seat and snatched the foundation
operative's binoculars using them to
look down at Arena below it didn't take
him long to spot the massive
multi-legged monstrosity that was choo
choo Charles but Fallen still waiting
for the chopper to descend low enough
for him to reach
crazy what on Earth is that thing the
captain exclaimed before taking another
look through the binoculars is that wait
what is an instance of scp-2086 doing
out here
scp-2086 was an Infamous anomalous
species the foundation had encountered
before much like Charles they were
anthropod-like creatures with multiple
long legs that protruded from a body
resembling a man-made mode of Transport
however
scp-2086s usually took on the appearance
of buses while in vehicle form sir I I
don't think that's an scp-2086 the
lookout replied to me it looks more like
an instance of scp-3023 impossible all
the way out here the captain retorted
we're nowhere near the region where the
anomaly occurs it could have scurried
its way from Germany and taken Nest here
sir the trooper responded yet another
anomaly that choo choo Charles bore a
striking resemblance to
scp-3023 was a rare phenomenon that was
known to occur at random but was limited
to a specific area of Central Germany
the effect of this phenomenon caused
ordinary everyday inanimate objects of
any shape or size to suddenly turn into
aggressive spiders sporting eight legs
That Grew From whatever was affected by
scp-3023 perhaps choo choo Charles was
indeed an instance of scp-3023 or some
distant evolutionary offshoot of
scp-2086 it was hard to say for sure the
only thing for sure was that Charles was
a man-eating Beast more so than an
Insidious villain and being so highly
territorial he considered the entire
island of Aaron nerum to be his natural
habitat and his hunting ground anything
that arrived in his vicinity was prey to
the terrifying train and his ravenous
craving for human flesh meant he was
ready to attack the descending SCP
Foundation Chopper all right let's go go
go the MTF Captain called to his troops
signaling them to start repelling out of
the helicopter and down to the island
keep
your ideas taking down this big ugly
beast wearing goggles specifically
designed to distort the shy guy from
their view the team began abselling out
of the aircraft but choo choo Charles
was already waiting for them rearing
back on its four back legs the
nightmarish trained spider swiped at the
descending MTF operatives but first
seemed like an instinctive uncoordinated
assault quickly became precise and
Relentless strikes as Charles sliced
through some of the cables the MTF
troops were using to repel down their
Lifeline cut the Unlucky Foundation
operatives plummeted from mid-air right
down towards where the terror of Erin
era was waiting for them to fall a few
of the mtfs made it to the ground alive
and immediately began retaliating
against choo choo Charles the gunfire
from their weapons flickered all around
the carnivorous creature but their
bullets could barely chip the red
paintwork on his steam train body
dashing towards his helpless human prey
on his many legs Charles began to Feast
then suddenly something started pulling
at one huge spider legs pulling Charles
back moments before he had a chance to
claim his latest victim the captain of
the foundation's MTF it was
scp-096 having zipped out of hiding and
shrieking wildly as it used all of its
strength to wrench one of choo choo
Charles's multiple limbs angered that it
couldn't reach the MTF Captain the parts
spider Park train hybrid stomped the leg
that was being pulled and a successful
attempt to free itself from the Shy
Guy's grip but in the same instant
scp-096 used its anomalous speed to
reappear in front of the already angered
locomotive monster with his railroad
rage about to reach its Breaking Point
Charles entered into a Relentless
Rampage making quick work of the
leftover MTF troops before setting his
sights squarely on
scp-096 but doing that was his biggest
mistake now choo choo Charles had seen
the shy guy twice and to the insecure
anomaly that meant Charles had to go
traveling faster and even the
multi-legged monstrosity could perceive
scp-096 began racing towards choo choo
Charles's many legs the Shanghai had
realized that it didn't stand a chance
of dealing with the terror of era niram
the same way it handled all the others
that I'd seen its face so instead it had
settled on a new approach specifically
tailored to taking down the spider
legged steam engine one by one
scp-096 started knocking Charles's many
legs out from underneath him effectively
tripping him up over and over again the
shy guy moved so quick that the
cumbersome Charles could barely react in
time having one like after the other
knocked out from beneath him causing him
to Tumble to the ground normally choo
choo Charles was smart enough to retreat
if he encountered something that could
fight back if he was injured badly
enough the spider-like creature would
Scuttle out of Harm's Way in order to
heal his wounds but the rage at being
constantly tripped up by scp-096 was
distracting Charles from the Shy Guy's
true Ploy with every leg it knocked out
from underneath the spidery steam train
scp-096 had been gradually directing
Charles towards a nearby Gorge with a
terrifying burst of anomalous speed the
shy guy caused choo choo Charles to
topple over sideways rolling over
himself until he landed upside down in
the bottom of the Rocky Gorge the
multi-legged locomotive Monster's
spindly legs flailed desperately as he
tried to reposition himself but with no
luck
scp-096 had managed what first seemed to
be impossible and beaten the terror of
era niram choo choo Charles or for now
at least silently passing through the
inky void of space a vessel was
hurriedly making its way towards its
destination the craft was Sleek designed
and built by hands not of this world
aboard one of the occupants knelt before
its Elders it was time it gathered its
Arsenal in a methodical almost
ceremonial fashion its spear latched
onto its back with its survival gear a
medi-kit containing surgical equipment
and specialized serums it donned its
gauntlets then reached for the final
piece its mask that it slipped over its
face ready for its task the creature
boarded a smaller Scout ship which was
jettisoned and began to descend toward
the planet below a world known as Earth
on the surface of the planet itself a
technician was sitting at his desk
boards staring at readouts from
satellites and the endless sweeping of a
radar scanning the skies above for any
signs of disturbance for a moment as the
Scout craft passed through the
atmosphere something happened that broke
the technician out of his boredom there
was a blip on the radar the tiny
detection of an unknown signal that of
an object traveling on a direct course
through the sky just as the technician
started to take notice the approaching
ship activated a stealth mechanism
reflecting all light away from it in
order to render it almost invisible
while simultaneously becoming
undetectable to radar the blip vanished
from the screen and didn't reappear the
technician Shrugged thinking it was
probably nothing but an equipment glitch
besides the SCP Foundation didn't pay
him enough to follow up on every time
a few hours later in several continents
away a mobile task force was on an
assignment the oppressive heat and
humidity of the wakandan Jungle was
bearing down on them especially in their
combat gear the operatives were all
feeling unbearably hot the foundation
researchers overseeing the mtf's mission
via satellite didn't have to contend
with the elements in the comfort of
their air-conditioned Command Center but
little did they or their boots on the
ground know there was something else
visiting the rainforest too it had been
stalking the squad for a few miles now
and not one of them had noticed just as
the creature planned a trio of red laser
beams cast three distinct dots over one
of the MTF operatives chest suddenly a
streak of energy shot through the air
crackling as it struck the agent tearing
through his chest and killing him on the
spot instinctively the remaining troops
turned and opened fire at the treetop
where the blast had come from spraying a
volley of bullets enough to start
shredding the wood of the tree splinters
and bark when down they hit nothing
there was no sign of whoever or whatever
had fired that shot and killed their
teammate from behind them a pair of
discs with a row of long fan-like blades
around their Edge flew through the air
there was so much force behind the arm
that threw them that the pair of
shuriken lifted two of the remaining MTF
soldiers off their feet and impaled them
to the trunks of nearby trees the last
remaining Foundation operative looked at
the bodies of his dead Squad mates in
horror before turning and fleeing but
just as he ran for his life something
caught him it was transparent cloaked
and near impossible to see but it had
plunged a pair of blades into the MTF
trooper's chest lifting him off his feet
with ease as he screamed in pain an
invisible leathery-skinned hand reached
for his throat and twisted and in an
instant with a sickening crack the man
was silent and dropped limply to the
floor from the command center watching
an awe as this imperceptible monster
tore through 4 of their finest
operatives with ease a pair of
researchers turned to look at each other
the Expressions they both wore were were
faces of sheer disbelief they both had
heard stories instantly recognizing the
destructive Behavior but never thought
they'd see or not see it carried out for
real we still don't have a name for them
do we researcher Hall asked has the pair
of them walked bristly down the corridor
ah negative replied his counterpart
researcher D ligirio that the files we
acquired for military intelligence
suggests they've been coming to Earth
for decades centuries even the earliest
known encounter took place in the 1700s
can we negotiate with this one at all
Paul asked fully expecting the answer I
don't think they respond well to that
kind of Engagement de ligirio said they
seem to come to Earth with One Singular
purpose to hunt for sport well it seems
so what about their capabilities the
senior researcher pressed their
technology is pretty Advanced even
compared to some of the things we've
seen the other explained on top of that
they're fast strong and completely
ruthless pretty much an apex predator
according to Intel the instances of
these creatures that have previously
visited Earth have displayed a sort of
tribal nature fair to elaborate palprobe
based on the files their hunts seem
partially recreational but also like
some kind of ritual to prove themselves
as capable or to challenge themselves
that gives me an idea the researcher
replied contact containment area 25b if
we play this right we can bag one of
these creatures and bring it in for
testing time seemed to race by as
Holland de ligurio were bundled aboard
at transport and taken directly to
containment area 25b a facility built by
the foundation specifically to house a
particularly dangerous anomaly within
the hour the two researchers were
standing facing a huge Stone Cube its
dark surface sporting a number of
symbols engraved into it growing
impatient knowing their window of
opportunity was rapidly closing Hall
turned to one of the foundation
Personnel stationed within the prime
Mary containment Zone around
scp-076 Play It Again be instructed wake
him up hitting a button a recorded
message began to play over the
facility's loudspeakers it had been
translated into an ancient Sumerian
dialect that the entity within the stone
Cube had historically shown a preference
for come on out the message stated we
know you don't think any of us are worth
your time but we remember
omega-7 you agreed to work with us
before even though you don't think we
present enough of a challenge to you but
we may have found something that will an
adversary that you could have the
privilege of besting in combat there was
a brief moment of silence before the
stone began to rumble the security
Personnel on site tends to ripping their
weapons shakily nervous hands slowly the
circular lock on the side of the cube
began twisting the door had kept sealed
beginning to open are you sure we can do
this how ASD ligurio if scp-076 isn't
willing to cooperate this could go South
real quickly and God forbid what if
somebody found out what we're having him
do Hall didn't answer instead watching
us the door to the cube finally opened
and a lean man in his late 20s stepped
out his gray eyes stared out of a mess
of jet black hair his body adorned with
tattoos of Arcane runes and occult
imagery the sneering faces of demons
over his olive skin as the guards around
him nervously raised their weapons at
the ready
scp-076-2 casually Strode up to
researcher Hall until the two were
inches away from each other where able
asked fitting him with a Communications
earpiece and having him board a
transport Abel was sent directly towards
the last known coordinates of the now
deceased MTF deep in the heart of the
lakandan Jungle sat atop a tree as the
aircraft made its approach the creature
had lowered its cloaking device certain
it was alone as it polished a skull it
had collected from one of the ill-fated
operatives the Predator was a member of
a species known as the yacha one of the
few details about its race that
delegurio's files hadn't mentioned
everything else was accurate though it
was indeed a hunter here to claim
trophies as proof of its skill these
trophies happen to be the skulls and
spines of whatever it killed hearing the
sound of an incoming vehicle the
Predator instinctively reached for a
control on its left wrist Gauntlet its
cloaking device reactivated bending the
light away from itself to render the
alien Hunter nearly invisible through
the lenses of its biomask the Predator
watched The Craft pass overhead and the
shape of a single humanoid Heat
Signature dropping from it and landing
in the rainforest trekking through the
Lush vegetation Abel walked towards the
location he had been given it always
irked The Immortal barbarian when the
foundation attempted to use him to
perform their menial Dirty Work to Able
such tasks were beneath him but he had
been promised to fight with a worthy
adversary and that was the only reason
he had agreed to undertake this Mission
looking around as he reached a clearing
there was no sign of the mtfh
until that is Abel craned his neck
upwards and found them something had
meticulously gathered up the bodies and
hung them from the branches by their
legs it felt distinctly like a warning
as well as a taunting gloat every
indicator pointed to this being the
action of a creature that was marking
its Newfound territory with a wave of
his hand Abel pulled a black edge sword
out of a pocket Dimension holding his
weapons and held the blade at the ready
looking down he saw three points of red
light had appeared on his bare chest
just as Abel caught side of the Treetops
where the lasers were coming from a bolt
of high energy plasma was fired towards
him within the same Split Second he
hurled his sword in the direction of his
invisible enemy the blast struck him and
knocked him down searing his flesh not
that Abel could feel pain at the same
time his sword spun through the air and
cleaved through the branch where the
Predator had been perched causing the
creature to drop to the Jungle floor
with a thud as the yacht just stood up
he noticed its Gauntlet was sparking
having sustained damage in the fall now
its cloaking device was flickering on
and off the Predator knew it would need
to repair its equipment but first and
foremost he needed to collect a trophy
from its latest kill the creature Strode
towards where Abel was laying a Scorch
Mark left by the plasma Caster burned
into his flesh its cloaking device still
malfunctioning the hunter reached down
to claim its prize Abel's eyes suddenly
snapped open and caught the creature by
surprise reeling his leg back he
delivered a sharp kick that sent the
Predator hurling backwards despite it
being well over seven feet tall and 520
pounds of armor and alien muscle Abel
hardly stood back up facing off against
the alien Warrior as it too Drew itself
to full height The Gauntlet on its left
wrist continued to spit Sparks until the
Predator reached a clawed digit over and
pressed to control with an electronic
beep its cloak deactivated fully and the
hunter was revealed he was tall standing
on two legs like a man it seemed life
and agile but clearly almost as strong
as Abel himself judging by how muscular
it was long appendages resembling locks
of hair protruded from its head behind a
metal faceplate a mass covered the true
face of the creature below a clicking
chittering noise emanated from beneath
the Predator's biomass as it reached for
a sash that went across its front and
produced a pair of small metal circles
able flexed his shoulders and ran at the
creature the Predator hurled both its
discs at able curved blades extending
from both of them as they spun through
the air able ducked out of the path of
one shuriken narrowly dodging the second
as he charged the alien Hunter reaching
for its back the Predator produced The
Long ornate handle of its Combi stick
both ends of its telescopic spear
extended and the hunter began racing
forward to clash head-on with its
Newfound prey it plunged the spear right
through Abel with all its strength
lifting the Barbarian off his feet on
the end of its weapon out of nowhere
scp-076 produced another of his swords
the Predator turning to look in
confusion at the weapon that had
seemingly just appeared in the hand of
what it had taken for an ordinary human
catching the off-world Game Hunter by
surprise Abel swept the sword through
the air leaving the creature's spear in
two causing him to drop back to the
ground landing on his feet following it
with a second Swift swing of his blade
Abel brought the weapon down on a slash
that cut across the creature's chest it
sliced through the thick reptilian hide
of the Predator leaving a streak of
fluorescent green blood oozing from its
torso the creature roared in pain it
sounded like a call of a lion echoing
through the trees in retaliation the
Predator extended a pair of blades
contained in its right Gauntlet and
swipe them at able the wristblades
nearly missed his face as he dodged in
incoming attack only to be caught by the
creature's other hand he gripped his
head and plunged downwards knocking Abel
over and sending him face first into the
rainforest floor reaching for his
cloaking device control the Predator
disappeared retreating in the jungle to
tend to its heavily bleeding wound what
manner of devil is this creature Hall
Abel yelled at the researcher over his
earpiece hacking branches out of his
path with his sword as he followed the
trail of luminous green left by the
wounded Hunter it's a warrior From
Another World Paul replied a hunter that
tracks its prey by their body heat
considers itself honorable but often
likes to go after more dangerous targets
to challenge itself not unlike you Abel
I am nothing like this demon the
Barbarian shouted in Fury this gutless
monster has no honor if it did it would
not give itself such an unfair Advantage
nor would it run away when wounded a
true warrior would be happy to die a
Wario's death in single combat and would
not rely on all its fancy Weaponry well
from what we can tell these things have
their own codes of sorts dealigerio's
voice said over the comms you might not
think of this Hunter as honorable but it
definitely thinks of itself that way
maybe use that to your advantage I do
not need to be lectured by the likes of
you Abel interact you have not known the
heat of battle none of you at the
foundation have I will follow the trail
of this cowardly BEAST's blood and
cleave its foul head from its shoulders
unbeknownst to Abel high above a branch
the Predator was watching him its
biomass had been zoomed in on him the
hunter listening to the barbarian's
outrage it turned to the task at hand
opening up its Medi kit and producing
the surgical tools within as it tended
to the Deep green cut across its chest
stifling Roars of pain beneath its Mask
The Predator stapled the injury closed
and applied a solvent to cauterize it
night was beginning to fall and Abel had
long since lost the trail of green blood
frustrated he thought back to what the
puny researchers at the foundation had
told him of his alien adversary if it
believed itself to be honorable to have
a code then perhaps using that to lure
it out to face him might work with the
sun rapidly disappearing beyond the tree
line Abel gathered a number of branches
hacking them off trees with a sword and
fashioning them in burning torches he
placed them in a circle around the
circumference of a clearing creating a
makeshift gladiatorial Arena he could
feel his blood boiling the urge to
defeat this monster making him sieve
throwing his head back and beating a
fist against his chest Abel roared up at
the dark sky come out Hunter he held
show yourself come on do it I'm right
here watching him from afar hidden by
its cloak the Predator recognized what
was happening this was a challenge a
direct call to engage in single combat
refusing this Challenge and shooting its
prey dead would be quicker easier but
the hunter knew it was being watched and
therefore judged with a growl it dropped
to the ground and paced towards the
circle Abel turned as the Predator
revealed itself appearing almost from
thin air as it did he drew one of his
weapons and stood ready to fight the
hunter Shrugged off the technology it
carried on its back dropping the plasma
caster and its medicate before reaching
up pulling off its mask its face was
grotesque four hooked mandibles
surrounding its mouth flared in Anger
you are one
ugly Abel said only to be interrupted by
the Predator extending the blades from
its Gauntlet and letting out another
beastial Roar holding his sword Aloft
Abel gave a goading back into his
opponent as the pair of them circled one
another finally the creature gave in and
lunged at him swiping its pair of
razor-sharp serrated blades at able he
swung his sword and at the last second
deflected the oncoming blow with a clang
of metal reaching into his pocket
Dimension Abel pulled a second weapon
out in his other hand and swiped at the
Predator slicing through the creature's
hide and leaving another gaping wound at
its thigh roaring in Fury the Predator
launched another strike able blocked the
attack yet again this time by Crossing
his swords but the Predator barged
forward driving its blades into the
prey's chest and pinning his two weapons
against him the Monstrous alien
viciously head-butted Abel the hooks of
its man scratching his face as it did
before reaching up to the back of his
neck with its free hand Abel could feel
the sheer strength of the hunter lifting
him off his feet ready to twist his neck
and pull his head off to claim it as a
trophy kicking the predator in the chest
able used the force of the impact to
push himself free from the creature's
grip back flipping through the air and
Landing a few feet away his swords
clattered together as they dropped to
the ground The Immortal Barbarian
summoning another and immediately
charging at the Predator it had been
winded by the kick and barely recovered
in time to defend itself as the blade
swung for its neck the Predator
staggered back green blood oozing from
its hide and pouring from its mouth that
blow had mortally wounded it it was
bleeding heavily and knew it might not
survive this hunt but it refused to be
vested by a human even one as seemingly
invulnerable as able hunching over
listening to him slowly approaching to
deliver the killing blow the Predator
tapped a series of controls on its
Gauntlet a gradually accelerating
beeping began emanating from the divine
turning around at the last second the
alien Hunter impaled Abel before he was
upon it skewering
scp-076-2 on its wrist blades his sword
had been raised above his head to plunge
through the creature and even while
impaled Abel was able to deliver the
final blow stabbing the Predator while
it too had stabbed him the pair were
locked in a stalemate angrily roaring
each other until an explosion of energy
bursts from the Hunter's gauntlets
reducing both Abel and the Predator to
atoms watching from their satellite feed
Hal and diligirio's side they wouldn't
have their specimen for testing but at
least they knew that Abel would
eventually resurrect within the stone
cube of
scp-076-1 but even higher up than their
satellite someone else was watching a
group of predators growled and chittered
amongst themselves having witnessed from
their ship as one of their own had died
in a battle with Abel although there was
no way of knowing the noises The Hunting
Party were making could have been
expressions of disappointment at their
fallen brother or a declaration of war
the aftershocks shuddered through the
foundation emergency alarms wailed as
injured staff and security helped each
other out from underneath Rubble that
had fallen on them as the building was
shaken by the Quake it had only lasted a
few short seconds but still managed to
leave a trail of Destruction in its wake
while the wounded were bandaged up
anyone and everyone who was still able
to started frantically checking the
containment of every anomaly on the site
the foundation could worry about the
origin of the Quake later first and
foremost they needed to assess the
damage luckily multiple rapid sweeps of
the facility revealed that there weren't
all that many high-level threat
anomalies whose containment had been
breached a few of the safer ones were
found cowering under tables or buried
under Fallen Rubble in their quarters
but for the most part every anomaly was
accounted for and none had been provided
with an opportunity to escape and cause
for their Havoc at least that's how
things seemed at first it was only when
the chaos started to die down and repair
efforts were underway that Personnel
noticed an odd change something was
missing but nobody could quite put their
finger on exactly what as a matter of
fact most could pinpoint exactly when
they noticed this odd feeling it had
only begun after the emergency alarms
had been shut off there was a sound that
everyone working at the foundation had
gotten so used to that they practically
stopped hearing it or at least they'd
stopped noticing it it was only now that
the noise was gone its absence no longer
drowned out by blaring alarms that staff
realized it had always been there
everyone had just learned to
subconsciously tune it out crying the
low soft whimpering that could be heard
emanating from
scp-096's containment chamber it had
stopped the cell within had fallen
silent and once someone at the
foundation made the right connection and
investigated they happened upon a
startling Discovery
scp-096 had vanished Panic immediately
engulfed the facility yet again the shy
guy could be anywhere and a search
effort to find it would only end in
deaths after all in order to find
something you have to look at it and
that was a fatal thing to do when
scp-096 was involved closer examination
showed no trace of the missing creature
there had been no reported incidents of
incursions with it anywhere in the world
every known photograph video recording
or other visual depiction of scp-096 was
either securely stashed away or
destroyed completely by the foundation
there was no way it could have possibly
escaped it was seemingly nowhere at all
but still the question remained where in
the world had the shy guy gone to if it
was still even in this world from
scp-096's perspective one moment all had
been normal the next it was lost
somewhere strange unfamiliar and above
all unsettling even to the shy guy
before the sudden Quake had hit it had
spent the day the same way it usually
occupied its time alternating between
aimlessly pacing the far wall of its
containment chamber and sitting in a
fetal position in the corner sobbing all
the while but then the room had started
shaking and in the blink of a deeply
sunken eye the shy guy found itself
while it had no idea where around it was
a large carpeted room open and sparse
with little occupying all the space the
wallpaper was a nauseating sickly shade
of yellow made all the more garish by
the rows of fluorescent lighting from
the ceiling above the entire Place
seemed to resemble an office space
although seemingly one that was in a
total state of disuse there was no
furniture not even one solitary
inanimate object to make the place seem
at least the tiniest bit closer to
normal little was scps 096 aware it had
somehow been transported to a strange
and terrible place the rooms unless
someone remains wary and ever Vigilant
they can unknowingly slip their way out
of reality it can happen anywhere all
that a person needs to do is be in the
wrong place at the wrong time and they
will no clip into the back rooms all
around scp-096 was the stench of old wet
carpet and a Labyrinth of uninhabited
rooms with the same drab yellow walls
the endless Buzz of the fluorescent
lights stretching out for who knows how
many square miles of empty rooms in
short the shy guy was trapped in a
purgatory-like nightmare however there
was at least one small Mercy for
scp-096 as it wandered around its new
surroundings there was nobody else
around no other signs of life no SCP
Foundation No Ordinary human beings no
one who could see it here in the
solitary confinement of the back rooms
scp-096 could not be perceived and yet
this brought this self-conscious
creature very little in the way of
comfort despite being completely alone
there was an awful lingering feeling
that hung in the air like the smell of
the old carpet underfoot
scp-096 still felt like it was being
watched and yet if someone or something
really was watching it wasn't triggering
the Shy Guy's usual rage State as it
lurked through the various rooms and
corridors the creature kept expecting to
find someone to look them in the eye
directly and get the same inescapable
urge to race towards its Observer and
kill them but it never came because
there was nobody else around at least
for a little while Adam Jenkins had been
out riding his bike when it happened
pushing one pedal around then the other
he gradually climbed higher up the slope
of a hill his house was down at the
bottom of the other side and Adam knew
once he reached the peak he could slip
nice and easily down the rest of the way
as long as he was careful not to let the
extra momentum carry his bike too far
and too fast you just had to keep in
control and gently compress the brake if
he needed to he made the same Journey
every day nothing could go wrong sure
enough Adam reached the top of the hill
and allowed the bike to slowly tip ever
so slightly over the other side gravity
started to do the rest the wheels
starting to spin rapidly the pedals
pistoning his legs as he plummeted
downwards he was one of the few
childlike Joys left in Adam's life those
few brief seconds of the day where he
got to speed down the hill back home
with Reckless abandon it was blissfully
unaware that he wouldn't have enough
time to miss how much he enjoyed it
without mourning a car came speeding out
from around a corner on the way down the
hill it was dark and the driver had
carelessly decided to leave their
headlights off so when Adam saw the
vehicle he only had a split second to
react he was still going too fast so if
he applied the brakes now his front
wheel would stop too suddenly and send
him flying forward over the handlebars
instead seconds before colliding with a
car's Hood Adam wrenched his bike's
handlebars and swerved around the car
but the added speed of going downhill
caused the entire bike to topple as it
turned so violently launching at him off
and sending him hurtling towards a
nearby wall Adam could tell in the Split
Second after coming off his bike that he
was about to collide with the wall his
brain and body anticipated the impact
bracing him for the painful crash but it
never came instead of hitting the wall
Adam passed through it that may well
have spared him a devastating injury but
now a whole new problem now faced him
just like no clipping through a virtual
environment in a video game Adam had
passed directly out of reality right
into the back rooms the first few hours
were the worst shouting as loud as he
could for someone anyone to come and
find him each yell rapidly growing more
and more frantic as Adam rushed around
his haunting news surroundings the whole
place was unsettling just to be in it
gave off a hostile on welcoming energy
that was impossible to ignore it was
only after an hour of trying to find a
way out that Adam realized he was well
and truly lost he'd strayed too far away
from his original point of entry and
just as he had the idea of trying to
make his way back to the world from the
same place he came in it was already too
late the back rooms at least on this
first level all look the same no two
rooms were distinct enough for him to
figure out if this was somewhere he'd
been before or an entirely new area it
didn't take long for an overwhelming
sense of hopelessness to set in Adam had
quickly given up calling for help there
was no sign of anyone around that would
be able to help him until the shuffling
of footsteps came from nearby it was
such a noticeable break in the dull
unsettling quiet of the back rooms that
it made Adam's ears prick up the yellow
cued maze had been so void of life since
he arrived so unnaturally empty that he
wasn't entirely sure he had made the
sound himself by his jacket brushing up
against the wall but no there was
definitely something here with him he
could hear it wandering nearby and it
had certainly hurt him too calling out
yet again with more caution in this tone
Adam Jenkins turned the next Corner met
with yet another dingy yellow Corridor
although unlike the others this one had
a key difference
scp-096 stood right in the middle of it
the split second that Adam's eyes fell
over the shy guy who was already too
late he barely had time to process the
side of the creature its tall humanoid
shape wiry thin and pale skin jaw
hanging unnaturally wide in fact
scp-096 dashed towards Adam so quickly
that he couldn't even finish his
startled scream meanwhile back at the
SCP Foundation efforts were still
underway to retrieve the shy guy
researchers were baffled that there was
not a single trace anywhere on the globe
of scp-096's presence they had quickly
rolled out out their usual method for
recalling the creature to containment
requisitioning one of d-class personnel
this individual was instructed to stand
in
scp-096sl and then was given a
photograph of the monster to look at
knowing that the shy guy would track
down anyone that saw its face even as a
single tiny pixel in a picture the
foundation expected the creature to
Simply reappear in its containment
chamber to kill the d-class they had
used as bait but nothing happened the
d-class was able to look at the photo of
scp-096 and survive it was almost as if
the creatures linked to reality was
weakened wherever it was it might still
be aware someone had looked at it but
the shy guy was somehow being blocked
from traveling to its most recent
Observer having drawn a blank on trying
to determine scp-096's whereabouts the
foundation eventually turned to scp-343
for his input naturally the powerful
reality vendor was reluctant as ever to
get involved the foundation insisted
knowing that scp-343's omniscience meant
he would already be aware of where they
could find the missing shine guy he
refused multiple times admitting he did
have the answer they were looking for
but not wishing to divulge that
information fine
scp-343 side coming to a compromise I
can't tell you exactly where 096 is but
when I tell you where to look for
answers you'll know async the
researchers were stunned into silence
nobody in the foundation had heard that
name used in a long time but scp-343 was
right they knew exactly what it meant
back in the 1980s async was another
shadowy organization that had been
investigating the existence of a liminal
space connected to reality a place they
had called the back rooms Gathering up a
mobile task force the SCP Foundation
dispatched its agents to a site that had
long since been abandoned they'd kept a
watchful eye over the disused lab
keeping the public away May making sure
nobody stumbled in by accident and got
trapped as the MTF Commander gave the
word the outdated 80s technology was
fired up and async's great achievement
was reactivated they had constructed a
portal into the back rooms moving
information the MTF operatives filed
into the empty yellow space unsure if
they'd find scp-096 alive or if it would
even want to come back meanwhile in the
back rooms level zero only the shy guy
remained having completely annihilated
Poor Unfortunate Adam he was enjoying
the Solitude once again knowing that now
nobody was here to see him until one
wrong step changed everything he no
clipped from Level zero to level one
where he would have a lot more company
what's up Gamers hello there everyone my
name's SCP explained a lot of SCP fans
have played the free survival horror
game SCP containment breach the game's
story places the player in the shoes of
a d-class at one of the foundation's
containment sites as they try their best
to survive a massive catastrophic
Containment Breach many players
including some of our viewers feel as if
the simulated experience has given them
the tools they would need to survive a
real-life Containment Breach but can
playing a video game really be
sufficient training for encountering
some of the deadliest scps in
containment and escaping with your life
in order to answer this question we're
going to speculate based on one of the
game's most prolific players famous
YouTuber and gamer Markiplier if playing
this game counts as training then
Markiplier has enough hours long to be a
Bonafide expert in facing off against
the many dangerous anomalies at the SCP
Foundation so kick back crack open some
g-fuel and let's see if Markiplier lives
to game another day to set the scene
let's all imagine that somehow through a
hiccup in time and space or by some sort
of wish on a cursed monkey's paw
Markiplier found himself inside of an
SCP Foundation containment site that
would be bad enough but the blaring
alarms and sounds of chaos signal that
he arrived at the worst possible time
during a containment breach the security
systems are down the cells are open and
danger lurks around every corner armed
with nothing but his wits and winning
personality the only thing he can do is
try to navigate the facility as
carefully as possible remember
everything he's learned from his time
streaming the video game version of this
place and hope he can escape with his
life let's start with one we know he'd
be well equipped to face
SCP-173 the next snapping sculpture is
the main antagonist of SCP Containment
Breach so Markiplier would be familiar
with the necessary precautions to avoid
winding up as its next victim if he
happened to walk into a room and spot
the figure Frozen in his gaze he would
know to keep his eyes on the sculpture
no matter what and slowly back out of
the room without blinking plus with all
the time he spends looking at screens
he's definitely used to keeping his eyes
on one thing for a long period of time
congratulations Mark you survived that
one he's managed to get away from
SCP-173 with his neck still intact
hooray but as he sneaks through the hall
trying not to draw any unwanted
attention a French accented voice breaks
the silence behind him good evening my
fine fellow are you feeling quite well
there behind him is
scp-049 the plague doctor in all of his
beak masked black robed glory you look
feverish please allow me to administer
some simple tests in this scenario mark
would have to think fast and use some of
that patented Markiplier charm to get
himself out of a potentially sticky
situation before one of those gloved
hands can touch him he would need to
politely excuse himself insist that he
just saw his doctor earlier that day and
then before the plague doctor can take
another step closer run as fast as he
possibly could in the opposite direction
as Markiplier stops to catch his breath
having thrown the plague doctor off of
his Trail the sound of sobbing in the
corner signals that he might have just
escaped the proverbial frying pan only
to wind up in the fire a quick cursory
glance up and the sight of a long-limbed
pale humanoid form would confirm his
suspicions yes yes indeed he's found
himself alone with scp-096 the shy guy
remembering the details of this
particular anomaly from the game he
would look back down at the ground
immediately making sure not to Glimpse
the creature's face as long as he
avoided looking at its face it would
stay in the corner of the room scarcely
even acknowledging him then he would be
free to make a Mad Dash for the exit all
the while scp-096 would stay hunched
over crying and completely aware it was
briefly in the presence of a beloved
YouTube personality things might be
going pretty well for Markiplier so far
but oh what's that sound the sliver of
tentacles on tile the thumping of a
large heart and the murmuring voice of
an elderly Englishman or Markiplier
video games definitely wouldn't have
prepared him for the arrival of
scp-058 the Heart of Darkness it's come
out of its cage and it's doing just fine
but the same can't be said for any
living thing that this creepy animate
and highly hostile creature encounters
and this suffering is the woe of
ignorant men who never lack to see the
depth of their own hearts and only see
the wealth of a poor World suffering of
silver and brutal gladness the heart
Whispers as it scuttles towards the
hapless YouTuber without much prior
knowledge of the anomaly mark would be
thoroughly unprepared for any encounter
with it he would likely fall victim to
its Spike tentacles or the sharp stinger
and any attempt to physically fight it
off would be ineffective due to the
anomaly's resilience to physical attacks
we don't need to get into the details of
how that specifically might
it would be a bit tasteless but there
are friendly anomalies that Markiplier
might stumble upon too suppose instead
of suffering an untimely end at the
tentacles of a heart monster that speaks
in creepy atmospheric gibberish he found
himself face to face with scp-073 Kane
it would be a nice reprieve to be sure
as Kane is generally Pleasant and
congenial to any humans he needs you
never know he might even be a fan of
Mark's Work the same can be said for
Kane's counterpart
scp-076 however it's nothing personal
Abel feels murderous rage towards any
and all human beings but it's hard not
to take it personally when you see Abel
running at you at full speed brandishing
a massive sword that's poised to take
your head off with one swing if
Markiplier faced Abel on his own he
would unfortunately not stand much of a
chance again it's nothing personal he's
a super powerful ancient warrior with a
taste for Bloodshed if Kane was in the
vicinity however then he might just be
able to escape on scathed Kane is one of
the few anomalies that can easily oppose
Abel as any damage Abel manages to do to
him will only affect Abel so the best
case scenario for Mark would be to let
the two Immortals go at it while he
sneaks away quietly after all the stress
of navigating the containment site
Markiplier would probably really need
some cheering up after all his entire
sense of reality is crumbling around him
at a rapid Pace good news because
scp-999 can always sense when someone
nearby needs that frown turned upside
down the Tickle Monster doesn't appear
in the Containment Breach game so Mark
might not know what to expect when he
sees a large mass of bright orange slime
oozing toward him at a rapid Pace but
once scp-999 wrapped him in a big hug
and its natural mood boosting properties
kicked in he would know that this
particular creature is friend not phone
he would give the slimy visitor some
affectionate paths and the Tickle
Monster would coo happily in return
scp-999 might try to follow Markiplier
down the hall but he would insist it
stay where it is needed helping the
various humans and anomalies of the
foundation when they need a little bit
of sweetness and light in their lives
then the two would part ways each with
their spirits lifted and with fond
memories of their new friend that would
last a lifetime but you can never let
your guard down at the SCP Foundation
not even for a second as you're enjoying
a hug from everyone's favorite happy
slime Creature if you relax and forget
to keep your wits about you you might
not notice the wall behind you starting
to warp and melt as something horrible
reaches through it from a dark place
outside space and time if Markiplier
turned around to find himself face to
face with the cold dead eyes of scp-106
the old man what would happen next the
rotten old man appears in Containment
Breach so mark would know exactly how
bad things can get of this ominous
octogenarian gets his decaying hands on
him he would also know that doors walls
and other solid objects are not enough
to deter this entity once he sets his
sights on taking you it is possible that
Mark could run could stay out of the old
man's sight until the creature gets
bored or find some other more convenient
prey to snatch up but it's more than
likely that scp-106 would be excited by
the Chase and would Delight in the fear
and pain that he is causing unlike in
Containment Breach where scp-106's
movements can be predicted the real
thing is far more crafty and malicious
and there's no starting over if the old
man catches up to you in the real world
unfortunately Markiplier would likely
find himself pulled through the wall and
into the entity's lair where only Doom
would be waiting how might Markiplier
fare against another prominent character
in Containment Breach though say one
very tricky possessive mask thankfully
his experience with the game would have
taught Mark in advance that scp-035
cannot be trusted under any
circumstances however the mask in the
game is at least a little bit helpful
off offering valuable information about
navigating the containment site and even
providing insight into other threats to
the player's safety the real thing is
nowhere near as generous it has no
desire to help humans or anyone but
itself really if it wound up in the same
room as Markiplier it would only have
one goal and one goal only get him to
take it out of its case and put it over
his face hopefully Markiplier would know
better than to wear the wicked porcelain
mask but its psychic influence is strong
we couldn't blame him if he wound up
succumbing to it putting it on and
becoming the mask's newest human host it
would be thrilled to have found such a
famous body to take over too who would
pilot Markiplier out of the containment
site take him back home and become the
first SCP with over 1 million YouTube
subscribers aside from this channel of
course I shudder to think what scp-035
would do with such a massive platform it
definitely wouldn't be anything good now
there aren't just anomalies at the
foundation there are are lots of Staff
members working to keep the well-oiled
machine running smoothly of course some
are better at this than others and some
staff are just agents of chaos all on
their own but that makes life more fun
Imagine a team up between the most
fun-loving memeable researcher at the
SCP Foundation and markiplier that's
right Dr Jack Bright himself now many
people don't know this but Dr bright is
a big fan of gaming YouTubers and has
wanted to start a Channel of his own for
quite some time the foundation won't
allow him to run any of his own social
media concerned about the potential for
secure information leaking to the public
but a chance encounter with one of his
favorite YouTube creators would be just
the kind of opportunity Dr bright has
been waiting for sure Markiplier might
be caught a bit off guard by a strange
man and an amulet asking him to collab
but Dr Bright's big personality sense of
humor and high energy would make him a
great guest to have on the channel at
least until he finds something else to
distract him from his own existential
dread and abandons his streaming dreams
for that he definitely get Markiplier to
autograph The Amulet first though that's
for sure lots of people love Markiplier
he's a congenial guy with a passion for
making enjoyable content but there's one
anomaly at the foundation that wouldn't
like him at all in fact he would find
him frankly
disgusting but that's not his fault
scp-682 hates all living things that's
kind of its whole deal well that in
being impossible to kill the massive
rageville reptile is incredibly
dangerous to anything and anyone it
encounters and sadly Markiplier would be
no exception this creature doesn't care
about likability or how much a person
has contributed to contemporary internet
culture it only cares about destruction
about snapping the poor YouTuber up in
its jaws or knocking him into the wall
with one swash of its enormous tale
unless Markiplier happened to have a
spare nuclear warhead on him it's not
likely that he would make it out of
meeting with scp-682 in one piece oh no
not his head wait is that The Bite of 87
sorry I had to do it for the meme
speaking of 87 however how would
Markiplier fare if he stumbled upon
scp-087 the stairwell it's not the
likeliest of events seeing as the
doorway leading to it is constructed of
reinforced steel with an electro release
lock and is disguised as the entrance to
a Janitor's Closet in an undisclosed
building but in this world stranger
things have happened Markiplier has
played more than enough horror games to
know that finding yourself in a dark
staircase that seems to go on forever
where you can hear the distant cries of
a distressed child isn't something
anyone would ever want he could try and
descend the staircase looking for a way
out but if he did all that would await
him is creeping dread and paranoia and
an encounter with a frightening face of
scp-087-1 his best hope in this scenario
would be to take a seat at the top of
the stairs and wait for his loyal fan
base to notice he hasn't been online for
a while the internet is a powerful thing
and it's possible they could track him
down and rescue him before things got to
die otherwise well best not to think
about that over the span of their
careers many online personalities and
digital content creators have found
themselves in need of a Rebrand maybe
they decide to make a new type of
creative work maybe they wind up at the
center of a scandal or maybe they just
got bored of doing the same thing over
and over again if Markiplier ever
decided to change things up there are
dozens of ways he could go about it but
there's one that he would need to visit
the SCP Foundation for it wouldn't be
necessarily advisable but what if
Markiplier decided to engage in some
anomalous self-improvement using scp-914
the Clockworks using live test subjects
with this machine is always a bit dicey
and he would need to be extremely
careful about what setting he used the
very fine setting could produce some
really exciting results maybe it would
improve his eyesight or give him the
ability to work long hours without
experiencing Creator burnout maybe it
would give him the ability to fly or to
spontaneously generate a Wi-Fi hotspot
no matter where he was or how little
phone signal he had maybe it would make
him the greatest gamer in the world
there's really only one reason to find
out just make sure to hit the right
button or several million people would
be very very
sad speaking of self-improvement what
would happen if Markiplier got his hands
on an anomalous computer program not one
of the Dangerous Ones but an educational
one intended to help children learn new
skills
scp-1594 Miss Jay's Wizkid Schoolhouse
would be a perfect fit he'd have to find
a way to play it on his computer but
once he did Markiplier could live stream
his experience with the software it's
uncertain how the anomalous effect of
scp-1594 would translate into a massive
audience but it would be amazing to see
if thousands of people could learn a new
skill at once it would be potentially
life-changing for everyone involved
speaking of helpful anomalies Markiplier
would greatly benefit from an
introduction to
scp-662 the butler's handbell running a
YouTube channel takes a ton of work and
having an eager Supernatural assistant
on call 24 hours a day would probably
really improve the quality of life for
everyone involved Mr Deeds would be
happy to assist with whatever date today
tasks might come up and could even
become a beloved background character on
the channel whether it's bringing Mark a
bag of Takis or helping edit video
footage there's very little this helpful
British Butler can't do when you get
famous and successful and when you
become a public figure online it seems
like everyone out there wants a piece of
you people want money attention to ride
someone's coattails to fame but what
about an anomaly that quite literally
wants a piece of Markiplier or any
person really
scp-082 Ferdinand the cannibal would
love to meet Markiplier and would love
to make Markiplier his meat he would
probably use his habit for lying and
spinning elaborate stories to attempt to
entice Mark into a dangerous situation
hello Markiplier it's me your friend
jacksepticeye he would say while very
visibly not being who he claims to be
it's time to film a new video challenge
see how long you can stay in the Soup
pot just hop in the pot of boiling water
don't mind me cutting up cards and
onions into it as long as Mark keeps his
wits about him and doesn't fall for the
extremely obvious lies he would likely
escape this confrontation without ending
up in a YouTuber's stew Markiplier is
somewhat familiar with the layout of the
SCP Foundation containment site thanks
to the gameplay of containment breach
but what if after freeing himself from
one anomalous nightmare he stumbled into
another one altogether what if months
after his inexplicable teleportation
into the containment site after life was
starting to get back to normal he was in
the market for a brand new gaming chair
and what if he decided to prioritize
convenience and Scandinavian furniture
Engineering in his selection process and
what if on top of all of that he had a
craving for some Swedish meatballs
consumed in a public food court why all
of those factors might just lead him to
Ikea and while there are hundreds of
Ikeas around the country it's not
impossible that he might just pick the
wrong one and find himself lost inside
of scp-3008
Markiplier is a fairly observant guy so
it likely wouldn't take him long to
notice that something is a bit off
inside of this particular retail store
there wouldn't be any other Shoppers
around him the aisles would go on
forever and the employees inside
wouldn't have faces that last one would
probably be the biggest giveaway
unfortunately once someone is inside the
infinite Ikea it's pretty unlikely that
they will ever leave he would give it a
noble effort to be sure exploring his
surroundings and finding the best places
to hide from the Ikea staff when the
lights go out if his phone is fully
charged he might even be the first
person to live stream from the depths of
this anomalous furniture outlet and
spread the word to his fans about the
existence of scp-3008 but sadly that
stream would probably wind up being his
last unless he somehow figured out a way
to recreate his YouTube setup inside of
his strange new home if he did though
that would be pretty cool almost cool
enough to make up for the fact that he
would never see any of his friends or
family ever again fortunately for
everyone involved it's highly unlikely
that Markiplier will end up interacting
with any SCP anomalies without the safe
barrier of a computer monitor in between
them but just in case reality ever bends
in on itself and worlds begin to collide
hopefully Mark will remember everything
he's learned and to anyone who's ever
told you otherwise see playing video
games can help you in the real world it
might even save your life here we are
again with the indomitron 6000. our
state-of-the-art simulation computer
that helps us create hyper accurate
simulations of some of the world's most
bizarre scenarios whether it's scp-096
versus siren head able vs chainsaw man
or now perhaps our most ridiculous
matchup yet
scp-035 the Diabolical possessive mask
versus The Mask the popular Jim Carrey
character based on the hyper-violent
comic book of the same name so what the
heck are we waiting for let's crank up
the machine and see what the results are
somebody stop me okay so what have we
got on intake today researcher were best
a tone of boredom hanging off his every
word uh possible anomalous entity his
compatriot Dr mackney replied sipping
his coffee sounding equally as
unenthused Caucasian male early 30s a
team of our agents picked him up in the
foundation doctor checked his notes some
place called Edge City real appealing
tourist spot he added sarcastically now
what's so anomalous about him warp
questioned his eyes lazily scanned over
a file mackney had handed him says here
he's just an ordinary bank teller
there's one prior arrest on his record
but the charges were dropped later on
and the sky's a nobody apparently he was
in possession of an anomalous artifact
came the doctor's reply he looked
through the one-way glass into the
interrogation room sat at the table
wearing a matching pair of hideous
pajamas was a wiry brown-haired man what
was it researcher worb asked not
bothering to check the file a mask
apparently mackney replied this thing
can form a symbiotic connection with
whoever wears it this guy's had it for a
while and causes him to undergo a
dramatic intensification of his
personality when he puts it on as well
as granting him some unusual abilities
hold on aren't you just describing as
cp035 worb said looking confused nope
the doctor responded by handing him a
clear evidence bag and it was a single
wooden mask a dull darkish green tint to
the object it looked to be almost Viking
in its design with three holes on its
surface one for the mouth and two for
the eyes it was hard to deny it was
completely different from the white
porcelain of
scp-035 what's this guy's name again
word side looking at the scruffy pajama
clad man waiting for them ipkiss his
colleague replied Stanley ipkes
meanwhile locked up tight in a
hermetically sealed glass case was
another anomalous mask
scp-035 was kept under lock and key by
the foundation guarded constantly by a
pair of armed security officers one of
them officer regert had noticed
something strange about the infamous
possessive mass today or Stranger than
usual anyway
scp-035 was known to compel people to
wear it if they were close enough often
through subtle psychic Whispers but
today it seemed Restless almost agitated
like it found something nearby to be
intensely annoying I already told you
everything I know Stanley ebka signed
exhaustedly he'd been dragged out of bed
at the crack of dawn by strange agents
and was now being interrogated about
what he knew of the wooden mask he'd
come across floating in the river one
fateful night I don't know where it came
from I swear I didn't even realize I
still had it we threw it back in the
river but my dog must have swung out and
fetched it Stanley explained you have no
idea what this thing is not even from
any first-hand experience Mr epcus Dr
mackney asked holding the mask up look I
did take it to a psychologist who told
me it might be Scandinavian a
representation of some Norse night God
the Loki I think he answered we're not
interested in this mask as a historical
art piece researcher were retorted tell
us what happens when you put it on
Stanley paused for a moment clearly
aware he was in real trouble but nervous
about coughing up the details to his
Shady captors with a sigh he decided it
was best to confess us
I don't know how it works but whenever
you put it on it's like it brings your
deepest desires to life I wear that mask
I can do anything be anything he
described remembering a key detail but
it only works at night Dr mackney and
researcher were of exchanged looks
uncertain if ipkiss was just a lunatic
or if there was truth to what he was
telling them assemble a security team
McNeese side will arrange a safe
environment for you tonight Mr utkus
elsewhere in the facility regert and his
fellow security officer Duggan was
watching over scp-035 with growing
concern what do you reckon has this
thing so agitated Dugan wondered aloud
who knows regard side I've already
reported it to command told them zero
three fives in a mood they said to
proceed as normal suddenly as the words
left his mouth officer regert felt
strange it was like he had been hooked
by an overwhelming urge to put the
possessive mask on he barely noticed he
had reached to unlock the door sealing
the area where scp-035 was contained in
its case and as he stepped through
officer Dugan's pleas for him to stop
barely registered the other officer
tried in vain to pull regard back as he
walked towards the possessive mask only
to feel his co-worker grip his shirt and
swing him face first over and over again
into the glass case containing the
anomalous object his body going
completely limp after being used to
break the glass rigor dropped Dugan to
the floor two lost in his trance-like
state to realize he'd just killed a
fellow Foundation security officer he
was too focused on scp-035 as he lifted
it up and placed it over his face
meanwhile Stanley idkis had been brought
to a testing area a team of security
officers standing around him the fact
that they were all armed did little to
ease Stanley's nerves Dr mackney strod
up to him pulling the green wooden mask
out of the airtight bag it had been
sealed in and handed it to Stanley now
funny business Mr ipkiss the doctor
warmed I really can't promise that
Stanley replied he looked at the mask in
his hands noticed a green Shimmer over
the reverse side of it as much as he had
gladly given it up part of him had
missed wearing it he could already hear
the low rumbling of thunder outside as
he lifted it towards his face feeling it
almost leap out of his hands and latch
itself onto him the green mask eagerly
became attached to Stanley the surface
of it spreading out where it covered his
face and wrap around his entire head
around him the guards cautiously stepped
back as they watched Stanley convulse
and writhe around the place
uncontrollably like a man possessed both
researcher word and Dr mackney looked at
each other in wordless disbelief before
turning back to the scene unfolding
Before Their Eyes the booming noise of
thunder and cracks of lightning rang out
despite this all taking place indoors as
Stanley of Kiss vanished in the center
of a miniature tornado that spun wildly
around the testing area before slowing
to a halt in its place stood a maniacal
wide-eyed figure dressed in a garish
yellow zoot suit and wearing an enormous
tooth grin on his bright green face how
do
you've had the mask bombastically hooted
at the guards having been trained to
deal with absurd anomalies of Plenty the
security Team all defensively raised
their weapons out of a mix of instinct
and confusion fish rough ground the
green face lunatic stated to nobody it
looked like he had turned aside as if
addressing some invisible audience
outstretching both arms and one leg The
Mask instantly zipped off hurling around
the room in a whirlwind of absurdity in
the style of an old Tech Savory cartoon
the spinning cackling combination of
Stanley ipkiss and the Magical mask
weaved in between the foundation guards
all of whom tried in vain to restrain
him until he disappeared out of the door
after after him Dr mackney yelled with
urgency in his voice the guards all
turned to run after the mask only for
each one of them to trip over and land
face first on the floor of the testing
area as if something had tied them all
up by their ankles it was only after the
security officers all struggled back up
to their feet that they noticed their
pants had been yanked down leaving the
foundation's finest somewhat embarrassed
to say the least outside the testing
area Stanley or rather the mask had
already closed the door behind him out
of nowhere he produced a series of
wooden planks and began hammering them
into the door frame boarding it up
before speedily adding chains and
padlocks to the mix sighing and in an
over-exaggerated manner wiping the sweat
from his brow he turned around only to
be met with the sight of even more SCP
Foundation guards lying in weight their
guns all trained on him the mass gave a
scream of pure Terror that briefly sent
his skull popping out of his head and
his eyes shooting out of his skull
before everything zipped right back into
its original National Place his eyes
started to round up the faces of the
foundation's security wondering how he
was going to get out of this one oh gee
this all seems familiar he said either
to himself or with his audience well if
it ain't broken hit it in the blink of
an eye the mask's bright yellow outfit
had transformed replaced by a silk blue
Rumba shirt with ruffled sleeves white
pants and a wide brim black hat as they
watched him stood at the ready a few of
the cards noticed the sound of music not
one of them could tell where it was
coming from nor could they help starting
to tap their feet or Bob their heads to
the rhythm of the Cuban Pete Rumba the
entire security team quickly erupted
into a full-blown dance number that
anyone who saw it couldn't resist
joining all led by The Mask wildly
waving Maracas in the air and singing
elsewhere in the facility officer regert
was beginning to melt he still had
scp-035 covering his face the frown of
the possessive Mass conveying the
entity's sheer discontent the black ooze
secreting from its porcelain surface had
the unfortunate effect of corroding and
melting down anyone that wore it
dissolving them entirely after a short
period of time determined as cp035
pushed on plotting its host towards a
storage room if it remembered correctly
the SCP Foundation had stored a number
of temporary hosts for it mannequins
that while not human had enough of a
humanoid shape for the possessive mask
to use of course after all of its
attempts to escape the foundation had
rescinded its privilege to be granted
new hosts not that it could stop it from
taking them by force using the last of
Officer regert's dwindling strength
scp-035 barched its way into the
storeroom sure enough waiting there for
it was a row of discarded mannequins
lifting regert's hands before they had
fully melted away the possessive mask
used him to place itself on a new body
elsewhere not too far away in the
foundation facility a conga line of
security officers and research personnel
was parading through the corridors all
happily dancing and jiving to the music
despite still no one being able to
figure out where it was coming from
dashing away from his spot at the front
of the line the mask zipped around a
corner his clothes having changed back
to his signature brightly colored Zoot
Suit never say no to a party he
exclaimed after having danced his way to
Freedom the sound of something shuffling
closer quickly caught the mask's
attention he turned around to find
himself standing green face to porcelain
face with scp-035 you the masked
mannequin raised a hollow arm pointing a
finger from its host at Stanley you bear
the god of mischiefs carving I could
sense its presence since you arrived
still in my luck nobody likes a copycat
Villa The Mask replied although
intimidation is the sincerest form of
flattery and that's how Jim Carrey's
career started
he added exploding with rash's laughter
cease you're prattling a CP 035 hissed
with spite say perhaps we're related The
Mask ignored it oh we could be long-lost
family you know I always wanted kids of
my own Son of the Mask has a nice ring
to it right he paused once again turning
away to his unseen audience
maybe not the scp-035 controlled
mannequin left forward gripping the
mask's arm causing him to scream and
shock at the advanced his eyes bulged
out of their sockets zooming in on the
corrosive black secretions oozing from
scp-035 the mannequin's other hand
started reaching upwards gripping his
oversized green head as if it were
trying to lift the mask right off of
Stanley's face zooming away again he
sped down the nearest Corridor his arms
stretching behind him still clamped in
scp-035's grip coming to a screeching
halt with a comical sound of car brakes
The Mask wobbled his outstretched arm a
ripple traveled all the way along the
elongated limb as if it was made of
elastic his wrists still being held by
the mannequin sporting the possessive
mask the force of the flailing rubbery
arm was so great that it flung scp-035's
host body around sending it head first
into the ceiling then plummeting back
down to the ground it's grip loosened
allowing the mask to reel back its
stretchy arm although it didn't return
to normal length right away his own hand
pinged back and hit him in the face only
to start urgently trying to communicate
of its own accord what's that boy The
Mask said to his hand as it started
performing a series of signals little
Timmy stuck down a well you'd like a
Friday night off there's a two-bit jump
wearing another mask walking men to
sling down the hall towards us the hand
suddenly turned the mask said to look in
the right direction sure enough
scp-035 was using the mannequin to walk
down the hall towards him his elongated
arm quickly returned to its normal size
as the green face lunatic took a quick
draw stance facing his oncoming
adversary now you have to ask yourself
one question he sneered doing a fairly
convincing impression of a green Clint
Eastwood do I feel lucky with a sweep of
his hand The Mask had drawn an enormous
weapon the thing was a gigantic mass of
different artillery clicking and
whirring there were barrels on top of
barrels rockets and other explosives
locked a place do I feel lucky the mass
continued well do you punk
scp-035 did nothing to slow its advance
so the mask pulled the trigger every one
of his weapons various components spat
out a tiny flag with the word bang
written on it ah performance issue he
said doing his aside once again not that
I'm overcompensating for anything
clearly growing agitated piloting its
host
scp-035 started charging towards the
mask immediately he spun around becoming
a tornado of hyperactivity and whooping
noises as he sped down the adjacent
Corridor the possessive mask staggered
after him the use leaking from the
porcelain anomaly was Dripping onto the
mannequin wearing it causing the plastic
to be melted away exposing the flimsy
metal skeleton beneath it knew it had to
merge with a new host find something
else to corrupt
scp-035 chased after the cartoonish
Troublemaker knowing that if it could
catch him he'd be able to survive
merging with it his body body while
wearing the other mask barely obeyed the
laws of physics making him invulnerable
to damage and possibly even the
corrosive substance oozing from the
possessive mask as if those weren't
enough reasons his power seemed
virtually Limitless combined with the
green-headed lunatic
scp-035 could do anything reaching a
stop at the end of another Corridor The
Mask spun around wearing a comically
undersized baseball uniform he reached
into his pocket and produced an
oversized baseball bat then proceeded to
start hurling baseballs into the air and
swatting them as hard as he could as the
mask increased the speed of his swings a
volley of hard-corked baseballs were
fired down the corridor like a barrage
of bullets ricocheting off the walls and
hitting the oncoming scp-035 each one
struck its Target reeling the mannequin
but doing little much else to stop it
getting closer and closer until With An
Almighty swing The Mask brought us back
crashing into scp-03 5 with enough Force
to send the possessive mask and its
hosts careening down the corridor it
sailed through the air bursting through
a wall then flew into a research lab
tearing a huge hole in the next wall as
it kept going finally it came crashing
out of the last wall the outer wall of
the facility and dropped multiple
stories to the ground outside changing
costumes back to his classic suit and
dashing after scp-035 the mask passed
through all the holes his adversary had
left in the multiple walls it had
crashed into he screeched to a halt
again and paused after getting through
the outer wall only to realize after a
moment that he was hovering in mid-air
not standing on anything reaching into
his suit pocket The Mask pulled out a
sign on a stick with a single word
written on it yikes he plummeted down to
ground level Landing with such an
immense crash that his body cracked into
the asphalt below it left a perfect
outline of him imprinted in the ground
causing the mass to go completely
pancake flat head to toe
suddenly before he could peel himself up
off the ground and go back to being
three-dimensional
scp-035 staggered to its host's feet and
pinned The Mask down finally it growled
I've caught you I've won your power is
mine once I've combined with you I will
be able to ravage this world I'm going
to fuse to your face then I'll start
with decimating those wretches that
imprison me the foundation will fall and
then so will the rest of their precious
World forcefully the mannequin's hand
wrenched the mask off the ground but as
scp-035 turned to look at what it had
hoped to be its next host well let's
just say the tragedy frown carved into
its porcelain face had never been more
appropriate it wasn't holding the mask
it was holding a life-size cardboard
cutout of a photo of the Mask grinning
out from one side enrage the possessive
Mass tore the decoy in half with its
mannequin's hands Hey Pachuco said a
cartoonish voice from right behind it
did you miss me the mask had reappeared
for real this time grinning with his
huge teeth clearly getting a kick out of
having someone to torment
scp-035 on the other hand had been
getting increasingly irritated by all
the wacky cartoon Antics with all the
aggression it could Channel through its
mannequin host it gripped The Mask by
the throat his eyes bulging out of his
head again
need to get all choked up over it he
gagged you are so tiresome the
possessive mask yelled having finally
run out of patience you know what I
won't merge with you I should just kill
you and put an end to your buffoonery
let me take this thing off you first
though its mannequin fingers started to
hook into the mask's seam at the back of
his bald green head wait wait the mask
bag putting up both his hands and
surrender at least give me a final
request huh Master mask before the
possessive mask could respond the mask
had swept it off its dissolving
mannequin feet he started to spin it
around in a wild over the top dance
number bopping and Swinging to a tune
that seemed to be coming from nowhere
the longer it went on for the more and
more of scp-035's host's body started to
dissolve away until the mannequin
finally wasted away all that was left
was a bubbling pile of black goo on the
ground with the possessive mask laying
in the middle The Mask chuckled noticing
the fumes trailing upwards into the air
as the corrosive substance melted away
the last of
scp-035's host talk about smoking
when you work for the SCP Foundation you
need to be ready for anything that's one
as part of the elite foundation training
regiment senior researchers and guards
are always running tests even against
things that aren't recorded anomalies
under the auspices of the foundation
that's why today for a real change of
pace here at SCP explained we're not
talking about the SCP Foundation we're
talking about made-up monster stories
crowdsourced over the Internet we're
seeing how the foundation might fare
against iconic Creepypasta monsters and
Maniacs like Herobrine Jeff the Killer
the Slenderman Eyeless Jack smile dog
and many many more we've even created
all new mobile task courses to take each
one down so could any of them best the
foundation's best and brightest let's
take a look and find out and be sure to
tell us which is your favorite
Creepypasta entity down in the comments
below let's get creepy Jeff the Killer
first up we've got everyone's favorite
disfigured knife-wielding homicidal
teenager whether it's his terrifying
Visage or the iconic go to sleep
catchphrase that's forever carved into
your mind there are probably a lot of
people out there who have lost nights of
sleep worrying that this pale-faced
monster could be crawling through their
window but we know what you're probably
wondering isn't Jeff just a serial
killer why would the SCP Foundation use
up its time chasing down any old regular
human murderer we'd ask for you to think
again Jeff has displayed Feats that
clearly Mark him as anomalous despite
suffering debilitating Burns to his face
and body he still shows superhuman
strength agility and durability he's
also able to see without eyelids
suggesting some Supernatural element is
at play victims have also reported him
dodging shotgun blasts while stalking
prey so how would the foundation catch
seeing as Jeff's modus operandi is
breaking into the homes of his victims
while they sleep the best method would
be staking out a neighborhood where he's
been shown to be active keeping close
observations on houses and even setting
up Personnel for mobile task force Sigma
9. my name is JF in vacant houses as
honey traps Jeff is undeniably strong
fast and tough but if attacked and
surrounded by operatives with Superior
Tactics he could be subdued without
casualties then it would just be a
matter of transferring him to a standard
high security humanoid containment cell
speaking of horrifying creatures that
come to you in the dead of night The
Rake this Supernatural entity has been
around for almost a thousand years as
far as scattered reports are aware it's
also been reported across four
continents and a huge number of
locations within those continents though
most recently it's been reported in
rural New York State and Idaho in the
early 2000s The Rake is an inhuman Beast
most often known for its large
frightening eyes and its Long brake-like
Claws not only does the monster feed on
human beings but it also produces a
traumatic level of fear in its victims
thankfully an entity like this is far
more familiar territory for the SCP
Foundation using their state-of-the-art
web crawler software they could catalog
reported sightings as they happen and
use clusters of these sightings to
triangulate the location of the rake and
dispatch field agents to perform
reconnaissance missions from there it
would just be a matter of waiting to
strike and sending in Mobile task force
Zeta 13 rake steppers fitted with Dr
Dan's scramble goggles to prevent them
from being affected by the seemingly
Cognito hazardous effects of viewing the
rake when the creature is placed in
containment and kept in the state of
Perpetual bright light it would simply
be a matter of applying a Scranton
reality anchor to prevent the creature
from somehow phasing out of containment
just make sure you avoid its big staring
eyes in the meantime though that won't
be a problem with the next Creepypasta
monster Eyeless Jack this stealthy
creature has its no eyes on one thing
and one thing only your kidneys and
unless you want to die or spend the rest
of your life on a dialysis machine we
recommend you keep your distance from
him he's discreet devious and diabolical
and if you wake up in the middle of the
night to see him staring down at you it
may be the last time your body is able
to filter toxins out of its blood
naturally thankfully we have a way to
make the foundation put a stop to his
organ harvesting ways sometimes to catch
a jack you need to use a jack there's no
way to catch Eyeless Jack without
delicious live kidney bait so we'd
recommend sending in someone who has
kidneys to spare Dr Jack Bright could be
the perfect bait without losing his life
luring Eyeless Jack into a decoy house
while mobile task force gamma 391 Hit
the Road Jack prepares to Spring their
cunning trap and plunge this unpleasant
kidney muncher into a humanoid
containment cell forever but our next
Creepypasta entity doesn't want your
kidneys it wants your life
Smile Dog our next entity seems like a
harmless little JPEG to the untrained
eye a little freaky sure but nothing to
lose your mind over but we know that
there's far more to this grinning husky
than meets the eye if some reports are
to be believed this image may even be
connected to the Devil Himself if you're
unlucky enough to see this image in the
world it may already be too late for you
those who see it typically as an email
attachment from a mysterious address
spend the last week of their life in a
hell of the Mind before eventually
succumbing to a bleak and mysterious
death it's a classic Cognito hazardous
image and the most frightening part is
that it's self-propagating with one of
the only ways to even mildly alleviate
the effects seeming to be spreading the
word by subjecting another person to
this nightmare that's when we bring in
Mobile task force row 19 Naughty Dog an
elite group of hardened military
programmers hand-picked from the cia's
cyber warfare unit they used their very
particular set of skills to design web
crawler software that Roots out and
takes down Smile Dog images across the
web and hopefully one day find the
origin of this whole thing the next
creature on the other hand we've given
up on finding the origin of that the
expressionless this entity kind of looks
like a terrifying store window mannequin
except rather than modeling fast fashion
she prefers to swallow cats whole and
murder hospital staff oh and she also
calls herself God is isn't she just so
quirky her primary abilities seemed to
be extreme strength and large sharp
teeth that will easily Rend through
human flesh thankfully not anything the
SCP Foundation hasn't dealt with
countless times before seeing as the
only recorded incident involving the
expression list took place at a hospital
in Los Angeles that would be the most
sensible area to stake out a detail from
the creature's original encounter is
also telling it reacted severely to the
doctor's attempts to sedate it implying
that chemical sedation is an effective
method of incapacitating the beast
that's why every member of mobile task
force Kappa 99 ain't no dummy is a
sharpshooter with a tranquilizer rifle
capable of putting a hippo to sleep with
a single shot she'll probably feel less
like a god in her containment cell but
while this monster is expressionless the
next one has one very notable expression
Mr whitemouth compared to some of our
other Creepypasta tenders Mr Widemouth
may not look like much but that our dear
friends is exactly what this nasty
little Mal Factor wants you to think he
may look like Gizmo's slightly demented
cousin but his intentions are even more
Sinister than that of your average
Gremlin if you're a kid home on a sick
day Mr Widemouth might strike up a
conversation after gaining your trust
he'll try to lure you to his special
place beyond the trees for some fun but
take it from us all you'll find out
there is your doom this crafty little
creep small stature and manipulative
stealth abilities might pose somewhat of
a challenge for the SCP Foundation but
that doesn't mean they can't get him
with a little intelligence and elbow
grease mobile task force Alpha 18 the
smile Smashers will follow reports of
children disappearing from their
isolated homes under mysterious
circumstances then using an extra
strength butterfly net straight from the
folks at Foundation r and D they can
chase down and capture the nasty little
monster but that won't be the case for
this next demonic offering no this
Creepypasta Legend is the one that
captures you
no end house in recent years there's
been a spike in interest in so-called
extreme haunted houses if you're not
sure what these places are like
basically picture a CIA black site with
the occasional plastic skeleton it's all
waterboarding stress positions and car
batteries but even those places are
nothing compared to the nightmare of no
end house it's a moving possibly even
sentient spatial anomaly hiding in a
haunted house attraction and if you find
yourself inside best believe you're
never going to see the outside ever
again thankfully mobile task force Delta
35 mckamey's Bane are on the case around
Halloween every year they use web
crawlers to detect chatter around no end
House events so they can swoop in and
intercept preventing hapless Thrill
Seekers from being devoured by the house
and providing amnestic treatment for
anyone who has too close of a call sadly
the foundation will not be able to
provide refunds for those who already
Aid speaking of paying you'll really pay
if you end up in our next Creepypasta
location of tune abandoned by Disney
mowgli's kingdom an abandoned tropical
Disney attraction based on The Jungle
Book movie is abandoned for a reason
it's a hotbed for anomalous activity
including freakishly large mutant snakes
reports of ghostly activity and most
prominent of all a terrifying photo
negative Mickey Mouse that stalks any
hapless Urban explorers who happen to
find their way onto the site of course
the Walt Disney Corporation keeps it all
hush hush and the SCP Foundation is
happy to give them a hand on that front
even if the frightening photo negative
Mickey was removed from the site it's
likely the other may appear and continue
haunting the site and seeing that the
site cannot be moved as a whole the
foundation's best bet is to form a
perimeter around the abandoned Disney
attraction preventing anything normal
from getting in and anything abnormal
from getting out mobile task force Omega
17 sons of Shira Khan are ever Vigilant
and maintain a strong presence in the
surrounding area but you don't need to
go anywhere for this next anomalous
Terror if you're a big Nintendo fan it
might be sitting in your house right now
Ben Drowned this haunted NES cartridge
of The Legend of Zelda Majora's Mask
contains the Restless Spirit of its last
owner a guy named Ben who well drowned
if you slot This creepy little gaming
experience into your Nintendo
Entertainment System you'll soon find
that the soul of Ben is communicating
with you directly telling you about how
he died and why his Consciousness
lingers on embedded in the code of the
game thankfully other than the
psychological trauma of experiencing the
game you're unlikely to be actually
harmed by playing it however mobile task
force beta 51 Gamers don't have rights
are still on the case they'll try to
intercept all cursed copies of the game
and then minister amnestics to anyone
who is unfortunate enough to play it
while it is still undeniably spooky it
does feel like a relief to finally find
a safe class anomaly on this list the
same can sadly not be said about our
next creature the goat man if you're a
fan of camping then this malicious mimic
is going to be your worst nightmare this
monster has existed as a fixture of
Terror in everything from a number of
Native American mythologies to iconic
4chan green text posts you may be
thinking oh What's So Scary About a goat
but this thing is no God aside from the
fact that it's the greatest of all time
and getting you to crap your cargo
shorts in the woods first you'll smell
blood in the air and then feel an odd
electrical static like the feeling all
around you right before a lightning
strike then you'll hear noises strange
noises something not quite like a voice
like an animal throat straining to form
human words that's when you might notice
your group of friends has one more
person than you remembered and the one
thing worse than noticing that is not
noticing that because if you don't you
may end up as the shape-shifting goat
man's latest victim mobile task force
Theta 11 got your goat are constantly on
the hunt for this one but it's extreme
intelligence and ethereal nature make it
a nightmare to track but forget
nightmares to track it's time for
Laughing Jack this candy striped clown
from hell is a really nasty customer
definitely do not engage unless you've
got a screen reality anchor on hand and
you've got a backup from members of
mobile task force Iota 40 put Jack in
the Box as a former imaginary friend
gone Rogue Laughing Jack is a
semi-intangible reality warper of
considerable power he targets his
victims with sadistic Glee pulling them
into his dark carnival to experience all
kinds of nasty tortures Laughing Jack
shows No Remorse giggling while
committing every evil act you can
imagine you'll probably only find this
clown funny if you're already a depraved
serial killer and his sense of humor is
likely to utterly break your mind unless
you've been given them nestic treatment
from the SCP Foundation this is an
anomaly that would probably get along
swimmingly with
scp-106 the old man they could chat over
a few drinks one evening and share notes
on how to cause the maximum pain to
their hapless victims that being said
few people understand maximum pain more
than the next horrifying Abomination on
our roster the Russian sleep experiment
test subjects has anyone familiar with
the work of Gru division P will tell you
the Soviets performed some pretty
horrific occult activities throughout
the 20th century one of the most
disturbing of these was the infamous
Russian sleep experiment where in a
group of unfortunate political prisoners
were doused on a classified anomalous
gas that robbed them of their ability to
sleep a chemical compound that the
scientists hope might increase the
productivity of their workers and
Soldiers by eliminating sleep instead
over several terrifying days the
chemical and the sleep deprivation that
ensued caused the subjects to instead
become demonic monsters while current
accounts of the story suggest that all
the subjects were killed we can't say
for sure there weren't more out there
but that the experiment hasn't been
repeated as such mobile task force
Omicron 8 99 is constantly only on the
lookout for freakish skeletal men
wandering through the woods never
sleeping outside the dark forests where
Siberian gulags used to be based better
safe than sorry right though of course
you won't feel safe at all if you've
spent your childhood watching scary
media like horror movies or Eerie SCP
YouTube channels like And subscribe by
the way or scariest of all a strange
little puppet show called Candle Cove
feel a little chill go down your spine
oh yes you remember this show don't you
you love seeing all those cute little
puppets going on swashbuckling pirate
Journeys on their adorable boat the
laughing stock though there was always
that villain wasn't there you think his
name was Jawbone but that's not what you
called him you called him the skin taker
because he always had that long cloak
made of tanned human skin you also
remember that one episode that was just
all the characters screaming I mean how
could you possibly forget and most of
all you remember asking your mom about
it and are telling you that you never
actually watched a show called Candle
Cove you just sat around watching static
for hours on end of course the SCP
Foundation keeps close tabs on
everything related to this traumatic
childhood memory broadcast of the show
are seemingly impossible to contain
while the foundation can really do is
track down people who have seen it and
provide amnestic treatment though trust
us there are things that will make your
childhood far worse than just watching
Candle Cove like running into this next
iconic monster the Slenderman this
terrifying entity is powerful as he is
Iconic a shape-shifting faceless
tentacled nightmare in a three-piece
suit who likes to hide in forests and
abandoned buildings either stealing
children away or influencing their minds
until they become his proxies
Supernatural servant who do anything
they're inhuman Master asks them to the
Slenderman is one of the most powerful
monsters in all of Creepypasta so the
foundation certainly has their hands
full with keeping his tentacles Under
Wraps all that mobile task force Chine
90 Marble Hornets can do is track
sightings and keep children out of the
woods when the danger of potential
Slenderman encounters arises getting him
actually contained basically seems out
of the question
after all this we might need to relax
maybe grabbing a nice sugar-free soda
and playing a session of Minecraft might
make us feel better we'll be safe there
right well probably unless we encounter
Herobrine the SCP Foundation funnily
enough is actually no stranger to
anomalies trapped in Minecraft they've
got
scp-4335 a welt in The Crucible to thank
for that but this Minecraft horror story
is a little more personal Herobrine is a
mysterious user with the Minecraft
default skin except with one difference
completely white eyes this mysterious
figure invades different Minecraft
servers acting incredibly strange
towards the people who created them what
makes this more than just some random
troll well according to Legends
Herobrine is the manifestation of the
Dead Brother of Minecraft's creator
Notch naturally the foundation doesn't
want people running into ghosts on
Minecraft so they dispatch mobile task
force chai 69 blocked and reported to
quarantine any servers where Herobrine
is cited and spread misinformation that
the crafty little entity had never
actually existed in the first place what
is the truth of the situation it's
unclear and that's exactly how the
foundation likes it so there we have it
folks how the SCP Foundation would
counteract some of the most infamous
Creepypasta creeps and creatures out
there which was your favorite do we miss
any and would you like to see any of
these expanded into a full video in the
future let us know down in the comments
if you dare
[Laughter]
everyone in the Sleepy Mountain Town had
heard stories about the abandoned mall
and the malevolent creature that lurked
in the wreckage there there had been
enough missing persons cases lost
children teenagers sneaking out to
explore and never returning home Urban
explorers who stumbled out of the
darkness disheveled and traumatized with
an eyewitness account no one wanted to
believe there wasn't anyone left in the
surrounding area willing to set foot in
that cursed place but that didn't stop
opportunistic out-of-towners from paying
the occasional visit especially if they
felt like there was money to be made in
those crumbling corporate walls Grant
and Jason the hosts of up-and-coming
investigative reality show ghostly
happenings were two such visitors when
they heard the rumors about an abandoned
Mall haunted by some sort of dark
presence blamed for The Disappearance of
local children they pack picked up their
van picked up their underpaid cameraman
Derek and headed straight for the
infamous building are you sure we're
allowed to be here Derek asked shakely
as he began filming nope Grant answered
cheerfully that's part of the fun Jason
laughed look man this place has been
left to rot by the city no one cares if
we're shooting some footage besides
worry less about the cops and more about
the ghosts of them all grandgrand
not funny Derek crumbled come on serious
faces were rolling Jason nudged his
co-host and the two snapped into their
on-camera personalities once a bustling
Center of suburban American life this
shopping mall has transformed into a den
of Terror Grant's voice dropped into a
lower register his expression intense
local swap stories of something inhuman
that calls this place home something
that doesn't take kindly to trespassers
Jason added a ghost a demon just an
urban legend that's what we're here to
find out Grant pulled out an EMF reader
which began beeping as he turned it on
ah there seems to be a lot of activity
in here already I'm picking up something
don't know if you folks at home can see
this put the meters going crazy Jason
exclaimed it was a fake meter of course
one that they rigged up to beep and
react when Grant press certain hidden
buttons but the audience didn't need to
know that they were tuning in for story
for spectacle not for the truth if they
wanted that they could flip over to the
nature Channel and watch some lions
chasing a gazelle on this show they were
chasing pure entertainment they
continued deeper into the building
taking in the massive echoey space the
dusty storefronts the beams of rotten
Woods strewn across the ground the rats
that skittered across the floor it was
the perfect creepy atmosphere maybe a
little too perfect a little too creepy
what was that Derek practically jumped
out of his skin spinning around to look
at something behind him hey stay on us
Grant snapped I saw something moving
back there Derek insisted it was a rat
Jason rolled his eyes there are tons of
them in here Derek shook his head no it
wasn't a rat it was way too big okay a
raccoon man come on get it together
we've been in way worse locations than
this remember that old tuberculosis
Hospital Grant shuttered God man that
was scary this is nothing well not
nothing Jason elbowed his partner I did
a good job scouting this place right
grant was about to answer when his foot
bumped something on the ground he looked
down and saw a Polaroid camera next to a
long empty water bottle and a small
backpack oh man get a shot of this Derek
obliged while Jason took a closer look
this must have belonged to one of the
Urban Explorer types who came in here he
unzipped the backpack rummaging around
hey look photos tons of them he dumped
the pictures out onto the ground think
he got some Spirit photography done
before he bit the dust I might as well
see Grant joined Jason on the ground
sifting through the photos as Derek
watched anxiously boring boring dear dog
Sunset now wait a minute he stopped
holding up one specific Polaroid this is
the money shot right here Derek zoom in
on this all three men looked at the
picture illuminated by the camera's
light it showed a tall long limbed pale
creature vaguely humanoid in shape but
at the same time distinctly not quite
human its mouth was stretched wide in a
wordless screech its eyes bloodshot and
wild it's long tapered fingers were
reaching towards the camera damn that's
spooky Jason laughed a bit of
nervousness creeping into his voice how
do you think he set this up Grant asked
what if it's real Derek swallowed the
lump in his throat don't be an idiot
Grant scoffed but then from the outside
not 100 feet away they heard a scream
ears splittingly loud filled with rage
pain and animalistic Instinct it was
like nothing any of them had ever heard
before the scream was followed by the
sound of splitting wood branches
crashing to the ground and horrifyingly
the sound of something breaking down a
nearby wall what did you do Jason backed
away from the sound me you open the
backpack Grant shot back guys I think we
need to get out of here Derek watched in
wide-eyed Terror as two pale hands
ripped a hole in the wall in front of
them making an opening for that pale
hairless head from the photograph to
poke through all three men prepared to
make a break for it and run for their
lives but as soon as the creature saw
them it was already too late with
another scream scp-096 sprinted toward
them grabbing each man and throwing them
to the ground the camera shattered into
pieces from the impact and Derek skidded
painfully across the ground as he rolled
onto his side to try and push back up to
his feet he caught a glimpse of the
monster opening its mouth impossibly
wide and descending on his bosses he
really didn't want to focus on what
happened next but suffice to say there
was nothing of them left afterwards
Derek tried his best to escape but he
was no match for the brute strength and
speed of scp-096 from the moment he saw
its face his fate was sealed there was
no Escape soon the beeping EMF meter the
scattered photographs and the broken
pieces of the camera were the only thing
left of the crew from ghostly happenings
their devoted fans would never get
another episode but at least one being
in the abandoned Mall could could rest
easy now
scp-096 was safe again no one was living
who had seen its face it slowly crawled
back to the hole it had made in the wall
ready to return to the forest and climb
back up the mountain there could curl up
beneath a tree and stay there for as
long as it wanted but as scp-096 reached
the hole in the wall where it had once
been able to see night sky stars and the
trees in the distance there was only
Blackness it was as if something dark
was stretching over the opening blocking
the outside world from view 096 reached
out a hand to push the blockage out of
the way but whatever it was slithered
away from the touch faster than the pale
hand could move the wriggling darkness
crept back into the building weaving in
and out of the shadows as scp-096
watched it curiously whatever it was it
hadn't looked at the creature's face yet
it wasn't sure if this thing even had
eyes but then stretching out of the
darkness an interview was a garish face
with wide white eyes with massive pupils
a round nose and a wide wide mouth
stretched into a toothy Grimace that
might have once looked like a smile this
was the creature that had made the mall
its home the apex predator of this
biosphere and it was staring directly at
scp-096's face it's face with the shriek
096 flew into a Primal Rage clawing at
the cat-like creature but before 096
could reach it the thing was gone where
was it where did it go 096 roared
tearing at the floor ripping up the tile
and gouging long deep scratches in the
concrete beneath a sound in the distance
Drew 096's attention and it bolted in
the direction of the noise swinging at
any obstacle in its path as it went it
wrote down a banner advertising free
frozen yogurt samples crushed an empty
cell phone kiosk and threw a gumball
machine to the floor with a crash it
would rip the entire Mall apart if it
had to if that was what it took to
destroy the being that I'd caught a
glimpse of its face and disappeared then
096 could see it that face that
wide-eyed grinning face it sprinted
toward the face as fast as it could the
cartoon cat was looking at 096 not from
a place in the room but from behind the
screen of a television in the
electronics store window somehow defying
the laws of physics and reality it had
made its way into the TV 096 didn't
pause to ponder the logic of this there
was no room for critical thought there
was only the need to shred to consume to
destroy it burst through the window
sending shards of glass in every
direction and reared back to attack the
screen it was so focused on its singular
task that it didn't notice the long
black arms snaking across the floor
winding around its feet all of a sudden
096 lost its balance as its legs were
pulled right out from under it those
stretchy arms dragging it into the TV
screen itself when 096 regained
Consciousness it was in a place it did
not recognize gone was the inside of
them all or the familiar forest and
mountains outside instead scp-096 was in
some sort of hand-drawn World a massive
house with a hallway that seemed to go
on forever lined with infinite doors
leading to who knew where the floor
tipped and tilted at odd angles and the
geometry made no three-dimensional sense
it was dizzying and deeply off-putting
scp-096 had no frame of reference to
compare it to but a human witness might
have noticed that this place looked like
something out of an old cartoon from the
days of Steamboat Willie and the like
scp-096 did not think such a thing it
only knew that it was in an unfamiliar
Place one that felt threatening though
there were no visible threats and it
knew that it still hadn't gotten its
hands on the creature that had seen its
face all along the walls between each
door there were clocks in the shape of
that horrible cat eyes ticking back and
forth with each second wide smile
mocking scp-096 as if to say try and
find me
scp-096 would not be discouraged there
was no room in its mind for that sort of
thing there was only the singular goal
of finding the cartoon cat and tearing
it limb from rubber hose limb
psychological warfare would have no
effect still cartoon cat would give it
his best shot this was his world and he
could do whatever he wanted here cartoon
cat poked his head out through a random
doorway waving to 096 with one of his
puffy white gloved hands as 096 wailed
and began to give Chase cartoon cats
slammed the door shut only to open
another door down the hall and poke his
head head out of that one he did the
same trick over and over jerking scp-096
around from end to end of the ever
expanding animated hallway after some
time passed however it appeared as cp096
was not going to get tired and was not
going to give up hope of catching its
prey it was time to end this cartoon cat
wrapped one long arm around
scp-096's neck restraining it against
the wall and began to squeeze Tighter
and Tighter but nothing happened
scp-096 did not collapse did not react
at all except to tear out the arm around
its neck until it broke free then it
returned to the Relentless Pursuit
tearing door frames apart pulling up
floorboards punching through walls every
time it dealt damage to the environment
the space filled itself back in an
unseen pen scribbling in the gaps in the
floorboards sealing up the holes and the
walls two powerful beings going back and
forth locked in a seemingly equal
matched battle cartoon cat tried to
destroy scp-096 in a myriad of ways he
tried to rip the Beast apart to snap its
neck to do any manner of unspeakable
violent acts it had done before with
great sadistic Glee but this pale
Abomination would not fold would not
break this wasn't going to be any fun if
there was no ending and if 096 kept
destroying one of cartoon cat's favorite
pocket worlds that was quite enough
cartoon cat grabbed hold of 096's arms
and legs the creature thrashing
viciously as he did so and threw it into
the blank space just beyond the
Illustrated world back in the mall
scp-096 crashed back to Earth was about
to resume its search for cartoon cat
when suddenly a bright light illuminated
its face a police officer stood a few
feet away holding a flashlight excuse me
you can't be in here your trespassing
the officer started to warn but his
words were interrupted when 096 began to
scream soon he would be screaming too
there's never a good day for a super
villain attack or a tense Feud with your
closest sibling and for the Mighty Thor
this day was turning out to be both as
the self-proclaimed strongest Avenger
flung his body across the planet Earth
using his trusty Magical Hammer molnir
the Asgardian steeled himself for yet
another confrontation with his evil
half-brother Loki the god of Mischief as
per usual Loki was terrorizing the
humans of a random City using his
allusions to manifest imaginary dragons
and other ferocious beasts and what was
also usual is Thor had no idea what his
brother's motive or endgame was all the
God of Thunder knew was that this kind
of trickery decree would not be stood
for while these terrible creatures
weren't real they were still very
frightening to the earthlings civilians
were running around in every direction
away from Loki and this was causing all
kinds of Chaos and traffic disturbances
regardless of what Loki's plan was Thor
knew that his brother had to be stopped
before things escalated further on Earth
humans needed to rely on vehicles to get
around and even the slightest
inconvenience in transportation could
lead to disaster Thor touched down in
the same City Square where Loki was
unleashing his horde of Make-Believe
monsters Landing in a classically cool
superhero way hello brother Thor
proclaimed I don't suppose you'll be
stopping this without a fight Loki
smiled a mischievous smile and replied
Arthur we meet again and once again
you're wrong I can stop this anytime I
want Loki swiftly moved his hand through
the air casting a new spell to dismiss
his diabolical decoys the Illusions
dispersed naturally and soon the two
brothers were facing each other one on
one see
Loki chuckled Thor was rightly confused
by his brother's unpredictable actions
he pointed small near towards Loki in an
accusatory manner no Illusions no
sorcery what are you really playing at
Loki said Thor and then Loki reached
into his robes and produced an unusual
cube-shaped object as his good brother
was all too aware this particular Cube
was the latest in a long line of
mysterious and Powerful cubes that Loki
had used for his various evil plans Loki
juggled the unknown Cube from one hand
to the other then waved it in the air in
front of Thor and began to laugh
maniacally all I need to do is open this
ancient box of mysteries and I'll become
completely Unstoppable don't you dare do
it Loki Thor shouted that sort of power
will be misused in your hands that's
precisely the point Loki continued to
laugh then Reach For What appeared to be
the lid of the cube he grabbed the top
of it and made a show of beginning to
twist this enthor's heroic instincts
into high gear and he threw molnir at
the cube knocking it out of Loki's grasp
as the cube flew away from the grinning
villain Thor Dove to retrieve it before
his brother had the chance he soon held
the strange item in one hand while
calling molnir back to the other as Thor
stared at the cube pondering its purpose
Loki stretched out his hands in
desperation oh no not by Cube if you
open it now my plan is doomed though he
pleaded Thor responded with a laugh of
his own nice try brother but I'm going
to open it and so the God of Thunder did
Thor popped the Cube's lid and braced
himself for whatever Cosmic force was
about to be released but for some reason
nothing happened still curious Thor took
a cautious look inside as it turned out
the only thing within this apparently
non-magical Cube was what appeared to be
a fully developed photograph what an
Odin's name is this Thor removed the
image and held it close to his face it
appeared to depict an emaciated pale
humanoid with long spindly limbs
standing in the corner of a compact room
with smooth metal walls in all his many
years traveling the nine Realms Thor had
never seen anything like it whatever the
creature actually was it certainly did
not look happy of course what Thor was
actually looking at was a photo taken of
scp-096 inside of its containment unit
at the foundation the shy guy as its
nickname suggested did not like having
its face looked at even via secondary
means such as photography or video
recording the anomalous humanoid sense
of Shame about its own appearance was so
great that a mere moment after Thor
fixed his Asgardian Eyes Upon its Visage
scp-096 began to stir in its containment
unit the creature wailed and covered its
face with both of its hands on its long
sinewy arms it screamed and carried on
for a duration of two minutes after
which point scp-096 sprinted towards the
steel walls of its containment unit and
smashed through reaching speeds greater
than most Motor Vehicles
scp-096 began to zero in on Thor's
location as was always the case when
another being saw its face the shy guy
was compelled to utterly annihilate the
offending Observer with its bare hands
Thor himself had no idea that scp-096
was in route and continued to squint at
the photograph perplexed by the
mysterious entity depict therein Loki
now resumed his mad laughter because
once more he had managed to trick his
foolish brother into falling for one of
his ingenious schemes make sure to get a
good look brother Loki gloated yes look
at the full creature that will bring
about your inevitable destruction Thor
was annoyed if you think that showing me
a gross picture of some lowly wretch
will strike fear into my heart you've
truly forgotten what it means to be an
Asgardian save your sentiments for the
halls of alhala the green clad evildoer
cackled you'll be there soon enough
and with that Loki used a charm to turn
himself invisible and vanish completely
from Thor's sight Thor stomped his foot
on the ground angrily he wasn't sure how
but it seemed as though Loki had gotten
the last laugh once again Loki he
shouted after his brother come back here
and face me with honor then the God of
Thunder sighed pensively and thought to
himself who am I kidding he's never
going to change Thor looked at his
trusty Hammer Mo and your old friend it
seems like we've saved the day yet again
shall we away back to Avengers HQ he
then shook Moneer up and down like a
puppeteer simulating a nod Splendid idea
ammonia glad you thought of it Thor
chuckled already in better spirits
that's when he began to hear the
footsteps of scp-096 rapidly approaching
him Thor turned his head towards the
sound and saw the same disquieting
Creature from the photograph that was
inside Loki's Cube zooming headlong
towards him with Reckless abandon the
Asgardian blinked he almost couldn't
believe his eyes whatever that thing was
it was faster than Thor could have
possibly anticipated was it looking for
the photograph he wondered hello there
Thor called out his scp-096 continued to
make a beeline at the Caped superhero
the God of Thunder waved the photograph
of scp-096 in the air is this your um
selfie in all likelihood Loki had been
his usual conniving self and stole that
self-portrait from the miserable
creature hoping that it would mistake
Thor for the thief the god of Mischief
had probably even used a glamor to
disguise himself as Thor when he did the
deed Thor believed that all he had to do
was clear up this misunderstanding and
that he and this strange Beast could go
their separate ways without coming to
blows it was a naive optimistic and
ultimately incorrect view of the
situation but at least the hero's heart
was in the right place I don't need this
so Thor said trying to reason with the
creature you can have it back if you'd
like but scp-096 showed no signs of
stopping and was seemingly enraged even
further by Thor flaunting its decidedly
unflattering photograph the shy guy
kicked the ground and shot forward with
a powerful burst of speed one of its
elongated arms slammed into Thor's face
with enough Force to nearly knock the
Asgardian off his feet Thor was so
surprised that he instinctively whacked
the creature with molnir sending scp-096
careening backwards down the street it
wasn't launched more than a dozen feet
before its powerful arms and legs dug
into the pavement and slowed its
velocity to zero even though the thing
from the photo had taken a direct hit
from molnir it barely looked phased on a
physical level one thing was for sure
the shy guy was still incredibly
distraught and it was directing all of
those negative emotions towards the God
of Thunder what was this thing what is
this thing Thor wondered to himself it
was fast strong and durable to an
unearthly degree if this thing wanted to
engage in single combat Thor wouldn't
back down he was an Asgardian Warrior
and sometimes that meant facing
challenges head on no matter how
suddenly they arose still his time with
the Avengers had taught him that having
a clear reason to fight was sometimes
even more important than the fight
itself hey quick question
um what are you he said aloud to the
creature
scp-096 didn't answer within seconds it
was on Thor again like a build snipe on
another build snipe the screaming
humanoid swung wildly pelting its
opponent with blow after blow Thor tried
once more to communicate with his
unknown enemy I have no quarrel with you
weird one Thor spoke so take your noodle
arms and be gone for all of its
Relentless ferocity the humanoid
Abomination left countless openings that
a seasoned Warrior like Thor could
easily exploit of course most mortal
combatants would be unable to endure the
brunt of the Shy Guy's attacks for long
enough but true to a nature Thor was a
god The Avengers struck back with
another crushing blow from molnir aimed
straight for the creature's sternum once
again the monster was pushed back for a
moment and then resumed its maddening
Onslaught a blow like that should have
at least busted a river to where the
bones of this horrible thing made a
vibranium or some other rare metal out
of the depths of space Thor realized he
was now fighting on the defensive while
he had faced foes in the past with much
greater physical strength than the shy
guy including his superhero colleague
Bruce Banner's mean green ever-loving
Alter Ego The Incredible Hulk the sheer
tenacity of scp-096 meant that being
careless with his own protection could
lead to Thor taking unnecessary hits
that would eventually wear him down in a
prolonged fight the wiry humanoid
certainly didn't show any signs of
slowing down or tiring even though it
had to be expending a lot of energy to
move so quickly between his alternating
deflections and counter blows against
the creature Thor mold over his
brother's words from earlier Loki was
right about one thing this is a fell
Creature if ever there was one still as
long as there is thunder in my blood I
won't allow a hairless curl like this to
bring me my own destruction think Thor
what would Stark do at a time like this
he says he's the smart one after all
humor him with his highly sophisticated
tactical Acumen that was similar to Iron
Man except for the fact that it was much
better and stronger Thor efficiently
assessed his current situation while the
pale Beast was undoubtedly violent and
far mightier than most terrestrial
creatures its attention and all the
brute strength that came with it have
been fixated solely on Thor since it
arrived in the city the asgardians best
guessed as to why was the photograph
that Loki had tricked him into looking
at devious trickster that he is Loki
must have known that this thing would
hunt down and attempt to pulverize the
latest being to see its face which now
of course happened to be Thor the
revelation of this fact meant that Thor
no longer had to worry about the fate of
civilians if he chose to relocate to a
less populated Battlefield since the
creature was now guaranteed to follow
him nobody else needed to get hurt while
running from the fight wasn't exactly
the god of Thunder's favorite strategy
who would massively reduce the chance of
collateral damage he'd be saving lives
in classic Avengers fashion Captain
America would be so proud not that Thor
would have done it any differently even
if he didn't have the Star-Spangled
man's approval
scp-096 leaped in towards Thor to
deliver its next whopping strike but the
Asgardian quickly grounded by the wrist
and pulled the Ferocious creature off
its feet he lifted it up and over his
head before slamming it down hard into
the pavement with a bit of space between
himself and his anomalous foe Thor began
to swing molnir around by its leathery
wrist strap the shy guy desperately
scrambled to its feet to resume the
attack but by that time Thor had already
thrown himself Skyward he soared between
the buildings using the force of
molnir's trajectory three making it his
mission to exit the city as soon as
possible Thor looked down to see that
scp-096 was following him along the
ground exactly as he predicted it would
well the battle with the Beast would
most certainly continue the second he
dropped back to Earth's surface he could
rest assured that the place where the
Showdown would take place could be
chosen by him he saw an evergreen forest
on a nearby mountain and decided that it
would do nicely as a place to finish
this I'm sure no one would mind a few
stray bolts of lightning around here
Thor thought the God of Thunder was
amused by the prospect of going all out
against this being even though it
probably had its reasons for wanting to
destroy the one that saw its face Thor
was past the point of Taking Chances on
diplomacy this distressing creature was
after all an adversary that Loki had
plotted to send after him through one
means or another and because of that it
was likely to have power and guile to
spare Thor breaking his sweat to
Vanquish the thing would be a fitting
replacement for the fight that he would
have to have with Loki Thor's feet hit
the ground on a Stony Mountain ledge and
once again he struck that iconic
superhero Landing pose remarkably the
shy guy had kept pace with Thor almost
the entire time the Asgardian had been
flying smashing through every tree and
Boulder that stood in its path even so
Thor was more than ready for it storm
clouds rumbled overhead the sky above
the mountain was trembling as Thor
decided that it was time to bring down
the thunder on his unfortunate foe boom
crack the heavens flashed with
electrical might as Thor channeled the
energy from several lightning bolts
through molnir before unleashing a
Consolidated blast of unbridled power
onto scp-096 the shy guy didn't even
attempt to dodge as Thor's thundershock
treatment bombarded it with light and
heat the likes of which few Mortals
could withstand Thor released a second
blast then a third surrounding scp-096
with as much lightning as these Earthly
Skies would offer him after keeping at
this for a while Thor decided to let up
momentarily to check in on his foe only
to see that there were no signs of
visible damage on the creature it wasn't
even slightly singed the God of Thunder
could feel his brother laughing at him
from somewhere out of sight and Out Of
Reach the Monstrous humanoid in the
forest below was proving to be far more
than Thor had bargained for but he was
nowhere near ready to give in and accept
defeat still maybe this wasn't a fight
worth having on Earth all Thor's
electrical attacks were doing was
destroying trees and the planet was
already facing unprecedented levels of
deforestation due to the greed of human
CEOs and Shady entrepreneurs Thor
certainly didn't want to be part of the
problem and now that it was occurring to
him he realized that he should probably
try to do something about that once the
situation with the shy guy was resolved
it didn't matter how close of a friend
Elon Musk was to Tony Stark these
overreaching humans had to be given a
Stern talking to by the God of Thunder
with or without hammer in his hand of
course Thor's environmentalist concerned
had to go on the back burner for now
since scp-096 was advancing towards him
once again with no hint of slowing down
let's see if you can follow me back to
Asgard you son of an elf Thor thought he
held his hammer Aloft and counted on
hemdel to deploy the bifrost the Rainbow
Bridge arrived seconds before scp-096's
arms would have reached the Asgardian
and as expected it instantly carried
Thor into the interdimensional space
between his destinations amidst the
swirling sea of multi-colored lights
Thor shared a laugh with nobody but
himself and molnir so much for shy guy
said Thor looks like he'll have to
resolve those body issues on its own
time I've been through something similar
so I can relate best of luck pitiful
beast but while Thor was congratulating
himself for his strategic Retreat he
almost didn't notice that his foe hadn't
actually stopped in its Pursuit as a
matter of fact scp-096 was currently
inside kind of the bifrost and swiftly
gaining on the God of Thunder the shy
guy was truly running in the 90s well 90
miles per hour or more but it made the
same difference the creature grabbed
Thor by his ankles and screeched in
mortified rage Thor punched scp-096 in
the face hoping to shake it off but to
no avail the two opponents spun through
the bifrost locked together in an
unbreakable grapple until they collided
with the walls of interdimensional space
Thor knew exactly where this was going
and he wasn't happy about it like a
sheet of ice composed of photons the
outer limits of the bifrost broke away
sending both combatants shooting off
into the void seconds later a wormhole
spit Thor and scp-096 out in a vast
junkyard filled with the remains of
countless spaceships and alien life
forms great I'm trapped in this garbage
world again I knew I should have picked
somewhere closer Thor shook off the
nauseating effects of the failed
interdimensional trip
scp-096 was already hail and Hardy for
another round Thor grimaced with
frustrated anticipation uh how about a
quick five-minute rest Thor implored the
shy guy gentlemen struce
scp-096 Ward and dash fourth more crazed
than ever Thor exhaled in futility I
thought not he whipped Monir around and
hurled it straight for scp-096's skull
the reliable uru steel Hammer made
contact knocking the creature onto its
back at the very least Thor could always
count on his signature weapon to help
him out or could he when the Asgardian
tried to call the hammer back he was
shocked to find that scp-096 had somehow
grabbed a hold of its handle even more
surprisingly it now appeared to be
wielding the Hammer as easily as Thor
could son of a you're telling me that
thing is worthy the shy guy now with
molnir in hand pounced on Thor Swinging
The Hammer with no technique or finesse
it was everything Thor could do to
Simply avoid the creature's range a blow
from molnir was enough to cause serious
injury to even the most formidable
Asgardian Warrior Damu Monier we talked
about this Thor thundered we're friends
aren't we but none of his words could
get through to the Hammer now that it
was in the hand of
scp-096 in an act of righteous Defiance
Thor called The Fury of lightning into
his own body this strange foe which had
come from Loki's latest prank was about
to find out what happened when a god of
thunder got serious with the speed of a
lightning bolt Thor flew at scp-096 and
punched it so hard that its grip
loosened on molnir for all but a second
and that second was all Thor needed to
reclaim his weapon his hand clung
tightly to molnir's handle as he swung
the weapon into the Shy Guy's body with
all of his might the Shockwave of this
forceful blow launched piles of debris
High into the air and sent scp-096
tumbling across the surface of the
planet like a thrown piece of discarded
food at an Asgardian Feast with another
pulse of electricity Thor magnetized the
portions of the rubble which can contain
spaceship parts and used his
manipulation of that same energy to bury
the shy guy in the deepest heap of trash
he could manage and with one last flick
of Monier Thor sent himself hurtling
through the largest wormhole in the sky
above and back into space where it would
be far more difficult for his foe to
follow him finally with some distance
Thor breathed to sigh of relief you
almost had me that time Loki what an
unusual being fought like a Berserker
but was somehow also pure of heart a
kindred spirit to myself perhaps even so
I truly hope to never meet that thing
again anyone working at the SCP
Foundation will no doubt be familiar
with scp-3008 also known as the infinite
Ikea for those of you that aren't it
essentially does what it says on the can
or rather it's assembled just like it is
in the flat pack Furniture instructions
while on the outside it appears to be an
average unassuming branch of the
affordable Swedish Furniture Outlet
inside wide is a different story
crossing the boundary of scp-3008's
automatic doors and venturing a little
too deep to its maze-like confines leads
to an endless Labyrinth of Collins and
herdahls a dimensionally transcendental
area that defies our ordinary human
understanding of physical space lurking
deep within the aisles of the infinite
Ikea are
scp-3008-2s that are known as the staff
a race of misshapen faceless humanoids
with long freakish arms that prey on
anyone that enters once night falls and
yes there are people inside
scp-3008 trapped Souls that have
wandered into the wrong Ikea only to end
up missing sometimes spending months or
even years inside if they ever get out
at all an alert was ringing filling the
air with loud blaring noise every member
of foundation Personnel stationed
outside the infinite Ikea was rushing
about guards standing at the ready the
storefront of scp-3008 had been silent
for quite a long while with nothing
reported go going in or coming out with
the foundation knew far better than to
assume that scp-3008 didn't have
surprises in store for them pun fully
intended hey don't you dare click off we
know where you live in red right hand
are lining up the shot
anyway there appeared to be some kind of
commotion Beyond the Doors that quickly
slid open just in time for something to
be slung through the front entrance it
almost looked as if the Ikea itself had
spat something out like it was so toxic
it couldn't endure having to keep it
within its confines any longer
cautiously approaching with their
weapons raised the foundation's on-site
security team moved towards the
discarded mess to get a better look at
whatever it was it turned out to be a
person a man in around his late 50s
beaten within an inch of his life he was
wearing some kind of rudimentary circlet
or crown around his head seemingly
fashioned by hand out of stationery and
other materials scavenged from the paper
shop Department of the infinite Ikea
speaking of the man was wearing an Ikea
manager's uniform with a name tag pinned
to his chest that identified him as
Chris hanging from his neck was an Ikea
brand notepad with a message scrawled on
it but before you find out what that
message was we have another important
message for you one that directly
impacts you yes I'm talking directly to
you it comes from the sponsor of today's
video private internet access we know
you've heard a lot of big claims from a
lot of different VPN providers but you
absolutely must hear why we've chosen
Pia as our personal VPN and why you
should do the same unlike the SCP
Foundation and some of those other VPN
Services out there Pia is the world's
most transparent VPN provider they never
record or store any user data at all
don't believe us their no log policy has
been proven multiple times in court and
was even verified by an independent
audit by Deloitte and they stay
transparent so that you don't have to
with Pia's VPN your IP address is hidden
and your connection is encrypted keeping
your Digital Life protected from the
prying eyes of network admins or even a
certain mobile task force unit and
they've just launched what is maybe
their coolest feature yet with servers
now in all 50 US states you can look
like you're surfing the web from exactly
where you want need to look like you're
checking out that SCP database entry
from Indiana they've got an IP address
for you there or maybe you're on the
west coast and want to catch the early
East Coast premiere of your favorite
show and avoid spoilers not a problem
with private internet access I could go
on and on about all the features I
regularly use but why not try it
yourself by going to
www.piavpn.com forward slash SCP and get
an 82 discount on private internet
access that's just two dollars eleven
cents a month plus get three extra
months completely for free not long
before Chris was found in his roughed up
State outside the only Ikea that goes on
forever he was working at a different
branch one that was much smaller on the
inside Chris was the manager of the
store and widely regarded by his
employees to be an awful person nobody
knew if he had always been that way or
if instilling him in a position of power
over other retail workers had somehow
caused him to develop a bit of a God
complex either way there was little he
ever did to invoke much camaraderie with
his colleagues whenever any of the
store's workers were on their breaks
which they usually had to remind Chris
were permitted by law and not optional
conversation often turned to their
Collective poor opinions of their
manager he'd been given the job out of
pretty blatant nepotism it was well
known how cozy Chris was with the
regional manager of all the Ikea stores
in the area on top of that Chris had a
pretty nasty habit of trying to force
his employees to stay behind after their
scheduled shifts had finished while also
refusing to pay them for overtime you
see it was his own mismanagement of the
work Rota that had left the store
understaffed at crucial moments of the
day the solution you would think should
be obvious hiring a few more new staff
to help with the workload and to start
their shifts at times when others were
about to clock out for the day ah but
new employees wouldn't work for free
their wages would come out of the
store's budget and why would Chris want
to take on new workers as the person in
charge of payroll he could help himself
to that money adding the wages of
prospective colleagues as a bonus on top
of his own unjustifiably exorbitant
salary perhaps the worst part about
having Chris as a manager was that he
seemed to get away with murder as long
as the store kept making a profit then
the management above him didn't care how
badly he treated his employees or
flouted the rules for his own game but
it was those same colleagues who had
suffered and been scorned by Chris's
Behavior who had finally had enough
retail work is hard having to deal with
rude and impolite customers on a
day-to-day basis working long hours of
uninteresting and repetitive labor all
for a paycheck that only just covered
rent like we said it is a hard line of
work and the people in it deserve the
utmost respect but you throw
megalomaniacal manager into the mix and
you've got a ticking time bomb on your
hands one that'll sooner or later
explode it was witnessing Chris
blatantly framing a younger member of
staff that finally triggered detonation
the kid had only been a student working
at Ikea all through his weekends to make
enough money to pay his bills Chris saw
this less experienced employee not as a
human being doing his best but a chance
to make a quick Buck by breaking the
rules the manager started stealing cash
from the register then blamed it on his
young staff member when the losses
started to show on the store's monthly
Financial reports seeing that for
themselves the other members of the
staff knew that it was the manager's
responsibility to empty the registers
regularly so they didn't have too much
cash in them in case of a robbery given
how much they all despise Chris it
didn't take much effort for the entire
Workforce to organize a walkout halfway
through the Working Day outraged Chris
had tried calling any colleagues that
were off shift barking at them to come
in and work on their days off all of
them said no the thing is when you work
in retail complaints to upper management
never seem to go anywhere like we said
if the store is making profit that's all
they care about but seeing such drastic
action from the staff of the store he
was supposed to be running the Ikea
higher-ups came down on Chris like a
hammer they instructed that he be sent
to another Ikea outlet for a whole
afternoon to receive some mandatory
interpersonal training little did anyone
realize that this was the last anyone
would ever see of him not that his old
staff was sad to hear that he had
disappeared arriving at what looked like
an ordinary Ikea Chris parked his car
outside the place seemed deserted no
customers filing in and out of the front
doors the only other vehicles in the
parking lot looking like they had just
been abandoned by their owners the
manager scoffed to himself these people
running this store we're going to teach
him how to do his job indignantly he
clipped his name tag on and stepped out
of his car marching across the asphalt
towards the entrance the automatic doors
gently slid open shutting smoothly
behind Chris as he stepped inside the
whole store was quiet barely a peep from
anywhere the high ceiling of the IKEA
store he so poorly managed carried a lot
of noise and made any sound Echo
throughout the building the squeaking of
shoes against the vinyl floors the
bustle of customers the electronic beep
of cash registers and the lull dulled
music played over the intercom but there
was none of that here a deathly silence
filled the aisles of flat pack Furniture
display models of hemnises and tricials
standing as still and foreboding as
gravestones suddenly the sound of
movement reverberated from between one
row of aisles Chris began marching
towards its source expecting to find an
employee who would Point him in the
direction of the office where his
training was supposed to be conducted
sure enough within a few steps Chris
spotted a figure and a familiar bright
yellow t-shirt and blue pants the same
uniform his Ikea underlings wore at his
store excuse me he called as he Strode
towards the employee's shoes clomping
against the floor with every step you
need to tell me where your manager is
I'm from the store across town here for
some pointless training seminar Chris
hadn't waited until he was close enough
to engage in Pleasant conversation
instead making his demands as he
approached the figure in the Ikea
uniform however didn't turn to face him
hey I'm talking to you Chris shouted you
deaf or something there was a pause
telling Chris that what happened next
wasn't in response to what he said
although that didn't make it any less
frightening the figure who had been
hunched over near the floor suddenly
Drew itself up to its full height it
towered over Chris it must have measured
close to seven whole feet as it turned
the malignant manager saw its face or
that it didn't have one no eyes no mouth
nothing but a smooth surface without any
discernible features its arms were
elongated huge claw-like hands hanging
down to the creature's knees being a
coward Chris turned and ran immediately
confrontation was another area his
employees had noticed he was sorely
lacking in whenever faced with a rude
and cantankerous customer Chris would
never defend his colleagues or their
actions instead he would suck up and
brown nose two customers who were
clearly in the wrong essentially rolling
over the minute anyone raised their
voice so now confronted with a lumbering
faceless entity his self-preservation
instincts were kicked into overdrive and
he raced deeper into the store not
exactly in the best shape he slowed to a
halt wheezing as he tried to catch his
breath that was when looking around
Chris noticed just how long the aisle
seemed he was sure he would still be
able to see the front door from here yet
couldn't spot the entrance anywhere from
where he was currently standing panting
like a Thirsty Dog he looked over his
shoulder there was no sign of the staff
member he'd encountered little did Chris
know that it had lumbered off in the
opposite direction the second he had run
away from it hardly paying him any mind
at least while the lights were still on
unable to find the entrance or even a
fire door he couldn't escape through it
didn't take long for the lights inside
the infinite Ikea to dim marking the
start of the night cycle something about
it being darker made the sounds of
shuffling even more noticeable there
were more than one of those faceless
uniformed creatures trembling Chris
climbed inside a klepstad a wardrobe
with a sliding door barely able to sleep
with his knees tucked up under his chin
he spent the entire night inside the
cramped confined space every sound of
movement from outside brought with it
the mental image of one of the staffs
sliding open the outer door and reaching
down to grab him the whole Sleepless
while Chris couldn't help but think
about what he could have possibly done
to deserve this cruel fate the next
morning the lights came back on and
started to bleed through the seams of
the flat pack wardrobe waking Chris from
what little Restless sleep he had gotten
he paused unsure if he should venture
out in case he came across another one
of the staff suddenly he heard the sound
of voices muted and muffled by the door
of the klepstad the definitely real
human voices had it all been some
horrible nightmare had he fallen asleep
at work and been stuffed into a wardrobe
by his ungrateful employees oh now he
had them he would sue every last one of
them out of their jobs sliding the door
open and tumbling out of the clubstad
Chris found himself flying face down on
the store floor his legs too cramped to
move just as he tried to will them into
moving again a voice called out to him
hey mister it said you okay there a trio
of footsteps raced over to where he was
before he could get a good look at who
they belonged to hands were pulling
Chris up off the floor he looked at his
Rescuers bemused to see other people in
this endless void of affordable homeware
they were two men and a woman each in
disheveled clothing that looked like
they had been wearing the same thing for
years easy there fella one of the men
spoke name's Buster which settlement you
from what do you mean by settlement
Chris asked confused looks like we got
another newbie the woman chuckled dryly
when'd you get here ah yesterday I think
the former manager answered time can be
a bit screwy in here the second man
chimed in I'm Nolan this here is Janine
you got a name uh Chris he nodded you
hungry Chris the three survivors LED
Chris through the winding expanse of the
Ikea without an end navigating The
Identical Isles with the expertise of
people that had been here long enough to
know their way around what felt like the
tiniest fraction of the time that he had
been lost the day before they brought
Chris to the food court it was bustling
with activity more so than the one at
his store with people patiently lining
up to take their fill of food from the
Ikea menu after joining the queue Buster
returned and handed Chris a plate of
Swedish meatballs with mashed potato
peas cream sauce and lingonberry Jam so
pleased to see food again Chris began to
gluttonously Devour the whole plate
while the others explained some of what
was going on here although he was barely
listening according to Janine who had
been there the longest the inside of
this Ikea was like an endless maze there
was no clear way out even when retracing
steps back the way one first entered
third Nolan then weighed in and
explained that there were pockets of
people who had survived this long Inside
scp-3008 by forming their own little
communities thanks to the sheer amount
of space within the store these
settlements were almost the size of
small townships built using whatever
Furniture appliances and other materials
the other survivors had been able to
scrounge up how come you don't run out
of food Chris interjected it replenishes
every day man Buster replied gesturing
to the food court around them sure it's
not ideal if you aren't a huge fan of
Ikea food but you get used to it could
be worse All Things Considered and what
the hell do you all do for money the
stubborn manager demanded look around
you Janine scoffed we don't need it in
here we're cut off from the rest of the
world stuff like money hardly makes a
difference can't get us home or kept us
Fed so what's the point Chris side
evidently frustrated at the prospect of
living inside in Ikea yet not having the
opportunity for monetary gain so who's
in charge he asked who runs this place
well no one no one Shrugged settlements
all worked together to help each other
out if needed but we don't have any
singular person running things hearing
that out loud caused a twisted idea to
form in Chris's balding head asking to
be escorted by Buster to the right aisle
he started Gathering up what he needed
to make a rudimentary Crown what's that
for Buster asked a little concerned
about what Chris was planning oh you
wouldn't understand he replied not
looking up from applying hot glue don't
worry I'll explain it in nice simple
terms when I'm ready that night despite
being welcomed into the Trio's town of
lighting with open arms Chris slipped
back to the food court while the other
settlers were sleeping carefully he
avoided the lurking staff and their
drone calls of the store is now closed
please exit the building reaching his
destination the malicious manager Lane
wait for the next morning Hiding Out
Underneath the counter where the food
was served the next morning the
collected survivors of the infinite Ikea
were met with an unfamiliar sight as
they approached the food court all the
food had gone it had still replenished
overnight like it usually did but
someone had gathered it up before anyone
had a chance to eat so they topped the
counter with a smug look on his face
Chris made a show of placing his crown
over his head morning everyone he
announced from today things are going to
be a little different around here but
I'm sure we'll be able to work together
like one big happy family holding the
gathered scp-3008 residents as his
literal captive audience all of them
hungry and irritable Chris outlined what
he had determined to be the best system
possible for how things should be run
inside the endless store I will keep all
the food secure and safe and we're gonna
start rationing it out he explained but
far a voice shot it from the crowd it
reappears every night anyway well here's
what we're gonna do if you just shut up
and let me finish Chris replied calmly
but with a condescending tone of
superiority according to Chris's grand
scheme every day each settlement would
be allocated what he deemed to be an
acceptable amount of ration food to feed
its population of survivors then he made
an offer to anyone who is willing to
help him if someone provided their
services in collecting the food each
morning and distributing the rationed
amount then Chris would allow them to
take an extra portion of rations just
for themselves you see now yes the crowd
oblivious to how many of them were
scowling at him anyone that wants to
help they get rewarded with a little bit
extra call it a bonus what if we don't
want to help you another onlooker called
well that's fine by me Chris sneered
back more for those who want it I think
what they mean is Janine shouted from
the group what if we don't want you to
implement this ridiculous system at all
what's to stop us from just taking the
food we need every morning like we did
before you showed up typical he tutted
how lazy you just want the privilege of
having more then you should work to earn
it and as for your silly little notion
of just taking I'm gonna be here every
morning I'll get to decide who eats and
who doesn't and how much they deserve
and if anyone one wants to take more
than they deserve without offering their
help in return then they'll get half of
the rations they would get and so will
their settlement so with those queries
out of the way allow me to introduce
myself as your new store manager when
they recovered Chris's body outside of
the entrance to scp-3008 the foundation
had no way of knowing exactly who had
beaten him up so badly the other
survivors inside the infinite Ikea might
have done it themselves while
overthrowing his short-lived stint as
manager or they might have decided not
to lower themselves to that level and
instead shunned him from entering their
settlements leaving him to fend for
himself with the staff around every
corner and their history of turning
aggressive towards humans come Nightfall
Chris's chances of survival were slim
the only real clue was the note that had
been found with him which read you can
have him back we don't want him good
grief said jotro Cujo as he his
grandfather Joseph joestar and the rest
of their Allied group of Stan users hid
from the light of day in the shadows of
a ruined building outside amorphous
semi-humanoid monstrosities roam free In
Search of Life how could this have
happened jotaro's family had been on
some Bizarre Adventures but this one was
proving to be the most bizarre of all
the sun now designated
scp-001 was burning with intense bright
red light and an anomalous level of heat
it beat down on the world below like an
evil and sadistic god of the desert the
entire world was at the mercy of these
oppressive solar rays and high
temperatures were just the beginning
from the looks of it any living thing
exposed to the Rays of scp-001 would
quickly dissolve into a horrible gooey
substance that would ooze towards other
organisms in an attempt to absorb them
into its biomass basically it was like a
zombie apocalypse straight out of an
Easy Bake Oven the Stardust Crusaders
had been passing through the city on
their globetrotting Adventure only to
find that morning had brought with it a
disaster the likes of which had never
been seen before by mid-afternoon when
the sun was highest in the sky most of
the people had already been converted
into slime monsters and those who fled
into the Shadows found themselves
relentlessly hunted down and absorbed
only the stand users of jotoros grew who
were already on the lookout for strange
happenings had been clever enough to
pick up on the situation immediately
they had been the subject of many
unusual Supernatural attacks over the
course of their Journey so the initial
anomalous effects of scp-001 seemed to
be another routine brush with an enemy
hey jotaro this has to be the effect of
an enemy stand right Joseph said what
are you stupid or something old man spag
Jean-Pierre ponref the Frenchman was
ever the impulsive one and he always
found something to complain about out
when a woman wasn't present he was
selectively polite one might say it was
fitting given the fact that his stand
silver Chariot took the form of a
sword-wielding knight and its reaction
speed was the fastest of any of the
Stardust Crusaders you think one Stan
could do all this polnerv was adamant
about making his point jotaro's fellow
High School classmate noriaki kakeon was
the next to speak honoref keep your
voice down we can't be sure it's not a
stand but either way those flesh
monsters are looking for us kakyon was
younger than polnarath pretended to
carry himself with more composure this
likely had something to do with the fact
that hero fent green was the group's
most technical stand and often used for
reconnaissance what do you think of it
all kakian continued you're the expert
here Muhammad Abdul a fortune teller who
possessed a stand that controls fire
magicians read was often knowledgeable
about the supernatural a stand this
powerful would have to be limited in the
range it could affect Abdul said well we
have have to do is get further away from
this area then we'll see if this strange
sunlight Fades but what if the user is
following us Joseph interjected how will
we know we aren't putting more people at
risk Mr Joe Starr we can win this battle
without more information Abdul replied
kakyun your hyphen green has the longest
range send it to scout for a place
outside of the Stan's reach our stands
shouldn't be visible to those
transformed humans and the heat from the
sunlight won't affect something without
mass friendly reminder to those of you
at home unfamiliar with the properties
of stands stands are spectral entities
formed from the soul of the user and are
essentially super powered ghosts without
physical presence as such they won't be
affected by scp-001 the way a living
thing would now back to this Bizarre
Adventure right
here off and green cocoon summoned his
stand and began threading hirofin
Green's long stretchy body throughout
the ruins as far as it could go the
young man concentrated looking through
the eye eyes of his stand as cockyan and
his stands search for the end of the
anomalous effects of scp-001 polnerv
continued to complain as usual so we're
still not sure what's going on but from
what I've heard you're already calling
it a stand did I get that right afterl
ponref grumbled do you have any better
ideas ponref avdol said sternly Iggy
barked Iggy the last member of the
Stardust Crusaders he was a Boston
Terrier who commanded a sand
manipulating stand known as the fool
Iggy didn't really have much to add to
the conversation but he liked to be
heard listen said Joseph joestar when I
was a younger man I actually did go head
to head with some terrifying beings who
might be able to turn people into
monsters like these but every single
time the sun was the enemy of those guys
nobody is interested in hearing your
stories right now old man jotaro chided
his grandfather meanwhile far from where
the Stardust Crusaders were hiding out
hero friend green was reaching the
limits of its effective of range and
seeing no sign of an end to the
anomalous effects kakian was baffled
could it be true that the entire world
had been affected by the frightening
ability of the sun now that it was
scp-001 if that was true then the
apocalyptic Wasteland was more than just
the work of an enemy stand user this
would mean that the sun itself had
become the enemy of all life kakian
wondered about his family back in Japan
would they manage to survive this
terrible catastrophe he couldn't help
but hope that there was some way out of
this utter Devastation even though the
information gathered by a stand told him
otherwise kakian withdrew hirofin green
and brought his companions up to speed
however hard it was to accept the world
as they knew it was Gone with the
Daybreak polnerv was beside himself in
sadness while Abdul and Joseph exchanged
a meaningful glance for once Iggy's bad
attitude subsided and the dog simply
whispered only jotaro remained
determined to carry on good grief would
you all get a hold of yourselves jotaro
said we'll remain human as long as we
aren't caught in that light so I'll use
star Platinum to Tunnel our way
underground jotaro's star Platinum was a
short-range stand but in terms of raw
power it was off the charts its punches
could easily tunnel through solid rock
and create a Subterranean passageway for
the Crusaders to retreat to a safer area
that a boy jotaro Joseph exclaimed will
make our daring Escape mole style jotro
nodded and called star Platinum shouting
its signature Battle Cry of
star Platinum smashed through the earth
below instantly creating the entrance to
a tunnel at that exact moment every
flesh monster in the nearby vicinity
turned its attention towards the sound
the Sten users had to move quickly
because they would soon be completely
surrounded oh my God shouted Joseph in
his usual way as a couple of flush
monsters began to enter the ruin
building luckily Paul and the Ruff and
avdal sprung into action and summoned
silver Chariot and magician's red to
fend off the flesh zombies silver
Chariot delivered an inescapably fast
Fury of Sword strikes to one of the
monsters while magicians read burned
them away with its Supernatural Flames
the two men high-fived at a job well
done just then the wall next to them
burst open revealing a new monster and
caused the sun's Rays to enter into the
building's interior with split-second
intuition avdal pushed Palmera further
into the Shadows the Frenchman tumbled
backwards into the whole jotoro made and
before he could get his bearings he
caught a glimpse of avdal being absorbed
into the monster's Mass Abdul he cried
out but it was too late avdal was
already starting to show signs of
transformation into an ooze-like zombie
himself the fortune teller breathed in
deep and called the name of his stand
with determined fervor magicians read
before avdol could be fully taken by the
slime he unleashed the totality of his
Firepower on every zombified life form
within range its destructive heat
enhanced by the dryness of the
atmosphere avdal turned back to his
friends and gave them a heartfelt thumbs
up before he disappeared into the Flames
polnerv cried out for his friend again
with tears in his eyes but kaukin and
Joseph grabbed him and made their way
deeper into the tunnel as badass and
heroic as it was Abdul's sacrifice
wouldn't keep those hordes of monsters
at Bay for long while kaikin and Joseph
dragged a crying pulmonary through the
underground Escape Route jotro and Iggy
were already at the front of the group
using a combination of star platinum's
digging ability and Iggy's sand
manipulation to stabilize the tunnel the
Stardust Crusaders were deep beneath the
surface of the Earth now so a Caven
could be a real problem we have to go
back ponderaf shrieked Abdul needs our
help it's too late Paul rev Joseph said
with grim conviction avdol is gone we we
don't know that for sure upon the ref
carried on let me go but Cochin and
Joseph held on to polnerv tightly and
continued to drag him down the
passageway hoping not to lose him to
this daytime nightmare as well on the
inside jotaro was shaken by the loss of
one of his companions but nobody would
have been able to tell by looking at his
stoic exterior he was solely focused on
keeping the tunnel expanding so that he
and the remaining Crusaders could
survive this ordeal together suddenly a
noise from the opposite end of the
passageway put the group on high alert
like a flood of liquefied horror the
flesh monsters had begun pouring
themselves into the pit and were now
moving towards the group inch by inch oh
no Joseph shouted he loosened his grip
on palmoreth and both of them
immediately booked it towards jotoro and
Iggy kakin however stood in place and
braced himself he didn't like it but he
knew what he had to do right now his
stand had the ability to stop these
things but first he had to slow them
down Emerald Splash kakian shouted
prompting herofin green to launch a
stream of concussive green gemstones
from its hands as planned the attack
slowed the Slime monsters down kakin was
then able to put the second part of his
plan into effect he identified what
appeared to be a face on the monster in
front and sent hierophant green to make
its way inside the creature's body this
was his Stan's most terrifying ability
and one [__] in seldom used hirofen
green had the power to control the
bodies of other physical entities from
within once his stand had established
control kaukin forced the massive ooze
to stop in place instantly plugging the
tunnel and preventing the rest of the
monsters from getting any closer how
long could he keep this up he didn't
know but because of herofin Green's
properties as a remote stand kakin was
able to run and rejoin jotoro and the
others at the front of the tunnel the
tether between himself and his stand was
stretching farther by the minute but he
dared not let his control of the oozing
entity slip lest he and his companions
suffer the same fate as afterl before
long jotaro felt a different sort of
surface at the front of the tunnel
rather than Earth it was brick with one
punch from Star Platinum he smashed
through and into what appeared to be an
abandoned subway station the power was
still on but most of the lights had
faded it was fortunate that there was no
natural sunlight in this place as
everyone's eyes adjusted to the light
the stand users crossed the tracks and
made their way onto the somewhat safer
area palmeroff drifted over to the
magazine kiosk searching for signs of
anyone behind the counter there was
nobody here and Iggy soon helped himself
to some of the coffee flavored chewing
gum at the concession stand the dog
couldn't resist his favorite snack after
all jotro stood by the tracks as if
Waiting for a Train while Cochin did his
best to maintain his hold on the
monsters further behind them in the
tunnel with a bit of searching Joseph
found a large portable music player
designed for CDs also known as a Boombox
with the use of his divination focused
stand hermit purple Joseph created
purple thorny Vines which weave their
way into the wires of the device and
generated a psychic message hermit
purple could usually be counted on to
provide more detail about a situation
but its powers were limited by the
device used to gain the information in
this case the CD within the Boombox had
a copy of the Beatles famous 1969 album
Abbey Road so hermit purple's message to
Joseph came out as a garbled but oddly
appropriate rearrangement of the lyrics
to Here Comes the Sun little darling I
see their faces slowly melting little
darling it seems like you since it's
been alright Here Comes the Sun here
Here Comes the Sun and I say I feel I've
been slowly melting
sun sun sun here it comes oh my God
Joseph said to himself quietly just then
kakin felt the body that hirofen green
was controlling give way apparently the
pressure of so many other ooze monsters
had been too much for it to hold back
and now these things were barreling down
the tunnel towards the Crusaders rather
than pulling herofin green back
completely kakin Unleashed his Emerald
Splash over and over again in an attempt
to force a cave-in but the creatures
were too resilient and their ooze-like
structures meant they could squeeze past
mere rocks in their path kakin told the
rest of the group that it was time to
leave and as if On Cue a train began to
pull into the station unfortunately the
crazy train pulled into the station with
several Cars full of ooh zombies ready
to grab the poor team and drag them into
the sun
there was no way out but up the stairs
back into the sunlight they had done
everything possible to escape from as
polnerv jotaro Joseph and Iggy did their
best to fend off the attacking creatures
using their stands Cochin made one
last-ditch attempt to contain the
monsters he stretched hierophen green
down to its most basic form a series of
long green fibrous strings and created a
net to ensnare the creatures while the
uses could still seep its way through
its wiry form kakin rigged his stand to
set off an emerald Splash on every bit
of anomalous goo that made it past the
Nets defenses it was a sustainable and
effective wall against the monsters
using both the tensile strength of the
stand and its energy attacks to
effectively stymie their progress there
was only one problem in order to
maintain this Perfect Defense Cochin
would have to stay behind I'll hold them
go on without me kakin said
Joseph shouted as the rest of them ran
as fast as they could out of the subway
having effectively lost two members of
the group The Stardust Crusaders were
low in spirits looking up through the
subway exit they could see that they
would soon be in contact with the
sunlight meaning that even their
survival would become unlikely but
jotaro wasn't about to give in he
grabbed Iggy and held the dog out in
front of him alright Iggy it's now or
never others show us you can be a team
player or be the first to turn into one
of those blob Monsters Iggy struggled in
Joe throws grip but to Noah fail the dog
knew that jotaro was serious so in an
act of self-preservation that was
unusually generous of him Iggy used the
fool to stir up the sand on the ground
above into a gigantic Shady sand Dome
moments later he compressed it into a
compact Fortress of sand Iggy's Moving
Castle as it were no light could enter
this Fortress but because of the
granular nature of sand oxygen was
flowing freely
the Stardust Crusaders now had a method
of travel in this world torn apart by
scp-001 of course there was still the
matter of dealing with the flesh
creatures outside even if the Fortress
of sand could move across the surface
without sunlight getting in the
surrounding oozes could still impede its
progress with the help of all three of
jotoro Joseph and paulnerev stands a
solution soon became clear Joseph would
use hermit purple on the sand to define
the location of any approaching threats
while jotaro and polnerv would Patrol
the outside of the miniaturized Fortress
with star platinum and silver Chariot
respectively that way whenever a flesh
creature got too close the two attack
type stands could unleash full force
barrages to knock them away the next
thing to do was for Iggy to increase the
speed of the sand construct by adding
Wheels to it it was like a gigantic sand
monster truck zooming through the ruins
with a platinum brawler and a silver
Knight repelling anything that came to
near once Iggy gained enough velocity
with the fool Joseph used hermit purple
to discern the location of a bit of
rubble shaped conveniently like a ramp
the sand castle vaulted off the ramp and
into the air while Iggy augmented his
creation once again with a pair of
gigantic gliding wings now they were
soaring out of the reach of the flesh
monsters Joseph and paularez shared
sympathies over the loss of their two
important friends avdalen kaukin had
both bravely given themselves to protect
the team and none of the Crusaders would
be here if it wasn't for them jotaro
focused on helping Iggy pilot the sand
glider using star Platinum to kick the
ground whenever the vehicle got too low
nobody was sure what they would
encounter next in the Daybreak or what
Bizarre Adventures were yet to unfold
but they had each other and for now that
was enough not everything in this world
is exactly as it seems in fact there are
many creatures in the wild that go out
of their way to be deceptive to disguise
themselves as something entirely
different from their true nature
aggressive mimicry refers to a
phenomenon in which Predators or
parasites take on the appearance of
something harmless or even appealing in
order to lure in their intended prey or
host without detection they might
resemble food an inanimate part of the
environment or even a potential mate
whatever they choose they're secretly a
wolf in sheep's clothing in the deep
dark Waters of the ocean the anglerfish
dangles an alluring light from its head
ushering in little fish that it can trap
in its mouth and devour whole the
alligator snapping turtle Wiggles its
long tongue like a worm attracting
Hungry Fish looking for their next Meal
instead they become the meal for
something bigger and more clever than
them false cleaner fish share their
appearance of another species one that
helps clean larger fish in a symbiotic
relationship when the imposters find a
victim they swim close under the
pretense of cleaning only to take a bite
out of them and swim away Predators use
similar illusions on land too
anti-mimicking jumping spiders wave
their false antenna in the air in an
imitation of an ant's movements
isolating the insects from their colony
before dragging them back to their Lair
to be devoured the mouth parts of the
male spiders are shaped like the head of
an ant but this imitation head splits
apart to reveal the spider's fangs and
its true intentions the photores Firefly
lights up its body in a mimicry of other
Firefly species mating signals signaling
male fireflies looking for companionship
when they respond to the call however
they will not find a willing mate
waiting but instead a femme fatale of a
firefly that just wants to eat the
spider-tailed horned viper has a bulbous
tip on its tail with false legs jutting
out on either side as the snake Wiggles
its tail running it across the ground
while the rest of its body lies in way
just out of sight a hungry bird spots it
from above when the bird swoops down to
seize the opportunity the snake reveals
itself snapping up the unfortunate bird
before it can escape thankfully humans
are so much smarter and more observant
than fish ants and birds were safe from
that sort of trickery there aren't any
animals out there who've learned how to
look like something familiar something
every day just to put unsuspecting
people at ease and lures into its
waiting Jaws right wrong only a couple
of years ago the SCP Foundation
discovered a being that has mastered
aggressive mimicry on a level previously
unseen in the natural world
unfortunately for us its prey of choice
happens to be humans and its hunting
ground is the very cities where we like
to think we're safe from something much
bigger meaner and hungrier than us a
short video went viral on a popular
social media platform the specific
platform has been redacted from official
files but the details of it are clear a
popular Creator on
a young woman known for her makeup
tutorials and restaurant recommendations
around her native city of Los Angeles
she was live streaming and answering
questions while going about her day when
she stepped onto a train at one of the
Metro stations around the city the train
was extremely crowded and she was
preparing to end the live video planning
to resume once she reached her
destination but just as she went to
press the button at the end of the
stream something strange happened the
train went dark and the space flooded
with a strange thick liquid the girl
screamed in either pain horror or both
and dropped the phone whatever it fell
into must have degraded the phone at an
extremely rapid Pace because the video
feed cut out immediately after a splash
all across social media people shared
the video with one question in mind what
happened on that train fans mounted the
campaign to find the influencer to help
her if she was in any immediate danger
but there were no leads her friends and
family said she never came home that day
and when authorities attempted to trace
her phone they could not get any kind of
signal becoming increasingly concerned
about this missing girl and the
possibility of some kind of unreported
train accident authorities contacted the
Los Angeles metro and showed them the
video footage but every train was
accounted for and in pristine condition
there had been no strange chemical leaks
no crashes and certainly nothing like
what the video appeared to show at the
same time there were missing persons
reports being filed all across the
country in every area with a thriving
public transportation system not only
were the occupants of the Los Angeles
train unaccounted for with no wreckage
or bodies to be found but people were
disappearing in train stations in New
York Boston Chicago Washington DC and
more a woman reported her husband
missing after he called her to check in
during his daily commute home from work
the train had kept going for much longer
than it ordinarily did drifting off of
its usual route he told her that
something was wrong that he had a
terrible feeling of foreboding and then
the call cut off he never made it home
for dinner a young woman was on her way
to start an internship at a prestigious
New York City magazine but never arrived
for her first meeting when her would-be
boss reached out to the girl's roommate
all he knew was that she had planned to
take the train to work that morning a
private detective trailing a man's wife
for him looking for evidence of an
affair lost track of her when she
stepped onto a train downtown he took
the next train hoping to catch her at
what he assumed would be her stop but
she never got off he wasn't able to
track her down and had to give her
suspicious husband the news that his
wife had somehow vanished Into Thin Air
it wasn't just one or two people every
so often either entire train cars of
people were just disappearing never to
be seen again no matter how hard anyone
tried they could not find any answers no
logical explanation for what could have
happened fortunately the video
circulated so widely that it made it
onto the feed of an SCP Foundation
employee who was idly scrolling during a
bathroom break he was so shocked by what
he saw that he almost forgot to pull up
his pants before running out into the
Hall fortunately he did remember and
rushed to his supervisor's office fully
clothed after determining that the video
was not a hoax or some kind of viral
marketing stunt intended to sell a new
brand of spicy chips the SCP Foundation
decided to launch a formal investigation
into anomalous activity involving trains
and subway systems around the country
task forces were set up in every major
city and field researchers were assigned
to take the train all day every day as
much as possible as they did they would
maintain communication with the head of
their task force would monitor their
findings via hidden cameras and
microphones a week passed without
incident and the foundation was starting
to wonder if somehow the Los Angeles
video had been faked when the Chicago
task force made a harrowing Discovery
officer Jamie Bauer was assigned to
monitor the trains on Chicago's Blue
Line taking the train throughout the day
and keeping an eye out for suspicious or
potentially anomalous Activity one
weekend and he pretty much had it down
to a basic routine he would grab
breakfast hop on the train and enjoy his
coffee and meal while reading a book and
riding the train to its last stop then
he'd pick up lunch and do the same thing
all over again he'd have dinner and
repeat it wasn't too exciting but then
again excitement in this case probably
meant Horrors Beyond his comprehension
so he was perfectly fine with traversing
the city in a subway car and catching up
on the backlog of murder mysteries he'd
been meaning to read it was Monday
afternoon he'd picked up a slice of deep
dish pizza excited to try it for the
first time and walk down into the metro
station as he took his first bite can
you try not to chew into your microphone
please it's gross Dr Susan Shepard the
head of the Chicago task force spoke
into Jamie's earpiece you got it boss
you said this mouthful thanks see
anything unusual today she asked you
tell me you can see the video feed right
he took another bite chewing as quietly
as he could sure but you're on the
ground just keep an eye out okay be
careful remember to draw your weapon if
something goes south don't just
disappear into your book and forget to
keep your wits about you Dr Shepard's
side yep getting on the train now not
gonna talk much so these folks don't
think I'm nuts Jaime waited for the
doors to open and just for a moment
notice that they seem to stick just a
little this time nothing to be too
worried about though everything looked
normal just as it had on every other
ride he'd taken he could feel the Agatha
Christie book calling to him from inside
of his tote bag and he wanted to crack
it open and see what Clues haircut Roe
had come across but Dr Shepherd was
right he'd been slacking off he needed
to pay attention to his surroundings so
he did just that he watched as the train
car steadily filled up with passengers
college students with bags full of books
and exhausted Expressions middle-aged
people and business attire tourists
wearing souvenir baseball caps and
snapping pictures of everything in sight
before too long the train was completely
packed and Jaime could barely move
without bumping elbows with someone it
was a little claustrophobic but that was
public transportation Jamie leaned back
in his seat pulled his book out and
focused on the comforting Rumble of the
engine the Rhythm Of The Wheels On The
Tracks suddenly without warning the
train screeched to a stop they were in
the middle of a tunnel Jaime assumed
from the darkness that flanked them out
the window on either side wait was it
dark or the windows just disappeared he
squinted through the Blackness and tried
to see what was outside but he couldn't
make sense of his surroundings all
around the other passengers were
becoming Restless nervous some were
calling for help others were just
complaining doc you seeing this Jamie
hist into the microphone I don't see a
thing Dr Shepard replied are you all
right fine the trains just stalled out
nowhere or what's wrong Jamie began
feeling along the walls of the train
looking for doors that's weird what well
the crack in the doors when they come
together should be right here but it's
all smooth no gaps or anything like it's
all one thing and it feels strange like
he cut himself off as his stomach
dropped a sudden Rush of fear of
flooding his senses like what Dr Shepard
pressed like it's alive Jamie said
shakily Campbell what's happening in
there Dr Shepherd began taking Furious
notes on her end I don't know it's so
dark everyone's scared I'm scared I
don't think this is a train I don't know
what it is but it's nothing good as
Jaime felt around he smelled something
sour foul and sharp in his nose he heard
liquid splashing onto the ground the
sound of something sizzling and then
people started to scream as he felt
along the wall something dripped onto
his hand and then it started to burn he
cried out in agony as whatever had
dripped onto him ate away at the skin
dissolving his hand bit by bit what is
it Dr Shepard's voice shook as she heard
the pain in Jaime's voice some kind of
acid oh God it's everywhere it's on the
walls floors it just keeps coming he
trailed off oh God oh God we're in his
stomach whatever this thing is it's
eating us Campbell you need to get out
of there right now Dr Shepard ordered
draw your weapon whatever you need to do
just get out Jaime pulled out his weapon
and started firing at the place where
the doors should be but the bullets
bounced off uselessly as if the fleshy
material was the side of a tank he fired
until there was no more ammunition left
and then he just kept squeezing the
trigger some more out of pure survival
Instinct but all it got him was a
useless click and the certainty that the
one thing he had brought with him in
case of emergency was completely useless
all the while the acid was creeping
higher dripping from every surface
filling a train car until it swallowed
the cries for help and the screams of
fear and Agony all Dr Shepard could do
was listen helpless as Jaime and the
rest of the passengers were digested
inside of the massive stomach what
happened to officer Jamie Campbell was
tragic but it provided important
information that the foundation would
likely never have gotten otherwise they
now knew a few key things about this new
anomaly it was some kind of living thing
able to disguise itself as a train it
was resilient to bullets and firearms
and it was hiding in plain sight in
order to hunt human beings they had
found the culprit for the rash of
mysterious disappearances and it was a
race of unidentified creatures capable
taking on the shape of a common
underground train the Newfound
information quickly circulated
throughout the foundation making its way
to the various task forces assigned to
operation Metro as it had been
unofficially nicknamed task force
members were no longer instructed to
board trains instead they would slip
hidden cameras onto as many train cars
as they possibly could each outfitted
with a tracking device then the
foundation could remotely monitor the
trains for any potential signs of the
mysterious creatures looking for
imposters masquerading as trains without
unnecessarily losing any more operatives
in action now as for what they would do
once they found one of these massive
creatures was still uncertain but at
least they had somewhere to Star the SCP
Foundation tried and failed to contain
several instances of the carnivorous
species before they finally got it right
they attempted to freeze the inside of
one train with liquid nitrogen hoping to
incapacitate the creature before it
could feed defend itself or Escape
custody the extreme cold seemed to have
no effect however and the false train
slammed its doors shot at the first sign
of discomfort then sped away at high
speed as it did the task force members
noticed that though they could hear the
sound of wheels on the tracks they could
see legs jutting out of the bottom of
the creature scuttling along the ground
next they attempted to take out the
creature's legs and render it immobile
so that it could be subdued the legs
were resilient to external damage
becoming hard as a rock whenever any
weapon blade or other Implement made
contact with them one Task Force member
tried to physically hold some of the
legs in place but they shifted their
shape becoming appendages resembling
tentacles and threw the man out of the
way before the false train hurried out
of the tunnel and out of sight they were
then able to track down a predatory
train just after a feeding when it was
slightly sluggish after a large meal
they pumped and aerosolized poison into
the Train's interior the belly of the
Beast potent enough to take out a
dinosaur and were relieved to find that
the creature wasn't able to flee
unfortunately though they were able to
subdue the creature they killed it in
the process at first they assumed it was
just inactive but it never resumed
activity again it was just like an
ordinary train car almost when the
interior was touched it felt warm and
slightly pliable less like metal and
plastic and more like flesh the longer
the creature was still the more the
windows on the sides stopped looking
like windows and started looking like
wide glassy eyes the front of the train
became a gaping maw the silhouette of
the conductor inside revealed as an
extension of the creature's body
resembling a tongue survivors and
Witnesses were given an amnestic to
remove any memories of the supposed
killer trains running under their city
and the foundation prepared to bring the
dead specimen in for further study a
cover story was used involving massive
repairs to the train system and while
the tunnels were closed off they managed
to remove the creature and transport it
to a nearby Foundation containment site
there it was given one of the most
extensive autopsies in Foundation
history and the first one conducted
largely from inside the subject the
autopsy provided a more in-depth look at
the nature of the bizarre creature and
its curious nature the creature
nicknamed the train eater referring to
its preferred disguise and favorite
activity was one of an apparent species
of carnivorous predators that use
shape-shifting and an advanced form of
aggressive mimicry to to prey on
commuters tourists and anyone else in
need of a ride from one place to the
next it would mimic the shape feel and
sounds of a train welcoming unassuming
victims into its stomach and once it was
completely full and able to efficiently
feed it would release an incredibly
potent stomach acid into the compartment
and quickly dissolve everything inside
the creature was highly adaptable able
to harden parts of its body at will and
display extreme resilience to weapons of
any kind due to this nearly impenetrable
flesh victims trapped inside would be
unable to force their way out as the
research staff turned in their autopsy
results and official report there was a
sense of unease in the air as everyone
wondered how many of these things are
out there which innocent trip to work
might be their last and how on Earth
could they hope to contain something
that could exist in endless numbers
something so expert at hiding in plain
sight there was no realistic way to
bring all these creatures into custody
and so they would have to neutralize as
many as possible without being detected
Foundation operatives embedded in
various city and state governments
introduced new measures to renovate
public transportation systems including
new sanitation protocols as part of
these protocols all trains would be
sprayed with a high strength
disinfectant before they could be
certified for use in reality this
disinfectant would be the same poison
used to take down the first train Aid or
the foundation studied once any and all
potent threats had been rendered
harmless trains that were found to be
formally living would be converted into
fully functioning trains and allowed to
run as normal in order to avoid
unnecessary interruptions to the public
in addition to these containment
measures the foundation monitors all
social media for mentions of unusual
activity on trains or mentions of any
more missing persons lost at Metro
stations the original Los Angeles video
that started it all was scrubbed from
the internet entirely so by all means
take advantage of your local public
transportation options but remain
Vigilant and keep your wits about you
and remember next time you travel by
train if you see something say something
more specifically if you see something
unusual on a train if it looks a little
different than it did yesterday if its
sounds don't seem quite right make sure
to let everyone around you know that it
is not safe to be here and quickly make
your way to the exit then maybe walk to
your destination instead it might make
you a little bit late but hey better
wait than dinner they are hummed a space
a few feet off the ground Rippling like
a calm like disturbed by a stone Throne
of its surface not that there was anyone
around to see which of course begged the
age-old question that has baffled
philosophers scientists and pretty much
everyone with a working brain for
centuries that being if an
interdimensional fracture leading to an
infinite Multiverse of endlessly
recurring realities opens up in a hotel
resort bedroom Mexico and nobody is
there to see it then did it really
happen at all well in this instance it
really did the flash of light a figure
came tumbling Through the Wormhole
fizzling out of existence in one place
only to arrive somewhere similar behind
him the purplish Terror in the very
fabric of reality sealed itself shut as
quickly and inexplicably as it had
opened setting up his Hawaiian shirt to
disheveled mess the man blinked through
his blurred vision Eddie Brock was
unsure of his headache was the result of
an intense hangover or the process of
being flung between universes seemingly
at random are we back a voice in the
back of Eddie's head growled I have no
idea pal Eddie replied aloud looking
around the vacant hotel room the last of
the daylight fading as the sun set we
should eat the gravelly voice replied
I'm hungry that's all you ever think
about he replied I don't even have any
money on me besides don't you think we
should try and figure out where we are
first nope in seconds a dark gooey
substance morphed over Eddie from head
to toe encasing him and his clothes it
formed a body a towering hoking monster
with wide white eyes in the shape of
teardrops its mouth was filled with rows
of long razor-sharp teeth the black goo
was constantly shifting in fact it was
alive an alien symbiote bonded with its
human host in order to survive together
the symbiota and Eddie were Venom
bursting out of the hotel's balconies
night rapidly fell venom-fired organic
webs from his wrists and swung through
the city in search of food agent Hardy
hated field work he'd imagine working
for the SCP Foundation would be full of
action and thrilling Espionage and had
enrolled in undercover training hoping
he'd be sent on missions to stealthily
infiltrate other anomalous organizations
like the Church of the broken God or
Global occult coalition instead he was
assigned to Deep Cover which was
Foundation euphemism for stay put and
keep your eyes peeled just in case you
spot something unusual he had been
stationed in Mexico City and was forced
to work a menial job in a tiny little
convenience store to maintain cover a
waste of his Advanced combat and
reconnaissance training he thought agent
Hardy badly wanted more and found it
personally insulting that the foundation
sought fit to waste an asset like him
while he should have been made part of
one of their mobile task forces only
adding to that perceived insult was the
fact that nothing at all unusual or even
remotely anomalous ever seemed to happen
nearby that is until a seven foot tall
500 pound oily black monster came
barreling into the convenience store
barged its way over to The Confectionary
aisle and started shoveling fistfuls of
chocolate into its mouth all before
dashing back out and Swinging away with
as many candy bars as it could carry in
one arm Hardy if somebody robbed your
store that's a job for the local police
department the board voice Foundation
operator replied over the radio as agent
Hardy contacted command no not just
somebody something Hardy yelled while
the store's customers ran screaming from
the scene it's a goddamn alien I saw it
with my own eyes it's huge hold on one
moment the operator replied before
turning to a colleague still audible
over the radio meanwhile agent Hardy
tapped his foot impatiently didn't We
Get Up Lift near there what I don't know
the exact time about an hour ago tops
any read on what it was interdimensional
disturbance that could be connected look
how do you want me to proceed Hardy
barked uh follow at a distance agent
Hardy the operator replied be advised do
not engage with the creature under any
circumstances it could be carrying any
number of unknown pathogens or diseases
we don't have cures for if it is from
Another Universe strict observation only
mobile task force knows is inbound to
contain your alien agent Hardy turned
and dashed out of the store sprinting
down the street a little way in the
distance Venom had been swinging from
buildings they were singing I got you
under my skin to themselves without a
care on the world before landing on a
rooftop and starting to ravenously munch
on their remaining chocolate bars all
delicious Venom growled after finishing
their feast so when are we gonna work on
getting back home Eddie asked half of
the Symbiotes protective mask retracting
to show him underneath this might be our
home then I'm retorted the splattered
looks the shame in every Universe look I
really think we ought to prioritize
getting out of here the human half of
them argued that should be our priority
not feeding you Eddie we've been over
this I need the Lettermen to live and
since you get all indignant at me for
eating brains we have to get it from a
more socially acceptable source the
alien creature replied unless unless
what broadcast unless you want to go
find some bad guys brains to eat the
symbiotequeried hey you someone yelled
hold it right there as if On Cue the
sounds of weapons being mocked and
loaded interrupted their conversation in
the time since agent Hardy had called it
in the foundation's mobile task force
had arrived on the rooftop Hardy was
with them hanging back and letting the
other operatives move in to apprehend
the alien drawing themselves to their
full height Venom turned to face the
approaching Squad of armed soldiers
their face returning to its full sharp
tooth form bad guys Venom ground
grinning wildly guys with guns pointed
at us I'm gonna guess probably bad guys
Eddie answered before noticing the logo
emblazed on the mtf's uniforms hold up
SCP Foundation like the life Foundation
who cares Undeclared their dinner open
fire the MTF Commander yelled before
being suddenly silenced Venom had
grabbed him and was beginning to close
his Jaws around his head the remaining
members of the task force followed their
squad Leader's final command and pulled
their triggers the rooftop erupted into
a handle of gunfire bullets impacting
with Venom's oily form but causing no
damage bouncing off their outer
gelatinous skin they lunged at another
of the MTF Troopers wrenching the man's
weapon from his hands and hurling it
away before grabbing him by the ankle
with Incredible strength Venom flung The
operative around in the air as if he was
a ragdoll swinging him into the other
troops sending them flying hanging back
from the fight agent Hardy was trying to
observe the creature's attack patterns
although it seemed to just be
chaotically flinging an MTF operative
around as a weapon rather than deploying
any form of actual technique he wanted
to spot an opening a weakness anything
that could take down this hulking alien
monster but not one was presenting
itself that is until Venom finished
swinging that helpless Foundation
Soldier around and threw the man over
their shoulder the MTF Trooper dropped
limply down to street level landing on a
parked car with a loud crash and the
sound of glass shattering which was
followed by The Wailing of the car's
emergency alarm the screeching noise
seemingly caused Venom to reel from
their fight with the MTF roaring and
gripping their head to drown out the
alarm sound hearty muttered to himself
its weakness is sound instantly he
turned to one of the other MTF soldiers
and dashed towards him while Venom was
lashing out in an enraged State the
strands of the Symbiote were recoiling
exposing Eddie contained beneath agent
Hardy grabbed the nearest Foundation
operative and violently struck him in
the face taking advantage of the
trooper's shock to pull his weapon out
of his hands and push him towards the
edge of the rooftop he delivered another
blow feeling his fellow Foundation
agent's nose cracking against his fist
as he took out all his frustrations with
is undercover posting the task force
operative could barely believe what was
happening too dumbfounded and in too
much pain to protest even when he did
weekly lift his arms to defend his face
agent Hardy effortlessly swatted them
away and smashed his forehead into the
other agent's face dazing him as he
dragged him right up to the ledge there
was nothing between the captive Soldier
just a sheer multi-story drop down to
street level lining him up agent Hardy
shoved the other men off the roof so he
landed on a second car its alarm started
blaring the horn too as the Fallen
agent's body went through the windshield
adding even more loud noises to the max
such a deafening combination of loud
sounds caused Venom to Keel over roaring
in pain as the Symbiotes main weakness
pierced it if the noise continued for
too long it would force Eddie and his
alien accomplice to separate and so the
slimy form defensively retreated into
its host leaving him alone wearing a
triumphant smug look on his face agent
Hardy marched over to the human being
that was left the alien form was gone
for now meaning he could just raise his
stolen weapon and strike Eddie hard in
the face knocking him out ready for the
foundation to take him and the Symbiote
in for examination after hours of
torture that agent Hardy had volunteered
to conduct personally the foundation had
learned that a sustained barrage of high
frequency sound waves could be used to
forcibly separate the gelatinous alien
life form from its host once they had
been parted Eddie Brock didn't need much
more containment than any other average
human while the Symbiote could be placed
in a glass tank for the foundation
researchers to take a closer look at the
creature seems to possess a
Consciousness its own Mobility it is an
entirely separate entity from Mr Brock
one of the researchers commented
observing a sample of the symbiont that
they had managed to slice off the larger
hole and was now slithering its way
around a smaller transparent containment
Cube that's pretty obvious Poindexter
agent Hardy retorted impatiently why
don't you give me something useful what
well the researchers stammered
intimidated by the imposing field
operative it appears to be rapidly
deteriorating that thing is dying Hardy
asked it seems so we've been able to
access some of the hive mind that it
shares with the rest of its kind
apparently these he checked his notes
planktar are able to share knowledge
across multiple realities but they need
to remain bonded to a host in order to
survive on their own their lifespans are
much shorter the researcher added but it
seems that once they have they increase
the host's strength replicate their own
Mass even use more of itself to create
weapons weapons the agent that code yes
yes anything it seems some of these
symbiotes could even create copies of
existing Weaponry that would act as an
extension of itself fully usable by the
host thank you doc that info should come
in pretty handy agent Hardy applied I I
beg your pardon agent the researcher
asked before agent Hardy's hand gripping
his throat silenced him elsewhere in the
facility Eddie Brock was yelling
demanding to be let free his only
thought was getting back to Venom aware
that his symbiotic partner would wither
and die if they remained apart for too
long thanks to their bond he knew Venom
was thinking the same thing this precise
moment and only spurred him on to try
and pull himself free he was handcuffed
to a chair barely able to move normally
the pair of them could get out of a jam
like this with no trouble after all
things were always easier when they were
together I got you Eddie started to sing
loudly and tunelessly under my skin
quiet snapped a foundation security
officer who stood nearby I got you they
ignore the garden continued making his
voice even louder deep in the heart of
me so deep in my heart that you're
really a part of me I got you oh I said
quiet the officer barked marching over
to Eddie baton raised threateningly with
a sudden unrelenting strike he kicked
the guard in the stomach with all the
force he could manage when did the
officer crumpled dropping to the floor
as he gasped for air not letting up
Eddie kicked again this time his boot
connected with the man's jaw and knocked
him out it wouldn't last forever though
using his legs and with a great deal of
difficulty Eddie tried to lift the
handcuffed keys from the officer's belt
he hardly possessed perfect coordination
meaning it required a lot of trial and
error but knowing Venom needed him made
him all the more determined to try and
try again until finally Eddie pulled the
keys up with his boots lifted his legs
so they slid down and caught them in his
cuffed hand freeing himself he left the
unconscious security guard cuffed in his
place before making his way through the
facility as quickly and quietly as he
could it didn't matter that he had never
been there before he could sense Venom
anywhere even though they were apart all
he had to do was follow the pole to
where it was being held however he could
have done with his symbiote partner's
protection when he arrived in the lab
something tore through Eddie's shoulder
embedding itself in his flesh screaming
with pain he lifted a hand to the
bleeding wound only to feel a second
shot strike him in the gut he could feel
the projectile in his hand gritting his
teeth he pulled it out it was a tooth
blood soaked and fired with the force of
a bullet it was then that Eddie looked
up and saw where from towering over him
agent Hardy looked almost unrecognizable
he had bonded with the sample cut off of
the Symbiote and it had encased his body
in a suit all of his own he had black
segmented plates like armor although
with the same gelatinous oily appearance
as Venom and his hand was what looked
like a submachine gun but was in
actuality something special that the
agent had requisitioned from the
foundation's anomalous Armory a it was
scp-127 a weapon that like the Symbiote
was also an organic living being capable
of firing human-like teeth in the place
of bullets to make matters worse The
Shred of symbiote Hardy wore had cloned
its own versions of scp-127 their
handles extending into long black
tendrils that protruded from the agent's
back the rest of Venom was still
contained in the tank frantically
slithering against the glass trying to
free itself and get to Eddie if it did
it could heal his injuries and make
itself whole again stomping over to
where his wounded victim lay symbiote
infused Hardy pulled Eddie up from the
floor and lifted him to his feet making
sure he dug his symbiote coated thumb
into his wounds making Eddie cry out in
pain gotta be said Mr Brock Hardy grins
sadistically I can see why you'd want to
be merged with one of these things the
strength it gives you is
amazing enough to make anybody take you
serious
remind them not to underestimate you and
that's all from me getting a little
peace imagine how strong I'll be when
I'm combined with your little alien
friend there you should know Eddie wins
Adam's a little picky about who he hangs
out with and trust me you're not his
type oh yeah agent Hardy roared with his
symbiote enhanced strength he hurled
Eddie across the lab with such force
that he smashed the glass tank before
colliding with the far wall and landing
in a heap Eddie was still bleeding
heavily from the teeth he'd been shot
with as Venom tried and it's weakened
state to slide across the floor to him
only for Hardy to catch it he lifted the
rest of the dark gooey symbiote and
dangled it tauntingly over Eddie as he
lay bleeding out on the floor you're
nothing without this thing attached to
you Brock Hardy jeard in fact even when
you two were bonded on that rooftop you
were easy enough to take down guess
together you two are nothing
no Eddie rasped weekly reaching his hand
up with the last of his fading strength
as he did Hardy didn't notice the
Symbiote reaching back to its host
together we're we're the alien life form
gave a surge and slipped over Eddie's
hand instantly his gunshot wounds sealed
up and repaired just as the dark slimy
form encased him once more standing up
catching Hardy by surprise Venom gripped
the agent by the neck where a lethal
protector you feel me they ground
grinning and showing off their sharp
rows of teeth Venom lifted agent Hardy
up and threw him hard enough to send him
crashing through the wall Landing a few
feet away glad to have you back came out
his voice good to be back Venom replied
were you singing Our Song earlier yeah
Eddie's side that's how I escaped before
they could continue their conversation
agent Hardy roared at them staggering
back to his feet he began firing scp-127
at
the various copies his symbiote had
created unleashing a barrage of toothy
projectiles at them they didn't Ricochet
off like regular bullets in fact they
seem to be strong enough to shred
through Venom's outer symbiote skin
until it added a chance to reform
ouch they roared oh yeah his guns shoot
teeth had he worn slightly too late this
guy sucks Venom growled no arguments
there Eddie replied he had a plan your
partner I am open to suggestions Eddie
the symbiotic half answered as they
retreated from the gunfire party
charging after them the agent launched a
thumb tackling Venom pinning them down
and delivering a vicious punch the force
of it split the Symbiote head apart
revealing Eddie beneath you don't
deserve this much power agent Hardy
yelled lifting one of his oily black
tooth firing guns to Eddie's exposed
face just as he fired Venom's mask
reformed in the nick of time to protect
its host as the tooth impacted their
face both Eddie and his symbiot partner
noticed some
Hardy's symbiotes seemed to suffer the
same damage slickly parting and then
quickly reforming he's just wearing a
part of you right V Eddie asked when we
get hurt he gets hurt we just need to
hurt him enough to get them to separate
and you can get that part of your body
back Venom lifted their head noticing a
button on the wall of the corridor the
foundation had plenty of Need for
emergency alarms in case an anomaly
broke containment and sure enough there
was one labeled activate in case of
emergency raising one arm Venom fired a
line of organic web at the button the
screaming ringing sound had both Venom
and agent Hardy writhing in agony the
Symbiote began retracting from the
foundation field agent as the alarm
glared he weakly tried to crawl towards
it desperate to switch it off before his
suit separated from him a fist sailed
through the air and clocked Hardy Square
on the jaw Eddie had landed a hit he'd
knocked Hardy over keeping him down for
long enough so that the portion of the
Symbiote that had been removed leafed
off of the agent's body and quickly
crawled its way back to its original
host shutting the alarm off again Eddie
was once again encased in the form of
the lethal protector and they towered
over agent Hardy long slimy tongue
unraveling from their razor tooth Jaws
just who the hell do you think you are
party spat enraged we are Venom agent
Hardy screams echo through the halls of
the site then quickly fell silent with a
meaty crunch not long after Venom
noticed that they were starting to fade
from this universe again of Eddie it's
happening again Venom exclaimed ah we
better end up home this time Eddie
signed as they disappeared leaving the
foundation to clean up the mess that
they'd Left Behind hello again dear
viewers you know what it is and what it
does it being the animatron 6000 our
hyper Advanced simulation computer it
also being one of today's combatants the
horrifying creature created by Stephen
King in his 1986 novel the most popular
form of this shape-shifting fear-eating
monster being Pennywise the Dancing
Clown and we thought what if Pennywise
met the SCP foundation's resident lover
of fear as CP 2006 also known as too
spooky well let's turn on the device and
find out it was the summer of 1989 and
for all across the United States it was
the time of freedom of childhood Wonder
splashing through Creeks searching for
frogs flying kites and riding their
bikes as fast and as far as they could
before it was time to be home for dinner
at the SCP Foundation however there was
no summer break no lazy days lounging by
the pool no trips to the corner ice
cream shop to sample every flavor before
finally picking one and certainly no
trips to the beach he never thought he'd
say this but agent Adams was beginning
to miss dumping sand out of his shoes at
the end of a long day tending to the
sunburn he always seemed to get instead
he was working sitting on board a
foundation-owned helicopter staring down
at the beautiful sun-soaked landscape
below and wishing he too could be having
a little bit of summer fun but there was
no time to dwell on the past no day for
Daydreams he needed to bring his
attention back to the task at hand
transporting this anomaly to its new
containment site it was hard to keep
himself focused he had to admit there
wasn't much company on board it was just
him the pilot the shy quiet agent Paul
and
scp-2006 Adams didn't know too much
about the entity he had to admit he
hadn't seen too much of it only cross
paths with it once or twice currently it
was contained in a miniature portable
version of its airtight containment cell
the little he had seen of the creature
had been confusing and to be honest a
little bit ridiculous it was hairy sort
of like a gorilla but more like a man in
a cheap gorilla Halloween costume and
wore an old-school space helmet on its
head complete with two goofy antenna
jutting out of the top he had laughed
out loud when he first saw it but a
supervisor had reprimanded him harshly
and promised that if he was caught
laughing at scp-2006 again he would be
reassigned to a far more dangerous
anomaly he didn't want to screw around
with either scp-682 or
scp-106 so he made sure to stifle his
urge to giggle the next time he saw the
Absurd creature now sitting on the
helicopter listening to the whirring of
the blades and wishing he had thought to
bring a book he couldn't help but Ponder
the nature of the entity he was helping
transport so what's this thing's deal
yeah station Paul who had been silently
working on a newspaper crossword puzzle
he had brought with him what scp-2006
yeah what's up with it it's kind of you
know Silly right agent Paul's eyes
widened and put a fingers to his lips
can't say stuff like that agent Adams
held up his hands in Surprise whoa buddy
sorry to offend no no no agent Paul
shook his head you don't get it we need
to act like this thing is terrifying got
it he lowered his voice I know it's kind
of funny when I first saw that thing it
transformed into a Killer Tomato from an
old movie for crying out loud but the
higher-ups don't want it to figure out
what actually scares people so we have
to play along like when a little kid
jumps out from behind a chair in a
monster mask and you give them a big
fake scream so they can feel powerful
it's like that only the fate of humanity
rests in the balance agent Adams
couldn't help himself with that comment
seriously how does protecting this
thing's ego affect the fate of humanity
agent Paul rolled his eyes so hard it
looked like he might hurt himself
because atoms this is a creature whose
only goal in the world its favorite
thing to do its entire life's purpose is
to scare human beings that's all it
wants right now it's not that great at
it because its idea of what's scary is
based on a bunch of horrible Drive-In
horror movies from the 50s but if it
ever figured out the kind of stuff that
really scares people I mean really truly
pee your pants level scares people who
knows what it could do imagine if it say
it gotta look at SCP-173 or even a more
recent horror movie like what if this
thing saw a Nightmare on Elm Street and
decided to start cutting people up with
Freddy Krueger hands seriously you need
to learn to think before you speak agent
Adams nodded thoughtfully taking in the
surprising outbursts from such a usually
quiet guy okay dang I had no idea maybe
you should pay more attention during
briefings agent Paul snarked Adams was
just about to retort when the helicopter
suddenly veered to the left with a Lurch
there was a grinding sound metal on
metal and it quickly became apparent
that something was wrong with the
helicopter something's wrong I never
seen anything like this before the pilot
shouted from his position at the
controls this thing's going down and
we're gonna have to jump if we don't
want to go down with it what about
scp-2006 agent Paul panicked unless it
has a parachute we'll have to leave it
to fend for itself the pilot was already
suiting up with his own emergency
parachute making his way to the door of
the helicopter I suggest you get moving
if you don't feel like exploding today
that was all agent Adams needed to shock
him out of his temporary crisis-induced
paralysis he grabbed the last two
parachutes on board tossed one to the
very pale extremely sweaty agent Paul
and prepared to make the jump to what
would hopefully be safety he batted the
side of scp-2006's mobile Containment
unit half-heartedly sorry buddy was all
he could think to say before he took a
deep breath tried not to throw up and
followed the pilot diving out of the
helicopter toward the ground below he
heard agent Paul jump out right behind
him and soon the only sound he could
hear was the Roaring of the wind in his
ears as his fingers fumbled with the
ripcord on his harness he pulled it and
the parachute ballooned out doing its
job and carrying him slowly down to
earth he landed with a grunt for feeling
around for any broken bones thankfully
he had landed smoothly a few moments
later agent Paul landed a great deal
less smoothly but still very much in one
piece the pilot was already dusting
himself off several feet away from the
two men in the distance they could hear
the booming sound of the helicopter
crashing and agent Adams winced
poor guy for us agent Paul added where
are we anyway somewhere in Maine the
pilot Shrugged small town nearby from
the looks of it he pointed toward the
nearby sign and the other two men sighed
with relief civilization somewhere they
could get cleaned up get a bite to eat
and apologetically call for backup nice
agent Adams grin Paul you're from this
part of the country you know this town
Dairy agent Paul shook his head nope
never even heard of it agent Adams
Shrugged and he agent Paul and the pilot
slowly made their way into the
unassuming little town of Derry Maine it
was lovely idyllic even such a picture
of small town Bliss that they didn't
even notice just how many missing
posters were stapled to the telephone
poles the wide eyes of Lost Children
seeming to watch them as they passed
meanwhile on the other side of town in
the middle of the marshy Barons where so
many children had gone missing that
summer and the summer 27 years before it
a figure was climbing out of the
smoldering wreckage of the helicopter it
was big
furry with massive Paws and that silly
metal helmet on top of its head
scp-2006 had survived and was taking its
first free steps in decades it looked
around at the Wilderness the trees the
Rocks the running water and the entrance
to the town's sewers it barely
understood any of what it was seeing but
it knew that it was in a brand new place
one that would hopefully be filled with
brand new people to scare oh how
exciting to think about seeing new faces
eyes wide with Dread mouths open and
screams the creature was in its favorite
most fearsome form too the mighty and
terrible Roman from the 1953 classic
robot monster none could behold this
shape without collapsing in Terror
scp-2006 clapped its hands together
delightedly laughing to itself it had
been nervous when the helicopter started
to fall out of the sky but now it seemed
that this was the best thing that could
have possibly happened with no one in
the immediate vicinity to frighten 2006
decided to wander off through the woods
in search of fresh victims after all now
that it was free from that awful box
there was plenty of time to look and an
endless amount of scares to be given the
creature ambled down the road passed a
public park a vintage Diner and rows and
rows of little houses a woman passed
walking her dog
scp-2006 roared at her expanding its
arms wide and standing up on its tiptoe
to appear as large as possible fear me
for I am Roman that's nice dear the lady
passively remarked stopping to let her
dog sniff 2006 his leg it lifted its own
leg and urinated on the creature's fur
how dare you I am monstrous Quake with
fear 2006 bellowed but the lady only
chuckled shook her head and continued on
her way puzzled the creature continued
to walk along the road looking for more
victims to terrorize and strike fear
into their fragile Hearts I Papa had a
group of little children playing with a
soccer ball perfect 2006 crouched low to
the ground and snuck up on the group
hiding behind a bush before popping out
with a wild yell drumbo before the
mighty Roman it shouted one child
screamed startled but his friends
immediately began to tease him come down
you big baby it's just a guy in a suit
one of his friends thumped him with a
soccer ball another boy who was eating a
cherry popsicle laughed loudly at the
side of the entity nice costume loser he
blew a raspberry and threw the popsicle
at 2006's head sugary Frozen slurry
dripping down its fur why aren't you
afraid
scp-2006 demanded unable to grasp how it
lost its scaring abilities so quickly
perhaps something had gone wrong during
the crash or perhaps this town was just
filled with unusually brave people
whatever it was 2006 wanted to figure
out the answer and fast after all who
was as CP 2006 if it wasn't scary
because we're not scared of some nerd in
a Chewbacca suit barf bag the kid with
the soccer ball threw it at 2006 who
caught it its claws puncturing the ball
and flattening it hey this doofus broke
our ball kick his butt it is you who
should be concerned with your butts
scp-2006 retorted changing its face to
the shape of a werewolf from a classic
black and white film it buried its teeth
rubbery tongue Walling out of its mouth
glassy eyes staring in two different
directions whoa how'd you do that the
angry boy lowered his fists escaping in
awe never mind that was kind of cool
bummer about the ball though the first
boy side fed up with all this confusion
scp-2006 dropped the deflated ball to
the ground then promptly turned and
walked in the opposite direction Hey
where's he going the kid demanded but
the anomaly did not respond one boy
began bragging about his new collection
of baseball cards and their attention
was soon pulled away from the strange
being that they believed to be a person
in a monster costume then as scp-2006
walked it heard the sound it had been
waiting to hear all day screams glorious
screams of absolute Terror the purest
sound of fear it sounded like a child
shrieking at the top of their lungs in
the face of something truly horrifying
where could that wonderful noise be
coming from and why hadn't scp-2006 been
the one to inspire it the anomaly was
desperate to get to the bottom of things
it followed the sound searching for its
source but just as the sound grew louder
and the creature got closer it cut off
all of a sudden as if swallowed up by
something all encompassing hello
scp-2006 called out in vain where did
you go come back so that I can scare you
please but I am Roman hi there Roman a
voice piped up from behind the entity it
spun around looking for whoever just
spoke hello who is it
scp-2006 could not see anyone only the
Suburban Street the houses the empty
yards down here the voice called This
Way the voice was coming from a storm
drain down in the darkness below
scp-2006 could barely make out a pair of
eyes a white painted face a red nose and
a pair of bright red lips boo scp-2006
shouted at the person in the storm drain
it burst into a fit of giggles
good what your name the clown asked I am
Roman the Mighty the Fearsome
scp-2006 replied nice to meet you I'm
Pennywise the Dancing Clown the clown
grinned showing a mouth full of sharp
teeth come a little closer why don't you
maybe we could be friends
scp-2006 was perplexed but approached
just the same the clown took a deep
breath catching a whiff of the entity's
unfamiliar scent and it frowned what are
you Pennywise asked the friendly
affection gone from his voice and face
you don't smell right to me not like
anything I've ever smelled I told you
are you scared 2006 replied Pennywise
laughed at this a wild unhinged cackle
[Laughter]
are you scared the clown stared at 2006.
its wide orange eyes glinting in the
light of course not I'm much scarier
than you are you're funny
you're funny the clown exclaimed very
funny why don't you come down here with
me want to float we all do down here I'm
not funny
scp-2006 pounded I'm scary sure
whatever you say the clown waved the
words away don't you want to come over
here we could be friends consciously the
anomaly approached the storm drain
leaning down to get a better look at the
strange clown suddenly the Clown's hand
shot out grabbed hold of scp-2006's arm
the Clown's mouth stretched open wide
revealing Rose upon rows of teeth and a
seemingly impossible stretch of Darkness
inside of its jaws Pennywise bit down on
the anomaly's arm pulling it into the
storm drain trying to swallow it whole
like a snake swallows its prey but as it
tried to devour scp-2006 it began to
choke its body rejecting The Entity it
had spat the furry anomaly back out
scp-2006 landed in the water inside of
the sewer with a wet plop as Pennywise
rubbed at its jaw thoughtfully
you really are strange the clown frowned
I told you before I'm scary I'm scary
scp-2006 insisted sure you are Pennywise
grimaced is that the shape you use to
scare people
scp-2006 nodded among others this is my
most successful though Pennywise shook
its head I know a thing or two about
fear it's what I use to season my need
fear is what I do and you though you've
got a lot to learn about fear would you
show me how to be more scary
scp-2006 asked Pennywise laughed again a
hacking coughing sound
you know what I will the more frightened
children in this town the better as long
as you understand this is my turf
scp-2006 nodded furiously I I understand
Pennywise beckoned The Entity over and
motioned for it to sit down
fear is personal everyone is afraid of
something different and there is a
unique way to tap into each person's
deepest fears normally I look like this
like Pennywise the Dancing Clown clowns
are funny children like clowns but
they're also terrified of clowns
Pennywise did a little jig laughing
wildly
it makes them taste so sweet when they
meet me like this and think I'm a friend
and then I show them what I truly am the
clown bared its teeth humans aren't
scared of clowns
scp-2006 shook its head in my experience
they only think clowns are funny they
laugh at them now this is scary
scp-2006 concentrated and changed its
shape it was a giant rabbit from the
film night of the lepus this strikes
Terror into their hearts now it does
Pennywise rolled its eyes listen to me
suppose a child has a fear of birds
maybe he watched a movie about a giant
pterodactyl maybe he was attacked by a
bird as a baby maybe it was both you
could try something like this Pennywise
shifted forms then changing from a clown
to a giant bird with sharp talons a
massive wingspan a pointed beak and wild
eyes or say the child is afraid to cross
a stream because he's afraid of piranhas
the shape of Pennywise changed again as
piranhas plopped into the water below
swimming around in a ravenous swarm so
being scary is about animals
scp-2006 cocked its head to the side
confused Pennywise resumed its clown
form growing increasingly frustrated no
it's it's about a person's darkest
thoughts the images that come to them
while they lie in bed and struggle to
fall asleep say there's a little boy who
lives in fear of sickness his mother
planted the fear in his head you see all
day long he imagines little bacteria
crawling across his skin infections
waiting to slip inside and rot him from
the inside out to him I would look like
this Pennywise changed into the shape of
a leper a man covered with sores and
limbs about to drop off with a hacking
diseased cough then it was a Clown again
or say there's a girl who fears one
person more than anyone else in the
whole world her father a man who was
once kind to her maybe but lost anger
and drink have turned him wrong made
anger curdled into violence inside his
heart to her I would only need to look
like him to say all the things she's
afraid he thinks Pennywise looked at SCP
2006 do you understand now I think so oh
the anomaly chirped so I should try
something like this it transformed into
something large smooth and slimy it was
one of the frogs from the 1972 film
frogs this will bring any person to
their knees with fright
oh Pennywise bellowed no no no no no no
no no no you don't get it so many things
are scary spiders being abandoned by
your friends be God love being buried
alive a man with no head a missing
poster for someone who isn't missing it
but you you're not scary you're not
scary at all
scp-2006 huffed even when I do this it
turned into the shape of a fluffy alien
with glowing red eyes and decidedly fake
looking paper mache arms Pennywise the
Dancing Clown sat down on the ground
resting his head in his hands with a
long exhausted sigh
listen kid I thought this would be fun
but I'm so tired you're not scary I
can't eat you what am I supposed to do
with you I've got a good thing going
here and I have for a very very long
time you being here it's messing things
up just get out of my town you're
embarrassing me go on get out of dairy
find some other talented scare this
one's full well you didn't have to be so
rude about it
scp-2006 huffed but it listened just the
same it left Derry Maine behind walking
off down the open road just in time for
an unmarked van from the SCP Foundation
to pull up beside it and open the door
Romance
called out agent Paul you're very
frightening and we almost didn't stop
because you frightened us so much but do
you need a ride in exchange for
promising not to tear us apart with your
Mighty claws of course will you take me
to more people I can scare 2006 asked
agent Paul hit his smile and beckoned
the creature inside
you got it buddy hey folks welcome to
another SCP explained Community
questions episode today we're answering
all your burning concerns about the
multiverses most monstrous Monarch the
Scarlet King you may remember the
episode where scp-343 was kind enough to
come chat with us directly about his
queries but thankfully the Scarlet King
hasn't been quite so Hands-On
it is
your future ruler in blood pain and
Terror the howling horror the Crimson
Khan the Scarlet King himself before I
tear down the walls of your universe and
Destroy every last one of you I will
first take the time to address your
idiotic questions so that your hope may
be thoroughly crushed before I crush
your world to match
said question even though you have taken
out literally Gods from your universe
and you ruled some of them how do you
feel to know that you have new Gods to
pray and possibly worry about in the SCP
Foundation
do you think you use your worthless Gods
hope any surprises
I was slaughtering Gods by the millions
before your universe's Inception by the
time your worthless for marriage was
slithering from the primordial suit I
have conquered and subjugated greater
pantheons of outer Gods than your minds
can even
the Scarlet King worries about nothing
the worthless Ricardo anguiano said
question what do you think about the
other anomalous GOI such as the
Serpent's head or the chaos Insurgency
what does the book think of ads it's
crushing those pathetic bookworms are
acolytes of knowledge that will become
meaningless under my mood I will
incinerate the library and toast skew it
serpents on its heat and this so-called
chaos Insurgency don't make me laugh
they wouldn't know true chaos if they
tour their world as somewhere beneath
them the feeble
that's good who said ah yes Mr King is
it Scarlet King to you I have but a
simple question what other scps do you
enjoy and you had to name another SCP as
a close friend who or what would that be
enjoy the only things I enjoy are pain
suffering subjugation and desolation I
suppose the ones I despise the leads
comparatively are those that seek to
further my own goals are turning the
universe back to its true state of
violence I'll destroy them last the
quivering jet Ender said I would keep it
simple but useful can 682 be destroyed
permanently not necessarily any
information about how just getting the
answer directly from 682's supposed
father of whether it's even worth the
trouble to keep trying to terminate that
dang lizard the only thing that can
destroy anything and everything is me no
exceptions but I wouldn't destroy a
downtaking opinion until he has outlived
his usefulness everything
will end but it will only end when I see
fit speaking of which the inadequate
Eris Skyler said question if you hate
all of existence so much why not get rid
of your children like they're
technically part of existence so how
come you hate existence but make
existence your children I don't like
repeating myself human as I said before
everything has its time for the time
being my daughters are still of use to
me I will not destroy them until they
have played their part in my
seed next question the unspeakably weak
Ross Albatross said I present them with
a query have you ever considered wearing
something other than red with the dark
colored horns on top you're definitely
more of a Wimbledon Than a Summer also
if your skin is inflamed with rosacea
have a really good serum for that next
thing you know the Scarlet King changes
his name to Gold King and forces
everyone in the world to wear only
complementary colors that fit our own
complexion and hair color my armor may
be another color than red when you learn
to bring rainbows I will not be changing
my name again I've done that enough for
one Eternal lifetime already
seems to have stuck the moronic Xavier
Valencia said question when did this
hatred for existence begin like did
something happen to you or have you
always had it my hatred for existence
began when I began to exist what a
secret
of this will they live to die regardless
of the blink of existence in between I'm
merely hurrying a natural process along
to its logical conclusion
during Mr underscore
man said I would just ask him how his
day's been if he's going through
something and needs someone to lighten
his mood you know the usual killing you
and your entire family horribly would
lighten my mood Muffin Man any pathetic
attempts to console me will only
increase my rage the insulin Adam arafah
said I have a question how come you
couldn't get to earth when you destroyed
powerful gods and big planets without
even having to use your full power you
dare question my power artha being shut
out of your worthless Dimension is only
a temporary affliction
before you know it the walls that will
keep you safe will crack and crumble the
last thing you'll ever see is my bread
Army spotting out the sky ready to tell
every last one of you to shreds
then you will know my true power a
buffoon known as the sauce
ourselves The Source said I would simply
ask him the question everyone has on
their mind how much wood would a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could
chuck wood and I await his answer that
was a terrible question and I hate you
when a Scarlet sun rises over your world
I will ensure that your death is
especially painful for this
especially given how stupid your name is
an insect named Denzel Brown said the
first question you usually have to ask a
being like this is in your Rampage
across the Multiverse have you ever
encountered another version of yourself
or one comparable in terms of power or
presence in so what happened can more
than one version
same space
there is only one Scarlet King I am an
immutable being a fixed point I have
never had an equal in all the desolate
claims of the universes I'd rendered
into Atomic fragments
this this is my power this is my Unity I
will bring the Multiverse together in a
quiet Rift of Oblivion next question a
worm named
rip said I would ask him who do you
consider the greatest clutch to your
goal there are no threats to Michael
only bumps in the road there is no
threat there is nothing that will stop
me from fulfilling my destiny and get
out of you next question next question
um the misguided Archbishop said
question have you ever faced a foe
that's giving you a good challenge if so
how did you manage to beat them many of
the Gods I once faced when I was a
wicked being gave me the closest battles
I've had in trillions of years
thankfully after defeating them I
feasted our left flesh making me even
stronger a weakling named night Fane
said question do you meet with Bride for
poker every Tuesday or Wednesday because
let's face it dude has to be one of your
best friends or your worst enemies you
are a fool to think a new human could
ever be a lie level with or without some
garish piece of magical jewelry in his
last moments this Dr rightful fake name
as I rip that Medallion from his stolen
neck and crush it in my music
of peasants named static production said
I will ask him what does he gain of
destroying the Earth is it really his
goal or is he trying to impress someone
I would also ask does he like pineapple
on Pizza I will gain peace silence
blessed emptiness in the destruction of
all things I will look across a quiet
Multiverse angry a sigh of immense
relief and my favorite pizza topping is
falling Warriors sliced very thin the
Mindless wind General said I'd ask him
if he knows anything about other
multiverses aside from the SCP multiness
like Star Wars
Halo HP Lovecraft Creepypasta
Etc if he does what does he know about
them I have been there and destroyed
them all already
Darth Vader I felt in a single blow as
he begged for mercy Gandalf I burn until
not even Ashes Remain the so-called
Master Chief I cast into an endless
black hole azathon was torn apart by my
minions I personally killed Jeff the
Killer you an extra Flame
next Supreme spider who are you kidding
here only I am truly Supreme said I
would ask him if in a hypothetical
situation he managed to reach his goal
of annihilating everything what would he
do after laugh next question the
platinous made this song said question
what is existing for you in particular
do you have a body capable of feeling
things like touch or smell are you just
a conscience gimbal to be manifested or
something so alien that can be explained
with our language I am able to exist as
a fixed point in time space while also
operating as a defuse Consciousness
across the scope of the Multiverse
existing at various degrees of strength
and influence the
the operations of my acolytes on Earth I
can only sense feelings and Impressions
until the gate is opened and rest
assured it will be opened for me the
machine loving bromial Maniac what a
dumb name said what are your thoughts on
the Audubon and McCain considering they
created what one of the things you hate
the most I am quite curious about your
thoughts on them mere Pretenders to the
Scarlet throne their Petty squabbles of
the fate of something as inconsequential
as an inhuman race is simply
embarrassing if Megan thinks he's the
broken God now
oh just wait until I get my claws on him
a nerd named Dr Veronica said if you
were forced to fight King Crimson from
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure who would win
in that battle between King Crimson vs
Crimson King devolo says that he's the
king of kings after all so the two of
you would seemingly be modern enemies
this means nothing to me you should
spend less time reading your picture
books and what I'm preparing for me to
preach or to mention and destroy all of
you a foolhardy mortal named green
question how do you feel about being
looked down upon as an end I wouldn't
know it's never happened to me how does
it make you feel insane a bootlegger
named James Rogers said I would ask him
if he was hiring since I know every
single SCP and everything about the o5
council I'm sure I could be of
assistance to him you can assist me in
sabotaging The Works of the SCP
Foundation who are slightly more
irritating than your average humans they
've been awareness of me and my plans
and thus they must be eliminated in
order to prevent any barriers to my
plans in exchange for your loyalty I'll
kill you quickly and personally and you
will have the honor of dying at my hands
the meaningless collection of letters
m-t-t-n-y-n said question what is your
favorite beverage to enjoy after a day
of Destruction and Mayhem The Blood and
Tears of my enemies of course next
question the appropriately named cake
Masters said I'd ask him what's the deal
with airline food humans survive for an
incredibly brief period of time every
time I blink another several thousand of
you will fizzle out of existence soon to
be forgotten another faceless Soul
immigration none of you will live long
enough to have any meaningful impact on
your world other than sucking up
resources and creating a mess in your
final years unless you die young or
violently you will feel your body and
mind starting to fail little by little
your faculties will you you will break
down you will exit this world just as
afraid and feeble and infantile as you
enter it and after it an eternity of
nothing awaits
instruct yourself from this immutable
and inevitable Reality by instead
focusing on details as trivial as the
poor taste of food on airplanes the
Godless Jason Gutman said I would ask
him if he reads High fantasy and science
fiction to get inspiration for his
conquests no authors of your feeble
fiction get faint impressions of my dark
conquests in the forms of nightmares
they cannot understand or shape when
they awaken they make these Impressions
into their work in hopes of exercising
them so your high fantasy and science
fiction get their inspiration from me
not
the way around the blabbering Olivia
Mueller said dear Scarlet King have you
ever considered taking a break from
planning the end of all living beings to
try and engage in some artistic
recreational activities there's coloring
in painting pitching a play creating
sculptures building Lego and creating
film media if you ever consider doing
one of these activities which would you
Olivia you misunderstand me I already
have a number of creative Pursuits I
create fear in my countless victims I
assemble armies from the rattles of
sadistic demons and incomprehensible
entities
I create dark schemes for the conquest
of the Multiverse each with intricate
and masterful details and if destruction
is also a form of creation then nobody
is not creative than me the disgustingly
dull April mulling said I've thought
long and hard about this and what I'd
like to ask is as follows what kind of
feline companion does one have knowing
that all cats are basically bent on
world domination it behooves oneself to
align with said company I have no feline
compared
enter your Universe I will destroy you
and your cat next question the Godless
difference why T said question how often
do you wash your body I wash my body in
the blood of my enemies every time I
battle which is extremely often the
grossly sentimental dial Garcia said my
question would be are you bored
hearing the Lamentations of their women
and then crushing their women too
be lonely on the other hand is my
intention I despise having to spend time
around any other living beings and no I
don't want to chat platypus King said do
you like platypuses
King the perverse coffee addict said my
learning question would have to be are
you single winky face
no I did have a wife once but I crushed
her to death and used her blood to paint
my armor since then I've taken my Seven
Daughters as my bride TLC has been in
touch about licensing a reality show but
I destroyed every representative they
have sent into my kingdom the sniveling
Emerald Inferno zero said I would ask
him if there was a possibility to turn
me into basically a less powerful but
still pretty powerful version of him I
can turn you into a steaming pile of Ash
that's my best offer crimson gorgetter
said I would ask him why he thinks
destroying the Multiverse would stop the
pain he has suffered because if he does
he will be completely and truly alone
forever suffering the isolation for all
eternity and that is exactly how I like
it when I have destroyed everything else
in destroying myself the universe will
then finally be silent but worry not
there will be plenty of time for
violence howling and bloody conquests
before then the hopelessly naive Mass TV
said has he ever considered becoming a
superhero but on a cable cow save people
from a few lateral disasters and get the
love and admiration of an entire world I
have no interest in saving people I
don't want the love and admiration I
their screens their blood no hero will
save them the defeatist Vixen lady said
I tell him that destroying all human
life is the right thing to do I'm glad
to hear you approve of my mission As a
treat I'll destroy you first when I get
into your dimension the Scarlet Sayer
said I'd ask him what are your thoughts
on anime waifus do demonic beings appeal
to you or are we nothing more than rough
snaps trying to present ourselves as we
were one like you you should feel
embarrassed for even asking this Scarlet
Sayer also change your name if you
infringe on me anymore you'll hear from
my bloodthirsty interdimensional lawyers
and if you think I'm cruel you have no
idea
lonely guy said have you ever considered
anger management classes I did join an
anger management group once but I had
them all liquidated for being insolent
in the end
truly
Johnny the gamer said my question is
simple why destroy existence and Conquer
Gods when you can just binge every
conceivable TV show or anime ever seeing
how you're Immortal and such you
suddenly have the time
because having an eternal life is still
having a life Johnny and I have better
things to do than waste my time on
binging your worthless television shows
and MMA when I eventually destroy you it
will be a mercy I am looking forward to
the last season of Better Call Saul
though the not at all foxy foxy TV say
everybody asks who's the Scarlet King
what's the Scarlet game I wanna know how
is the Scarlet King he is furious after
answering all of these moronic questions
my existence is eternal and this still
feels like a profound waste of my time
everyone who took part of this I hope
you know you're online list and when my
terrible armies Reach This Dimension
rest assured they'll be coming after you
first hello again SCP fans we've once
again sparked up the animatron 6000 our
state-of-the-art supercomputer that
takes countless data streams from the
SCP foundation's various anomalies and
allows us to simulate potential
scenarios that could never normally
occur for example what if Boba Fett one
of Fiction's most iconic Galactic bounty
hunters took out the sarkic Menace that
is the flesh that hates well let's press
the button and find out a long time ago
in a barely explored corner of a galaxy
far far away the rhythmic blink of
bright red emergency lights brought the
hunter back to Consciousness beneath the
tinted visor of his helmet his vision
was still blurry from the blow he had
taken to the head as his ship had jolted
to a stop blinking away the haze
clouding his eyesight he focused on the
light still flashing up at him from the
console in front of the seat he was
strapped into wait was he he lifted a
gloved hand to double check still secure
buckled in time finally able to see
again the Bounty Hunter turned to the
console checking the readouts on the
circular screens of a ship's cockpit it
didn't take running a quick diagnostic
for him to realize his predicament as
durable and heavily armored as his
trusty fire spray was the vessel had
taken a pretty nasty hit he knew he was
taking a risk flying through an area of
space controlled by the infamous Crimson
Dawn the crime syndicate maintained a
fragile alliance with the Hunter's
slothful slug-like employer but after
spotting his ship trying to pass through
their territory undetected they had
retaliated sending a squad of ships
after the fire spray and outmaneuvering
them hadn't been easy especially the
smaller single person finders that could
zip around at much faster speeds than
the Hunter's heavy gunship but The
Syndicate had used its Fighters as
merely a distraction drawing his
attention away from the larger attack
ship drawing in from the rear receiving
a full blast from an ion cannon was bad
enough the energy bolt had struck the
hunter ship serving a direct tit that
slowed his vessel down to a crawl albeit
still intact for now ion blasts weren't
designed to cause lasting damage to a
ship only to disrupt all electronic
systems on board from his cockpit the
Bounty Hunter knew exactly why his
adversaries had done this they wanted to
capture him alive and possibly take his
fire spray too he wasn't about to let
that happen the ship had been passed
down to him by his father along with the
armor he now wore that made him
instantly recognizable as one of the
most feared hunters in the Galaxy but
having his ship rendered without
navigation systems or control over the
engines meant he couldn't steer it clear
of the path of an oncoming Fighter the
smaller ship moved to Swerve out of the
way only too late it clipped the fire
spray's Wing causing the hunter to Lurch
forward and hit his head as his ship
spun out of control drifting away Lost
in Space by the time he came back around
he found himself adrift in an unfamiliar
Uncharted corner of of the Galaxy his
ship was still badly damaged running on
a reserve of emergency power that was
quickly depleting the hunter fumbled
with the controls taking a look at the
star map on his display he didn't
recognize this quadrant or even the
system he was in there was one planet
looming ahead a green and blue world
with a single neighboring Moon it was
then the hunter recognized what the red
light had been warning him about in its
damaged State the fire spray had been
caught in the planet's gravitational
pull and was now hurtling towards the
surface holding on tight bracing himself
for impact Boba Fett prepared for a
particularly bumpy Landing the entire
ship buckled as it passed through the
planet's upper atmosphere the metalwork
creaking as scraps were torn away from
the outer Hull by extreme g-forces Boba
yanked at the steering columns barely
able to change the course of his ship's
descent the power was still minimal
after the ion attack practically Running
on Fumes looking out of the large front
viewport vet could see streaks of heat
as his fire spray plummeted to the
surface he had an idea a risky move but
it just might work if it didn't then his
storied career as the Galaxy's most
infamous Bounty Hunter might just come
to an unremarkable anti-climactic ending
pulling up the controls he repositioned
the ship's remaining fin-like Wing the
ones still mostly operational and angled
the fire spray so that its rear boosters
were facing towards the planet its
internal gyro system keeping him set
upright still tumbling straight down now
in landing position all Boba could do
was hold tight and pray prayers that
were answered when the console lit up
with an alert the heat of the re-entry
had jump started the engines reigniting
the gunship's propulsion system not
enough for sustained flight but adequate
to allow the hunter to control his
descent and lessen the impact of the
rough Landing the fire spray came to a
crashing halt in the snow still mostly
intact but too badly damaged to take off
clambering his way out Boba Fett
examined the wreckage of his ship it had
been in far worse scraps over the years
but every time the fire spray sustained
damage he couldn't help but think of
what his father Django would say or his
donor as some would call him given that
bobo was a pure unaltered genetic clone
of his dad turning around he looked out
over the expanse of the Frozen region
he'd crashed on the Wind carried with it
an icy bite that was only shielded from
it by the insulated flight suit he wore
under his green painted plates of this
car's steel armor he lowered the antenna
on his Mandalorian helmet using its
viewfinder to survey The Horizon
instantly his eyes spotted a sign a warm
sheet of metal half buried in the snow
there was something off about this sign
though that instantly told Boba he
wasn't on Hoth illum Ortho plutonia or
any other ice Planet he knew of he
trudged closer to the sign crossing the
frozen tundra alone the cape over his
shoulder whipping in the freezing cold
Gale where there was a sign there could
easily be civilization maybe even
somewhere fat could get parts to fix his
inherited ship he forced himself not to
stop and examine the sign but couldn't
help glancing at it as he passed Boba
couldn't recognize the lettering written
on it at all not the characters that had
printed on the medal nor the word
painted over it in red at first he
thought it might be aubreish but the
closer he got he realized it was a
language he didn't understand continuing
on past it Boba tried to put thought of
the sign out of his head unaware that it
read Lake Baikal Siberia and that
someone had painted the Russian word for
run over it it didn't take long for Boba
to reach the civilization that he was
looking for or what was left of it
anyway the small fishing Town reminded
him a little of the city of mosespa back
on Tatooine although it looked to have
been abandoned for quite some time the
rickety buildings were all constructed
out of wooden planks with a thick
coating of frost over almost every
surface as Boba marched further in a
gunslinger walking into a frozen ghost
town there was almost total silence the
cold winds had died down to barely a
whisper now the stranded Bounty Hunter
looked around finding no signs of
anything nearby no Spaceport no dramas
he could trade with no townsfolk to ask
for directions no signs of life
something moved behind him causing Boba
to instinctively whip around to face it
producing his ee3 carbine Blaster with a
draw speed rivaled by a few of the
fastest hands in the Galaxy his weapon
was trained on nothing whatever had
caused the sound was nowhere to be seen
keeping his gun up and at the ready in
one hand Boba reached for a button on
one of his gauntlets within his helmet
the Pure White of the snow blinked away
replaced by a blue filter providing him
with a heads-up display that highlighted
any nearby heat signatures there was a
trail on the ground just a few feet from
him not tracks my view just a single
streak of warmth left carved through the
snow cautiously Boba followed it the
trail curved around a nearby Shack and
then disappeared through a hole that had
been punched through one of its walls
the wooden planks it was built from were
all splintered outwards as if something
large had burst out of it inside the
shack had been coated in enough Frost to
freeze everything solid cups and plates
at the dinner table look like they'd
been encased in carbonite looking around
the dark abandoned interior Boba barely
noticed something slithering down
towards him from the ceiling a windy
fleshy appendage whipped around boba's
arm locking it tightly in place he
pulled against it with all his strength
but the Bounty Hunter couldn't free his
hand or the Blaster he was holding
turning to see his attacker through the
boards of the Upper Floor Fett could
make out a writhing massive Shadow
attached to the long grotesque appendage
that now had him in an arm lock in all
his years of bounty hunting he'd never
seen a species like it whatever it was
his baskar and flight suit were
protecting it from feeling its
disgusting slimy grip against his skin
although he wasn't too keen on being
held by this monster for much longer
with his free hand Boba tried to wrench
the tentacle off of him only to feel it
snaking further and Tighter around his
arm bending it in the opposite direction
his elbow was meant to bend Boba grunted
stifling a scream under his helmet as he
felt his arm on the verge of snapping
but the pain brought back reminders of
his lessons his training under his
various mentors his father or even old
Bane even with his Blaster arm ensnared
a good Bounty Hunter was never unarmed
knocking The Gauntlet on his free arm
against his leg to activate it he lifted
his fist upwards as a streak of flame
erupted from the Mandalorian boundaries
setting fire to the wooden floor above
and the culture which shrieked in pain
as it cut a light relinquishing its grip
Thinking Fast and moving at a speed to
match Boba loot out of the way as if the
huge monster Came Crashing through the
burning wood planks had he not rolled to
a safe distance just in time than it
would have landed on him crushing the
Bounty Hunter under its weight back on
his feet Boba spun on his heel and
opened fire with his now freed Blaster
each blast of the red laser light
Illuminating the horrific sight of what
had attacked him it was a mass of Flesh
distorted
appeared like a bloated coagulated wound
for their form it might once have been a
person but now extra legs had sprouted
beneath it arms having melted into slimy
blood red tentacles that were flailing
in pain as the creature tried to douse
the fire Boba backed out of the Shack's
front entrance still firing his carbine
Blaster its bolts were having little
effect on the fleshy inhuman monster
seeming to only cause it irritation
rather than leaving lasting damage but
as the infamous Hunter moved his foot
behind him a wooden porch step snapped
beneath causing him to topple over
landing on his back in the snow his
Blaster had fallen from his hands as he
came crashing down forcing him to roll
over and reach for it
when he saw the others emerging from the
abandoned rural town a group of
nightmarish Abominations were slithering
out of nearby Shacks they shambled
towards Boba each one of them looking
different from the next but no less
stomach churning in their fleshy
blood-soaked appearances some were
bipedal walking on the remnants of two
legs but with their entire upper body
fused into a single monstrous Mass
others look like they had once been
small animals but had been cruelly and
unnaturally Twisted into amorphous slimy
mutations of their former selves the
horde of beings a veritable Smorgasbord
of Flesh that hates were crawling
towards Boba he had spent the earliest
parts of his childhood surrounded by
cloners on kamino alien experts in
genetics since then he'd been all over
the Galaxy and met people of all
different species it wasn't hard for
Boba to see what these things these
monsters were they were the townsfolk
that once lived in the snow third place
or at least they used to be people now
they were horrific from behind him the
first creature the one that had drawn
him out re-emerged still enraged but as
he turned to look at it making sure he
was aware of all threats surrounding him
Boba spotted its skin the part where he
had singed with his flamethrower were
still severely burned practically
reduced to a cinder fire that could hurt
them reaching into the ground to
retrieve and Stow his Blaster Boba felt
something tugging at the weapon pulling
it in the opposite direction another of
the fleshy monsters a crawling
spider-like collection of arms and legs
with no body or head had flung an
appendage outwards and grabbed the
carbine trying to pull it back Boba
slipped in the snow and was being
dragged towards the writhing monstrosity
a loud bang echoed around the nearby
Town punctuated by a bright red light
soaring through the sky and gently
floating back down towards the ground
the white hot flare filled the area with
a glow the creatures all momentarily
turning their attention
sensing its heat that Split Second was
his one chance all of boba's instincts
every lesson Django had taught him told
him to strike first if he wanted to make
a way alive he dropped the Blaster
leaving it in the creature's grip he had
spares back on the fire spray but they'd
be no good to him if he was dead hitting
one of the tiny switches on his van
brace two scorching hot flames spat from
the exhaust of boba's jet pack
immediately he was lifted up off the
ground hovering just above the roofs of
the small wooden structures around him
in that same microsecond the
Abominations of Flesh turned their
Collective attention back to their
Airborne prey the ones that still had
heads or had grown extra disfigured and
misshapen growths in the place of a head
looked up at Boba to them he was merely
another vessel for them to infect with
the same disease that plagued them but
little did any of them know he was the
Boba Fett the Galaxy's deadliest most
famous baskar clad Bounty Hunter and a
good Bounty Hunter was never unarmed
igniting in an instant the flickering
nozzle end of boba's wrist mounted
flamethrower began spraying superheated
fuel over the horde of monstrosities
below long tongues of orange flame
engulfed the writhing slithering
creatures burning them to a crisp as
Boba Fett reigned unrelenting hell down
on the flesh that hates hovering above
them he had given himself enough High
Ground to gain an advantage ironically
the distance Boba had put between
himself and the Monsters wasn't
dissimilar to the Detachment he had for
those he had killed or captured for
Jabba the Hutt in the past they had all
been people too just like these Twisted
masses of Flesh had once been human
putting those thoughts down like he'd
been taught to boba's attention was
focused on blasting any of the fleeing
creatures burning them with enough
intensity to leave little behind a
charred remains except he had forgotten
in his haste to check behind him the
monster that at first attacked him was
making quick work of scaling the new
single story Shack and flailed one of
its appendages at Boba it caught him in
mid-air plucking him out of the sky and
wrenching him back down to the snowy
ground once more winded Boba was
grasping to catch his breath underneath
his helmet he certainly didn't need to
look to know his jet pack had most
likely been damaged by his fall but that
was currently the least of his worries
towering above looming over him the
repulsive monster looked like it was
rearing up to pounds Boba reached to
relight his flamethrower only for his
Gauntlet to spark it had taken a hit on
the way down too desperation set in he
lifted his knee and fired two darts from
the micro cannons mounted on his yellow
knee pads the spiked darts became
embedded in the fleshy creature's Mass
barely phasing it loading a wrist rocket
Bobo raised his other vambrays to fire
only for the arm he wore on it to be
grabbed by one of the other creatures
still burning half alive meanwhile the
one on the roof looked ready to LEAP it
sprung into the air ready to come
crashing down to kill the feared former
Bounty Hunter a bright light first from
somewhere nearby it wasn't another flare
this one was a blinding eruption of pure
white even through the tinted t-shaped
visor of his helmet it stung boba's eyes
so much that he had to cover his face
with his hand as he peered back he
almost mistook the light gray of the sky
for the same light looking around the
monster had vanished those that were
left still writhing their amorphous
bodies coated with fire which rapidly
spread to the wood of the nearby houses
keeping his guard up as he always did
Boba climbed to his feet lifting The
Gauntlet with a miniature Blaster
mounted on it to defend himself he'd
seen and even used disintegration
weapons in the past but the Bounty
Hunter had never known anything to make
a creature like that monster completely
vanish in a single flash he turned at a
sound not one of the creatures or the
gentle crackling of flames but the
gentle crunch of snow under someone's
foot three strangers walked slowly up to
Boba not one among them flinching when
he lit van brace standing his ground
their clothing was Patchwork cobbled
together from scraps but looks similar
to the same cloaks worn by the Jedi of
old as the group approached him the
Bounty Hunter noticed their bodies had
also been altered although not in the
same way as the vile fleshy creatures
that now littered the snow around him
metalwork mechanized components and
devices of all manner protruded from
their uncovered arms and necks pieces of
Machinery embedded in their skulls in
place of their eyes Boba was no stranger
to cyborgs those who had modified their
own bodies with technological
augmentations and modifications one of
the three was missing an entire hand in
its place with what looked like some
kind of Cannon still warm from having
just fired the cloaked mechanized Trio
looked at fet with curiosity as if they
were examining no admiring his armor
just like his damaged ship boba's armor
belonged to his father and if these
three wanted to take it they'd have to
kill him for it I take it that was your
clear that distracted them he growled
beneath his helmet the frontmost of the
group nodded bowing his head gently
indicating he meant no harm indeed we
saw something a vessel We Believe fall
from the sky not far from here the park
Man part machine replied was that your
craft Warrior lowering his arm at last
Boba nodded in response don't suppose
you know where I can get my ship fixed
the hunter asked we may be able to
assist you one of the two interjected
you have Machinery we watched you use it
to fight are you one of us I give my
allegiance to No One Boba stated as he
eyed the speaker he barely looked older
than a teenager who are you people some
have called this mechanites others know
us as the Church of the broken God the
leader spoke up in reply little of that
matters now not since the Flesh of
around this place they split via skin
contact only the parts of our bodies we
have yet to mechanize are still
vulnerable to their infection I
certainly hope none of them touched you
Boba took a look over his shoulder at
the bodies of the still burning
creatures lab that his helmet was
pressurized and his flight suit was on
tight
he muttered to himself I'm fine he
declared with certainty in that case the
lead mechanite said let's see about
fixing your ship shall we the year was
2015. Lewis Joseph and Sydney were like
a lot of kids their age which is to say
11 years old they secretly stay up past
their bedtime watching scary videos on
the internet when their moms and dads
think they're sleeping they go to school
every day and daydream about all the fun
things they're going to do when that
school bell finally rings at the end of
the day and of course they play a lot
and we mean a lot of Minecraft whenever
they're not at school hanging out at the
local park and filming goofy Tick Tock
videos or watching those aforementioned
scary videos on the internet there's a
good chance that they'll be online
together logging a few extra hours
building bases digging big holes or
playing survival mode and seeing how
long they can last against the onslaught
of mobs but there's one particular
Pursuit they have while playing
Minecraft together that takes up the
majority of their Play Time One kihoric
Quest that drives them forward despite
all the naysayers and doubters tracking
down and finding the legendary Minecraft
CreepyPasta entity Herobrine for those
who weren't around on the internet back
then Creepypastas like Herobrine were
all the rage like any video game the new
frontier of Minecraft with all of its
procedurally generated Landscapes felt
like it held new Mysteries and Mysteries
are equal parts exciting and frightening
after all who really knows what's going
on behind a closed door Herobrine was a
Minecraft specific little urban legend
stories told of a default Minecraft skin
with eerily white eyes manifesting in
the game even in Solo matches and
terrorizing players one internet sleuth
who looked into the mystery of Herobrine
claimed it to be the haunted soul of the
Dead Brother of Minecraft's Creator
Marcus person also known as notch in the
years since the legend first started
Notch himself has come forward and
disavowed the claim saying that in fact
he didn't even have a brother and never
had so the rumors were completely
baseless but as we here at the SCP
Foundation know the truth has never
gotten in the way of a good story so
Louis Joseph and Sydney were happy to
remain Believers as long as they could
keep having fun chasing alleged digital
ghosts how could any of these boys know
that in the midst of their fun they'd
run into a real monster amidst
Minecraft's blocky distance it was a
school night like any other when they
made that first fateful Expedition it
was 7 15 pm and the boys were all in
their shared server Lewis had chicken
tenders Joseph had chicken nuggets and
Sydney who'd eaten his dinner earlier
than the others was snacking on a pack
of Skittles they'd all outfit their
characters with full diamond armor with
diamond swords to match because Joseph
had somehow convinced the others that
diamonds were ghost proof he read it on
the internet he claimed together the
three boys had made themselves an
impressive Minecraft castle to be the
base of their Herobrine hunting
operations a safe haven surrounded by
high stone walls and MOB repelling
torches to keep them safe if ever they
got a little too spooked while playing
though playing was perhaps too mild a
word for it in the minds of these three
boys they were doing extremely important
investigative work after all if they
manage to actually find Herobrine
themselves they would be Creepypasta
Legends and wouldn't that be worth all
the hours upon hours of rigorous Mining
and crafting they'd been methodical in
their search scoping out different
corners of the map and canvassing them
together surging high and low and then
marking said area off their checklist it
was a level of consideration and thought
that their parents and teachers had long
wished the boys would put into their
home or school work but alas seeing as
none of the homework was find Herobrine
they really weren't that interested
today they were searching an area deep
in the misty forests in the dead of
night they fought off a few spiders and
sword-wielding skeletons thankfully no
creepers oh man and kept foraging on
into the darkness it's so creepy out
here it was set over his headset why do
we have to come out here at night it was
way more dangerous with all the mobs the
night is like the perfect time for
ghosts Sydney retorted you think a ghost
is gonna start hanging around in the
middle of the day no way it's got to be
a night man and Lewis simply could not
argue with such incredibly Sound Logic
they forged on doing their typical
methodical search for any phenomenon
that one might generously be able to
describe as Supernatural so you can only
imagine the excitement coursing through
them when Joseph discovered a strange
dark cave that looked as though it had
no business being there well leech held
their own private reservations they all
knew what they needed to do go inside
and investigate as they entered the cave
a few strange realizations occurred to
them such as the fact that there were
seemingly no mobs down here the cave in
the dead of night surely there should be
some enemies right plus the typical
lighting implements like torches and
lanterns didn't seem to offer the same
kind of Illumination that they normally
would it was almost like the darkness
was more oppressive here more tangible
there was undeniably something Eerie
about the whole setup that much couldn't
be denied you guys see anything Lewis
asked no Joseph said sounding oddly
cautious as though he sent something
strange was on the horizon something
that perhaps these boys shouldn't see
yeah I haven't seen anything either
Sydney chimed in maybe we should Joseph
screamed and the two others turned their
Minecraft Avatars to look at him
Joseph's character had bumped into
something some stranger cave an NPC
design that looked oddly realistic for
something inhabiting the purposefully
Lo-Fi blocky world of Minecraft it
seemed to have a dark furry body with a
canid skull-like face bearing a pair of
milky white eyes that seemed to stare
off into nothingness was this another
mob maybe something added in the latest
patch if so why wasn't it attacking what
is that thing Lewis asked over his
headset I don't know Joseph replied it's
so creepy though suddenly a message
appeared on the screen as though it had
been typed and sent by another player a
player with the username Mal o the
message read hey that isn't very nice
you shouldn't judge on appearances kid
that certainly gave them pause so many
things about this didn't make sense it
had all the Hallmarks of an NPC but
apparently it understood their voices
and could send messages it clearly
wasn't actually another player in a
conventional
but it didn't attack like your typical
mob none of the boys could really make
sense of what they were dealing with
here are you a hacker Sydney asked no
Malo typed back I'm just lonely and a
long way from home it's nice to have
your company down here though I don't
get visitors often have you heard of
Herobrine Lewis asked mellow typed back
is he a friend of yours you should
introduce him to me I love making new
friends the three boys were in some
regards rather mature and polite for
their ages and so remained civil with
this bizarre mysterious figure it was
curious and inquisitive asking them
questions about their school lives and
their friends it did seem earnestly
happy for their company so it didn't
give any of them the sense that it was a
threat as Knight Drew on in the boy's
respective parents told them it was time
to log off and get some shut eye mellow
finally typed I've really enjoyed
hanging out with you kids come back and
visit me again tomorrow if you don't
I'll come
none of the kids picked up on the
probably rather obvious stranger danger
Vibes of this message and instead they
went to bed excited and curious the next
day they met up on the playground for a
kind of State of the Union on the
strange phenomenon they had encountered
the night before do you think it has
anything to do with Herobrine Lewis
asked forget Herobrine Sydney replied oh
sitting gasp from the two others all the
other people have Herobrine we have
something better something only we've
discovered we've got mallow later that
night Joseph who was probably the most
studious of the group tried to do a
little background research on malho
everything seemed to turn up dead ends
aside from one slightly shitty looking
app called Malo version 1.0.0 it's
description read never settle for those
awkward feelings of being alone ever
again mellow is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but just after a few hours of mallow you
will soon forget all about those painful
emotions of disappointment be part of
the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute remember the
more you participate the more Mao will
engage you your experience is completely
up to you absolutely no ads enjoy weird
so unless the thing they encountered on
Minecraft was some kind of weird viral
marketing campaign for the app it was
probably just a coincidence maybe it was
a popular character from Japan or
something by the way for the next
several days the boys honored their
promise they'd visit Mal o in the cave
every night and chat trying to tactfully
get more information out of it though
the best they could get on the entity's
origin was the cryptic statement I'm not
usually here but everyone wants a
vacation once in a while don't they we
can't just spend our whole life on a
phone they'd become so acclimated to
Malo over the days that they forgot what
the entity had said to them the very
first day they met come back and visit
me again tomorrow
if you don't I'll come visit you instead
but on the day that they didn't come and
visit mellow because Miss Grayson had
sent a particularly challenging piece of
English homework that received a
frightening reminder that very night
they all started receiving strange texts
on their phones as you can probably
expect they were all photographs each
and everyone depicting some regular
haunt that the boys all like to frequent
with one addition Mal O's grinning skull
face hiding somewhere in the image like
some kind of demented parody of where's
Waldo the strangeness of this new
development left all the boys shaken and
they hopped back onto Minecraft as
quickly as possible so go find and talk
to Mellow in its cave however this time
the cave was empty and mallow was
nowhere to be seen But the text still
didn't stop they'd come in so frequently
with Malo getting closer to home
literally in each one the boys thought
about telling their parents but would
their parents believe them it probably
lumped Malo and with the same Tall Tales
of childhood imagination as Herobrine
and write it off as bored kids playing a
prank even though in this case it was
anything but more photos arrived and
these ones Mal o was right outside each
of the children's homes lurking watching
in some of the photos they could see
themselves in the windows going about
their evening business having no idea of
the creature lurking just outside none
of the boys felt like playing Minecraft
that night it wasn't fun anymore instead
they shut themselves up in their rooms
closed and locked their windows and
pulled down the blinds after checking
under the beds with flashlights of
course but still more photos came in all
depicting Malo getting closer and closer
and closer right about the time they
were wondering whether the scratching on
the outside of their bedroom door was
real or just a figment of their
imagination another dark irony had
occurred to them all this time trying to
find something Supernatural and in the
very end something Supernatural had
instead found them
Bev had always loved going to the mall
when she was a child it meant spending
quality time with her mother taking in
the bustling science of the storms the
enticing smells of the food court when
she was on her best behavior she might
be rewarded with a new toy a soft
pretzel or A Fistful of quarters to
spend at the arcade when she was a
little bit older first coming into her
independent teenage Spirit the mall was
a place of Refuge of Freedom somewhere
she could spend time with her friends
away from her family's prying eyes
trying on outfits she'd never be allowed
to wear to school filling up on free
samples and imagining what it might feel
like to be grown up but as Bev had
gotten older Left Behind childish things
the mall had started to die she knew it
wasn't her fault but it was sad to watch
the source of so many simple Joys wither
away bit by bit stores closed one by one
driven out of business by the
convenience of online shopping slowly
but surely the thriving Center of her
Suburban youth hollowed out turned into
a graveyard of Commerce left behind in
the endless March towards the future the
colorful signs and advertisements for
coming attractions remained but there
were no customers the Phantom smell of
uneaten Cinnabon lingered in the air the
lights were on but no one was home and
then the lights went out too the city
didn't want to deal with the abandoned
malls upkeep but they didn't want to go
to the trouble of tearing it down either
so they just left it there there was a
running joke in town that the last
security guard to lock up the place had
left the doors wide open and just let
nature get inside and start taking its
course the mall belonged to the wild
plants and animals again a strange
artificial enclosure where raccoons
could scavenge and deer could hide from
hunters and their rifles then of course
the small town had done what small towns
do best it fired up the rumor mill where
a parent's pastor around email forwards
warning about dangerous Drifters hiding
out in the empty mall or gangs
conducting violent initiations there
teenagers stared each other to go inside
before chickening out and going home
riling each other up with Promises of
ghosts or evil storm mannequins ready to
attack children at recess or on Scout
camping trips gave each other nightmares
with stories of giant monsters hiding in
the old building waiting for lost kids
to wander inside so they could gobble
them up Bev knew none of that was true
it couldn't be but she still couldn't
shake the Curiosity she felt about the
mall that the town had left behind what
did it look like now what had the
elements the time the influence of
intruders both curious and destructive
done to the place she had never planned
to get into urban exploring but then
again she hadn't planned to move back to
her hometown after flunking out of law
school either it was strange being back
in such a familiar place that now so
different she could try to adjust could
let her life fade into a gray routine of
Diner breakfasts and drinks at the one
bar in town and endless cups of coffee
where she could find a way to lean into
the inherent strangeness of being back
home when she bumped into Daniel her
best friend from high school and he told
her all about his new slightly illegal
hobby she knew she had found the answer
he had a crew of fellow Urban explorers
a term they preferred to use instead of
trespassers a mix of friends from high
school and other exploring enthusiasts
he had met online Bev was casually
interested but not entirely sure if the
dangerous hobby was for her until Daniel
mentioned the mall like Bev he had
continued thinking about it long after
its official closing he wanted to go
inside to see what had happened to it
over the years and to see if there was a
crumb of Truth to any of the rumors
about what lurked inside Bev didn't take
that part seriously but her fascination
with the old mall was an enough to
convince her to join the crew on their
expedition inside Daniel provided her
with a list of rules turn off your
cellular data once you get there so the
police can prove your trespassing bring
water bring a flashlight and wear all
black the group agreed to meet about a
mile away from the old mall where they
would park their cars discuss their
plans and head inside Bev felt a bit
silly lying to her parents about where
she was going at her age but she didn't
want them to worry about her she told
them she was going to meet up with some
friends at a dance club just out of town
they didn't bother to ask what kind of
Club she would wear a black sweater
black pants boots and a black knit hat
too she was happy to leave without any
more scrutiny as she drove out towards
the abandoned Mall she gripped the
steering wheel with sweaty nervous hands
what was she thinking what if something
went wrong while they were in there the
old building could be full of exposed
wiring and loose beams just waiting to
fall down and Crush someone there could
be enough of rabid animals ready to
defend their territory she tried to
shake off the sense of foreboding Daniel
and his crew had done this sort of thing
dozens of times before everything would
be fine by the time she pulled up to the
meeting spot and parked her car Bev had
managed to calm herself down this would
be a fun weird night of poking around
the ruins of her childhood the remains
of a long gone piece of suburban
Americana and that was all nothing bad
would happen she introduced herself to
the rest of the group a pair of brothers
named Mark and Lewis that she recognized
from high school and a young woman named
Rachel who didn't look a day over 20.
she must have been one of Daniel's
internet buddies is this everybody
bevast Daniel nodded this is the crew
for tonight ready ready as I'll ever be
Bev Shrugged and laughed everyone else
nodded in agreement holding up their
various flashlights excited to get into
the mall and explore the place was every
bit as fascinating as bed had hoped it
would be a mixture of almost untouched
storefronts Khloe clothes rotting off
their internal plastic mannequins
beneath plastic signs advertising going
out of business sales and the wild world
encroaching on what had once been a
piece of suburban retail Paradise
spiderwebs hung along the walls possums
and rats skittered along the floors
Vines crept along the remains of the
fountain at the center of the food court
that had long ago run dry Bev screamed
in shock as something ran across her
foot when she cast her flashlight Beam
at it she found that it was just a small
raccoon running from the sudden
intrusion on its home sorry I'll keep my
cool next time she laughed it off yeah
it's fine it happens to me too Daniel
reassured her you never quite get used
to roaming around these places in the
dark but look there's a lot of cool
stuff to check out he used his
flashlight to illuminate the food court
specifically the soft pretzel stand on
top of the stand leaning precariously to
one side was the enormous model of a
soft pretzel that had once attracted
hungry Shoppers looking for a snack
hungry equipped Bev didn't help herself
she pulled out her phone and snapped a
picture it was creepy and was a little
sad but it mostly was a reminder of the
simple joys of childhood when the flash
went off it illuminated the darkness
behind the stand and she caught the glow
reflecting in the eyes of the animals
hiding back there it unsettled her at
first but she reminded herself this
place was theirs now she and Daniel and
everyone else they were just visiting
for the night she checked her phone to
see how the picture came out and frowned
hey Daniel look at this she held out her
phone to show him and his eyes widened
what is that can you zoom in Bev zoomed
in on the picture and the two took a
closer look there in the background of
the picture just barely illuminated by
the phone's flash was a large silhouette
they couldn't make out any defining
features other than a large round head
and long thin noodle-like arms did this
place used to have a mascot or something
Daniel asked Bev shook her head not that
I remember huh Daniel side weird anyway
where'd the others go he looked around
for their flashlights or any other sign
of Life guys did you get lost his voice
echoed through the wide empty space but
no one responded hello Bev called out a
chill running down her spine only
minutes ago she had heard the others
laughing and joking around as they
explored the other end of the mall but
now she couldn't hear a thing even the
chittering of the rats had gone quiet
suddenly a blood-curling scream rang out
and sent Bev's heart leaping into her
throat she and Daniel shared a look of
deep concern as they both silently
wondered if their worst fears had come
to pass had someone Fallen had there
been an accident she and Daniel followed
the sound looking for the source are you
guys okay Daniel shouted the lack of
response spoke volumes whatever had
happened the rest of the group was in
big trouble Bev quietly kicked herself
for neglecting to bring a first aid kit
finally the two reached the other end of
the mall where the scream had sounded
like it was coming from but there was no
one there only a dark web smear along
the ground it looked incredibly fresh
and it smelled metallic violent Bev
didn't have to look more closely to tell
that it was blood whatever had happened
to the other three she wasn't sure they
were going to find them alive Daniel
reached into his jacket pocket and
pulled out a small pocket knife it's not
much but just in case he held it out in
front of them as they walked following
the trail of blood something crashed to
the ground behind them and Bev Whirled
around to see a large steel beam only
feet away any closer than they would
have been crushed her eyes started
around searching for any more potential
danger and then she saw it up in the
rafters by the ceiling was a strange
figure it was unlike anything she had
ever seen it was tall impossibly tall
and Pitch Black its head was bulbous
with pair of feline ears on top she
could make out a nose a pair of wide
white eyes with big dark pupils and it
was smiling a broad Wicked smile filled
with Jagged Blood Stained teeth its hair
and looked like enormous white gloves it
was almost like she felt ridiculous
thinking this even as Terror prickled at
the back of her neck but it looked like
an old cartoon the sort of thing her
grandmother used to watch except those
always look friendly even if they were a
little unsettling this thing it looked
evil At first she thought it was some
sort of Twisted graffiti or a statue
left by a Macabre experimental artist
but then it moved the creature tilted
its head to the side it smile broadening
and its pupils dilated it was looking
right at her and it was excited Daniel
Bev whispered weekly I see it too he
replied his voice shaking we need to go
we need to go now Bev couldn't be sure
what this thing would do if it caught
them but she didn't want to wait around
to find out she grabbed Daniel's arm and
yanked him toward the exit it took him a
moment to start moving again Paralyzed
by fear and confusion at the
incomprehensible sight of the entity on
the ceiling but once he started running
it seemed like he would never stop the
two raced toward the exit arms and legs
pumping as fast as they could behind
them they could hear the creature
chasing after them but they didn't dare
look back to see just before they passed
the threshold out of the mall Bev felt
Daniel's hand slip out of hers she spun
around searching for him and watched in
helpless Terror as the long long arms of
the creature looped around his chest
pulling him back away from her and
lifting him up in the air it opened its
massive mouth wide wider wider and
swallowed him whole Bev screamed but she
forced herself to keep running to save
herself from the same fate she could
feel the entity's eyes on her back as
she ran out the door but once she
escaped she knew it would not chase her
any further for some reason it was
letting her go she couldn't imagine if
it was out of some kind of Mercy but she
was grateful to escape with her life
just the same Bev stumbled into the
local police station a disheveled mess
face streaked with tears and told the
officer on duty what she had seen he
didn't believe her at first asking her
to repeat her story again and again
every time she insisted that she knew
what she encountered out there or at
least she knew that she couldn't explain
it the officer sat her in an
interrogation room alone with a cup of
coffee and asked her to wait until
someone more qualified to help her
arrived she wondered if they were going
to try and have her committed if they
had assumed she had lost her mind but
when a man in a white lab coat opened
the door and greeted her he said he
believed her he wasn't from a hospital
or affiliated with the police he was
from a special organization a foundation
dedicated to investigating The
Unexplained he was going to look into
what happened at the mall all he asked
was that she tell him in her own words
what she had seen I don't know she
sighed it looked like some kind of
messed up cartoon cat with the first
hand account of Bev and a series of
confirmed disappearances that could all
be traced to the and Maul the SCP
Foundation opened an official
investigation wanting to eliminate as
many potential complications as possible
the foundation selected only one
researcher actually entered the
abandoned building an operative with a
great deal of field work experience
named Dr Bagan though Dr baggin would
enter the building alone he would not be
without support he would be fitted with
a microphone and camera and his progress
would be monitored remotely by his
supervisor at a nearby Foundation site
if the need for backup arose they would
then be able to deploy additional
security officers to enter the mall and
extract Dr Bogan if at all possible he
would also be armed with a standard
pistol as well as a foundation issued
flamethrower with the team selected and
the appropriate safety measures taken it
was time for Dr baggin to enter the mall
and see just what he could learn about
the entity dwelling inside if at all
possible he was to neutralize it and
bring it into containment alive so that
it could be studied closely in a
clinical environment a if live capture
was impossible he was instructed to
terminate the being and bring its body
in for a thorough autopsy with his
weapon already drawn and ready and his
eyes sharp and alert Dr baggin walked
into the empty mall he saw a lot of what
Bev and her friends had seen the old
pretzel Stan the dried up Fountain the
creepy but harmless Rose of faceless
mannequins still locked in the same pose
as they had held for a decade the
spiderwebs made him a little nervous but
that was Garden variety Arachnophobia
more than any real sense of danger I
don't know about this one honestly he
spoke into his microphone to his
supervisor on the other end so far seems
like this place is your standard
abandoned building death trap maybe our
missing persons just weren't careful or
properly trained to deal with navigating
a place like this just keep looking his
supervisor ordered look for anything
anomalous got it Dr baggin nodded he
stepped on something with a loud crunch
he looked down to see the oldest
staleless soft pretzel he had ever seen
anyone hungry he equipped turning his
camera towards the unappetizing site
don't worry I'll keep looking he carried
on walking heading past a shoe store a
music store some kind of novelty
porcelain figurine store he stopped at
the toy store when something Eerie
caught his eye you guys seeing this he
asked what is it bargain his supervisor
replied just this creepy stuffed animal
thing the cat right over there I don't
like how its eyes follow me when I walk
by I don't see a cat sure enough when Dr
boggin did a double take the strange cat
mic toy was nowhere to be seen well
there's your first anomalous activity he
joked though his heart was beginning to
pound nervously in his chest keep
looking he nodded and continued his
patrol of the area he couldn't get the
face of that thing that wasn't a toy out
of his head its eyes like the old Felix
the Cat clock his grandparents had in
their guest room bad thing had scared
the hell out of him as a kid he could
never sleep in the room with it all he
could think of outward's eyes going back
and forth back fourth stopped in his
tracks he thought he could hear the
sound of a ticking clock clear as day
just behind him he turned to look but
there was no clock nothing but darkness
and emptiness the same as everywhere
else he felt something suddenly tugging
at his foot he looked expecting to see
an animal pulling at a shoelace
something ordinary but instead he saw
long pointed fingers curling around his
ankle he couldn't see what the fingers
belonged to couldn't see a body but
could only see a long looping snake of a
shadowy arm curling around the corner up
ahead before he could tell his
supervisor what was happening the hand
had grabbed hold of him and was dragging
him across the ground the hand lifted
him off the floor then dropped him back
down he felt the lens of his camera
break are you okay we lost visuals no no
I'm not shouted as he looked up into the
face of Pure Evil its pupils were dark
and endless its eyes bloodshot its teeth
bared do not send back up I repeat do
not send backup oh God oh God the audio
cut to static and the signal was lost Dr
baggin's body was never found the entity
referred to as cartoon cat was given the
object class ketter regarded as highly
dangerous and nearly impossible to
contain due to its reality bending
nature because it cannot be physically
contained the foundation solution to
minimize cartoon cat's damage was to
block off access to the abandoned mall
all civilians were warned of a deadly
amount of radiation in the area in order
to deter them from conducting any more
urban exploration vandalism or other
visits to the location any of the few
survivors that have encountered cartoon
cat are given amnestics and their
experiences are written off as substance
related or Vivid nightmares the empty
Mall may not be the only place cartoon
cat has made its own nor is it likely to
be the only Bill building of its kind
that houses an anomalous monster after
all when Humanity decides to vacate a
place to leave it standing vacant and
abandoned you never know what might
decide to move in
scp-096 the shy guy woke up in an
unfamiliar room without a thought in its
head however one thing quickly occurred
to it this was not its containment
chamber no the solid steel Cube that had
kept it locked up for decades now didn't
have a front desk or wall walls covered
in strange childlike murals or tinny
party music playing over old speakers
wherever scp-096 had found itself it
certainly wasn't the place it had come
to call home if it could read it would
have registered the words behind the
front desk painted onto the wall ban
bans kindergarten where Joy Comes Alive
little did 096 know something really did
come to life here at bamban's
kindergarten but it definitely wasn't
Joy
scp-096 was typically used to a much
more confined space so presented with so
much strange Freedom its natural
instinct was to wander around whimpering
quietly to itself this place was
certainly peculiar with multiple large
reinforced doors each one having a large
red button fixed to the wall above them
a strange green creature was painted on
the wall within a fixed speech bubble
that read jumbo Josh says eat fruits and
vegetables if you want to be strong like
me though 096 paid no mind to such
things this place looked like an SCP
Foundation containment facility mixed
with an off-brand Chuck E cheese and
some tiny part of the Shy Guy's dim and
dismal brain wanted to see more of it
what other Secrets could it hold the shy
guy pressed one of the big red buttons
causing the doors to open underneath it
there was a feigned sound of childish
laughter somewhere down the distant Hall
how had it ever found its way into such
a strange place the deeper the shy guy
wandered the more strange murals it saw
on the wall there was one for a large
orange cartoon jellyfish with one
staring eye where the speech bubble red
Stinger Flynn says having many arms
allows me to help a lot of people then a
squat blue gorilla-like creature with
sharp lower teeth had a speech bubble
that read Captain fiddles says
a white feminine cat-like creature had
the speech bubble vanbelina says
kindness is free so sprinkle it
everywhere a misshapen pink bird
creature had the speech bubble opila
bird says laughter is the best medicine
so make sure to smile and of course most
importantly of all presiding over the
creativity room was a mural of a
grinning red creature wearing a pair of
party hats on its head like horns his
speech bubble read banban says sharing
is caring your pancreas is mine a
whiteboard not far from this mural had
the words run for your lives hastily
scrawled onto it to anyone but the shy
guy who had no point of reference this
was clearly not a normal kindergarten as
the shy guy passed into the hallway
slowly lumbering along it suddenly felt
an intense Spike of burning pain right
through its forehead Rising like a fever
pitch the shy guy subdued whimpers
quickly escalated into horrifying whales
of animals rage this could only mean one
thing somewhere something had made the
terrible mistake of gazing at the shy
guy's face in fact not 10 feet away the
unfortunate opala bird had made that
very mistake it typically peaked out
from behind one of the hallways pillars
to get a good look at any potential
Intruders or new prey wandering into its
midst but this time the beastly Birds
curiosity had taken it from Predator to
prey itself though it wouldn't realize
this until it was already too late as
the mutant bird creature skittered back
into the cavernous Hall filled with
plastic trees and an underwhelming play
area the shy guy came Galloping after it
on all fours roaring with Fury the opala
bird was shocked to see the creature
giving chase this doesn't make sense I
meant to chase you you're not meant to
chase me but things are rarely fair when
it comes to the shy guy arguably one of
the most dangerous euclid-class
creatures ever in Foundation containment
the opala bird flapped desperately
towards the boarded up escape hatch but
the shy guy was so much faster he
grabbed hold that the bird gripping it
in its iron clutches and began to
stretch open its bottom jaw with a blood
curdling Roar we'll spare you the
details of what happened next but
suffice to say little more than a
handful of feathers were loud after
finishing off the opala bird the shy guy
reverted from Rage back to pitiful
sadness this place was no better than
the SCP Foundation there were still
creatures here to look at its face and
drive it into a state of extreme
emotional distress it was horrible the
shy guy needed to find a way to hide
himself away again so he decided to tear
away the planks covering up the escape
hatch and looked down the narrow Hall
and there the shy guy actually found
something to its liking two platforms
one on either side of the room with what
seemed to be a deep dark Chasm between
the two
for most there was an electrical lift
system for carrying them between the
platforms but the shy guy had no
interest in the platforms he only sought
the darkness below where nobody could
see his face that would suit him just
fine the shy guy jumped over the
guardrail and plummeted down below into
the dark feeling the air against its
cold gray skin as it fell felt wonderful
I dared to think that it might even find
solace in this deep dark place but as
soon as he hid something solid some kind
of metal lift system alarms went off and
flashing red lights soon made everything
down there in the darkness visible to be
exposed like this while it thought it
was hidden was the dreaded Shy Guy's
worst nightmare little did he know he
would soon become the worst nightmare of
a number of other beasts as the shy guy
crawled off the metal platform hoping
that perhaps it could find another place
to hide down here its hands and feet
splashed into shallow water had
something sprung a leak down here the
shy guy began wandering the half dark as
the water of this flooded sub-basement
area pooled around him it had no idea
that another creature was already
sneaking up behind it getting ready to
strike before 096 could even react
several whipped-like orange tentacles
wrapped around its Limbs and began
delivering an antagonizing shock through
its body more tentacles came in soon
after wrapping around the Shy Guy's body
and face delivering shock After Shock
After Shock with its millions of tiny
venomous Stinger barbs for a second it
seemed like the surprise attack might
actually be able to subdue the monster
but little did the Shy Guy's attacker
the Monstrous real Stinger Flynn know
that attacking it was just another way
to activate its Infamous rage State the
second that Stinger Flynn relented even
just for a moment the shy guy grabbed
him by the tentacles and slammed him
into the watery floor again and again
and again until the grip of his
tentacles loosened around the Shy Guy's
body and he was defenseless with stinger
panicked and immobilized the shy guy
released the full force of his
Supernatural Fury striking the Demonic
jellyfish with his fists until what was
left couldn't be distinguished from the
water it used to be floating in Stinger
Flynn had been completely annihilated
the shy guy once again temporarily
returned to a state of calm and wandered
out of this watery basement into a
nearby hallway where everything was
bright and dry the walls were painted in
garish childlike drawings of a jungle
with janky looking animals the shy guy
paid no mind to any of it all he wanted
was to find somewhere that he could
actually be alone and away from prying
eyes of all these freaks this dream was
short-lived because as soon as the shy
guy found a new room a wide open
Auditorium filled with inflatable jungle
trees like a crude play area he was
being stalked yet again a powerful Musk
regular Predator with veins stretching
over its bulging muscles and blue skin
it knew that this Intruder had already
killed two of its fellow Garden dwellers
but this time it would put this spindly
pale Stranger in its place the Shanghai
heard something rumbling towards it from
behind and turned upon hearing the
blood-curdling war cry of ooga booga
booga ooga it was the gorilla-like
captain fiddles with strands of saliva
hanging from his tusks he leaped onto
the Shy Guy and began pounding into its
hideous face with this huge blue fists
Captain fiddles would destroy the shy
guy pound him into the concrete until he
stopped moving the one thing that
Captain fiddles didn't expect was for
the shy guy to start fighting back and
he was about to learn the hard truth
that the shy guy could fight a lot
harder than him the SCP spindly but
immensely powerful arms grabbed Captain
fiddles by the shoulders and threw him
into the wall causing huge cracks to
crawl up towards the ceiling before
captain fiddles could even think about
wrenching himself free the shy guy
leaped to his feet and bounded over to
him the shy guy grabbed Captain fiddles
by the ankles and ripped him out of the
wall letting his body drop to the floor
and then unleashing hell upon Him
Captain fiddles would have begged for
mercy if he wasn't already dead before
the shy guy could even begin to calm
down a trapdoor opened in the floor
beneath him dropping him into a new area
a multi-colored maze where 096 was
trapped like a helpless rat with the
body count of an atomic bomb once again
the shy guy didn't need to go looking
for trouble because trouble was already
on its way the pure white cat like Ben
bellina pounced from a sharp corner in
the Maze claws barred she jumped onto
the shy guy latching onto him incline
trying to scratch his nightmare of a
face if the shy guy had ever possessed
anything resembling patience he would
have run out long before now he grabbed
vanbelina shrugging off the pain of her
laws and tossing her into the darkness
high above she flew off with a cat-like
yell and hit some distant ceiling with a
crunch suffice to say she wouldn't be
back to bother the shy guy again tired
and angry the pale Abomination didn't
feel like wandering through a maze
instead it just charged straight through
destroying a colorful wall after
colorful wall when it encountered
whatever was behind this extremely
frustrating afternoon it would destroy
it with extreme prejudice that was
almost certainty after breaking through
one more wall the shy guy tumbled out
into a strange room where a grinning red
creature was waiting for him wearing two
party hats on top of his head this was
no mere Lackey it was bamban himself the
one behind this nightmarish kindergarten
he stared right into the shy guy's face
with no fear at all almost like he knew
something that the shy guy didn't and it
was true he had no plan to fight the shy
guy himself he'd brought a champion in
with him as the shy guy started to
scream and rage all the boxes behind ban
ban tumbled out of the way as a huge
figure Rose a behemoth at least 50 feet
tall with green skin giant teeth and
huge staring eyes it was jumbo Josh and
if the shy guy wanted to graduate from
this nightmare kindergarten it would
need to defeat him and Bam Bam the shy
guy growled digging its claws into the
ground and preparing to charge forward
challenge
accepted it had been the same nightmare
for weeks now but always Fading Into
Echoes as he awoke not tonight though
tonight he was able to see more to hold
on to the details of his Dark Twisted
dream and the warning it contained Dr
Steven strange had once been an
accomplished surgeon yet fate had
destined him to become the sorcerer
Supreme of Earth after a car accident
claimed the use of his hands now strange
was a protector of his world and
countless others in the vast expanse of
the Multiverse a master of the Mystic
Arts wielding his skills in sorcery and
Arcane artifacts to defend against
malevolent otherworldly threats but even
he had never seen anything like this
nightmare before on the night were the
details of the dream felt easier to keep
a hold on a sleeping Steven was shown
all manner of Horrors the world he had
devoted himself to protecting was
crumbling burning all around was death
and suffering the air shrill with the
screams of tour tortured innocent souls
to make matters worse within the dream
strange could feel the same suffering
reaching out crossing the boundaries
between realities it wasn't just his
world he saw dying it was all of them
every corner of the Multiverse falling
it turned his stomach it all felt so
real not just an anxious unconscious
fantasy of something he feared might
happen this was a warning of something
that would come to pass the dread felt
by The Sorcerer's Supreme only got worse
as he witnessed a familiar figure
injured and broken crawling free of the
rubble of a destroyed City the
flickering light of endless fires doing
little to mask the man's wounds
instantly Doctor Strange recognized the
wounded figure from the distinctive
flared cloak he wore to his goatee and
dark hair graying at the temples it was
him or rather another version of him
from a different reality within the
Multiverse
help the other strange said weekly
instantly Stephen knelt to help his
interdimensional doppelganger up what
happened here he asked concerned at the
vision of Destruction all around I
couldn't stop it the messenger strange
replied and labored breaths he was
wounded fatally barely holding on slow
down breathe Doctor Strange calmly
instructed his other self still
retaining a bedside manner from his days
as a surgeon this Vision I take it
you're trying to warn me of something
yes the dying sorcerer replied I cast a
spell that should reach you in your
sleep although sending a message across
the multiverses
he paused to wince in pain feeling his
already fading strength dwindling
further it takes a lot more than I have
left it's all right strange assured him
I can hear you I'm listening I only wish
I could do more for you it's alright his
very enforced a weak Smile by the time
this message reaches you I'll already
have been dead but you need to be warned
what happened here strange urged it's
not what has happened it's what's coming
it had to be us of course it did the
other's breaths started slowing I tried
everything I really did but he I've
never felt power like it just tell me
who Stephen shouted where his other self
was fading fast desperate to hear the
full warning before the dream ended
already Dr Strange's mind was racing
with potential candidates who could have
been responsible he knew of a plethora
of deities and destructive creatures
capable of launching attacks on his home
universe and many of whom had time and
time again there were the likes of
nightmare and schumaguaras and of course
his arch nemesis dormammu an entity who
had long desired total control over this
plane of existence Stephen's Earth
inhabited but not one of them had the
power to subjugate the entire Multiverse
in one Fell Swoop please messenger
strange rasped leading up to Steven's
ear don't make the same mistake I did
beware the Scarlet gang he collapsed his
breathing stopped as Doctor Strange
looked at the horrific side of a man
almost identical to him dying having
failed to prevent the chaos that was now
consuming everything the sorcerer
Supreme had an encyclopedic knowledge of
the Mystic Arts and all kinds of occult
beings that he had never heard of the
Scarlet King as he woke in a cold sweat
still feeling the same dread he felt in
the dream Doctor Strange could remember
the warning from his other multiversal
self it had to be him he had to stop the
Scarlet King The Scarlet who repeated
Wong Steven's trusted friend and
confident an expert in both and martial
arts as well as an accomplished scholar
Scarlet King the other me was adamant
that this thing had to be stopped by
another version of me Doctor Strange
explained having woken up flustered with
growing concern over his vision Stephen
had spent the whole morning in the
library the sanctum santorium had long
been Strange's home and base of
operations since he had inherited the
title of sorcerer's Supreme from the
ancient one additionally the magical
building in the heart of New York's
Greenwich Village also possessed a
sprawling Library filled with tomes that
contained what was thought to be the sum
total of all occult knowledge his books
were filled with useful information on
spells other planes of existence even
detailing accounts of threats Steven had
already faced like dormammu and yet
there was no mention of any Scarlet King
I don't understand it my other selfie
mentioned it specifically by name but I
can't find a single reference to it in
any texts strange side and frustration
the book of kaglistro nothing no mention
of a Scarlet King strange Wong
what no I mean it's unusual you found
nothing his friend answered trying to
hide a smile at catching Steven in a
joke perhaps the book of vishanti holds
more answers it contains all the
knowledge the great sorcerer agamoto
collected on the Mystic nope already
tried that doctor strange interrupted I
consulted our copy on the dark hole too
while I was at it you did what Wong
exclaimed ever concerned by Steven's
arrogant and Reckless Behavior the dark
hold was a dangerous Tome a book of
spells used only for Pure Evil written
by an elder god named python even though
the original true darkhold Was Out Of
Reach the knowledge contained within the
copy Stephen possessed was still
perilous to be exposed to ah relax
strange replied in a rather blase manner
still absent-mindedly flicking through
the pages of another book the Codex
Imperium damn it I need to know what it
is I'm up against he yelled in
frustration Wong you didn't see what I
saw in that dream it was chaos
destruction unlike anything I've ever
felt before I understand Stephen his
fellow sorcerer answered and as sorcerer
Supreme you hold a duty to protect this
reality from those that would seek to
threaten its safety but this is
dangerous a being we know nothing about
is rare perhaps consider if there's a
reason why we know nothing of this
Scarlet King there is some knowledge
that is not meant to be uncovered
knowledge is power old friend Doctor
Strange retorted if I'm gonna do my duty
to protect our reality I need to know
anything that will give me an edge I'll
be in my study with that the sorcerer
Supreme Strode off to a private corner
of the sanctum he spent the next few
Restless hours using his Mastery of the
occult to peer into the future
understanding the mystical mechanics of
time in the way he did when Steven was
aware that there was no singular future
but rather Millions upon millions of
possible outcomes a web of potential
courses that fate could take and any
decision made could create a new strand
in this already Tangled mess still there
was no outcome where any Scarlet King
existed however it was then that doctor
strange realized what he had been
missing a detail so small that it had
gone unnoticed but so crucial that it
changed his entire approach he had been
thinking of the situation entirely wrong
in an insular fashion that focused
solely on his own reality his universe
but the warning had come from across the
Multiverse from another strange in
another world what's more was the
feeling the sense he'd felt during the
nightmare although he knew nothing of
his enemy strange could tell the
destruction the Scarlet King was capable
of had the reach to threaten all corners
of the Multiverse this wasn't just a
threat to his world but all worlds
strangest search for answers about the
Scarlet King had proved fruitless thus
far yet remembering this was a threat
coming from across the vastness of the
infinite Multiverse oddly seen to
provide some sense of comfort because
there was one entity he did know of who
might be able to help hands a glow with
magic Doctor Strange performed the
correct ritual he knew would allow him
to communicate with the Living Tribunal
Sharon enough the room around him faded
away and he was presented with the
highest Authority in the Multiverse The
Towering vastly powerful entity was
humanoid in shape save for a head
floating separate from its shoulders
with three faces one fully hooded one
half and the other uncovered the
sorcerer's Supreme had conversed on a
few occasions with the entity enough to
know it was responsible for safeguarding
the Multiverse to prevent universes from
amassing too much power in case they
threatened others maintain balance which
made the fact it had done nothing to
prevent the imminent danger of the
Scarlet King all the more concerning
speak strange Living Tribunal I've come
seeking answers Doctor Strange replied
there is a being an entity that poses a
threat to my world and all others in the
Multiverse I am not aware of such a
threat
the multiversal Arbiter replied please
strange urged it's out there and I need
to be the one to stop it there's no
information on it in my universe so I
ask you please tell me where I can find
someone anyone who knows about the
Scarlet King there was a silence for a
moment as the different faces of the
Living Tribunal conferred all three had
to agree on whether or not it could
interfere the answers you seek lie
beyond your universe
the tribunal finally answered we are in
agreement
I will send you there but exercise
caution Stephen Strange
in a Flash Doctor Strange had appeared
somewhere new the room was dark filthy
nothing short of Bleak but still was a
far cry from the destruction he had seen
in his vision the walls were covered in
scribbled writing that had seemingly
been scrawled over every Surface by
someone in a state of Madness there was
one that caught Dr Strange attention a
figure adorned in red armor large
antler-like horns protruding from his
head it didn't take someone with as much
knowledge of sorcerer Supreme to know
this was a drawing of The elusive
Scarlet King himself who's there a voice
rasp Stephen turned to see an old man
withered and alone laying on a grimy
hospital bed in the corner of the room
sorry I I didn't see you he said calmly
cautiously approaching only lowering his
guard when he heard the elderly man give
a horse cough you're very sick strange
remarked dying I think the man replied
are you Foundation Foundation the
sorcerer echoed in confusion yes yes
don't be surprised I know all about them
the anonymous man said weekly I haven't
forgotten when I used to work there or
how they felt about what I know though
they'd stop at nothing to silence me God
knows they've tried over the years
listen I was sent here because I need
answers Doctor Strange interrupted aware
of the impending threat he felt he
needed to avert so uh Mr doctor
the old man corrected Dr Robert Montauk
Dr Montauk Steven echoed what can you
tell me about this Scarlet King Montauk
started chuckling a dry wheezing sound
almost like he was taunting the sorcerer
his laughter lasted far longer than that
of a sane man paired with the drawings
and markings on the walls Stephen was
certain something inside Robert Montauk
was broken oh I could tell you so much
about the Scarlet gang I was one of his
children once so long ago now he said a
loud hacking cough brought on by his
laughter forced its way out of montauk's
throat
but that's his strength you see being
known being understood look this being
is threatening my world I need to know
how I'm supposed to stop him strange ass
stop him
Dr Montauk chuckled at him what makes
you think you can I was told I have to
the sorcerer's Supreme admitted it has
to be me and if you won't tell me what I
need to know that I'm very sorry
normally I'd never do this but in the
grand calculus of the Multiverse there's
nothing I won't sacrifice to protect it
with the wave of his hands Dr Strange
conjured his third eye which snapped
open in the center of his forehead it
functioned as an organic manifestation
of his Amulet the powerful mystical
artifact known as the eye of agamoto and
through it Stephen peered into Dr
montauk's fractured mind seeking out the
information he was withholding about the
Scarlet King no no no you can't Montauk
shouted his frail withered hands
gripping his temples as he felt the
sorcerer invading his memories I'm sorry
strange repeated but knowledge is power
and I need to know how to stop the
Scarlet King you think knowledge is
power the old man rast it's more than
that to him it's a weapon his weapon the
more we know about him it was too late
Doctor Strange had found what he was
looking for years earlier Dr Robert
Montauk had been working at the SCP
Foundation and that uncovered the true
nature of scp-001 tough toe's proposal
otherwise known as The Scarlet King The
King was an elder god a force of pure
chaos and the manifestation of a hatred
for modernity but it was far worse than
that a huge Crimson crack split through
the concrete wall a doorway to the
Scarlet King's domain pulling himself
out of Robert montauk's mind the second
he realized his mistake Doctor Strange
was still reeling as the portal opened
how could he have been so stupid his
nightmare hadn't been a warning to
prevent what was coming it was either a
warning to stay away or a trap snapping
back to awareness Steven found he was no
longer in the filthy room where the
dying Dr Robert Montauk lay instead he
was in a vast multiversal void a space
between universes and there among the
huge expanse of nothingness stood the
Scarlet King he towered over Dr Strange
his physical form adorned in armored the
shade of blood atop his head was a
crown-like ornament the large antlers
jutting out above his hands were gnarled
claws clenched into massive fists and
his many eyes were looking at Stephen
having seen inside montauk's mind Doctor
Strange had realized all too late that
the Scarlet King was more than just an
ancient evil being and a desire to
return to a more violent age but if
nobody talked about him he would gain no
further power the Scarlet King had only
grown in strength the more the SCP
Foundation had tried to learn about him
and now the sorcerer Supreme himself had
done the same the king had achieved even
greater power thanks to strange falling
into his trap enough to open a Gateway
and bring him here you already know
the Scarlet King snarled his voice
sounding like billions upon billions of
insects chittering
Stephen looked in horror at the
interdimensional Abomination even just
by observing him being able to receive
his physical form he was unintentionally
empowering The Entity but living idea or
not strange had seen the destruction
that the Scarlet King could unfurl on
the Multiverse by the hoary hosts of
hoggoth Doctor Strange declared
summoning up a spell that he hoped would
reverse whatever power the king
possessed you will not harm my world nor
any others unleashing his magic in a
blast of light the beam struck the
Scarlet King the elder god was harmed
but not undone the force of the Mystic
Arts being almost as ancient as the
Scarlet King was and thus he could still
be hurt the Scarlet King raised a mighty
fist bringing it slamming down towards
Stephen it was barely able to cast The
Shield of seraphim creating a protective
circle of mystical energy that formed a
barrier between strange and the oncoming
attack as the descending gigantic Fist
of the Scarlet King was deflected he
instantly brought his other down in a
vicious attack the sheer force of it
broke Steven's concentration causing the
shield to dissipate barely withstanding
enough of the King's Physical strength
to prevent the sorcerer from being
knocked down it was like one magically
powered ant fighting against a being
impossibly bigger that could stomp
strange out of existence in seconds but
even failing to the imperceptible ground
of the Void Doctor Strange didn't let up
refusing to relent and let the Scarlet
King unleash his wrath on the Multiverse
his cloak of levitation lifted him back
to his feet and with a wave of both
hands Stephen burst into multiple astral
projected copies of himself the images
of Icon the multiple doctors strangers
floated independently through the air
surrounding the Scarlet King then as
every Stephen gave an outward flick of
his wrist the Crimson bands of xidarock
flew from their hands the bright red
belts of energy virtually indestructible
bound the powerful chaotic King lashing
around his physical form Doctor Strange
being able to see and perceive the
Scarlet King was granting his adversary
power he pulled with all his physical
strength the Crimson bands starting to
wane slackening despite Strange's
efforts to keep all his duplicates
holding on ripping the bands in his huge
gnarled hands the Scarlet King swung the
multiple strangers around forcing them
all back into the same singular body as
they collided still holding the one
remaining Crimson band of sirak the
Scarlet King started to drag Stephen
towards him the king didn't want him
dead strange knew it he'd be tortured
made and unmade even until the entity
forced him to use his third eye again
like he had done to Dr Montauk if Doctor
Strange could fully comprehend the
Scarlet King's nature origin and
ideology then the king would be able to
achieve his full strength that was the
Trap the sorcerer Supreme had been lured
into his own arrogance his need to be
the one who saved the Multiverse the man
holding the scalpel was a weakness the
Scarlet King was prepared to exploit in
order to achieve the power he needed to
overthrow the Multiverse there was only
one thing left that doctor strange could
do one last Stitch effort it was a long
shot but he hoped it would be enough
releasing his remaining band Steven
began casting a spell to send a message
to another of his selves somewhere else
in the Multiverse he could hear the
Scarlet King looming behind him ready to
strike maybe the king would kill him but
strange wouldn't let that stopping him
cast his spell his warning would reach
the other self even after death in the
form of a dream a warning not to make
the same mistake as this strange had to
not go searching for the Scarlet King
adjacent to known reality lies an
infinite abyss of liminal spaces and
monstrous beings the back rooms as with
all unusual and supernatural phenomena
the SCP Foundation was set on cataloging
the back rooms as an anomaly and finding
a way to contain it but unfortunately
all it took was one failed experiment
for the opposite to occur a huge part
version of site 19 has begun no clipping
into the yellow walled Maze of the back
room's first level taking the research
team some d-class and a handful of
mobile task force agents into the
disturbing alternate reality with it but
this isn't the most terrifying part just
before the experiment went wrong
scp-096 aka the shy guy was transported
to the testing area of site 19 to be
used as a means of clearing backrooms
entities from the path of the research
team in the midst of the chaos that
ensued while Dimensions fused 096 was
exposed to the Gaze of a shadowy being
known as a Smiler and was able to
instantly Break Free of containment
sprinting through the maze towards The
Smiler
scp-096 was quickly too far away for the
foundation staff to attempt recapture
moreover this situation demanded a far
more immediate concern there was no
apparent way to no clip the Lost
portions of the site back to Native
reality the researchers d-class and MTF
Personnel who are now on the other side
would have to adapt and fend for
themselves in this new reality agent
Cullen the highest ranking member of the
mobile task force present identified
several hostile entities approaching
these bundles of arms were known as
clumps and since they did not possess
eyes they had evaded 096's wrathful
response to entities that saw its face
on Cullen's orders the researchers and
d-class took cover behind the agents who
opened fire on the clumps meanwhile
scp-096 caught up to The Smiler that had
glimpsed its face in most cases smilers
are highly dangerous entities that prey
on humans who are trapped in the back
rooms by pulling them into the Shadows
because this was its nature The Smiler
was not prepared for 096 to not only
Approach at top
but to deliver a slamming arm thrust
straight into the creature's face The
Smiler instantly knew that one more blow
like that would be the destruction of
its strange monstrous existence but it
was too late to get away and 096
certainly didn't stop at one after
beating the Smiler to a pulp
scp-096 briefly returned to a more
neutral state of being it was not at all
phased by the new surroundings in fact
it was temporarily relieved by the
Solitude of the back room's maze that
was when scp-096 felt the Gaze of
something unknowbly powerful staring at
it from deeper within the back room's
Dimensions
scp-096 was no stranger to being
remotely viewed and becoming enraged by
it but this was different these eyes
were everywhere and nowhere all at once
scp-096 felt like he was being torn
apart by its own violent impulse to
destroy whatever entity was currently
seeing its face
with no clear Target present
scp-096 dropped to all fours and in an
instant it ran like a mad Beast through
every conceivable Corridor of the
infinite yellow maze in less than a
single second during this blindingly
fast Rampage 096 found itself back near
the foundation Personnel for a fraction
of a moment none of the humans present
could perceive the shy guy at the
Hypersonic speed it was going but the
result of it passing by was evident in
the abrupt death of several MTF agents
who were still focused on fending off
the clumps it was collateral damage to
096 who didn't intend for its speeding
body to collide with the agents but in
any case the clumps were at that much
more of an advantage when it came to
brutally attacking the members of the
research team the clumps's numbers were
increasing as well as more of the fleshy
aberrations rolled forth from the wood
one of the d-class
d-3461 panicked breaking away from the
defensive line and bludgeoning an MTF
agent from behind the others were still
reeling from the sudden Slaughter
created by scp-096 and were not quick
enough to stop d-3461 from turning tail
and running off into the maze with a
stolen mobile task force issue firearm
clumps seemed to ignore this and focused
on the larger group of humans present
closing in well a clump of clumps senior
researcher Dr Hart an expert in reading
the body language of anomalous creatures
notice this idiosyncratic movement
immediately she immediately notified the
rest of the research team that the
clumps seemed to prioritize going after
humans in groups as much as it was a
cliche in horror and Adventure media it
seemed like the best course of action
was to split into groups of two or three
and run in all directions without
momentum the clumps weren't especially
fast and given the sharp turns and
numerous Crossing Pathways to the back
room's first level the humans could with
a head start keep themselves at a safe
distance if they use their brains and
less cumbersome limbs to maximum
efficiency Dr Hart chose her most
trusted scientific understudy Dr
Whitaker as her Retreat buddy and the
two began to hurry down the many
hallways away from the clumps if there
was a way to survive these entities even
on their home terrain it would be
through the superior intellect of the
researchers that is what Dr Hart
believed in her doctor's heart she and
the others who followed her plan were
lucky that 096 had stopped zooming
through the Maze of the back rooms as
first level this was because it realized
that the entity or entities which were
looking at it were not here in this
Dimension or rather this level of the
back rooms but that didn't mean that
whatever it was could hide for long
especially not from
scp-096 the shy guy is capable of many
things when provoked by another being
seeing its face and among the most
obvious was its nigh invulnerability and
extreme speed both of these factors
would come into play as scp-096
attempted a bizarre and fascinating feat
the Shy Guy's entire body shivered
vibrating in place at an even faster
velocity than it had used to cross the
infinite maze in an instant moments
prior this unorthodox psychic straining
movement pattern made scp-096 especially
prone to no clipping which was the only
reliable way to navigate between levels
of the back rooms the sustained
vibration was highly damaging 2096's
body but it felt no pain and the broken
bones and frayed muscles were returned
to normal instantaneously furiously and
with no further preparation
scp-096 no clipped through the floor of
the Maze and began to descend known
levels of the back rooms towards the
offending entity that was still looking
at its face down one level then two then
three the pressure of maintaining this
feat would more than likely kill or
incapacitate any other being including
many of scp-096's fellow powerful
anomalies but that level of endurance
was what made
scp-096 so distinct and so Unstoppable
four levels down five levels down as
scp-096 continued to descend the
scattered Personnel from the foundation
were making their own discoveries about
no clipping through the back rooms
d-3461 had found himself in a strange
new level of the back rooms filled with
sewer pipes and swooping death moths the
rifle he had taken with him would prove
to be ample protection for now but he
knew his ammunition wouldn't be there
forever still taking his chances
sneaking around down here felt better
than trying to go back towards anyone
who knew him from the foundation like
most d-class d-3461 formerly known as
Gene Beatty was a hardened criminal
through and through and he had done
unforgivable things prior to his time
contained by the SCP Foundation he
didn't want to go back not to the
foundation not to prison and not even to
the real world forget them all he
thought he would survive in this hellish
Abyss known as the back rooms with only
his malice and sense of
self-preservation to guide him agent
Cullen on the other hand who was
accompanied by two of his surviving
mobile task force subordinates was
focused on patrolling the yellow Maze
and searching for potential human
survivors if other people had been no
clipping into the back rooms for as long
as the foundation's data suggested it
was possible that enough of those
unfortunates were able to carve out a
life for themselves that a sizable
faction had formed over the years such a
group would always have a need for armed
assistance and well-trained soldiers so
Cullen knew he could easily find himself
a place among them from there he would
do everything in his power to muster
resources track down the scattered
Foundation personnel and ultimately
return home they have to be around her
somewhere he told himself and his agents
of all the now hopelessly lost
researchers it seemed that Dr Hart and
Dr Whitaker had made it the farthest
into the back rooms they were both now
wandering in the infinite Hotel
otherwise known as level 5 a sprawling
Labyrinth of Suites and lobbies that
would rival the finest establishments in
the front rooms of reality that is if it
were not also full of the same kind of
hostile entities that were so common
through the back rooms Dr Whitaker
attempted to stay in High Spirits
however making a sophomoric joke about
needing a vacation from his vacation Dr
Hart groaned but on some level she was
grateful to ever younger and more
eccentric colleague close by though he
lacked Common Sense he was a prodigy at
science and more than that he was loyal
the two of them would need teamwork and
perseverance to keep going in this place
and through her mentorship of the young
man the groundwork was already there he
and I will manage somehow Dr Hart
affirmed in her mind elsewhere several
levels down
scp-096 had arrived at the source of the
strange gaze that had been fixed upon it
in level 11 of the back rooms the city
which fittingly enough resembled a
modern human city of vast proportions
scp-096 was found locked onto the entity
known as Argos entity 74 an ancient
eyeless humanoid whose Vision was
pervasive and near omniscient throughout
the back rooms the cruel and judgmental
being could observe the sins of any
sentient creature that entered the back
rooms and would carry out a brutal
punishment accordingly this was its
routine behavior and it didn't single
out scp-096 anymore than it did
d3461 whose sins were much more severe
in the eyes of Argos due to the ill
intent behind them that is not to say
that Argos saw the shy guy as innocent
even out of perceived defense the amount
of lives that scp-096 had taken was on
principle enough to call even the most
well-meaning being a sinner a fight
between Argos and the shy guy was
inevitable Argos was accompanied by
several scores of spear wielding
Warriors in tactical gear human
explorers who had joined his cause they
would prove to be little more than speed
bumps as scp-096 made skid marks out of
them on its way to Pummel the
ever-loving snot out of Argos but Argos
was not going to allow the sacrifices of
his eyes to be in vain The Entity used
the reach of his spear to strike 096 at
a distance impaling the creature in
mid-run to the ground this held the shy
guy for all but a moment before it moved
its body up the beer and slammed into
Argos throwing the two of them through a
nearby building Argos fought desperately
to remove his spear from his opponent's
body as all the while 096 pounded him
with punches that could each reduce an
automobile to scrap metal the two
interlocked monsters tumbled through
wall after wall of the skyscraper taking
the lives of several unlucky human
citizens in the process when Argos pride
is spear free from 096 he immediately
jumped back several Paces but once again
he had underestimated the shy guy who
was at his throat in seconds passersby
on the street watched in horror as 096
hurled Argos by the throat into the
skyscraper directly across from the one
they had been fighting in Argos crashed
through the glass of one of the windows
and into an office floor one Titanic
leap from the Shanghai later and 096 had
joined Argos on this new fighting stage
Argos to roll this spear in a frenzied
display of combat power us if this thing
insisted on advancing towards him with
no regard for its well-being he would
have to go through his spear multiple
times over but 096 was not the kind to
let fear stop it from advancing it
charged taking every attack Argos could
dish out before pummeling him downward
through several floors of the building
until they reached the ground level
scp-096 could have taken far more
punishment but Argos had reached his
limit The Entity spear fell from his
hand as 096 continued to hit harder and
harder over and over again until Argos
was close to death as in Immortal
backroom's entity could be at the very
least he had been injured so severely
that his All-Seeing gays had become
weakened for the shy guy this meant that
Argos was technically no longer looking
at it it became docile once more and
wandered out of the building into the
streets to its relief and to the relief
of the nearby entities the facelings of
this city had no eyes and no interest in
looking at 096 preferring to continue
their mindless pantomime of normative
life aren't we all in a cosmic sense
regardless
scp-096 walked through the streets of
the city with one goal return home but
home was far far away from where the
Shanghai was and the no clipping
maneuver that it performed earlier was
not something that the anomaly could
muster the recklessness to do at all
times only when its face was glimpsed
did scp-096 possess its murderous
determination at the moment
scp-096 was like a morning jogger
traveling through level 11 at a Brisk
pace and searching for a way and out
this naturally led the anomaly towards
the Suburban neighborhoods which were
themselves an entrance to the back rooms
level 9. Suburbia it was here around the
dark streets of the Limitless suburbs
that 096 encountered A New Nightmare the
neighborhood watch compress surprised of
a series of hostile entities resembling
in part human eyeballs these ocular
adversaries were known to patrol
Suburbia and keep the peace by
eliminating all Intruders of course the
floating Watchers were capable of
shooting disintegration beams while the
Towering Striders possessed sinewy limbs
that could easily bash most entities
into submission but unfortunately for
everyone involved they were giant
eyeballs one look from the neighborhood
watch in the direction of scp-096 and
their Fates were sealed being ogled by
humongous eyeballs was simply more than
the shy guy could take with a primal
Screech it ran towards the oversized
peepers with a massacre on its mind a
few of the Watchers had time to fire
disintegration blasts which slowed the
approach of scp-096 but it was too
little too late
scp-096 smashed into the Strider
knocking it to the ground and delivering
a crushing blow to its pupil without
missing a beat
scp-096 leaped into the air and smashed
one of the Watchers against a Charming
Suburban home the shy guy Rampage would
continue until there were no more eyes
on it in the back rooms or anywhere the
Scout class starship in Nobis was still
suspended against a backdrop of stars
and the colorful glow of distant nebulas
Frozen in the inky void of deep space
calm at least from the outside but
inside the main hall of the ship was far
from the silent Stillness of the Stars
pandemonium hit as the sounds of a
claxon reverberated through metal
corridors each whale punctuated by the
flash of blood red warning lights blue
looked up at the blinking strobing color
and instantly knew what it meant
emergency meeting he muttered to himself
behind the visor of his spacesuit blue
turned heel and ran his boots clanging
against the metal floor of the Corridor
he ran as fast as he could in his
spacesuit arriving panting to the
cafeteria his breathless wheezes fogged
up his visor but beyond he could still
see the other six fellow members of the
ship's crew or at least he thought all
six of them were there it was only as he
walked closer that he spotted someone
was missing white red green orange
yellow and now blue were all present but
where was pink you took your time blue
white declared I was over at the lower
engine he pan it back it's further away
sorry I'm late ran as fast as I could
what's the situation here orange asked
well I I think we should wait for Ping
to get her before we get into red
started to say only to be interrupted
that's why I called the meeting green
announced pink has gone missing but
that's impossible red immediately
responded drawing a glare from White I
saw pink only a few moments ago we were
both over in electrical to Blue along
with some of the others that seemed a
little bit odd if red and pink had been
close to each other then how had green
known to call the emergency meeting the
room erupted into a brief debate with
white implying in a rather spiteful way
that red knew more than he was letting
on interjecting Blue suggested that they
all split up and search for pink which
was quickly shot down white reminded the
rest of the crewmates that their ship
was in need of constant maintenance if
they didn't perform the necessary tasks
to keep it running then the anovis would
never reach its destination report back
here when you're finished white barked
as they all split off blue couldn't help
but wonder what had gotten white more
agitated than normal however little did
any of the crew aboard the anovis
realize but they had picked up a
stowaway the creature had been slipping
through the ventilation system curiously
watching the assembled group in the
cafeteria before they broke away and
headed off into the various different
areas of the ship spotting one of the
crewmates a man wearing a bright orange
spacesuit the thing in the vents felt
oddly drawn to him and slithered off
down the vents in the direction orange
had been heading now while you might be
forgiven for at first expecting this
extra passenger to be some kind of Alien
Parasite that uses human bodies as hosts
before bursting out of their chest only
to then proceed to kill everything in
sight then you'd be sorely mistaken
Stand Down Sigourney there are no
Xenomorphs aboard this ship no this
slippery little stowaway was none other
than the lovable blob of orange slime
known as scp-999 otherwise referred to
as the Tickle Monster known for being an
adorable amorphous anomaly resembling a
pile of gelatinous orange matter
scp-999 has long been considered one of
the most harmless and affectionate scps
ever cataloged it has a habit of honing
in on the nearest person and leaping
right at them not as a means to attack
them or attach any scary eight-legged
egg-laying head-hugging creature to any
faces instead scp-999 off offers a
loving Embrace and wholesome nuzzling to
a person's face all while emitting
soothing gurgling and cooing noises as
well as pleasant scents that change
depending on what the person it's
hugging finds most appealing or calming
while not in any way harmful and only
ever acting out of the most well-ment
intentions
scp-999 had been the one responsible for
Pink's disappearance the Tickle Monster
had been discovered by Pink while he was
traveling through a corridor past the
med Bay taking the longer route back to
electrical there 999 had playfully
pounced on the crewmate to offer a hug
this had caused pink to experience the
full effect of scp-9999's anomalous
properties slipping into an
overwhelmingly elated state so while not
currently injured he was calmly relaxing
in a hidden corner of the med Bay with
the rest of the crew completely unaware
of what was going on
scp-999 had spotted orange and had been
able to recognize the same color as its
own like body drawn to the crewmate the
Tickle Monster snuck towards orange
while his back was turned busy cleaning
out the filters in the O2 chamber before
he could turn around and spot the
creature scp-999 left to Orange and
lured into the med Bay with pink not
long after blue had finished up his
latest task fixing up the wiring and
storage brushing off his hands he began
casually walking back in the direction
of the cafeteria only to see the Crimson
of Red's spacesuit zip past he was
rushing down the corridor almost like he
had just been caught well red-handed
something didn't seem right blue thought
to himself red had seemed pretty
indignant earlier when pink had vanished
although he couldn't say with any
certainty if it was because red really
did know what was going on or if they
were just nervous returning to the
cafeteria however the crew quickly
realized that orange was now gone too
I'm calling it now white declared this
was you red you're up to something I
swear I'm not red pleaded it was hard to
see how sincere his expression was
through the tinted space helmet visor
well if anyone else knows anything or
saw anything then come forward white
said to the group the rest of the crew
were awkwardly shuffling on their feet
each one clearly uncertain but nobody
wanting to come forward and be the first
to speak actually I um blue found
themselves saying I saw red dashing
around in the corridor he seemed like he
was in a hurry or maybe he was up to
something maybe look it doesn't prove
anything you don't know that yellow
chimed in who knows he may have been
eyeing you up as his next victim victim
red exclaimed look I don't know what
you're implying here I haven't killed
anyone nobody said pink and orange were
dead white replied unless you know more
than you're letting on I swear I don't
know what's happening I'm just in the
dark as you all are red insisted in that
case prove it green interjected bluntly
prove you didn't kill orange and pink
how red yelled how can I prove that you
could prove they're both still alive
said yellow completely unaware that pink
and orange were actually still alive he
can't prove it white announced solemnly
because I bet they're not even on the
ship anymore the missing crewmates were
in actuality still aboard the ship in
fact they were having the time of their
lives inside the med Bay with scp-999
but that hadn't stopped the rest of the
crew turning on red come on red blue
side I mean you've got to admit you're
acting a little well not suspicious but
definitely evasive oh sure what just
because I'm wearing red you all think
I'm some kind of murderous traitor red
shouted his desperate pleading tears
obscured by his helmet's visor this is
McCarthyism look why don't you just give
us a straight answer blue offered trying
to remain reasonable and not join the
rapidly growing Witch Hunt because I'm
scared red insisted scare that we'll
find out what yelled leaping at red and
pinning him down quick the rest of you
grab his arms and legs a struggle ensued
with red desperately kicking and
flailing about while green and yellow
gripped an arm and leg blue was
reluctant he wanted to urge everyone to
calm down and not do anything irrational
but it was already too late if he
opposed the blame might shift to him
under White's Direction the crew lifted
red up and carried him to the anovis's
outer airlock they threw red past the
inside door which slammed shut behind
him as he turned and started slamming
his hand against the surface begging for
them to let him out his pleas fell on
deaf ears as white threw a nearby switch
the outer door of the airlock opened the
vacuum of space pulled red out of the
ship practically firing him out of a
hull like a cannon leaving him to drift
away alone and with limited oxygen in
his spacesuit right now that imposter's
been dealt with everyone get back to
work white announced we need to keep
this ship in a fit state to move blue
was speechless he thought they were just
going to hold red prisoner in a secure
part of the ship until he calmed down in
instead he'd aided his crewmates in
murdering one of their own even the very
thought of it made blue feel sick and he
would have been if he wasn't wearing a
space helmet it all happened so fast
he'd barely had enough time to consider
all the facts after all white it seemed
adamant from the very start that red was
somehow responsible for orange and pink
disappearing but he had no concrete
evidence to base that assumption on then
again where were those missing crewmates
there had been no sign of them no bodies
or discarded suits maybe they weren't on
the ship at all anymore what if white
was right and red had killed them or
Worse what if White had been the one
responsible and blue would just helped
him kill an innocent Spaceman to cover
up his cruel misdeeds of course the
surviving crew were so wrapped up in the
horrifying moral and ethical
implications of the situation that none
of them had thought to check the med Bay
meanwhile scp-999 had found two more new
friends green and yellow the parrot
seemed rather glum since they had just
helped kill red and so the orange blob
of Good Vibes had sought them out now
the two of them plus orange and pink who
were still fine were all enjoying the
company of the Tickle Monster in the med
Bay at the same time though blue was
returning from his tasks of uploading
data over an admin to find only white
left waiting for him in the cafeteria
neither one of them said anything they'd
both already made up their minds in each
one's head the other was the real guilty
party the culprit responsible for the
disappearances and apparent deaths of
the other crewmates both blue and white
were convinced that the other was truly
the Imposter Among Us
oh God enraged they charged at each
other rather than act rationally Maybe
by sticking together and searching the
rest of the ship the two Spacemen
engaged each other in a scuffle your
sauce blue roared punching white in the
stomach causing him to stagger backwards
I'm not the one who sauce white wheezed
rushing back towards blue and shoulder
barging him into the cafeteria floor
they continued their scrap trading blows
until blue was able to throw a punch
that cracked the glass visor of White's
helmet there was a hiss as the air
escaped and white was desperately
fumbling with his helmet trying to plug
the crack blue was able to grab him by
his oxygen tank and drag him towards the
airlock blasting his adversary out into
the unforgiving cold emptiness of space
blue staggered through the ship it was
certain that he received a broken rib
during the fight and hobbled along the
corridors towards Med Bay when the
entrance opened he stared in disbelief
at what he saw sat inside were the
entire crew minus the pair who'd been
ejected from the airlock of course pink
orange green and yellow were playing
with a friendly blob of orange slime
that seemed to have the energy and
enthusiasm of a peck dog the crewmates
were laughing hugging the Tickle Monster
and engaging in tickle fights clearly in
a state of heightened Elation in a
sudden instant of realization the horror
caught up with blue he had just murdered
white and red for enough
both of them were innocent in fact
nobody on the ship was actually missing
just before this horrifying Epiphany
caused blue to suffer an emotional
breakdown
scp-999 glided across the floor towards
him smiling as he knelt to Pat the
orange blob on the head blue suddenly
felt better about the two deaths he'd
been responsible for actually he felt
great compelled to start giggling
uncontrollably as he joined his fellow
surviving crewmates in playing with the
stowaway as CP 999 although thanks to
that delightful distraction not one of
the remaining astronauts realized that
their ship was still adrift in space
heading right towards a sun a blurry
photograph of a man in a Black Cowl is
taped to the wall a black knife held by
a tattooed hand pierces his face you
want him dead a blast dealt with his
foundation Handler replied same thing
Abel said and laughed the helicopter was
ready to go outside
it was another rainy night almost all of
them were plumes of black smoke
billowing from factories on the far side
of the city blotting out the already
darkened sky and plunging Gotham into
deeper Shadow but those Shadows that
Darkness were something that Twisted
underbelly had come to fear the dark was
a tool that one man used to prey on
those who enacted Injustice on the
innocent every shadowy alley or a
flutter of movement atop a roof made
every thief and murder on the streets of
Gotham take pause think twice Batman had
been trailing the movements of
suspicious cargo trucks moving in and
out of the city some were decoys driving
around with empty containers and
changing their routes every night to
throw the world's greatest detective off
the trail but those were just a
distraction a theatrical deception being
deployed so that the real cargo could be
smuggled in undetected Bane a muscle
mercenary with the guise of a Luchador
was one of Batman's most physically
imposing enemies for weeks he had been
stockpiling Venom a strength enhancing
compound somewhere in the city and now
Batman had picked up the trail the
trucks weren't Distributing the Venom
that was being done by a network of
low-level street thugs posing as
motorcycle delivery drivers swooping
through the night sky watching one of
the bikers from above there was
something else playing on the dark
Knight's mind recently he'd gotten the
feeling he was being watched at first
the man under the cowl billionaire
philanthropist Bruce Wayne had chalked
it up two paranoia a side effect of his
nightly escapades as the cape Crusader
is trusted Butler and Confidant Alfred
had even suggested as much but as the
weeks rolled on Batman couldn't shrug
the notion that every move he made every
case he helped Commissioner Gordon solve
every battle with the worst of Gotham's
Rogues Gallery that's somebody was
studying him already Bruce had a list of
potential suspects the likely candidates
for who were having him followed so he
gradually began paying them all visits
as his alter ego the larger of the
city's mob families the falcones denied
any involvement with their leader
Carmine Falcone currently Behind Bars
the rest of the family were laying low
to avoid being arrested themselves next
came Hugo Strange a brilliant but
unhinged scientist who had become
obsessed with Batman for a number of
years Bruce had worried that Hugo had
finally cracked the secret of his true
identity but the Despicable doctor also
refused that he was the one having the
Dark Knight followed the next possible
culprit on this list was Amanda Waller a
powerful and high-ranking government
operative strategic genius and another
of Batman's Rivals known to some as the
wall she was responsible for a number of
shady covert operations that not even
the cape Crusader knew about Waller down
felt in secrets and seem just as likely
to be having Batman tailed in order to
pick up dirt on the detective but as
with strange and the falcones Amanda
Waller denied all of the dark Knight's
claims the heartbeat scanners built into
his cow's eyepieces confirmed that they
had all been telling the truth shrugging
the notion off Batman focused on
following the biker transporting Venom
across the city silently gliding between
skyscrapers with his cape he followed
The Smuggler all the way to an abandoned
chemical processing plant formerly owned
by a company called Ace chemical he
suspected that was where Bane and his
thugs had established a base of
operations using the plant's leftover
equipment to refine the Venom the source
of veins in human strength scanning
through the rooftop with his cow's x-ray
capabilities from a distance Batman
spotted a group of armed men unloading
the boxes they were acting under the
command of a larger figure Bane himself
but then a new unidentified figure had a
appeared and come striding into the
building met with hostility as Bane's
forces Drew their weapons whoever this
was he clearly wasn't with them suddenly
just as Batman fired his grappling hook
to swing onto the roof of the chemical
plant all out chaos erupted inside down
below watching intently by Batman as he
slipped inside staying concealed in the
rafters the new figure had begun
violently attacking Bane and his men the
man was lean shirtless around his late
20s with gray eyes and a mess of jet
black hair his entire body was covered
in tattoos depicting Arcane ruins and
occult imagery on his olive skin in his
hands had appeared a pair of sharp black
blades seemingly from nowhere to some he
was HIV Alban Adam The Butcher of the
West the great traitor and first sword
of Davon but to the ones that had sent
him there he was
scp-076-2 able he charged towards the
group of thugs as they opened fire there
bullets missing as Abel moved with
Incredible speed with a strong upward
swing of both his swords he cleaved the
nearest two mercenaries weapons into
broken pieces as if their guns were made
of plastic not metal Abel brought both
swords slicking downwards felling both
men simultaneously another nearby turned
and ran only to be caught by one of
Abel's blades as the barbaric Warrior
hurled it through the air watching from
above Batman was taken aback it was rare
for him to be so alarmed by a display of
violence especially given he had devoted
his life to crime fighting but the
figure below was taking on Bane's men
single-handedly with such speed and
aggression but it gave the cape Crusader
pause as much as he abhorred killing
Batman held back to observe this new
adversary as Abel squared up against
Bane himself the Luchador charged at him
with the unbridled Rage of a snarling
feral animal while Abel leaped into
battle with equal ferocity his hand
reached into a tiny dimensional Rift a
hole in space out from which he
retrieved an extra weapon that he swung
directly at Bane's head the imposing
muscle monster caught the blade in this
huge hand blocking the blow he lifted
Abel off the ground his own hand
gripping the sword by its Hilt and was
about to deliver a crippling punch that
would have sent the Barbarian flying
that is had he not slipped another sword
seemingly out of thin air had used it to
slice through the blade that Bane had in
his grip Batman had only ever seen
combatants with Abel's level of fighting
prowess among the ranks of the court of
owls and League of Assassins ancient
orders of killers who operated in secret
maybe this barbaric fighter was part of
such an organization maybe Abel had been
watching him the detective watched and
pondered over possible connections to
Ra's al Ghul Talon and even asriel as
Abel took on the mountainous mercenary
he had ducked out of the way of an
oncoming swipe rolling between the
wrestler's legs in an open stance having
outflanked Bane before before he had a
chance to turn around and face him Abel
jumped outwards a pair of his black
reflective swords in hand slashing
through both the air he severed the
tubes on Bane's back part of a harness
designed to pump the Venom chemical into
his body and enhance his strength sickly
green fluids spewed from the pipes with
Bane reaching his muscular arms behind
him fumbling with the mechanism
desperately trying to repair the device
that kept his body strong it was too
late the Luchador dropped to his knees
and collapsed defeated as Abel stood
over him with his swords in hand you can
come up now bat he called up to the
ceiling by now you have no doubt
guessing that I am not here for this one
it's you they sent me to find never one
to charge headfirst into a fight without
thought Batman dropped a smoke pellet it
burst as it made contact with a concrete
floor below filling the area around able
with a heavy gray fog that was
impossible for the warrior to see
through a trio of sharp tip batarangs
came spinning through the air Abel
barely had a chance to see them coming
in time to block them with his swords
only to be caught off guard as an attack
struck him from behind dropping from
above Batman landed a devastating
gliding kick knocking Abel to the ground
the Barbarian rolled over angered at the
outmaneuver as Batman stood casting a
towering pointy-eared Shadow over him
who are you Batman demanded in the Deep
authoritarian voice of a grizzled
veteran vigilante I am known by many
names the man replied the detective
taking note of his distinctive Middle
Eastern accent you will call me Abel the
man who will be your undoing tell me who
sent you the Dark Knight retorted adding
or else able chuckled dryly before
swinging one of his swords downwards
blocking it with his gauntlets Batman
trapped the blade between the row of
claws on his forearms before using them
to snap the weapon in two just as Abel
went to stab at him with his other one
The Dark Knight spun out of the way
grabbing his opponent's hand and guiding
the weapon away in a smooth Parry
telling of his years of martial arts
training but with both hands holding
Abel's attack Aloft Batman couldn't
prevent the barbarian from pulling yet
another blade from his pocket Dimension
with a slash from a smaller knife Abel
cleaved open the gray and black costume
that the Caped Crusader wore causing him
a serious injury grunting in pain Batman
head-butted Abel Square in the nose
causing him to reel back still chuckling
at the tenacity of his Target impressive
Abel mused the foundation sent me here
to kill you I wasn't expecting to find
such a worthy adversary he slowly
lowered his swords while Batman kept his
fists raised in a fighting stance I will
not be that puppet you and I are both
Warriors The Barbarians stated I'm not a
killer Batman argued perhaps but you are
a fighter and a fighting man does not
deserve to be killed like a sheep at the
behest of cowards and fool
you deserve a Warrior's death Abel
replied two hours from now midnight we
meet atop the tallest building in this
wretched City there and then that is
when you die at my hand with that Abel
turned and walked away Batman thought
about going after him tackling him to
the ground and restraining him but he
was still wounded he needed time to
recuperate I checked the records sir
there's no mention of any metahuman with
the power to create weapons on either
the Argus or Star Labs databases Alfred
explained over Batman's earpiece after a
quick Retreat to the cave to tend to his
injury Bruce was already racing back out
into the night careening through the
streets of Gotham in the Batmobile what
about the foundation that Abel mentioned
he asked Alfred not much luck either
there Master Bruce his faithful Butler
answered there is one mention of an
organization called the SCP Foundation
in an old August document but the
majority of the foul has been redacted
the only reference to it is an addendum
that someone must have forgotten to
remove good work Alfred Batman responded
there's only one person in the city who
might be able to give me more
information oh heavens you don't mean
who else has a knack for knowing too
much the cell was quiet lit only by the
low flickering of fluorescent bulbs that
hung from the ceiling of Arkham Asylum
it had been hours since the guards had
called for the inmates to go to bed
although they were no less alert any one
of them could break out at any time and
there was one who'd been waiting for his
chance rather patiently riddle me this
Edward said aloud aware of a figure
approaching his cell I am always around
but unseen I'm often avoided but never
outrun I could find you at the end of
the road or even the next corner what am
I death Batman answered monotonously to
what do I owe the pleasure Dark Knight
The Riddler asked I need information the
cape Crusader replied and you've got
more than your fair share after a decade
of rivalry detective decides to come
crawling to me for answers to offer some
recognition of my Brilliance not
Brilliance Edward persistence he
corrected
your cheerias ever the SCP Foundation
what do you know he peered over the rim
of his glasses offering Batman a wry
smile if you know me you'll want to
share me if you if you share me I'll be
gone what am I he asked a secret are
they certainly are Edward exploded with
laughter the foundation are an art Bunch
they'd even make some of the patients
here at good old Arkham seem sane by
comparison think of them as the resident
experts in unusual phenomena anomalies
they call them the maniac obsessed with
Mind Games explained they are everywhere
all across the world an organization
older and with more reach than any
you've encountered you know me oh my the
things they have locked away monsters
that would scare even you Batman how do
I know this isn't one of your delusions
Riddler Batman barked banging a fist
against the bars to intimidate his
Nemesis don't insult me Dark Knight you
and I both know that you wouldn't have
come to see me if you were going to
disbelieve what I had to say the Riddler
yelled and mark my words if the
foundation has it sights on you well
riddle me this
already Batman had turned and started
walking away down the corridor my
inventor doesn't want me the man who
bought me won't need me and the man who
needs me doesn't know it what am I the
Dark Knight paused a few feet from the
cell a coffin it could all be a
trickster Alfred urged as Bruce Departed
the Asylum Edward nashton is hardly a
reliable source of information he has a
compulsion to always prove himself as
the smartest to always be right Batman
replied what I still can't understand is
why this Foundation would Send Abel to
kill me what's the connection between
them and me perhaps Master Bruce it's
less what connects you and more how you
could be an obstacle to them the butler
reasoned if this Foundation are experts
in unusual phenomena then there are an
abundance of such things here in Gotham
everything from the copious super
criminals to the giant coin here in the
bat cave then with me out of the way
Batman began to catch on they'd have
free reign Alfred finished the sentence
in sending a Madman to kill you it's
clear they didn't come to play fair sir
the clock tower in the middle of Gotham
let out an ominous bong marking the
approach of midnight the neither will I
Batman replied Abel had been waiting
atop the roof of a skyscraper the name
Wayne Enterprises emblazoned on its
front it was almost midnight there were
minutes left but the barbarian was still
confident the bat would show he could
almost taste the adrenaline of their
looming battle anticipating their final
showdown Abel could hardly wait to have
a worthy opponent to best in combat the
sound of some kind of advanced aircraft
whooshed overhead and the barbaric
Warrior craned his neck upwards soaring
above was the Bat Plane set against the
backdrop of the night sky with a single
beam of light reaching up into the
clouds projecting the dark Knight's
Insignia above the bat signal
parachuting down Batman had donned a
heavily armored battle suit over his
costume it originally designed it to go
to the toe with Superman encased his
closest Ally ever went rogue but the
Armor's bulkier plating would easily be
more resistant to the Ferocious damage
Abel could dish out he landed on the
rooftop with a thud as Abel geared in
disgust coward he spat you are not the
honorable fighter I miss took you for
just another Pretender like that
Luchador giving yourself an advantage
rather than relying on your skill are
you so afraid of me that you'd encase
yourself in armor are you afraid that
you'll lose Batman replied calmly
roaring in Anger Abel charged towards
Batman pulling a fresh pair of swords
from his pocket Dimension he swung the
blades through the air only for them to
clang off the thick plating protecting
the cape Crusader's arms as he lifted
his gauntlets to block the incoming
attacks immediately feral bloodthirsty
rage on his face Abel swiped again this
time directing his weapon to a tiny Gap
where Batman's helmet met the rest of
his suit at the neck the sword stayed
locked between the armor only for Batman
to pull back and launch a devastating
punch that sent Abel's staggering back I
built this suit to survive hits from a
Kryptonian trust me you won't even
scratch it Batman declared give it up
Abel walk away tell the foundation to
stay out of Gotham seeing red noticing
one of his weapons was still stuck at
the joint in Batman's armor Abel let out
a mighty yell and ran towards his
adversary stomping forward to clash with
him head on Batman started moving as
fast as the bulky bat suit would allow
him but moments before the pair of them
collided Abel dropped skidding along the
rooftop under Batman's legs using the
size and weight of his opponent's armor
to his Advantage just like he had done
with Bane earlier before Batman had a
chance to turn around Abel leaped onto
his feet and grabbed his cape pulling
the Dark Knight over and causing his
heavy armor to topple Batman clattered
down onto his back and Abel gripped the
sword that had gotten stuck with one
hand gripping the bat by his cape the
Barbarian used the other to grab his
weapon try trying to lever off his
opponent's protective helmet struggling
to get himself free Batman reached for
his belt throwing a barrage of batarangs
that spun through the air only to return
and strike Abel in the chest he barely
registered the impact shrugging off the
projectiles as if they were made of
paper you cannot win even if you could
best me I always come back evil grunted
feeling his sword breaking through the
joint in Batman's armor I am able I am
Immortal but underneath all your tools
and tricks you are nothing but a man now
do what men do and die a sudden winding
blow struck able Square in the chest
Batman had activated the heartbeat
sensors in his helmet's eyepieces and
sent both his armor-plated fists
rocketing upwards connecting with the
barbarian's heart reeling Abel staggered
back trying to catch his breath as
Batman stood to his feet the hulking
unmistakable silhouette towering over
the immortal Warrior I'm not just a man
he growled I am then
bam his words were punctuated by another
devastating punch to the same spot I am
the Knight pow once more The Dark Knight
struck Abel in the heart sending him
closer to the edge of the roof I am
Batman A thundercrack Rang out as Abel
looked up wheezing at his adversary you
you will not kill me back he rasped no I
won't Batman answered leaning in close
you always come back with a final
uppercut he knocked Abel over the ledge
sending the Barbarian careening down
into the Gotham Reservoir below despite
being exhausted from their encounter
Batman scoured the reservoir for any
signs of Abel's remains he couldn't find
anything there was no body but Something
Told The Dark Knight that the undying
Barbarian would be back from a distant
rooftop a pair of foundation operatives
were watching through night vision
scopes wow that seemed a little
excessive one remarked to the other
didn't think he was the type to show off
but I don't think he was showing off the
other replied I think that was a warning
the thin pale humanoid anomaly had just
found itself in Minecraft of all places
the all too familiar whale of emergency
alarms rang out through the corridors of
the foundation facility it had happened
again another containment breach of
course the on-site Personnel were more
than familiar with the protocols for a
situation like this so well-versed in
what to do during an emergency that it
had become second nature whether they
were research staff evacuating for their
own safety or security teams moving in
to recapture the escaped anomaly and get
the situation under control everyone was
moving like they had been programmed
muscle memory taking over the loose
anomaly was none other than
scp-096 all Foundation Personnel were
alerted and reminded not to look
directly at the creature there was just
one problem they couldn't look even if
they'd ignored their order to try nobody
could because the shy guy was nowhere to
to be found well nowhere in the real
world at least this whole situation
bizarre even by foundation's standards
had all started with an experiment
involving a member of the Disposable
d-class Personnel yet another dangerous
convict serving one of several life
sentences now being used as an
Expendable human lab rat for the
foundation's often Sinister purposes the
experiment in question was an attempt to
further test the limitation of
scp-096's abilities by now the
foundation had done extensive research
into the creature known as the shy guy
they knew its particular brand of
anomalous qualities were triggered when
anyone looked directly at it being
observed would instantaneously send
scp-096 into an uncontrollable rage
State causing it to pursue its Observer
until they were no longer standing
scp-096 was known to be able to travel
at speeds so relentless it was pretty
much impossible to stop one moment it
was sobbing in screeching in its cell
having just been observed and minutes
later the wide jawed long-limed monster
was standing behind whoever had seen it
making its screaming face the image its
victim took to the Grave with them
Foundation researchers knew that
scp-096's rage State could be triggered
by as little as someone seeing the
slightest hint of a creature even if the
shy guy had been captured as a tiny
Speck in the background of a photograph
it would come after anyone whose eyes so
much as glanced over that Speck it also
didn't matter how far away the Observer
was
scp-096 could not be outrun it could
track down anyone wherever they were in
the world but what if a person who had
observed the shy guy was no longer in
the world the experiment had taken a lot
of trial and error after all digitizing
a human being and transforming their
entire Consciousness into code was no
easy task but the foundation was an
above breaking more than a few eggs to
make an omelet especially when those
eggs were the brains of a few d-class
Personnel actually the first test
subjects turned out more scrambled or
fried certainly overdone given the
amount of smoke coming from their ears
but eventually the research team had
perfected the device they dubbed the
neural harness a headset that could
translate a person's mind into pure
digital code their Consciousness would
be extracted from their body leaving
their physical form an empty shell while
a digital copy of them was able to
Traverse the local on-site computer
network of course the foundation wasn't
about to let a digitized d-class run
amok with their systems so their coding
experts wrote a number of specialized
parameters into their successful test
subject now the digital d-class could be
programmed to follow the foundation's
directive from his perspective it was
like he was floating through cyberspace
towards the system that the foundation
had directed him to a surveillance
camera inside
scp-096's cell that usually remained
inactive but not today the k camera
blinked to life as soon as the d-class
is code-based consciousness reached it
and through it it was able to observe as
cp096 sitting against the far wall of
its containment chamber gently
whimpering and walking back and forth
that is until the creature felt that
same familiar sensation of being watched
it stood up enraged wailing
uncontrollably as the d-class watched
from within the camera then a split
second later
scp-096 appeared to Blink out of
existence it hadn't worked the
experiment had failed and the digital
d-class began to panic before the
foundation coders could stop him he
frantically scoured the local network
for anything some kind of Escape Route
back into the real world maybe he
thought if he could get back into his
body it wouldn't count technically his
digital self was separate from his
physical form so he might get out of
scp-096's clutches on a technicality but
it was impossible his body was already
burned out by the neural harness us
there was no way for the d-class to
transfer himself back there was only one
option left hide and as it turned out
someone had forgotten to uninstall a
certain building game from a computer in
one of the foundation doctor's offices
the d-classes digitized mind zapped him
into Minecraft from his point of view it
was like he existed within the game
itself he did a computerized equivalent
of breathing a sigh of relief only to
take back all those ones and zeroes in a
horrified gasp as he noticed a tall wiry
frame figure before him it hadn't worked
scp-096 had still managed to follow him
into Minecraft even in a world of
computer code the shy guy was able to
dispatch its digital Observer quite
easily in what had once been a living
human mind in the form of binary code
was quickly deleted but that's when
scp-096 started to take notice of its
surroundings but the most recent person
to see it gone it had the chance to
actually take in where it was the bright
rays of warm light coming down from a
cube-shaped sun reveal a welcoming
landscape all around constructed
entirely from cubes it fascinated
scp-096 instilling a kind of childlike
Wonder in the shy guy the likes of which
it hadn't experienced since well since
it couldn't remember when rather than
leaving instantly reappearing in its
containment chamber
scp-096 made the conscious decision to
start exploring there was a mountainous
biome surrounding scp-096 Stoney spiers
reaching up towards a clear sky with a
waterfall cascading its way down the
nearest of them at the foot of the
mountains was the opening of a cave
which the shy guy found itself wandering
towards the light from the sun while a
pleasant and welcoming change to the
surroundings it was used to was a little
harsh on scp-096's sunken eyes so
instead it began to gravitate towards
the shadowy confines of the caves not
unlike the usual darkness of its
containment chamber back back at the
foundation traversing through long
winding corridors of stone as cp096
found itself having to bend down to
avoid hitting its head on the Cave's low
ceiling obviously this formation of
Rocky blocks had informed with someone
of the shy guy's height in mind there
was a low Warm Glow coming from the
farthest side of the tunnel and the thin
creature made its way closer and closer
despite the stone walls around it
feeling like a tighter confinement than
its cell approaching the source of the
light
scp-096 was relieved that the cave
opened out into a more spacious area the
grand tunnel giving way to an expansive
chamber that lay within the heart of the
mountain the warm orangey glow that had
been coming from a flowing stream of
boiling hot lava that seemed to trickle
down from somewhere above creating a
deadly fiery pool directly in the Shy
Guy's path but just before it could turn
back and leave the cave through the way
he came
scp-096 sensed that familiar feeling of
something observing him across the lava
pool on the other side was a creature
comprised of a green Cube for a head
with a long armless cuboid body and four
cubed feet if it had been present in the
real world it might have been made out
of leaves like a living shrub it was
staring directly at the shy guy from
across the lava only for this strange
newcomer to disappear a moment later the
creeper hissed before it realized that
scp-096 had leaped up behind it to land
a fatal blow but little did the
infamously anxious anomaly realized that
the sentient shrub wasn't done there was
a colossal boom that caused scp-096 to
stagger backwards whimpering at the
sudden loud explosion and the pain that
had accompanied it the creeper had blown
itself to Pieces but in doing so had
left a lasting injury that caused
scp-096 considerable discomfort as it
began limping towards the cave that led
out the opposite side of the mountain
despite its injury the shy guy was still
able to move with relative ease and the
further it went the more it seemed to
gradually heal however it was as it
stepped out once more into the sunlight
that the creature realized just how
hungry it was back in the real world it
hadn't eaten for several hours and
surprisingly even while accidentally
stuck in digitized form the hunger
mechanics of Minecraft were having an
effect on
scp-096 the shy guy started searching
around for anything that could prove to
satiate its hunger there was a Grove of
trees not far so scp-096 lumbered to
take a closer look it couldn't be
certain but it felt there was at least a
slim chance that there were apples
growing amongst the leaves but even at
the anomaly's own elongated height it
couldn't simply reach up to pick them
however it was while swiping its arms up
at the tree that the shy guy swung its
Fist and knocked at the tree trunk to
the creature's surprise who was able to
chip away at the wood with its hands
punching at the tree until the trunk had
been reduced to a collection of wooden
blocks the shy guy was able to collect
and sure enough some red apples dropped
from the leaves above enough to quell
the hunger that scp-096 was feeling at
least for the time being nearby
something was moving through the trees
it was yet to lock eyes on scp-096 but
the second it did the mob would surely
have sealed its own fate as it moved
around minding its own business the tall
figure overheard the sounds of the shy
guy eating and its attention was drawn
to where the creature was standing
enjoying an apple sensing that it had
been seen as cp096 turned and locked
eyes with the entity it was perhaps the
only other being in Minecraft that was a
similar height and stature to the
anomaly itself in fact the pair were
strikingly similar before scp-096 could
carry out its usual method of attack the
Enderman suddenly teleported out of view
but it was too late now both it and the
shy guy had looked at the other's face
both had been provoked and were
compelled to react in exactly the same
way just as scp-096 entered its rage
State the Enderman 2 opened its mouth
and began to shake making loud lengthy
sounds not dissimilar to the Shy Guy's
own angered screams but something
profoundly strange happened next
scp-096 and the Enderman kept attempting
to pursue one another appearing in a new
location within the Minecraft world
neither one getting close enough to the
other they'd teleport only for the other
to teleport away the moment they saw
each other each trying to catch one
another but only staying one step behind
this rapid Chase almost became a strange
ongoing sort of teleporting dance
between
scp-096 and the Enderman at first the
shy guy had been compelled to attack the
Enderman like it was with any who looked
directly at it but as they appeared and
disappeared from place to place the
creature started to feel an odd kinship
with this shadowy fellow it was so used
to being frightened and alone to its
overwhelming feelings of insecurity and
self-loathing that the Simplicity of
just traversing the open world for the
creature very alike itself in many ways
it had all come as a welcome change
scp-096 found it therapeutic even and
before long was following the Enderman
not out of any intention to do it harm
but just to feel for a little while like
it had a friend just a little bit longer
scp-096 thought welcoming the enjoyment
it felt playing this game of Minecraft
here's something that everyone at the
SCP Foundation knows portals to another
world located in Indiana are incredibly
bad news the best example being
scp-2935 the Limestone Cavern in Indiana
that leads to a dimension where all life
has ended and death Reigns Supreme so
considering the importance of keeping
things like this under control we've
decided to fire up the animatron 6000
and simulate sending one of the
foundation's most reliable senior
researchers Dr Charles Ogden gears to
investigate another dimensional anomaly
this time in a little town called
Hawkins Indiana conductor gears in his
younger years hold his own against the
demogorgon demma dogs the Mind flare and
even vekna himself let's fire up the
machine and find out it was November of
1983 and Dr gears awoke to a call on his
home phone ordinarily he liked to start
his day with a cold shower and a cup of
plain black coffee but on this
particular very early morning he was
yanked out of a lovely dreamless sleep
by the sound of his Superior at the SCP
Foundation guess there's something
strange going on in this town in Indiana
We're putting together a task force and
you're going to lead it what's been
going on we don't know much yet but
there have been reports of strange
noises unusual activity the local kids
gone missing that was all Dr gears
needed to hear alright we'll start
packing he placed the phone back in the
receiver brood himself that cup of
coffee hopped in the shower and filled a
suitcase with all of his usual
Necessities flannel pajamas five white
lab coats plain slacks and shirts and
one pair of sensible shoes he dressed in
an identical outfit to the ones lining
the inside of his slate gray suitcase
combed his hair and straightened his tie
and that was that he was ready for
whatever awaited him on this new Mission
when the official SCP Foundation issued
Transportation came to pick him up one
of the task force members handed him a
dossier and a thermos filled with more
coffee enough to sustain him for the
drive so Dr gears flipped open the file
taking a look inside where we headed
don't know too much about it sir the man
shrunk some little Podunk place called
Hawkins Dr gears spent the drive to
Hawkins Indiana looking over the few
details the foundation knew so far their
interest had been peaked when a young
boy will Byers disappeared mysteriously
on a bike ride home from a friend's
house in addition to the missing persons
report townspeople had called the
authorities to complain about strange
noises and there were rumors of a secret
research project being conducted by the
US government in the area all of these
factors combined to make Hawkins a
potential hotbed for anomalous activity
and a place of significant interest to
the SCP Foundation Dr gears would be
tasked with setting up a temporary
Foundation site in town disguised as the
headquarters of a new landscaping
business leading a group of researchers
in the investigation of the buyer's
disappearance as well as cataloging
other potential anomalies present in the
town they were to remain there
indefinitely and to ensure their work
would not be compromised they were given
strict instructions not to draw any
unnecessary attention to themselves from
civilians or operatives from any
government organizations with an
established presence in the town as Dr
gears and his team rolled into the town
he was struck by how completely
absolutely ordinary it was they passed
the town hall the library a general
store a movie theater one sleepy little
Pub packed with a few regulars a hunting
and camping supply store a few
diversions for the kids and young at
heart like the arcade schools all
Hallmarks of classic American small town
normalcy as they drove out into the
forest around the town however away from
the friendly veneer of Suburbia Dr gear
spotted something unusual something he
made a note of the second he caught a
glimpse of it there was a large official
looking building surrounded by barbed
wire and armed military guards what's
that there he asked one of his
assistants uh Hawkins National
Laboratory she replied says here they're
under the jurisdiction of the Department
of energy
was all he said he would make sure to
send someone out to investigate once
they were all settled properly after
several years at the foundation he had
something of a sixth sense for detecting
things that didn't seem to belong this
place was not what it claimed to be by
Nightfall Dr gears and his team of six
officers had settled into their
foundation-provided housing located
across the street from their front
business privately Dr gears hoped that
the people of Hawkins weren't especially
interested in landscaping he didn't know
a damn thing about Hedges or whatever
else that job entailed while the SCP
Foundation maintained a steady quiet
presence in Hawkins the anomalous
activity only escalated there were
reports of a monster a giant horrible
thing with a humanoid build and a face
like an open flower filled with teeth
doctor gears and four members of the
team attempted to track down one of
these creatures hoping to bring it into
custody and study it up close and
outside of the home of the missing boy
they finally came face to face with the
thing the predatory creature was tall
and thin with elongated limbs ending in
sharp claws it reminded doctor gear is a
bit of an anomaly he had seen in passing
though he had never seen that thing's
face this Beast however gave him an up
close and personal look at first glance
its head looked like the closed butt of
a flower with no discernible features
however as it prepared to attack letting
out an unearthly Screech fleshy Powers
unfurled revealing rows of razor sharp
teeth and a gaping maw of a mouth the
officers opened fire immediately but
their bullets did little to deter the
advancing creature they only seemed to
make it Angry before they could
apprehend the creature or more likely
find themselves pulled into its wide
open mouth they were interrupted by a
group of surprisingly enterprising
children luring it away seeming to trap
it two teenage boys and a girl managed
to light the beast on fire and send it
retreating back to wherever it came from
Dr gears and his stayed out of sight as
one of them remarked I guess the
children really are our future meanwhile
the other two officers were following up
on reports of a strange girl appearing
in town as if from nowhere it was
difficult to separate rumor from reality
admits talk of secret government mind
experiments roving gangs of children and
something to do with Eggo waffles but
they managed to trace the person of
interest to the local Middle School they
arrived at the middle school just in
time to watch the girl use apparent
psychic abilities to fend off government
operatives before the same monster
arrived to Massacre the men as the two
operatives watched from a distance
hidden just out of sight they prepare to
apprehend the monster and administer
amnestics to the children present but
before they could the girl in The
Monster were gone shortly after this
incident will Byers was reportedly
returned to his home but Dr keirs
couldn't leave Hawkins just yet not with
so many new questions unanswered where
have the buyer's boy been in all this
time what was the creature they had
encountered where had it come from what
had that unusually powerful girl done
with it and most importantly with more
follow in the beast's footsteps coming
to snatch more children from the streets
with authorization from the SCP
Foundation Dr gears reached out to Dr
Owens at the mysterious laboratory he
offered to share the information they
had managed to gather if Dr Owens would
provide him with full transparency and
do the same Owens was hesitant but after
being subjected to one of Dr gears's
trademark hour-long lectures consisting
of reasoned logical extremely dry
arguments he relented Dr gears
celebrated this little Triumph and Dr
Owens reported a persistent headache
after listening to the other man prattle
on for such a long time Dr gears and his
team now had concrete information to
share with their higher-ups at the
foundation they learned all about the
gateway to another world that the
scientists had opened at the lab the
creatures that had come through its
Supernatural doorway and the connection
to the psychic girl that had disappeared
at the middle school now that an open
line of communication had been
established Dr gears was working to
convince Owens and the rest of the
scientists at the lab to allow him to
use their portal it was his intention to
take his team of six operatives through
the Gateway into this other world there
he would be able to create a first-hand
report for the foundation allowing them
to categorize the various creatures
inside and perhaps the strange new
dimension itself however just after Dr
Owens and his staff agreed to allow an
SCP Foundation Expedition into the
upside down as it was colloquially
called disaster struck a presence from
the other side of the gate use the
buyer's boy to infiltrate the laboratory
dispatching a group of juvenile
creatures to attack the scientists there
Dr gears was inside when it happened
looking through some of the official
reports he had been granted access to
suddenly there were sounds of chaos from
down the hall streaks of Terror and
Agony he peered through the window of
the room to see quadrupedal almost
canine variations of the larger monster
bounding down the hallway leaving a
trail of blood in their wake remembering
his commitment to avoid involving
himself unless absolutely necessary Dr
gears barricaded the door and hid from
the creatures as they ripped through the
rest of the lab the dog-like monsters
tore the lab staff apart and injured Dr
Owens in the process then in retaliation
the psychic girl closed the gate between
the worlds in doing so she removed the
threat of the monsters tearing Dr Gear's
limb from limb as they had so many
others but the damage was done just the
same if that wasn't bad enough a tape of
Dr Owen speaking candidly about the
lab's activity was leaked to the local
media and the laboratory was promptly
shut down for good with it it seemed all
the foundation's access to the anomalies
and Hawkins were lost still in spite of
these new obstacles Dr gears refused to
give up there were terribly strange
things afoot in Hawkins and he had been
sent there to uncover them he was going
to continue to do his job until some
Authority told him otherwise besides he
had gotten quite used to living
undercover in this little town he didn't
get out much but he hadn't gotten out
all that much before Hawkins either it
was nice to settle into small town life
where very little ever changed until the
star Court Mall opened local businesses
began to close disrupting Dr gears's
routine and causing him a great deal of
irritation and then of course there was
the matter of the secret Russian
laboratory beneath that mall which
Unleashed a malevolent entity from the
upside down into the town the foundation
team watched as yet again The Familiar
group of civilians neutralized the
threat and closed the gateway to the
other world several of Dr gears's
assistants suggested interrogating the
civilians or at the very least giving
them amnestics to make them forget what
they had seen Dr gears ever the stickler
for the rules reminded them that they
had been given strict orders not to
interfere if the threat moved outside of
the bounds of Hawkins that would be one
thing for now it seemed fairly well
contained in fact it seemed as if all of
it might be over for good the buyer's
family left town for California and life
in town settled back into a mundane
Rhythm or at least it did until the
murders began first a well-liked
cheerleader found mutilated in the
trailer then an ambitious student
reporter the town flew into chaos
blaming anything they could think of for
the horrific losses Dungeons and Dragons
the Misunderstood tabletop role-playing
game was a convenient scapegoat but of
course Dr gears knew better this was the
influence of something from the other
side something not of this plane if only
he could get back through the gate and
finally take a look for himself Dr gears
was not a Praying kind of man but his
quiet wishes were answered when one of
his men returned to headquarters after
taking a swim in a nearby lake he ran
through the door still sopping wet sir
he pounded you're going to want to see
this please get a towel first Dr gears
insisted you're dripping all over the
floor it's hardwood show some decency
after the man was sufficiently dry Dr
gears brought the team to investigate
the lake there at the bottom of the
water was an ominous red glow a gate he
couldn't be sure how or why it had
opened on its own down there but an
opportunity had finally presented itself
he called the superiors at the
foundation suited up in protective gear
complete with pistols and waterproof
communication systems and Dove down into
the water three officers right behind
him the other three would remain on the
other side ready to call for backup or
swiftly flee town if anything went
sideways finally Dr gears would lead an
expedition into the upside down as I
swam toward the bottom of the lake into
the gate to the unknown writhing black
tendrils slithered out from the opening
snaking around the three men
accompanying him and yanking them
through Dr gears was an excellent
swimmer the monotony of laps in his
local pool being one of his favorite
ways to maintain top-notch physical
shape and he spent through the water
after them when he entered the gate he
suddenly emerged into a dark facsimile
of the world he had just left behind he
peered through the visor of his suit
taking in his surroundings it was a cold
shadowy landscape shaped vaguely like
Hawkins but alien and foreboding more of
those vine-like tentacles curled along
the ground and gray spores drifted
through the air like falling snow the
cries of strange creatures filled the
air drowned out only by the pain screams
of the three men he had followed through
the gate Dr gears looked around for the
source of the sound and spotted it the
three members of personnel were
struggling to free themselves from the
grip of the ropey tendrils that had
pulled them inside and as they did
winged creatures were descending on them
from above on all sides they vaguely
resembled bats with flapping leathery
wings but faces their mouths were
completely unlike anything Dr gears had
ever seen with the exception of the
other monsters that had crossed through
the rift from this place and into his
own world these badlike creatures were
swarming his team biting at their flesh
as the men helplessly tried to fend them
off there was only one thing left to do
Dr gears drew his weapon and fired into
the sky at the teeming mass of wings and
teeth the bad things reacted and turned
their attention to him his Marksmanship
did not miss however and he managed to
take out a dozen or so the Vermin before
his men could free themselves and come
to his Aid two of his men at least one
unfortunately succumbed to his wounds
and would have to be left behind it was
a shame of course but he knew what he
was signing up for when he joined the
ranks of the foundation it was then that
Dr gears remembered something else he
had brought with him inspired by the
victory he had witnessed all that time
ago the only thing that had sent the
monster back to hell was fire so he
strapped a foundation-issued
flamethrower to his back he drew this
secondary weapon the flamethrower and
sent a blast of flames soaring through
the air barbecuing the bats to a crisp
would the threat dispelled at least
temporarily he'd beckoned the men to
follow him through the unforgiving
landscape making note of everything he
saw for each and every detail that made
Hawkins memorable there was an
equivalent to it here covered in those
strange spores and a layer of palpable
malice as the group made their way
through the upside down Dr gears at the
front they spotted what appeared to be
the remains of the teenagers whose
deaths were being investigated by the
town that were bound up in the vines
left on display but by what or more
likely by Who Doctor gears could not see
any other sign of human life here as his
mind began to wander running through the
possibilities something caught his
attention a long loud clear sound like
the ringing of church bells no not quite
like the chime of a grandfather clock it
rang once twice three times a fourth he
couldn't see a clock anywhere but the
sound appeared to be coming from a
massive house up ahead nestled within
the trees Eerie red light just barely
illuminated the place's silhouette but
as gears and his remaining to assistants
approached he could see that it was a
stately home now an obvious disrepair he
had somehow missed its Earthbound
equivalent and had never seen the place
before but here it was the door standing
open as if beckoning him inside wait
here keep watch you know that to the
officers behind him I'll take it from
here with the pistol in one hand and the
other poised and ready to draw the
flamethrower at a moment's notice he
stepped into the house he was right to
have his weapon drawn no sooner had he
stepped inside that the vines coiled
around his ankles one winding around his
throat and squeezing with a few quick
shots he was able to force them to
recede and continue his investigation he
climbed the creaky stairs to the attic
looking for signs of new life he briefly
thought of trying to use his
Communicator to check in with the men on
the other side but when he pressed its
buttons it only emitted White Noise it
was a favorite sound of his when he
vastly preferred to to the cacophony of
music but now is not the time he
switched it back off and carried on
alone then just as he crossed the
threshold into the attic he heard it
again the chime of the clock in the
corner of his eye he spotted it an
antique grandfather clock before he
could react to that though he heard a
voice behind him daddy he turned to see
a little girl staring up at him why are
you leaving us don't you love us he was
too stunned to speak the little girl's
eyes turned white her face dripping like
melting wax as she repeated why did you
leave why why why he couldn't explain it
but his heart began to pound he could
taste blood in the back of his throat
behind the little girl a figure emerged
human in shape only a twisted face and
form made of exposed muscle and more of
those awful tentacle Vines approaching
him slowly it haunts you doesn't it
doctor when you didn't to your family
the figure asked in a menacing voice
finally Dr gear has found the ability to
speak again this all seems like a bit
much don't you think he didn't have much
patience for pageantary of any kind and
he certainly didn't appreciate this what
is this some sort of psionic Mind prison
The Entity that Dr gears had no name for
but those determined kids from Hawkins
knew as vechna tilted its head to the
side quizzically I can see your heart I
know the darkness within you it hissed
Dr gears reached down for his
Communicator giving it one more shot as
the entity approached him was slow
threatening steps as it reached its
fingers towards his face he flipped a
switch and that lovely white noise
blared to life suddenly the little
vision of the girl was on the clock
stopped chiming vechna was still there
though glowering at Dr gears with a
mixture of Fury and just plain
irritation I have more important things
to attend to than you go back to your
world while you still can with a flick
of his wrist vechna threw Dr gears back
down the stairs and out the front door
of the house where his assistants were
still dutifully waiting Dr gears Was
preparing to inform them of his
Discovery when he heard several new
voices in the distance human and
familiar those same children were back
once again seemingly to save the day as
they had so many times before ever the
pragmatist Dr gears brushed himself off
and headed back in the direction he came
best to stay out of their way shortly
after Dr gears and his task force
withdrew from Hawkins Indiana returning
to their original Foundation sites they
could monitor the situation from afar
and in the meantime leave Hawkins to the
US government the Russians and that
constantly surprising group of Brave
clever civilians hell maybe a few of
them could be recruited to join the
foundation when they got a bit older
when asked to submit an official report
on his findings in Hawkins and his
recommendation for how the foundation
should proceed with the situation there
Dr gears simply wrote this to be
completely honest I think those kids
have got it covered the SCP Foundation
has gone up against a lot of anomalies
that can be best described as demonic
but few fit the bill better than the
demons and imps of
scp-5049 demon Dan's Discount homunculus
Depot a skin stealing Enterprise
designing bespoke demonic disguises on
the behalf of seven mysterious demon
Lords anyone that the foundation has
managed to capture related to this
anomaly has been assassinated by the
demon Lords eliminating the prospect of
further investigation but what if the
foundation brought in another expert to
hell a Bonafide expert in the occult
DC's devious demon detective himself
John Constantine maybe he can finally
give us the lead we need to bring down
those demon Lords once and for all and
with the help of the animatron 6000
we're going to find out exactly how that
situation would play out let's rev up
the machine and take a look it was a
cold night in New York if you've ever
been there you'll know that most nights
are but on this particular night a
certain chill was streaking its way
through the air as I see cold as the
grave this wasn't just a deathly gust of
wind or any other freak occurrence of
the weather though especially judging by
that piercing wailing shriek it gave as
it passed by I cry loud enough to wake
both the living and the dead alike and
hot on its tail chasing through the rain
dampened streets after it long trench
coat whipping behind him was the one
man's stupid enough to try and catch it
you see this thing he was chasing was a
spirit some might have called it a
Banshee or a yanaki baba but all our
coat clad friend called it was a right
bloody nuisance as for who in heaven and
hell or on Earth he was that's easy if
you were to rummage through the pockets
of his coat you'd find the answer along
with an interesting assortment of
mystical objects beneath the charms and
trinkets that he carried on this person
was a crumpled off-white business card
printed on its surface in simple black
lettering was one name John Constantine
and underneath along with a phone number
were the words Exorcist demonologist and
master of the dark arts although the
word master has been crossed out with
Petty dabbler written above our friend
John really hated putting on heirs he
turned down an Alleyway just as the
spirit did it screams Rippling through
the silence dead end there was nothing
but a solid wall ahead not that it
mattered the shrieking entity lacked a
physical corporeal form but the sight of
an obstacle in its path caused it to
pause just for a split second a short
moment as it tried to think over or
through and that tiny little instance of
hesitation well that's what John had
been waiting for as he ran towards the
spirit he reached into his coat pocket
pulling out a lighter its surface was
engraved with a phrase in Latin that
read Fiat eustitia at pariat Mundus
meaning let Justice be done though the
world may perish that had long been
John's Credo to stop at nothing to
achieve righteous Justice no matter what
the cost or how bad things got
admittedly that was a little easier to
accomplish when you owned a blessed
liner striking at John breathlessly
uttered an incantation to command the
Holy Fire Within his hand caught Ablaze
as he took hold of the flame barely
feeling the pain of it burning casting
it towards the screeching Spirit a
bright orange streak shot forward and
then snare of the runaway creature it
hovered above the ground thriving and
thrashing in the air as it struggled to
free itself from its fiery bonds shaking
his hand to extinguish it Jon reached
into his other pocket looking for the
small jar he'd put there to his horror
the glass container was gone Constantine
frantically patted the outside of his
coat trying but unable to find it he
must have dropped it during their Chase
and without the jar he had nothing to
trap the spirit in typical he grumbled
to himself turning to look at the
shrieking Specter wriggling its way out
of the flame Jon looked around for
something anything he could use to
contain it finally he spotted something
left discarded in the alleyway it was an
empty Whiskey Bottle filthy and covered
in Grime well suppose this will have to
do Constantine said aloud to no one than
himself he was a bit of a fan of his own
voice even if his overconfidence did
regularly cross the line into arrogance
placing the bottleneck up on a dry patch
of ground John Hurley pulled a piece of
chalk from his pocket he started to Mark
the asphalt creating a circle around the
bottle symbols taken from ancient
languages and magical texts surrounding
the unlikely vessel his hands at his
sides Constantine took a deep breath and
began muttering in Aramaic to the
untrained era would have sounded like an
incomprehensible incantation although in
no uncertain terms Jon was just telling
the spirit to pack it in and get in the
bottle before you wake the whole city
with a final Screech of dissatisfaction
The Entity was pulled into its cramped
new home like a mystical vacuum cleaner
sucking up a cloud of dust with an
exhausted sigh Jon knelt down to pick up
the bottle the glass surface was warm to
the touch now that the shrieking Spirit
was contained inside
Beyond putting the bottle in the pocket
of his trench coat he had a nice cozy
shelf back in the house of mystery where
he could keep this Troublesome siren and
let it gather dust trapped and unable to
cause harm to any mortal ever again but
it was just as Jon Was preparing a spell
to transport himself back to his base of
operations but his cell phone started to
ring hello he answered bluntly he was
too tired for whatever this was
um hi is that Mr Constantine a female
voice as from the other end of the life
depends on who wants to know love John
replied my name's Emma a friend of mine
gave me your card they said that she
paused sound like she was sniffling they
said that you could help me get my
brother back as much as it had already
been a long night and even though he
might often act like he didn't care Jon
was rarely heartless enough to turn down
a request for his help giving another
sigh Jon told Emma he'd look into it but
she'd need to give him the full story in
person the coffee shop was one of the
few open this early as mornings started
to Dawn over the city all of New York
was gearing up for another day of hustle
and bustle people shoving past each
other to ride the subway to jobs they
hated stepping inside with his usual air
of swagger and bravado John spotted Emma
sitting and waiting for him she had a
mug of coffee in her hands but wasn't
drinking it the lack of steam seemed to
indicate it was already Stone Cold you
must be Emma he greeted her doing his
best impression of a friendly smile
extending a handshake John Constantine
At Your Service oh hello Emma responded
awkwardly accepting the Shay you sure I
can't get you anything stronger Jon
offered as he sat down opposite stronger
it's eight o'clock in the morning isn't
it a bit early for that she asked never
too early in my book John chuckled dryly
picking up a menu and scanning his eyes
over it here we are breakfast lunch or
never battled demons on an empty stomach
so what can I do for you ever yes not
even looking up from the menu still have
focused on what he was going to order
well then it began like I said over the
phone something happened to my brother
burn off Diddy Constantine interjected
yes and no not exactly she sounded
confused like she was aware that when
she was attempting to describe wouldn't
make any sense when she said it out loud
he did disappear for a few days actually
we've been living together since our
parents died in this tiny little
apartment so we can tell when one of us
has left it was like one moment he was
there and the next he wasn't sounds like
a pretty run-of-the-mill missing
person's case love John's side not
exactly my department you're best going
off to the compass for something like
that I tried that Emma raised her voice
slightly getting agitated or scared I
told the cops Ethan was missing and they
filed the report but they dropped the
case when he John thought about making
another snide comment to get her to
finish her sentence the toes to wait
instead he came home
just like that a few days later the
police questioned Ethan and asked him
where he'd been and he just told them he
had gone to a hotel for a few nights she
explained open and shut then John
Shrugged except the thing that came back
it's not my brother Emma continued
trying to hold back frightened tears it
looks like him and even sounds like him
but it's not Ethan if you think
something happened to him Constantine
pondered maybe I don't know about
possessions and demons and all that
stuff but I was told you might be able
to help as much as I'd love to help you
out I'm afraid I need a little more to
go on than that John admitted a tiny
shred of sympathy in his tired eyes I
recorded this Emma exclaimed producing
her phone that's part of what made me
call you since he came back Ethan well
not Ethan he started staying up late at
night doing what exactly the Paranormal
detective asked chanting she answered
hitting play on her phone the audio
recording started it was Fame but John
could just about hear someone growling
it was a human voicemail as expected but
it sounded all wrong Ethan or whatever
was pretending to be him was making
noises closer to that of a wild animal
than a person speaking in a garbled
unintelligible tongue that sounded
distinctly demonic to John's experienced
ears what was he doing the night before
it disappeared he asked after a solemn
moment's pause just sitting at home
watching TV nothing out of the ordinary
Emma answered but specifically John said
with urgency in his voice what was he
watching uh I I don't know she exclaimed
it was just flicking through channels
but there was hardly anything on that
late except ads leaning back in his seat
John tutted to himself shaking his head
demon Dan you old culture he muttered it
was demon Dan I'mma asked I'm sure sorry
love John replied dodging the question
but your brother's gone and right now
there's some nasty blighter from the
pits of Hell itself using his skin as
its own personal human disguise we need
to find it and send them all the way
down south South I'm Echo too confused
to cry you mean like to New Jersey John
smirk Charlie oh much further than that
laugh he chuckling now where would Ethan
usually be at this early hour normally
he isn't up this early he'll be asleep
back at the apartment perfect
Constantine clapped his hands and stood
up from the table ever seen an exorcism
before hurriedly Emma escorted Jon back
to the apartment she and her brother had
shared there they found Ethan or rather
the thing pretending to be him seemingly
laying sound asleep it was only as Jon
approached hands raised cautiously but
the disguised demon Rose and lunged at
him snarling like a rabid animal again
luckily while the entity within was a
powerful agent of Darkness the outer
shell it was wearing was still mostly
human a quick blow from a frying pan
connected with Ethan's head thanks to
Emma and knocked him out long enough for
Jon to make the preparations clearing
the floor ripping up the carpet to gain
access to the floorboards below John and
Emma shifted the unconscious Ethan into
the center of the room around him
Constantine began marking out a ritual
circle on the woodwork he'd brought
along his bag producing a series of
candles from it placing each one at the
point of a pentagram he drew within the
circle buried in the bag were a few
extra tools of his many trades some
extra spell books holy water and even
some hallowed brass knuckles he pulled
one of the knuckle dusters out and
pocketed it he hadn't used them in a
dog's age but better to be safe he
didn't answer before Emma chimed in
watching the demonologist at work come
again John replied as he started
painting runes around the pentagram when
I asked you who demon Dan was she
clarified a right pain in the backside
I'll tell you that for nothing he
chuckled think of him like the used car
salesman of the underworld I've only
ever heard stories mind you I wasn't
certain until you mentioned that Ethan
was watching ads on the Telly so why
Emma asked this damn the Dan guy he has
his own commercials spot on John Smurf
he runs some place called demon dance
discount homunculus Depot the ad appears
on your TV usually at random and then
Dan starts harking in Wares you know
real salesman type battle infomercial
lock what is he selling though she cut
in her voice telling John she had
already half figured it out but didn't
want the answer to be as horrible as the
one in her head John paused for a moment
looking up from the nearly complete
circle of occult symbols us he replied
plainly human beings once the ads over
the nearest door becomes a gateway to
his little corner of paradise whoever
sees it ends up there that's when Dan
howls a person out Scoops out their soul
until they're just a husk that's what
happened to poison here Emma sniffled
holding back tears but why demons need
vessels love Constantine answered they
can well be running up about here in
broad daylight that's what Dan does he
takes him apart them back up turns human
beings into bespoke skin vehicles for
the worst hell has to offer with the
circle finally complete John retrieve
one of his spell books in a vial of holy
water from his bag it was time opening
the book to the right chapter he
splashed some of the Blessed liquid over
Ethan laying in the middle of the circle
instantly he woke up again growling
angrily as the water singed his skin
like burning acid even through its
disguise it was still enough to Sting
the demon who went to lunch at the
English Exorcist again only to find an
invisible barrier blocking its path the
spell John had cast was working keeping
the monster contained for now yo the
demon gurgled from inside its skin suit
lifting a finger to John you are known
to us Constantine oh yeah he replied
sarcastically my reputation has a habit
of preceding me
indeed the creature replied chuckling in
a mocking fashion we know what you've
done your transgressions your mistakes
owe so many failures the great John
Constantine nothing but a fraud that's
enough out of you mate John spat
flicking through the pages of his Tome
looking for the right incantation your
mother and father the demon growled
Marianne Thomas and Cheryl your sister
was it worth it John a spell to make you
a powerful magician was it really worth
the fire that claimed their lives Jon
forced himself to ignore the demons
taunting beginning to mutter a spell
under his breath all the while he was
aware that Emma was standing next to him
he could see her concerned frightened
look out of the corner of his eye and
then poor defenseless Astra the hell
spawn continued practically handed over
to nergal on a silver ladder at all
thanks to you John I told you John smirk
finally reaching the right passage
that's enough the whole room shook books
flying off shells as if full force of an
earthquake had hit the apartment in fact
it was worse than that it was as though
a tornado was blasting through the place
magical gusts of wind throwing
everything into disarray images
bombarded Constantine's mind the sights
that Ethan would have seen that night he
was taken he could see the commercial on
the TV the logo for demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot appearing on screen in
baby blue bubble lettering then there
was the monster himself demon Dan his
dark green skin patches of thick brown
fur appearing randomly over his body
next came the sight of the store itself
the rose upon rows of hanging human
corpses all hollowed out shells ready
for Dan's demonic customers to slip
inside but all the while Jon didn't let
up slinging more holy water at the
disguised demon he shouted the words to
the spell as loud as he could repeating
the entire passage over and over inside
the circle the creature thrashed and
growled hovering above the ground as the
hellish host was forced out of Ethan's
remain there's seven Lords are ever
planning their Invasion the demons
snarled you can't stop what's coming
Constantine if I had a quid for every
time I heard that John chuckled with a
final deafening crash the body finally
dropped back to the ground still and
lifeless Emma couldn't help but scream
as she looked at her brother deflated
emptied inside and now left as little
more than his empty skin no time for
that love Constantine urged her pulling
his phone from his pocket and typing out
an urgent SOS text now we're in real
trouble what the hell do you mean real
trouble Emma yelled sobbing
uncontrollably as she cradled Ethan's
hollow body well demon Dan's not gonna
be too pleased when one of his customers
complains about what I just did John
replied checking his phone Jen texted
back yet this was an emergency so he'll
probably be here any second now
practically On Cue the front door to the
apartment swung open an outstepped demon
Dan himself he towered over both John
and Emma almost seven feet tall on his
long goat legs and even uglier than he
had looked on the TV I should have known
he bellowed showing off Rose of pointed
teeth as he laughed
if it isn't the hellblazer himself
you've got some nerve messing with my
business little man and you've got some
bloody cheeks snatching human beings for
your little hustle might John retorted
slipping something out of his coat
pocket as he squared up to the grotesque
green skin demon a few words of advice
lad cash up pack up your bags and
clothes shop demon Dan threw his head
back and laughed a twisted inhuman sound
[Laughter]
or what he snarled with a grin I've got
a thriving Enterprise business is
booming do you really think you can stop
me all alone Constantine John smirk
feeling his phone buzz in his pocket who
said I was alone a blast of magical
energy lit up the apartment as the
raven-haired woman appeared in a black
tuxedo jacket and matching Top Hat a
white shirt and bow tie beneath she gave
a flick of her hand right towards Dan
casting a spell
before the Demonic salesman could
comprehend what was going on a portal
erupted behind him with enough Force to
drag him into it demon Dan tried
desperately to Scrabble to grip at the
floorboards only to feel a shoe standing
on his clawed fingers looking down at
him Jon was wearing something metal over
his fingers we are out of business mate
with the swing of his fist the hollowed
brass knuckles smashed into demon Dan's
face burning his green skin and sending
him tumbling backwards into the Portal's
magical pole he took her time Jon
jokingly scolded a thank you wouldn't go
and Miss Jon zantana is Atara side I
didn't have to come just because you
texted me cheers Constantine said
earnestly he knew that demon Dan
wouldn't be gone for long but maybe a
short stint in purgatory would at least
put a halt to the satanic salesman
schemes for the time being although
swept up in the excitement of his
temporary Victory Jon didn't notice
Emma's eyes quickly flash an infernal
shade of
when it comes to beings with fearsome
reputations there are few scps that are
as widely dreaded as the hard to destroy
reptile
scp-682 no sane mortal would ever choose
to face such a creature and its
overwhelming ferocity and strength have
even given the reincarnating warrior
scp-076-2 able pause on more than one
occasion but then again this saying
aren't exactly in high demand at the SCP
Foundation or at equivalent
organizations formed for the purpose of
battling anomalous and Supernatural
entities organizations such as the
public safety devil hunters from the
popular Manga and Anime chainsaw man
count numerous peculiar individuals
among their ranks and sometimes the best
of the best are marked by a distinctive
tendency for out of the box thinking
that's putting it politely at least but
this isn't the story of some aberrant
loser Freakazoid no definitely not the
hair heroin of this tale is none other
than the mightiest and most charismatic
future Nobel Prize winner ever to Grace
the rest of us shameful worms with her
presence the Invincible and dearly
beloved blood fiend power who just so
happens to be the Undisputed best
character in chainsaw man and of all
fiction as well it appeared to be an
unusually Boring Day At Public Safety
and for this kobeni was grateful the
young woman had come to expect the
absolute worst from her job as a devil
Hunter as her assignments usually
entailed facing down hellish entities
born from the very fears of the human
race while one would think that someone
who worked so diligently in the field
would have grown numb to it all kobeni
still very much retained her anxieties
both on and off the job at least all she
had to do today was file paperwork from
one of the public safety's like-minded
Partners in Supernatural management the
SCP Foundation it was a safe and
harmless task aside from the risk of
paper cuts and the associated potential
for the paper cut devil to show up even
so kobeni would do her best to make this
rare moment of Peace last as long as
possible a voice cried from down the
hallway oh no not her kobemi thought why
is she even at work today she's a
fighter for division four and she's not
good at anything else loud exaggerated
footsteps rang out through the hallway
as the blood fiends stomped through the
offices of Public Safety cabani wanted
to shrink until she vanished from sight
or let herself sink into the floor her
desire to not have to see Power today
was so great that she contemplated
opening a window and climbing down this
side of the building to the ground floor
please don't come this way gobeni was
still carrying a heavy stack of freshly
filed paperwork and she didn't want her
tireless efforts at organization to go
to waste she looked frantically at the
cabinets in the storage room she was in
hoping to find enough space for her to
crawl into and make herself scarce but
it was to too late power slammed open
the door of the storage room and
announced her presence the shock was so
great that kobeni screamed and flung the
stack of SCP Foundation papers all over
the ground she clutched her fast Beating
Heart unable to attend to the mess
immediately kobeni hadn't had to
experience a fright that sudden since
the time that she was sent to hunt the
jump scare devil the poor girl could
never have a surprise party thrown in
her honor again Drew to her name power
immediately reprimanded kobeni for
dropping the papers stating that her
workmanship was sloppy and that power
herself could easily carry 10 times the
amount of paper kobeni tried to not let
the chatting of her co-worker affect her
mood she bent down and scooped up the
papers but much to her Chagrin power
decided to help with this task as well
the bloodstream began grabbing the
papers and stacking them as assertively
as possible on the nearest surfaces
resulting in many crumpled edges and
uneven piles cobeni attempted albeit
hesitantly to correct Powers paper
collect method only to be met with more
scorn gobending nearly cried this was
just too much for her to handle
especially on what was supposed to be a
calm day that was when power picked up
one of the files and began to read it
was a record of the infamous cross test
between
scp-682 and
scp-076-2 since Public Safety had
previously assisted the foundation in
re-containing
scp-076-2 there had been an agreement to
send copies of all relevant documents
involving Abel over to Japan in case of
another incident as power struggled
through the scientific language and
specifics she began to Envision her own
version of the events that played out on
the page she imagined herself as able
facing off in pitched combat against
scp-682 and giving the terrible lizard a
run for its money in the process in the
mere seconds it took for power to finish
reading the document she had not only
concocted an entire epic battle in mind
but was not fully events that her
fantasy was indistinguishable from one
of her own lived experiences in her head
power had definitely fought against
scp-682 and she'd do it again in a
heartbeat just to teach that overgrown
reptile another lesson power asked
kobeni if she had ever told her about
the time that the blood fiend had
totally defeated
scp-682 kobene is still clutching to her
increasingly frail understanding of
reality responded with confusion what
was she talking about nobody in public
safety had fought against an SCP other
than
076-2 there was no possible way that
power was telling the truth but the
scariest part was power herself didn't
even know that she was lying the blood
fiend began to relate the sore details
of her pulse-pounding fight with scp-682
tukubeni in great detail cabani for her
part was too emotionally drained at this
point to try and stop her it all started
at the bowling alley Where power was
hanging out with her much less
intelligent friends Aki and denji the
bloodfiend had just finished winning her
fifth perfectly scored game in a row
when some shady characters a few lanes
over decided to cause some trouble the
leader of this little gang was none
other than
scp-682 the way you ball is disgusting
the troublemaking lizard said this
wicked remark would not be stood for not
in the proud bowling establishment that
power had founded with her own money and
achieved several years of successful
business running herself the bowling
alley was a pillar of the community and
she was the owner there would be no
further disrespect on her watch power
put up her dukes and got ready to bring
the pain down on scp-682 Aki and denji
were too terrified to help her out as
usual but did their best to cheer their
leader on from the sidelines
scp-682 also dismissed its minions and
called forward like the big ugly lizard
that it was it obviously didn't know
better which is is why it wasn't backing
down in the face of the greatest devil
hunter that the world had ever known
either way this would be a Brawl for the
ages rather than cause damage to her
beloved place of business power
suggested that she and her opponent took
this fight outside despite its uncouth
demeanor the reptile had a healthy
appreciation for the fine sport of
bowling and most especially this
particularly excellent run five-star
bowling alley it agreed to step outside
in the interest of not bringing bowling
into this intensely personal Grudge
Match but then again wasn't the fight
about bowling no matter power and
scp-682 walked outside the bowling alley
into a vast trackless Wasteland the
perfect place for both of them to go all
out without hurting any civilians using
her ability to control and reshape her
own blood power constructed an enormous
Crimson Mallet that she was able to
wield gracefully in both her hands
despite its incredible size scpc 682
readied itself it had faced many
different kinds of humanoid weapon
wielders before including Abel but it
was too clever of an adversary to let
its guard down especially because in
this case the blood fiend it was
fighting was a remarkable businesswoman
and an Olympic gold medalist in
everything the reptile certainly let its
card down power held the hammer above
her head and jumped High into the air if
she wanted to she could have circled the
globe in a single leap but out of
respect for the fact that scp-682 was a
paying customer at her establishment she
decided to hold back for the first
attack at least nonetheless she brought
the hammer down on the hard to destroy
reptile with Supreme Force
scp-682 smashed into the ground with
such a force that a crater opened up
beneath its body the reptile itself
didn't seem especially damaged but the
effects on the surrounding environment
were certainly dramatic and fitting for
an Ultimate Showdown
scp-682 shook off the blow and pounced
on power such ferocity that even she
couldn't remain on her feet she tumbled
back into the dust and debris of the
Wasteland for several miles before
catching herself and standing back up
remarkably there wasn't even a scratch
on her she pointed and laughed at
scp-682 mocking it for its weakness and
stupidity the reptile grinned wickedly
and responded with a mocking laugh of
its own the creature had intentionally
taken a hit from power in order to
better understand her fighting moves who
wouldn't want to steal those masterful
techniques after all they're just too
good to resist making a cheap copy of
and from what power could remember from
her speed read of the file that appeared
to be
scp-682's whole thing soon a barting of
blood red armor appeared around
scp-682's body in the short time that it
had been fighting Power it had clearly
learned how to manipulate its own blood
and was now even stronger for it ha ha
ha
now I'm as strong as you I can't lose
scp-682 barked at Power she swung her
Mallet in a show of force the two
combatants now both wielding the near
Limitless powers of the blood fiend
charged at each other across the
battlefield this was not just a mere
sparring match anymore it was a fight
for the fate of the entire world
snapping back to reality Powers
retelling of the story had devolved into
a series of random exclamations and
sound effects cabani was now finding the
events incredibly hard to follow but
thankfully she had been able to use
powers highly distractible mannerisms to
finish restacking the files from the
foundation not a minute too soon either
as both she and Powers boss makima
stepped into the storage room apparently
makima was in the process of doing a
headcount of all employees who had come
into work today as any normal and
benevolent Superior would she had been
looking for kobenian power for some time
now and was surprised to find them here
of all places cabani explained that she
had been putting away the last of the
SCP Foundation files and would badly
accept whatever new post she was given
but Power wasn't done with her current
scp-682 Fascination and turned to makama
hoping to be encouraged to continue the
story makama simply smiled and implied
that if power was so inclined to settle
her score with a hard to destroy reptile
Public Safety could get in contact with
the foundation and have her on a flight
to site 19 by that evening power
suddenly realized that she had come down
with a terrible case of whatever
crippling disease that would be a
sufficient excuse for her to not do that
makima nodded and encouraged her
subordinates to return to work that's
right it's that time again we're
recalibrating rebooting and hitting
restart on our Infamous animatron 6000
the specialized supercomputer we've
developed to simulate improbable
scenarios between the SCP foundation's
various anomalies and any other
characters from any other Universe you
could possibly imagine on today's agenda
what do you think would happen if John
Wick the notorious hit man highly
trained in all forms of combat was up
against an enemy that won't go down in a
single shot an undead Menace known as
scp-008 well we're about to hit the
button and find out either by a pure
unpredictable instance of human error or
through the act of some Twisted karmic
fate the SCP Foundation had an outbreak
on their hands a sample of the complex
prion a virus known as scp-008 have late
the foundation had hoped to keep the
existence of the disease highly
classified even among its own Personnel
Their Fear had been that some hostile
force would attempt to synthesize or
even weaponize as cp008 after all the
disease had a 100 rate of both infection
and lethality it killed anything it came
into contact with or at least it killed
them to begin with before long everyone
in the foundation facility that had been
exposed to the leaking sample of
scp-008's already infected victims stand
flu-like symptoms were followed swiftly
by a coma however the disease hijacked
the bodies of all those it had passed to
reactivating the motor functions of
their corpses and turning them into well
you can already guess no one was safe
even the mobile task force on the scene
were soon infected with scp-008 they had
been a squad of rookies and fresh-faced
new recruits sent in by the foundation
under the assumption that an outbreak of
this sort should have been easy to
contain it wasn't the entire facility
was soon overrun the bodies of
foundation researchers security officers
and MTF troops reanimated after their
deaths now jostling around in search of
survivors to pass scp-008 onto that
should hold them Dr Alto cleff yelled
locking the entrance to the Watchtower
tight this really is another fine mess
Cliff his colleague Dr gears replied in
frustration our MTF backup are all down
we could be the last two people on site
we're locked on a tower with only one
entry tell me what the hell are we
supposed to do now I will relax clef
insisted don't worry there's someone we
can call to get us out of this jam oh
don't say I know a guy gear side as his
fellow researcher gave a wide grin and
reach for his cell phone a few moments
later and only a matter of miles away
another phone started ringing its owner
a man in a dark all-black tailored suit
with a shadowy shirt and tied a match
reached into his pocket and lifted his
cell phone to his ear good evening I
apologize for calling you at this hour
came the unmistakable voice of Sharon
the concierge of the New York
Continental Hotel that's quite all right
replied the suited man we received the
call asking for your whereabouts sir a
job the man asked in a monotone voice
indeed Sharon replied up front I'm
afraid not the hotel's receptionist
answered sympathetically the contract is
only in exchange for payment upon
completion the man who made the call was
very insistent he said he would be in no
position to pay until the job is done
but they asked for you specifically and
told us he'd be grateful for your
assistance the man on the end of the
line side where oh don't worry sir the
friendly concierge replied we were
sending a car for you at that precise
moment a yellow New York Cab pulled up
to the sidewalk best of luck Mr wake
Sharon said before hanging up the call
straightening his suit the infamous
Hitman John Wick climbed into the back
of the taxi As It sped off towards its
destination arriving at a complex
Upstate far off the Baton track John
examined his surroundings while the car
inched closer to the nearest part of the
facility his ears of training as an
assassin under the tutelage of roskroma
had given him an instinctive spatial
awareness one that came in handy in his
line of work but even then Jon couldn't
have predicted that something would come
leaping down from above crashing through
the Cab's Shield the car's Hood buckled
under the impact fragments of glass
sprang everywhere as an arm cracked the
front window the thing snarled and
gurgled like a wild animal as it reached
for the taxi driver gripping his arm it
pulled him by the wrist Biting Down
causing him to scream in intense pain
meanwhile Jon had already moved with
lightning fast reflexes and sprung out
of the back seat he hadn't had a chance
to assess the threat his instincts told
him his best option was put some
distance between himself and whatever
had just attacked the car then he'd be
able to get a better idea what he was
dealing with the job description he'd
been hired for had been light on details
John's mystery employer only referred to
it as a quote cleanup operation
sprinting towards the facility John
slammed the door behind him he pulled
off his belt from around his waist and
wrapped it tightly around the door
handles it would hold for now it was
only when he turned around that he saw a
few clustered groups of figures
shuffling around inside the building's
age Atrium the nearest Gaggle were close
enough that it was easy for John to make
out their pale skin sunken eyes and
cheeks the unnatural twitches and
erratic movements they were making as
the creatures turned to look back at him
zombies John Wick muttered under his
breath that's unexpected the nearby Trio
of scp-008 infecties looked like they
were about to make a dash towards him so
Jon moved fast he raced towards a nearby
Corridor hearing that the three zombies
were already chasing after him their
shambling footsteps had quickly become
an animalistic charge their limbs only
able to move after death thanks to the
virus that they were infected with
turning a corner John Wick took cover
his shoulder pressed to the wall he drew
his pistol from its holster underneath
his suit jacket and stood in a
battle-ready stance the second he saw
one of the zombies faces appear around
the corner he raised his weapon and
fired swooping around one of his hiding
places to fire another two shots all
three hit Center Mass right through
their chests the noise would no doubt
have drawn the attention of the other
scp-008s in the building but for now the
three that had been on his tail dropped
to the floor only to start getting back
up again Jon wasn't used to his Target
standing to their feet after he'd
already fired at them and the nearest of
the zombies staggered back to his level
he lifted his firearm again before his
finger could compress enough force on
the trigger though the undead
Abomination took a wild flailing swipe
at him the scp-008 instance knocked the
weapon out of Jon's hand causing it to
clander to the ground while it reared
back its other arm for a second strike
catching the blow John Wick displayed
his incredible reflexes and Mastery of
martial arts he delivered a series of
precise punches and chops deploying a
combination of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
Aikido and Krav Maga to try and knock
the snarling monster down with each hit
he was careful to avoid the zombie's
mouth having seen one bite to the cab
driver earlier Jon had assessed that
scp-008 could be transmit through biting
and he was correct exposure to mucous
membranes or bodily fluids of an
infected individual was what allowed the
virus to spread one of the other scp-008
zombies that were still in the process
of climbing back up swipe John's legs
out from underneath him the master
assassin toppled over landing on his
back with the weight of the first
Monster still on top of him while the
second Claude of this tapered suit pants
seconds before it could snap its teeth
down on his ankle Jon pulled back his
leg and shot it back out in a
devastating bicycle kick that sent the
second zombie reeling into the third
which was still trying to get back up
after its earlier gunshot but the first
of the creatures were still bearing down
on him mustering as much of his Peak
Physical strength as he needed John Wick
held the zombie at Bay blocking it with
one arm stopping it from getting close
enough to bite him his eyes started
around looking for something anything he
could use that was one of Jon's most
enviable and impressive skills one that
made him so renowned as a legend of the
Assassin world in the hands of John Wick
any ordinary everyday object could be a
Lethal Weapon reaching out with this
other hand Jon felt his fingertips brush
against something metal who was so close
just Out Of Reach on top of him the
zombie flailed its arms trying to clod
him lifting both legs in a fluid
balletic motion John Wick kicked the
creature off of him crawling towards the
nearby object and grabbing it just as
the zombie started to approach again
with the swing and a loud metallic clang
the heavy fire extinguisher collided
with the scp-008 infecties had the force
of the blow caused it to drop in an
instant Landing in a heap on the floor
Jon waited a second to see if it would
get back up again but it was still the
other two zombies suddenly dashed
towards the infamous Hitman only for
their prey to duck and weave
effortlessly between their aggressive
clawing swipes bashing his makeshift
weapon against their heads like a
battering ram against a door all three
were down but the entire facility was
still crawling with a mass of the
reanimated monstrosities calmly John
smoothed his suit and straightened up
his shirt and tie walking with the fire
extinguisher in hand back down the
corridor towards the sound of more
scp-008 zombies snarling they were next
the Baba Yaga would use anything he
found to take down each and every one of
them until not one was left standing it
didn't matter if all he had was a fire
extinguisher or one of the Fallen
security officers batons or even just a
tiny pencil nothing would make it out of
that facility alive
just had to go for the head still
trapped in the Watchtower Dr clef and Dr
gears have long since grown irritated
with each other's company they had no
security feeds no way of knowing what
was going on within the overrun
Foundation facility for a while the pair
of researchers had been toying with the
idea of climbing out of a window and
scaling down the side of the tower but
giving up on that plan when they'd
realized they'd only be dropping back
into a horde of scp-008 zombies a sudden
explosion erupted from one corner of the
complex causing gears and cleft to
direct their attention towards it from
their elevation they could see the
ground below was littered with the
bodies of the scp-008 infecties rendered
lifeless once again by significant
cranial trauma in short something had
been bashing the zombies in the head or
someone the sound of a banging against
the locked Watchtower door startled both
Foundation scientists instantly they
thought that the zombies had made their
way up the steps and found the two
researchers easy prey trapped in a cage
the heavy thought against the metal door
repeated then there was a pause
deafening tense silence filling the room
a polite knock came from the other side
of the Watchtower entrance cautiously
clef approached to a market standing in
the doorway as it opened was a single
figure panting with exhaustion but still
nowhere near Beaton he looked out at
clef and gears from his dark hair a
Stern expression on his face neither one
of the researchers could believe that he
was still alive still uninfected but
then again he was the one and only John
Wick the Baba Yaga welcome back dear
viewers of SCP explained we hope you've
been keeping well and we also hope that
your health insurance covers blown Minds
because today we're using our trademark
anomatron 6000 to pit an anomalous
Legend against another Marvel Legend
that's right it's scp-682 versus Dr
Michael morbius of the 2022 cinematic
Masterpiece morbius of course there is
one issue that we should share with you
before we begin we haven't actually seen
morbius however here's the wonderful
thing statistically you haven't either
in fact we tried to get the animatron
6000 to process morbius as raw data for
the simulation but our antivirus
software kept stopping it intriguing so
instead we simply hit randomized traits
on the animatron so it's free to use
Advanced AI could conceive what morbius
is like and what his abilities probably
are and as far as you or I know it might
even be correct so let's get this show
on the road and see if the hard to
destroy reptile could hone against its
own at Cinema's most tragically memed
upon superhero prepare for perhaps the
most absurd and ridiculous video with
the exception of the Among Us video that
we've ever released on here in other
words it's morbin time it began as many
bizarre SCP Foundation stories do with
scp-682 cracking the glass of its acid
tank and preparing to spill chaos and
Terror onto site 19. for most people
even seeing actual footage of this would
be a life-defining traumatic incident
for most season Foundation researchers
it was just another Sunday when 682
busted through the nearest wall like a
psychopathic reptilian Kool-Aid man
while guards engaged in the futile task
of trying to subdue it with small arms
fire the senior researchers languidly
made their way to the nearest secure
Panic Room and hunkered down as was
standard protocol for scp-682 escapes
all available mobile task force units
would be dispatched single-mindedly
focused on cutting the lizard back down
to size but the problem was this wasn't
just any other Sunday it was Super Bowl
Sunday and seeing as most mobile task
force operatives are incredibly tough
and manly they generally love football
and promise they definitely come and
take down 682 as soon as the game was
over this would be one thing if scp-682
was content to just terrorize the usual
denizens of Psych 19 today but no it'd
been a while since the hard to destroy
reptile had tasted civilian flesh and he
intended to rectify that toot sweet in a
state of murderous Fury 682 barged
through wall after wall with the effort
that a normal human might walk through
rice paper soon enough it was free from
the dribe gray walls of the containment
site and feeling the sun on its scales
once more such a lovely day out with a
distant sound of people laughing and
chatting and children playing happily
with their pets 682 predictably found
this disgusting and resolved to destroy
them all and with all those mobile task
force operatives swigging beer eating
peanuts and giggling at amusing
celebrity cameos in Super Bowl Halftime
ads there would be nobody who would stop
682 from completing its dastardly task
except of course one man Dr Michael
morbius while 682 was escaping morbius
was sitting on the the deck of his
private yacht drinking a martini glass
full of two percent milk because morbius
understands the importance of having
healthy bones he was listening to a
fantastic podcast about the Curative
powers of beef jerky when high above the
SCP Foundation activated the morb signal
a batman-esque light shining up in the
sky in the shape of a clown this was bad
morby has paused his podcast and
prepared himself finishing the last of
his milk and washing out the glass so it
didn't get smelly he raised his arm and
summoned the morb orb a glowing red ball
that seemed to be the source of his
powers according to a number of internet
memes he clutched the orb feeling its
power flow through him as he made a
small prayer to his Guardian deity the
late David Bowie and with that he took
flight twin Jets of fire blasting out of
his shoes like rocket ships he could
only hope that he'd be able to intercept
scp-682 before it was too late meanwhile
scp-682 was indulged in one of his
favorite hobbies just killing lots of
people he'd invaded the American city of
San Fran English New York which was
known for being the biggest population
of people within the proximity of site
19. 682 was truly rampaging he knocked
the ice cream cones out of children's
hands causing them to weep profusely he
literally kicked dogs and he also
murdered a number of adults with his
vicious fangs and Claws the local police
attempted to stop him but they were
hopelessly outmatched they attempted to
Cuff the monster several times only to
find out that by the time they were
halfway through trying to read the Beast
it's Miranda rights he would break free
and Rampage yet again all in all 682 was
having a grand old time and was
delighted that nobody was coming to stop
its Rampage of utter Devastation it
seemed almost as though the Rampage
would never end until a dark shadow fell
over the ravenous reptilian monster it
turned up its head to see a new foe
floating above it was it a bird was it a
plane no it was Dr Dr Michael morbius of
course wielding his trademark flaming
Trident of Justice another lamb to the
slaughter 682 growled are you ready to
meet your end morbius laughed and shook
his head I don't know who you are you
scaly monster but for hurting all these
innocent people you're about to get
mobbed on and with that he threw his
flaming Trident at the reptile striking
Brave and true but it wasn't enough 682
had developed incredibly strong reflexes
after years of the foundation's attempts
on its life so morbius would need to try
a lot harder than just using his classic
beloved Trident to end this fight even
then before morbius had a chance to
think up another method of attack 682
had adapted and switched to the offense
two great dragon-like leathery Wings
unfurled on the monster's back and it
took to the air lunging towards morbius
with fangs born in claws at the ready
before morbius knew it the creature's
Jaws were ready to close around his head
thankfully at this moment another one of
morbius's classic superpowers comes into
play his short-range teleportation
abilities in a moment of reflex that
would impress 682 morbius teleported out
of the monster's path remanifesting
instantly floating a few feet away 682
growled in irritation of course it would
never be so easy it said the foundation
always sends one of its freaks to
distract me you may think you're strong
but really you're just another puppet
I've never heard of this Foundation
morbius quipped back and I'm not your
standard hero either I really blur the
line between hero and villain entirely
in fact before morbius could finish
explaining what a complex character he
was if you could even use that word 682
flew after him again this time however
morbius was ready he lifted up his arms
and Unleashed another one of his
patented attacks opening up human mouths
in the palms of his hands which
Unleashed men miniature yet still
extremely powerful air-to-air missiles
the missiles blasted out and struck 682
causing an impressive explosion but 682
was well versed in explosions it kept
flying after morbius he needed to get
out of here fast or he'd become a
lizard's lunch morbius turned and flew
in the opposite direction the hard to
destroy reptile hot on his heels the
first step of course would be to get
away from populated areas to limit
collateral damage no matter what
happened morbius refused to let this
mysterious entity harm more people you
cannot run forever 682 ground your
wretched life will be brought to a slow
and painful end stranger they were
passing over the water now flying at
Quantum speeds watching the Pacific
Ocean whiz past beneath them that's when
morbius noticed it and had an epiphany a
volcano and by the looks of the smoke
Rising above it an active one too
morbius had a plan now but to execute it
he'd need perfect speed and timing he
stopped in mid-air as the Beast flew
towards him but moments before 682 could
make contact morvis grabbed it executing
a perfect mid-air suplex and tossed The
Roaring Beast directly down into the
volcano below for any other monster this
would be the end of it but for 682 a
double triple or even quadruple tap was
often required to reliably incapacitate
it morbius's work was not done he flew
down towards the volcano ready to engage
in the next hectic stage of battle bet
you're not feeling so cocky now you
nasty reptile Morpheus yelled but the
reptile in question was too busy
flailing around in impossibly hot magma
to reply at the time such is the way
when falling into an active volcano
scp-682 burnt and chart but still alive
began to crawl from the top of the
volcano wheezing out smoke and Ash how
could such a strange confusing creature
have been such a formidable opponent no
matter it will destroy this Morpheus it
might just take a little longer than
expected little did the unfortunate
reptile know morbius Was preparing his
next weapon perfect for immobilizing
this ornery monster an eight ball in a
gym sock forming a kind of dangerous
makeshift flail it was the kind of
lethal improvised weapon that would
strike fear into even the strongest of
enemy combatants and now scp-682 would
learn to fear its power as the flame
broiled reptile began to stand perhaps
preparing to adapt to its latest set of
injuries morbius began relentlessly
beating the hard to destroy reptile with
the eight ball sock dazing it with
repeated brutal strikes that never
seemed to stop morbius had learned this
technique from years of being involved
in vicious bar fights normally caused by
him cheating at darts this can stop any
time you want Morpheus yelled you just
need to stop getting back up initially
682 wanted to remain defiant but if even
it could not deny that being struck
again and again by the eight ball sock
was actually extremely painful was it
really worth the fight after performing
some quick mental calculations
scp-682 determined that no it probably
wasn't time to throw in the towel okay
okay 682 said mostly just annoyed at
this point I'll stop rampaging honestly
you just took all the fun out of it 682
just sighed and laid on the ground
exhausted slowly regenerating from its
injuries morbius smiled content with his
victory who knows how many people he'd
saved by luring this creature away from
a population Center by this point the
Super Bowl was over and the legions of
mobile task force operatives who
technically should have done this hours
ago finally decided to suit up and take
care of business it didn't take long for
Black Tactical helicopters full of
foundation soldiers to triangulate the
location of the volcano where the end of
682 and morbius's epic battle had taken
place it wasn't long after that that
there were copious Foundation boots on
the ground this story of course has a
happy ending mobile task force agents
successfully recaptured scp-682 and
returned it to its containment cell in
site 19 and in the process of recovery
they mistook Dr Michael morbius for the
actor Jared Leto and shot him roughly 30
times in the chest with armor-piercing
rounds killing him instantly want an
anomaly of your own check out
www.scpswag.com for high quality SCP
merch now go and check out scp-096
versus siren head and scp-076 able vs
chainsaw man who has the most lethal
weapon for more Wild versus battles